welcome to this machine learning course
for beginners taught by hayu Singh he is
a data scientist and popular instructor
this course is your gateway to mastering
the intricacies of regression analysis
in the realm of machine learning IUS has
designed this course to provide you with
in-depth knowledge practical examples
and Hands-On projects that will set you
up for success with the curriculum that
covers everything from the basics to
Advanced Techniques this course offers a
unique opportunity to not only learn the
fundamentals of machine learning but
also explore the often overlooked power
of regression analysis so get ready for
a deep dive into the world of machine
learning what if I told you that there's
a core machine learning course that does
not have only detained explanation of
regression analysis but also have bday
lecture notes as assignments with
personalized feedback on that and a
scheduled learning plan for you well
guess what I'm offering all of this but
absolutely free hi I'm ayush and I'm
currently working as a data scientist at
Epic and has demonstrated working
experience as an envelopes engineer at
xenomen and a data scientist at artifact
and a founder of Anton and I welcome you
to our core comprehensive machine
learning course out here the course is
designed to give you a solid foundation
of machine learning and tradition
analysis which is often overlooked in
most of the courses available right now
we beg it by linking the downward for
machine learning so even if you're
beginner you are able to understand it
you talk about what is learning we talk
about generalization we talk about
inductive bias and a lot of things
initially and then we gradually move on
regression analysis and recover as much
as we go in depth and to ensure that we
are quite equipped with the Practical
applications as well I'm going to
introduce two projects by the end of the
course which you have never seen like
that project before as well because I
have worked personally at several
companies and I know how we deliver data
science process to them and the same way
I'm gonna do it in this course as well
but that's not all if you want to
maximize your learning opportunity from
this course then we are offering free
updates to the course regular
assignments with personalized feedback
to you and a tailored learning plan for
you to complete this course in just one
month you can simply go on a GitHub page
for the course and then get access to
the lbs directly from there and all of
this were absolutely free one of the
major issues which are on a highlight
you might be asking here use just for a
question most of the instructor takes
around only one audio of taking freaking
so much of our super teacher I tell you
that people forget the foundation people
forget the basics of it and they'll just
just strictly goes on Advanced topics
like deep learning and then they are not
able to secure the job and then they
complain me that hey I used data science
has no jobs plus actually if you think
in a way that the talent is less than
the actual drops because they are not
going to pay you thousands of dollars
for just three lines of code which you
ride inside but anyone can do it and
then crowd is increasing but the talent
is decreasing they're forgetting what's
the base of machine learning what's the
base of data science before getting the
solid foundation which was used to be
given in 90s and all so that's what the
course focuses on we make sure that we
emphasize the core concept of machine
learning and regression analysis so that
you can even learn further things on
your own our course is designed to put
emphasis on core concept of machine
learning and traditional analysis so
that you can tackle critical business
problem and solve it the way real data
scientists solve so that's enough of it
now let's get started with the course
you can directly go to the LMS and then
start from there by seeing the tailored
learning plan or you can get started
from here let me know if you have any
notes in the comment section and find
any errors or irata in this course
please feel free to make an issue on the
GitHub page for the course hey everyone
uh so let's get started with our machine
learning content and actually we'll get
started with
um a bit of discussion on learning the
machines learning intelligence and give
you some of the concepts which is
required eventually to build up your
ideas right so let's get started
so I would suggest you to open up your
notes if you have got it so once you
have the notes that you can see on the
front of the screen so we're going to
start off with what is learning right so
let's eventually talk about what is
learning and slowly we'll get into the
get into the concepts of you know a very
very good examples of learning and
intelligence Etc
so the first one is that what is
learning so I'll suggest you to write
your answer in the comment box if you
know so according to what exactly uh
what exactly you know about in terms of
machine learning we have the training
data we take some sort of you know
um the data don't worry what data looks
like and everything will cover that so
we have the data right and then we feed
to a sort of a black box and then we get
a trained algo that is trained on that
data for example assume that you have a
man right you trained that man with the
with that particular skill and then
whatever output after six or seven
months you will be getting a trained man
specialized in that skill right so this
is how your model model gets trained
your model gets the data gets the
training from the data and then get it
it gets trained by some instructor right
or assume that in this case it's an
algorithm and then after after after
some time we get a trained algorithm
right that in terms of a very simple or
very you know mind understanding
standing behind any algorithm but let's
talk about a very nice example very nice
example which is called which is known
as rats learning to avoid poisonous
dates so what is baits baits are some
sort of you know food or Etc so the
formal definition of beets is that it is
it is some sort of you know
um it is a type of prey that is used to
attract when hunting so
um sometimes you we use that baits to
attract you know poisonous thing it it
is a poisonous thing that you use to
attract uh food right uh sorry a mouse
is or any aerial things whatever for
example fish we also have the beets
right so in this way we have the baits
so basically the problem statement the
problem statement is that the rats are
learning to avoid the poisonous baits so
how do lats rats learn to avoid that
poisonous Spades right so rats assume
that rat came and then uh assume that
rat game a rat game and that and then
they given a no they there was a food
available where this was a bait this was
a bait right uh so it got they gone and
then they um it was like smelling good
and Etc right eight rat ate this food
rat eat this and there's an ill effect
on that game right there's an ill effect
of that game there's a effect of rat
game when they eat this food and and
then rats will not eat this food because
this is this is the learning mechanism
which happened right now where where
according to the past experience
according to the history or the mistakes
in the in in the past this rat did and
he's not on rats will no more gone to
repeat this step again
this is one sort of a learning mechanism
another learning mechanism which you can
think of is assume that you you have
done some sort of mistake in your past
or a very simple example assume that uh
you go for someone for guidance right
why why they are capable of giving items
because they have gone through the
problems they have already gone through
the problems so you go to them so that
you get an easy path so that you get an
easy uh guidance from them you you so to
achieve something in your career right
so in that way I'm saying that they
already have an experience of something
now they're capable of you to guide
right just like I do I guide so many
people right so we I got so so many of
books right now so I am a capable
because I've already gone through those
problems now I'm capable because of my
past experiences so whole point to take
out right now I have learned what
mistakes I what mistakes and what things
I did that leaded me to success and
failure right that I've
well to learned that so now that's a
learning mechanism for example you learn
you know you you study some maths
concept right you study quadratic
equations or maybe some calculus concept
so when you study that when you study
that
um what eventually happens is that uh
you you take a look at that particular
particular concept and once you take a
look at the particular concept now you
understand with the helpful examples and
then you do a problem and if you did any
sort of mistakes you you change it
according to you know um Lex ask ask for
help or see the solution but to when you
s but but when you saw similar questions
you will be able you you will be able to
answer that why because you have learned
from the past mistakes which you did
right because you are not going to
repeat the mistakes which you did in the
past even while solving problems
sometimes it happens as well sometimes
it does not right so you you look that's
on the learning mechanism that's why we
say the failure is a part of success
because it gives you the learning phases
the learning of opportunities to
actually go to grow forward
right so there are several types of
approaches which we go through the first
approach is learning by memorization
approach so this is something that's
very interesting uh where we we say in
Indian language it's ratification and in
ratification what what we do we memorize
things whatever we we we we want to
study so for example I've seen students
to literally memorize you know signs
answers SST answers even computer
science answers because they literally
memorize code and they just go and write
in the sheet of paper in uh and then
they they memorize literally like even
mathematical questions however it's so
obvious that daily not will perform well
but but but over here assume that if you
memorization every concept each and
every line of your answers will you be
able to perform good in examination so
even if one line you forget you'll mess
up with all the answers you'll start
integrating first answer to second
answer second answer to first right so
you have to apply so over here
memorization literally fails in your
daily life you can not literally
memorize everything and then go and set
an examination and you expect your that
you'll score good it it works till class
six or seven but it does doesn't work
when you actually grow right so you can
actually can't literally memorize each
and everything whether it be answers
whether it be mathematical Solutions or
literally anything
so I hope that that giving a good sense
about what exactly I want to talk on is
um
learning by memorization approach where
we memorize we learn some things by
memorizing uh that sort of thing right
so now so now what so now what what
exactly I'm going to do is talk about
some of the uh examples which we have
listed out here for you to better
understand things cool so assume that
you have you you have a you want to
build a system so you might have seen in
your email you know uh Gmail where you
where you have several photos promotions
folders social folder Spam folders and
it's an updates foldering Etc so you
have these folders and this one folder
called spam where all the spam goes in
right where all the spam goes in so what
are what are those spams right that's
question that's a question so now now
we're going to build a system you want
to build a system you want to build a
system that given the past data right
first of all we if if you're learning
something to identify a spam you need to
have the data you need to have the you
need to have some some sort of you know
content to understand tantrum right so
in this case if you want to build a
system you'll build a system that given
an email given an email it classifies
that email is a spam or not spam okay
that given an email it classifies
whether that email is a spam or not spam
right so now that's a question right so
you you so now what you so now what you
will do is that the first step is for
anything for learning literally anything
you need content for this so we need the
data for it right so we are we are going
to collect the collect the collect
collect collect the data
um we want to collect the data which is
where where we have the spam emails
right so we will collect the data which
is spam emails out here so we can we
collected the data which is spam emails
out here now
we have the content now we are now we
want our machine to learn from this
content so there will be two types of
guys first who will memorize this so the
four we'll talk with the first guy the
first level will memorize this will
memorize each and every email each and
every email so machine will memorize
each and every spam email
right and now now you're now that
machine is capable now with that machine
is even if if that is 100 correct even
if that memorized a very hundred percent
correctly right so machine will be able
to class will will be will will be able
to memorize each and everything now if
our an email comes em email comes
through this machine and now this a
machine is stored to classify this email
to be as a spam
or to be as a not spam right whether
that email is a spam or not spam so you
you go to new email and you classify it
so how machine will classify machine
will search this email into its memory
whether this email is available into end
to its memory or not right whether the
words of this email is available to in
in my memory or not right it if not then
we say that it is non-spam but because
the data is but because the the content
which we learned is about spam right so
if the if this is not available in that
content in his memory what he what the
model has memorized from the data then
he then the model will be able to see
that it is non-spam but if that email is
available then it will be spam so what's
the problem with this approach what's
the problem with this approach right
that's a good question what exactly the
problem with this approach that's a good
question to actually go forward to the
problem with this approach the problem
with this approach it is not
generalizable it so why it is not
generalizable so let's talk about a very
instance example assume that you have
got a new email you you've got a
completely new email which where your
model has not uh you know memorized for
example you sat in your mathematics uh
let's say Science examination you got
your questions which was in a textbook
which you memorize but you also got a
tweaked question but you also got a very
different thread set of questions so
where you have to apply logic and you
know apply several skills in that so he
there you will fail right because you
memorize only the consequences which
came but you're not able to answer the
questions which are new which are unseen
by you right so in this case as well
model will fail to gen to to to predict
for examples or predict for emails which
are unseen to buy the model which are
not seen by the model
right so that's that's the problem with
uh with the approach right now right so
that's one of the approach the problem
is that the machine which we have does
not have the ability to email any unseen
emails to to predict for any unseen
email so for example if any any email
comes and let's assume that it is a spam
but this is not available in this memory
content so that will be flat as non-spam
but actually it was a Spam right so this
is one of one of the problem so we need
what we need to do we need to figure out
a solution to further generalize it
further make into to to generalize means
to have to give to give this machine an
ability to give this machine an ability
to further classify even unseen emails
by logical thinking so I'm going to make
this guy so the second number of guy
wear it also understands analyzes the
data and applies logical thinking in
further to predict emails so that's
where to generalize and this is called
something known as inductive inference
okay this is not nothing but called
inductive inference
so we will talk we'll talk let's uh
let's talk about inductive inference uh
in the in detail in the next lecture so
now we'll talk about something known as
a generalization which we had had a talk
and then we'll talk about who and what's
the issue in this as well right so we'll
talk about that so the we we call that
generalizing our model is known as
inductive inference right please read
the if you want to know more examples
and all I have linked the very nice book
the chapters and every chapters is also
included in the in in the LMS so please
go over there you won't be able to see
everything uh um each and everything
with the resources and everything uh and
the reading materials regarding if if
you want more examples but that's it you
will stay here if you have understood it
so generalization generalization is it's
an ability to
um to add the feature in a machine to
actually improve right to to actually uh
work on even unseen examples but to
apply logical thinking
so now let's take an example over here
is that the the problem the problem
which we had the problem the very basic
problem which we had so I'm just going
to take a very very nice example right
now
so now now over here over here this is
right so in the end in this example This
Thread if we have the generalization
available if we have the generalization
uh available where your rat will be able
to decide whether to eat this food or
not be whether to eat this food or not
based on its smell right so rat will be
able to decide to to eat this food or
not
with the help of its milk
right so generalization how does this
help how does this generalization have
this had this right it helps it to
decide and answer examples which is
similar to the bad food so what is this
saying that rat may have seen the
similar similar food right so that may
have seen the similar food so
generalization is that that even that's
even a similar something comes in that
will be able to refuse okay this is a
bad Pro this is a good food right so
that should generalization gives an
ability to even rat to decide on this
particular food which has net never
written before based on the based on the
similar things which everybody eat which
he has written in the past
another example which which we have seen
that the that we have a machine which
scans the emails we'll scans the emails
it extracts the words that appears to be
spammy Words which is spammy words and
then it says spam or Not by seeing the
spammy word so basically that email
comes and then see what proportion of
the spammy votes is in that email and
then classify it based on that
but there's an issue so now by this if
you have the if you have the if we have
the words that is that is spammy and
then we check the proportion in that or
we give the machine the ability to even
classify uh based on The Logical
understanding of that and or a
generalized understanding of okay this
is this this is how the spam email looks
like right so your model will is able to
generalize accordingly according to the
things right that's one of them but here
your system might be able to perform
their event right so in this case you
might be thinking that you will be your
system will be able to perform OMG right
but actually it's not true
um you have to give the ability to the
model that to identify your nonsense
examples and then you think okay it's
over right it's not over so inductive
inference might lead us to false
predictions misleading predictions let
us see how so this uh prison super
session is an example business
supercision is an example
um I will which I have read in a machine
learning theory from algorithms's Theory
and also this is a very famous example
on learning conducted by some sort of
you know University which I don't
remember they have written it very
nicely is about how this inductive
inference might lead us to bad incidents
how this inductive inference might lead
us to bad inference so let's talk about
the very nice stuff as of now is this
this particular thing pigeon
superstition so you will be seeing a way
you'll you'll be seeing a very nice uh
I'll be linking a very nice video which
you which I suggest you to go over there
and watch that video first right so go
over there watch that video first or
I'll be giving a short
um short experience on what exactly is
going on so also you can actually pause
the video right now go over there and
understand what exactly is going in that
video but I'll be explaining you in
simple English terms so you can actually
go over there and understand it by your
own terms but I'll be explaining you in
the very same simple English terms so
you have um what what thought what the
experiment was experiment was the you
have you have set up you know you have
set of pigeons you have set up pigeons
which was contained in a cage so you
have you you've taken a set of pigeons
and what they did they have
they've kept it in a cage right and that
cage had a small hole has had a small
hole where the food was coming and going
at a certain interval of a Time assume
that every three seconds four seconds
five seconds ten seconds 12 seconds 14
seconds and all these pigeons are super
angry okay so so we have a cage and that
we have a pigeons which is super hungry
and then we there's a hole where the
food is coming at a certain interval of
a Time
okay at a certain interval of a time now
now when smooth is delivered now they
are angry right so sorry there the
patients are hungry right so if the
patients are hungry they'll keep on
doing some things they'll try to Peak no
they'll they'll try to peek and try to
find you know some sort of
um Foods you know so that they try to
Peak or they try to you know wings as
like spread their feathers and then try
to uh go from here to the other Peak
right so in this case as an experiment
I'm taking example if the pigeons if one
of the pages F2 two three are peaking
right so they're they're searching for
them they're they're active okay they're
active and they're peeking like this
which is my like searching for food uh
they're peeking now so when food is
delivered when food is delivered at
every interval of a time they are
engaged in some sort of activity that
activity can be peaking or that can be
Feathering up right anything literally
anything so if you see the video we'll
be seeing that some birds are peeking
some birds are
um this is only one body which the
they're engaged in some activities
now now now when the food was delivered
they were engaged in some activity right
so when food is delivered they go on and
eat in that right and then again start
doing the same action
again started doing the same action in a
hope that food will deliver it once
again right so if they would like pigeon
is doing some peaking and the food is
delivered by doing that action so you're
gonna need and again started peaking
so he thought that if I pick I'll be
getting
um
food to me right so so basically pigeons
started doing the same action in a hope
of food arrival but I'll come to that
part later on
so the pigeon Association of the
delivery of the food with whatever
actions they do
peeking Feathering flying literally
anything actions it with whatever
transactions they had been performing
when when it was first delivered so if
the first time it were delivered so
there were beacons so they continue to
do peaking in order for the food arrival
because they hope for it because they
hope for it so what's the problem in
this right what's the problem in this
right so let's talk about what exactly
the
um uh problem which which comes so
basically pigeon build an association
pigeon built an association with pigeon
pattern Association of the delivery of
the food the delivery of the food with
whatever chance or actions they had been
performing right so they built the
association between delivery of food
with the actions like peaking or flying
they did so they they tend to do peaking
in Hope of food arrival
right so very interesting so your your
vision learned that this that they
learned this right they learned it but
what exactly but but but now
now this now let's try to figure out
what exactly the problem in this problem
is that human Learners the we can rely
on Common Sense filter right to fit to
filter out meaningless sense for example
for example assume that uh every time I
throw this pen over here every every
time I throw throw this pen over here
right every time I throw throw this pen
over here my food will be coming right
like it is at a certain a certain in the
end of a time in the morning and
afternoon in the night it does not
matter how much I do this I'll be
getting that interval of time in this
case as well it was delivered on the
interval of a second it was not
dependent on what actions patients are
doing it was just lost intervals three
seconds four seconds three seconds six
seconds eight nine seconds 12 seconds
um I mean 12 seconds and then it is
going on the at a certain end Tower over
time it is not associated with what
actions patients are doing doesn't
really matter
this is so now we we can even we can
rely on it is a meaningless right
whatever pressure has understood it is a
meaningless right this is a meaningless
and this is something which is not so
human Learners can filter out
meaningless things we can filter out
that's a coincidence or that's something
that that's something super meaningless
and meaningless learning conclusions I
by doing this if I get money like it's
one time assume that you you are
throwing this pen out here right you're
throwing this pen out here and you you
any and you got money on your bank now
you are now you cannot keep on doing
this to get money till the end of Hope
of money arrival money will come at a
certain amount of time right
um so this is something which this is
meaningless conclusion but there are
some humans who cannot apply the common
sense filters to not take out the
but never mind so and now
now we now uh now over here region also
learned a very bad meaningless
conclusion where is where it he thought
that peaking will get me a food
right that's a bad so we also have to
give this Builder to our machines
right so in this generalization approach
the problem was that your model may end
up learning a Minix meaningless learning
conclusions so we must give the well
defined crisp principles again I'm
reading we must give well defined crisp
principles so that will protect our
program that from reaching in senseless
like What patients reached
that will protect our machines to reach
that to to to to reach that conclusion
this excerpt is taken from understanding
from ml from Theory to algorithm this is
very nice that's why I've taken it from
there what exactly it tells it tells
that your that we need to beautiful
gives filters to our model so that our
model is able to identify the
meaningless conclusions like this right
meaningless conclusions so we have to
give the well defined meaningless sorry
well-defined Tris principles crisp
principles to a model and those
principles are only called and those
well
well defined
crisp
principles
are called
what that are called nothing but ah
development it's it's that's what we
learned that's what the theory of ml
comes in theory of ml that's what the
theory of ml where we give the
well-defined principles to our model I
hope that makes sense to you uh that
give it a very nice understanding
about whatever we want to have a talk on
now there is a very interesting concept
which is known as inductive bias
inductive bias so let's talk about that
and then we can end this video and then
we can go to the next step which is
exactly learning about what is machine
learning and then now we know about
learning and then we can go over a bit
off you know
learnings so look cool
so assume that uh so sometimes
um uh you you might be noticing that a
new cat that a new cat that that a new
sorry new rat whatever I'm saying a new
rat might refrain from eating a food
because they think that that this food
is is is poisonous why because of the
prior knowledge inherited from the
previous generations so they have some
sort of genes that tells us don't need
this food this is poisonous because of
the past Generations because of the
habitual understanding if you've studied
the biology then you have studied that
there are there Evolution or the or the
evolution is necessary for human beings
if there is no Evolution if there is no
you know chain of you know
um for a whole food chain so assume that
you have a you you have a lot lots of
humans and they died from the disease
but but there might be some some newborn
newborn humans where or babies which
later they would develop in humans where
they are capable of fighting with those
diseases they are capable of that right
they have inherited they have built a
very nice combination so fighting with
the diseases we so in this case this rat
has inherited from the previous
generations previous generations of
their ads to further to to further say
that okay I'm not going to eat this food
I'm not going to eat this food because
it gives some sort of sense
so you might be thinking why rat so this
so why rat why rat was able to
successfully classify to not to do not
eat that food whether pigeons was not
able to they just was reaching to a
meaningless conclusion because drats
were having the prior knowledge and
prior knowledge is super important where
the rats were having the prior knowledge
so pigeons learning was not more
successful as compared to what rats said
because of the prior knowledge and prior
knowledge
is also called inductive bias prior
knowledge is also called inductive bias
I hope that makes sense
um now I hope that that every very
nicely introduction to learning in the
next lecture what I eventually going to
try to achieve is talk about a very nice
introduction to machine learning with
applications and will also do several
examples as well that's something
um
isn't necessary for you right so let's
go to the next lecture and then try to
understand machine learning with a very
nice definition with the very nice set
of examples so yeah so now what I'm
going to do is actually talk about uh
start talking about you know machine
learning stuff and that's something
which is super important for you to
actually go forward with it right
let's talk about that so now what we're
going to do we're going to actually talk
about what is machine learning I'm going
to talk about some of the applications
of it and then we'll see some of the
formal definition which comes in machine
learning now you know what exactly
learning is right now you know exactly
what learning is and then you'll start
referring that we have solved some of
the problem now to div now just just to
conduct the dots to connect the dots the
dots how we're going to connect it the
dot is first is there first where are
the where we learned about learning
mechanism where our rats were learning
two are two two to further classify
where the whether to eat this food food
or not right so we've gone through
memorization approach where um by taking
a simple spammer ham examples and for
him memorization we thought that
generalization that we have to
generalize it so that is inductive
inference so we've got another another
issue which we see in inductive
inference which is the misleading or
reaching to a senseless conclusions and
for defining that senseless curve and
for for refraining or protecting our
programs for senseless conclusions or
the principal conclusions we have
something known as machine learning
wherein this machine learning we Define
a well defined well-defined crisp
preface principles so that our model or
model does not reach us to uh senseless
conclusions
cool
um so let's get started so I suggest you
to maybe have a coffee with you because
that's something is super important
to refrain from it so correctly I'm
recording at 3am because I have boats as
well and I have to prepare uh so uh I
know how I'm managing this because I
have a class 10 both class 10
examination in 20 24 days I guess and
have to prepare a lot and uh
I'm doing my day and night on that but
eventually I have to also do for
community and I'm doing it because I
like it not something who's forcing me
to do this but coming back to what
exactly I want to do it is what tells
machine learning question so whatever
you know about machine learning write
that in a comment box edit your comment
or whatever you can do and just just
write that in the comment box what is
machine learning right so what is
machine learning it's an artificial
intelligence domain it an artificial
intelligence domain where we extract
patterns from the data and analyzes the
data and make intelligent predictions on
the new data according to the pattern
your machine has learned a very nice and
influential statements so let's try to
talk about uh the very highly
highlighted statement it's an artificial
intelligence domain where we extract
patterns from the data
analyze the data make intelligent
predictions on the new data this new is
very nice keyword according to the
pattern your machine has learned so
these uh these you know keywords if you
understand you know machine learning so
let's try and understand each and every
keyword first it's a domain of
artificial intelligence so if anyone
calls you know MLS AI say ml is AI of
course it is but it is but it is a
domain of Nei it is a subset of an AI
domain right
our way to extract patterns from the
data where the exact patterns are data
so I want to explain this to you with a
very nice you know practical example
let's forget you know bookish examples
so assume that you um you wanna you are
doing something like um yeah so you're
starting some sort of mathematical
Concepts assume that you're studying
quadratic equations so you're studying
about quadratic equations and in that
quadratic equations you had something
known as taking out the you know uh by
you have some sort of quadratic
equations from there's a form formula
for taking out using
loses
um like the concept right so there are
so many word problems regarding ages uh
distance and speed Etc so now many
actually when you actually solve those
problems when you actually solve those
problems you learn some sort of patterns
that this is how I should solve it when
you learn those chapters we expect those
chapters when you actually understand
those chapters you learn
how to what what what patterns are there
what patterns of questions are there and
how the solutions how the solutions are
framed right so in this way in this way
we have to figure out in this way you
are learning patterns from the from from
the chapter and by learning that you're
able to reach to a conclusion right so
once you have the pattern now if the new
question comes replies that whatever
patterns which you have learned are
analyzed your your your content now you
use that analyzer whatever whatever you
learned to answer those or predict
predict them cqs right so answer those
new questions right and what from
whatever you have learned till now so if
you if you didn't find the pattern well
you will be not able to you will be not
able to you know answer that well but if
you know but you will be able to answer
very well right
good so that's exactly machine learning
work so we're going to understand in
that way so it extract patterns from the
data so for example if you take an
example of a Spam or ham example spam or
ham example it extracts patterns from
the data it extracts patterns from the
data where how spam email looks like how
hammy looks like it learns analyzes that
whole data data means the collection of
information in this case you have a Spam
and Es spam and have emails that's the
collection of information you extract
the patches you understand that house
fam looks like how ham looks like now
once you have that I analyzed it now now
when new spaniel comes in you use the
model uses that analyzed or patterns to
make intelligent predictions on the data
which you have right according to the
question your according to the pattern
which a machine has learned that's what
exactly machine stores so now you might
have several questions by now I know it
first is again how to extract patterns
how machine extract patterns from the
data how machines analyzes the data how
machines make intelligent predictions
from the data and Etc
right so these are questions and in the
whole course we'll answer this we'll
answer this question answer this how
machines extract patterns how we analyze
the data how machines make predictions
from your data right so there are set of
mathematical as of now the answer is
their set of mathematical algorithms
that helps us to extract patterns
mathematical or statistical algorithms
it's from the data which we'll study
throughout the course okay
uh so that's an answer so let's go to a
more formal definition which I really
like by Tom Michelle and that's here's a
nice book I recommend you to read that
book really nice book
if Tom is still is seeing this I don't
expect him to be seeing this but hi to
him I'm just kidding uh here's my one of
my big inspiration and Machinery field
to get started with his books on machine
learning is really really influential
and his lectures as well so nice
a computer program is safe to learn from
experience a with respect to some class
of a task T and some performance P if
it's performance p on on task t as
measured by P improves with experience e
if you got this very nice if you know if
you don't that's totally all right
because I was also the one even in in my
middle of the faces I was not able to
understand this definition
this is by Tom Michelle okay so let's
understand this definition by this
flowchart which I prepared for you so
you have a computer program assume that
this is your machine learning machine
learning uh whatever you can come to
program what is model I've been taking
model name right so assume that model is
your machines as of now okay machines
assume that as of now I'm just taking
model just assume that as a machines
this is not having so much of jargons
so you have this computer program you
have this computer program that computer
program learns
from The Experience e and in this case
experience e is your data your computer
program they learn or analyze extract
patterns from the data for some task
the data is for for some tasks right so
for example if you have a Spam or ham
data which is a collection of
information of the spam emails and ham
emails so that's the experiences
available now the task was to identify
spam so that's what for that task
and that performance on the task is
measured by P so we measured the
performance and once we have the
performance we improve and that
performance is in being improved by
adding more data or adding more
experiences in that so that's what
exactly it says
hide highlighting the important terms
it's safe to the learn from the
experience e with respect to some task T
and some performance measured P if the
performance on T the task spam and ham
measured by performance if the measure
by this it improves to the experience if
if you increase the experiment
experience it will also be it it is
going to be improved so this is a
definition by Tom Witcher
I hope that makes sense another example
is Indian house price prediction Indian
house price prediction system so here a
task is to predict the house prices of
Indian states where you want to build
any ml system you need one of the key
ingredients which is data which is in
this case new experience
so your trained model which is your
computer program on the experience and
this is the EXP on the pass data which
is experience because password is
experience right and here past data is
your experience so the performance p is
measured how well your model is
performing on that particular task and
if you add more experience in the the
performance will be improved that's it
that's definition very easy now I hope
that you understood do it for other
applications very very nice practice
however if you if you want to do the
practice all along please enroll in our
official ml course as well as well as
you can also go um and review some of
you know uh
um courses available the the three LMS
which we ask you to enroll yeah
good so what are the steps done by your
machine Learning System so that's
something what are the what are the
steps for machine learning follows to
actually do this I know this is early
phase to talk about that that's
something is super important which I
want to have a talk hurt to her talk
with my viewers on this however if it's
okay if you don't understand it but I
won't just want to have a do a talk with
a very detailed explanation of
everything and then we'll talk about
data and then and after that we'll talk
about some of the applications and then
we'll
um talk about a very nice application or
the type of machine learning which is
supervised learning we'll talk about
unsupervised later on uh but as of now
I'll talk on supervise only so hey folks
welcome to this video in this video what
I'm going to do is to talk about some of
the steps uh which is done by usually
done by Machine Learning System so what
is the procedure what is the process for
going through uh for for building a a
good machine Learning System what is
machine Learning System the system in
which we give an ability we given
ability to a two two two to a machine to
be able to to learn from the data which
which means to be able to learn from the
data or extract patterns from the data
and make intelligent prediction so we're
going to make a machine a system what is
the process of that system where we
extract the data we analyze the data and
make intelligent predictions according
to what it has learned
so um now so what the like everything
for example while while creation of you
know maggies or any sort of short sort
of fools you have a processes so just
like that like well creation of machine
Learning System there's a processes
created or recommended processes which I
really want to talk to you guys so let's
get started actually with that uh so it
may happen some of you may not
understand the fully thing that's
totally all right totally all right if
you don't if you don't understand it
because I feel like it's it's something
which you might focus on things like
um definitions and the understanding
core and a Crux of what exactly each
step is doing as as there is a section
in cs01 course so the the the course
which I teach on Anton so there's a
section called ml Ops where I cover
these these things in great detail and
talking about several case studies and
all so if you're interested in something
you know learning in depth and all I
recommend uh see ESO one if you want to
learn something fully so now coming back
to this you have something known as
scoping so you have something like that
scoping and
what that's what does this scoping means
scoping is something like uh the first
step in your machine Learning System is
scope out the problem you're trying to
solve scope out the problem you're
trying to solve the first step is
scoping where you where what you do you
understand the problem statement and
write down or jot down the key
requirements for your ml project so
basically whenever you start off with
any sort of project or machine learning
project machine learning any sort of
machine learning project so what you do
over there
um you simply first of all understand
the problem statement right you you
understand the for example let's say
you're building a Spam or a ham
classifier so you have a system they
have a machine M you want to build a
machine M that that classifies whether
that is a spam or ham right so the first
step is scoping where you understand
what exactly this problem statement is
what what sort of data which you have
right what sort of data which you have
what are the key requirements like
requirements what is useful analysts do
you understand the problem statement
according to given by the state
stakeholders and the second step is you
understand key requirements like do I
require the how many data scientists to
work in this what what should be the
compute power of this what should the
infrastructure required for this
Etc so scoping out means getting a brief
understanding what this project will be
about and creating a brief plan of go to
strategy for working on this project
then after you have a brief plan and
everything now what you do you simply go
to the data part where you do where the
examples of the steps is now now once
you have the data you have to eventually
clean it we'll talk about data cleaning
and all in one of our project so when
you have the data
when you have the data you have to clean
this data you have to clean the data
your processes you have to process the
data in a good way and Etc so basically
what I'm trying to sell over here what
I'm trying to tell over here that given
the data you know you you want to you
know uh understand it you wanna to uh
clean it Etc so I think the and then you
have the data then you cross collect and
validate the data accordingly right and
then you clean the data where uh where
you have removing of missing values Etc
so I know that this say this will not
make sense if you're a beginner so it is
something like you have the very bad
data you convert that to a good data by
data cleaning and Etc you validate the
data whether that data is from truthful
resources or not whether we can trust
the data information or not
now we have the data now now what now
what we need to do we need to extract
patterns from the data and for
extracting patterns from the data we
have something like modeling
not something which actors do on a ramp
work but I think on this modeling
requires something like you know uh some
something like yo your your your shifts
your system tries to extract patterns
from the clean data which you have right
and then once you have the ones who
wants once you're done with modeling you
have now you're gonna put this you want
to put this so that your users can make
predictions from this model M so once
you have the trained model get it low
with learn to extract patterns so now we
want to make predictions for it for
example if this machine is of spam and
ham classifier so I'm going to put this
in production so that it is able to
classify so that every email can get to
this and the model is able to classify
in couple of stuffs which is spammer ham
so you know put this in production so
that it can be used by folks um in real
time and also we Monitor and maintain
our system we see like how our system is
performing what is the like whether a
system whether a performance of a system
is degrading or what what is the
possible errors which are coming what is
the etc etc so what is the wrong
predictions which are coming Etc so we
have to monitor our system as well so
there's four steps for any uh this photo
four to five steps of recipes of machine
learning where you first of all plan out
what exactly you need to do by
understanding the problem statement and
then you get the data and while getting
the data you have to validate whether
that data is from truthful resources and
clean the data in a good data and once
you have that good data now you model it
which means that you extract you learn
to extract patterns from the data and
now you have the model which which has
the patterns from the data it should be
able to successfully use it in the
production right and then and then you
have to continuously monitor it so these
are the steps for your machine learning
applications now
now let's talk about uh I hope that this
this makes sense but now now let's talk
about something known as data so what is
data so data is info is in information
contained in an structured or
unstructured format so um so data is set
of Records so you you might have seen in
your you know machine learning lectures
or sorry uh in your class eight or nine
lectures of computer science where you
might have gone through a data is a set
of Records right it's a records or set
of information available for the
particular uh product so for example you
have Amazon listing you have Amazon
listing let's say you have you have
Mouse right you have Mouse so that Mouse
might have several several data right
several data like what is the title what
is the description what is the price so
these are the
uh set of records for the particular day
Air Products so just just like that data
is in information
which is in structured and unstructured
format okay and
um what we'll talk about what is
structure and unstructured in a bit but
here's here's an example of a data where
this is the example of a structured data
where it is contained in a table where
this data contains the the it is the
data of house price prediction where we
are given the some of the information
about the house prices uh House housing
price data where we given the sum of the
information about house prices which is
first one is floor what is the floor
space how many number of rooms in that
apartment how what is the lot size is
there any other apartment attached to it
right Row House Corner House detached so
these are the information for a
particular house right
and this is the price and one thousand
dollars right so this is a price for the
for for this feature but this feature
this is the price uh for that particular
house then so we have the second data
point this is the this is the this is
the record for the second house this is
the record for the third house so you
got for the um this first house second
house third house fourth house fifth
house sixth house seven hours six eight
and nine house so you have the nine
thousand nine houses where for every
house is you have your own infos using
uh including pricing floor space rooms
Etc so these are nothing but uh uh these
uh these are nothing but your your data
where we actually have something uh uh
information contained right
cool so now what we do now what we know
what what you want to do is talk about
a bit of application uh in machine
learning right the first application
which we really want to talk on is a
loan protection system so if it it is an
application so loan protection system is
an application in which of machine
learning so assume that you are in a
banking sector you're you're in a
banking sector and and Bank provides
loans to the customers right so you
might have visited loans and also your
bank might provide loans and also the
customers who require uh rights so now
so now you assume that you are working
in a bank and then that that bank gives
loans to the customers who requires the
loans so when providing loans there's a
high risk that that that the person may
or may not return the loan so this case
that the person will not uh return the
loan back with interest right it it may
return loan back but will it are they
going to return back with interests or
not so given the bag down information
about the particular customer what is
the history of them like my salary
etc etc we've given those infos we're
gonna predict we're going to predict
whether we should give loan to that
person or not this is one example
another example is the spam hand
detection system where you promote
another example is Spam ham detection
system uh where you have where you given
an email you know a classifier that that
email is a spam or have
recommendation engine you might have
searches something like this which
you're seeing in front of you so this is
a recommendation engine uh in Google
searches or maybe recommendation engine
in your YouTube so these are a couple of
applications which you might have
already seen I don't intend to you know
just just to give you a feel about it so
I hope that you understood uh in a nice
way about a very good processes of
machine learning what I want to achieve
in the next set of video is talk about
the last thing of this uh to talk about
the last thing of this lecture is to
talk about supervised learning and
we try to learn super supervised
learning with a very Visual and very
storyline of examples so that anyone
even if a class 5 you will be able to
understand very easily hello everyone
um so now we'll talk about something
known as supervised learning and hello
everyone hello everyone we'll talk about
supervise so now we'll talk about
supervised learning and
uh we don't want to directly get started
with you know definitions and all I want
to tell you a very nice storyline a very
nice example relating into the Practical
stuff
so let's get started with that the first
is for is to understand the concept so
now so now whatever you're saying in
front of me is to understand the concept
for example for example you have assume
that you are studying a mathematics book
right so you're studying a mathematics
book and there you understand some
concept you understand some examples
a date so you understand something so so
you have a mathematics book you
understand you know some concept you but
you for example you have a quadratic
equation as a chapters you do some
examples you want to analyze some
formulas you want to analyze some
patterns for solving a particular
questions and Etc so now you have once
have the questions now what you do
you're trained with the text to your
train so now you understand the concepts
you're trained with the from the
examples and train for the exercise
questions with the help of Supervisors
so when doing exercise we are doing
examples you're analyzing the patterns
so you're getting trained with examples
and exercise questions with the help of
our supervisors so of course you have a
question and this you're also seeing the
solution if you're not knowing if you
are if you're getting error in that uh
question right you're not able to solve
that question so you seek help from
supervisors or whoever the instructor is
out there
so by now that our storyline is that you
understand some concept you get trained
from that examples you do also do the
back exercises exercise questions with
the help of your instructor and whoever
now once you're trained with everything
now you sit for an examination you sit
for an examination and in that
examination you're not you do you you
don't have any help of Supervisors you
don't have any help of exercise
Solutions you don't have any help of
answer sheets Etc right so you sit for
an examination and if you were trained
well then you will be performing well
otherwise you'll be not performing well
okay so this this was your uh this this
will be condition after giving the
examination so if you're if you are
trained well with the help of your
supervisors and everything you will be
able to answer it very well so now
now you can see that how you are trained
you will train the examples questions
where you're given question as well as
the answer to it so that you can
understand the pattern right in exercise
questions you have a question as well
the help of Super Soap supervisors which
is question around so you have a
possibility to see the answer right so
just like this you the your train with
examples and the questions now you sit
for an examination you sit and give the
examination and then that will predict
whether you're going to really
um pass the examination or not if you
were trained well analyze the question
well you will be able to pass and the
whole concept is nothing but called
supervised learning so let's let's talk
about what exactly supervised learning
is so in supervised learning you're
given the question as well as the answer
so that your model learns from it and
get trained from that
right so in supervised learning you're
given the question just like this just
like in this case you're in what for for
training for this particular child you
are given the examples and in that
example of the questions as well as the
answers right to uh to understand the
pattern so in supervised learning as
well you're given the question as well
as the answer so that your model learns
to analyze pattern from it
and then whenever you set for an
examination which is the new examples
you and if you if you were analyzed well
or if you're trained well you'll be able
to solve it right but now but now what I
want to do but now what I would really
want to talk is on something which is
which you which you might notice is that
assume that you have an example over
here for house price protection system
so you so you have an example of housing
price price protection system where you
want to predict the house prices based
on the given features so you know you
know you know you know invest in real
estate and you predict the house price
in the coming 10 years by giving the
following requirements for that
reports for that particular house so
this house number one is the house
number two it's house number three so
given this characteristics of the house
we are we under predict the price of the
house right given the characteristics of
this house we want to predict the price
of the house characteristics means what
is the floor space rooms and all given
all of this you want to predict what is
the possible price if you have this so
so now first of all we have to analyze
it right so any for every way before
sitting in any examination you have to
learn it right so you're in supervised
learning we are given the question which
is a predict as well as the target which
is the solution which from where we have
to learn it so your model sees the
question okay this is this is the
question this is the information given
in a question so any provide problems
has the wrong information right and they
ask us to predict something and also we
are given the solutions as well so
your model will find the relationship
between the price floors your
relationship between Solutions and
problems and analyze patterns from the
data right uh and then and then get
trained get get trained so over here
this solution the solution is acting as
a supervisor for this model for this
question so basically uh this will be
this is this is this is helping this is
helping your model to learn right if you
don't have solutions for example if you
sit for mathematic examination and you
want to prepare for it if you don't have
the solutions how will you understand
the pattern right so over here you
should have the solution you should that
that that that is called Target variable
right so you give some features based on
that the target which is price and then
algorithms learns from this and then you
give new examples which will be without
Target so now so now your model trained
on this now
you you want your model to set an
examination where you only give this
information you only give this
particular a question and then say Okay
predict the house prices based on the
given info say for example this now your
model will predict this price you don't
have to give this because now now now
it's our and now something will will
introduce to evaluation system where it
will check yes or wrong right which
which is the which is the task of an
examiner or a test Checker but as of now
uh once the model is trained we can give
only this question we'll have the answer
later on where the algorithm tries to
predict the answer
so supervised learning is the type of
machine learning in which models are
trained using well labeled training data
so labeled means every data is labeled
well right so this this particular
information is labeled well out here
this particular information is labeled
well outer right so you have the
question as well
the solution and machine learning tries
to predict the output
so here we mean labeled me so here we
mean labeled means what does labeled
means it means that let's say you're
working on spam or ham protection system
so for every email you every email for
example email number one you have the
label related so so that your model
learns right so you have the you have
the data you have something like this
data and for every email you have the
weather for the foreign first of all you
have to make it learn by the historical
data so you have the email number two it
is ham even number three is Spam so the
the the the label that label order or
the thing which are to predict
is given over here so this is what the
label is in machine learning where it is
label means that for every given input
feature in this case the email
we have to we have the correct we have
the correct uh label for that whether
that email was that and then we ask a
model to learn from this data right and
then and then after after more learned
we just say we we just only give emails
and then tries to predict what will the
possible outer from that
okay so uh super supervised learning
problems can be classified into two ways
so first ways is regression and second
ways is classification so we'll talk
about a classification regression in
detail this course focuses on regression
but uh if you if you want to learn more
about you know complete ml with earning
opportunities I recommend CSO one
you can go and watch that but uh in
regression in regression here here and
supervised learning problems can be
classified into two set of problems the
first problem is the first problem the
first problem is that your target
variable which you predict is continuous
values so assume that applications like
predict prediction
of house prices so in this house prices
you have your target variable your
target variable which is the house
prices which are continuous which are
continuous value so if you don't know
what is continuous discrete Etc you can
skip to the data fundamentals lecture
where I'll be talking about data
fundamentals in detail right so over
here here a Target variable which you
want to predict is continuous so for
example the house price your pricing
example is continuous right a revenue
prediction sales prediction Etc so these
are the examples of your regression
values right there you're very the the
problems where we want to predict are
the uh when you predict where the target
variable is of continuous value but in
classification our Target value isn't
discrete whether a person has a cancer
yes or no whether the person whether a
answer is correct or not yes or no
whether this is this true or not yes or
no so this is called sort of
classification problems in this course
we'll only deal with regression problems
if you want to know more about CM things
in real you can go to classification
problems however we'll talk about each
things in detail as we go
now I think uh this is something which
which we are done with whole machine
learning now you may think here use
various unsupervised learning where is
reinforcement learning this course is
intended to make you inclined towards
the learning the core stuff of it so
I'll just give you the idea what is
unsupervised learning is and so while
learning in which you don't have the
solution you only have two you have only
have to make this loss any sort of sense
of logic from out of the data and then
get the prediction anyway so in
unsupervised learning you don't have any
sort of supervisor in this case in this
case in this case you don't get any
examples you don't get any questions you
just don't get any help of Supervisors
you just strictly sell an examination
and then you have to learn from it you
have to analyze the questions and then
make a pattern sort of it right so
that's what answer revised which is the
most challenging today and most of the
work is being done in supervised
learning but uh but unsupunt
supervisoring is very challenging but uh
that's something we'll take a look at
later on right that's something which
we'll take a look at later on at the end
of this course but I want you to stick
with as of now is with supervised
learning and let's try to learn the core
of supervised learning and master it hey
everyone welcome to the another module
which is linear regression so what we'll
try to achieve in this module is we'll
try to learn in depth about a linear
regression we'll try to understand each
and every concept so the table of
contents and everything is already
introduced to you so I hope that you
know what you're going to learn so
before starting up this video I would
like to talk about the two terms right
now is to talk about linear and then
talk about regression as this course is
only based out of you know machine
learning code and linear regression so
we'll talk about only these two terms
which is linear and regression
separately so what is linear linear is
something which
which is which which is like a straight
line like you know so you you might have
seen linear graphs where it is just a
straight line right and then what is
regression regression is or a sub
problem of your machine learning you
know it's it's it's it's it's a sub
problem of a supervised machine learning
uh machine learning task where your
output variable is by output variable
where your output variable of your so
the output variable or the Target baby
build which you want to predict is
continuous what is continuous we have
already seen in our previous lecture on
data fundamentals so continuous means
the height of the person if you're
predict the height of a person you
predict the stock or a stock of a stock
of the particular company or if you want
to predict anything which is which is
which is uncountable or I would say
non-finite or
something which is continuous like
height a uh height age Etc but there's
this discrete where if your target
variable discrete where you have a
finite number of possible outcomes over
there then that's a classification
problem so we are going to approve
approach regression problem outer
regression problem out here using one of
the one of the algorithms called line
iteration so now one of the now you
might have seen in our definition of
machine learning that we use
um that that we how we how we extract
patterns from the data so this is one of
the ways we are going to study one of
the ways for extracting patterns from
our data and then this sets a very nice
base so once you have this you you'll be
easily able to learn logistic regression
and other things but if you fully want
to learn I suggest cs01 cores for you
which is the best for you maybe
yes so let's get started eventually and
let's try to talk about what are the
things which is needed out here cool so
over here you're seeing something known
as
um we use ml for estimating or
establishing relationships between two
variables so that's something that's
very confusing so I would like to take a
time to make you understand what exactly
I mean by that so over here over here
what are what I exactly mean by that is
that assume that you have
um you have that you're working on
something like let's let's take an
example that you are working on cancer
you're you're not you know predict you
know predict whether the person has a
cancer or not you know right so so you
know predict whether person has a cancer
or not so you're given them you're given
some of the information about the person
so you're given about the the B BMI info
person which is blood which is BMI and
then you're given the weight of the
person you're given the height of the
person so you're given these three
features these three features you're
gonna predict
he ought to predict whether the person
has a cancer or not I know this these
features are not enough but bass assume
that based on this hypothetical
situation based on these given features
you're going to predict whether that
person has a cancer or not
okay so how we're going to approach this
and how exactly we are going to uh take
up from here so one thing which I just
want to tell you is how how we are going
to approach this like why how can we
relate this to establishing
relationships so you have these feature
you want to predict whether the person
has a cancer or not so over here you
want to establish a relationship between
every feature you have so you know to be
honest you establish a relationship
between these these two things whether
there is any relationship between BMI
and cancer whether BMI has any effect on
the person is having cancer so if BMI is
high whether the person is having cancer
ba BMI is low the person is having a
cancer so we have to you want to
identify the relationships out of it
identify the relationships or something
like I identify any sort of you know and
any sort of
um uh you know the
any sort of relationship between uh over
there
out there so you know establish the
relationships in
um in various like you know the BMI and
the cancer or maybe establish a
relationship between feature number two
which is weight of the person and the
cancer so does weight of the person
affect whether the person has a cancer
or not does does this particular info
affect whether a person is going to have
a cancer so over here what exactly we we
use ml for exactly identifying that
exactly the same thing we use ml for
establishing the relationship with this
particular feature is going to affect my
output variable in this case where my
age or weight or BMI will affect whether
I have a cancer or not okay individually
like this feature the effects or not
this feature if it's if yes then how by
what units Etc so these these questions
are answered so we'll take a very nice
problem statement to make you understand
this particular statement
which would be easy for you so let's
take an example your marketing
strategist a data scientist for a
company and basically this is what the
data scientists do eventually have the
marketing team would have the decision
team to take certain decisions or
marketing team to take some certain
marketing steps so you prepare a
marketing plan for a car company so you
have a car company and then you prepare
the marketing plan how does marketing
plan should be there for car company or
to help the marketing strategies out
there with your data driven decisions
so manifold of the first is a
manufacturer of the car so so you're
given these particular infos about the
car the features about the car right so
you saw you're given these one two three
four four information about the car four
features of the cars and based on this
how to make a marketing plan okay so
your make a marketing plan so in what
way the marketing strategist asked you
as a data scientist asked you that tell
me which info we should highlight out of
all these infos in our main ad so when
you make our when we make our main ad
which info out of all of this we should
highlight so that we make maximum of
sales for that car understanding what
I'm trying to say what I'm trying to say
that there is a marketing team sitting
out there you're a data scientist out
there they ask you that out of all these
features can you recommend me which info
which info I should I should take and
show it in ad so that I have a most of
the market uh most of the sales okay
and just I don't want the prediction I
also want to know the following
questions so marketing's team is setting
and asking asking this question so what
are those questions question says is is
there any relationship between N4 that
particular information the car so is
there any relationship between the
manufacturer of the cars and the sales
so of course as you think that let's
assume that manufacturer is BMW
but but it may have like there might be
a very nice relation some it may happen
that the brand manufacturer of the car
is high but the sales might be low
because the brand is super highly
expensive right but if you have
something wagonal or you know low budget
the brand is Tata you know Tata Motors
and all so they produce less expensive
so the sales will be also very high so
the manufacturer of the so we have to
understand is there any relationship if
yes then what a relationship is
available between both of them and that
answer is how strong is your
relationship between that particular
manufacturer and the sales you do for
every model of the car engine size
horsepower right so what is the
relationship between a horsepower and
the sales so it horsepower is high what
is the sales if low what is the sales
right if if engine size is highs size is
highs what is the sales if the inner
sizes though what is the sales
Etc
which info contributes to the sale so
which information sometimes it may
happen that this that that any
particular information may not
contribute to may not have any effect
that does not really make sense just
like in prison pigeon example which is
senseless
right how accurately can we estimate the
effect how accurate we are in estimating
the effect of each individual features
each individual features on our output
variable y
and is the relationship linear between
both of them and what exactly we say
that the relationship is linear which
means do they follow the linearity or do
they follow the the straight line
convention so what is linear things
which are you know in straight line or
something in any in any straight line it
should be linear it should not be like
this right it should be uh linear so you
might have studied new lower classes
about that so I hope that this gives you
a very nice sense about you know uh we
use ml for estimating relationships in
the next video what I'm what I'll try to
achieve in the next video what I'm
trying to achieve is I don't know what I
want to do is to work about geometrical
understanding is to work about
geometrical understanding geometrical
understanding right sort of work about
geometrical understanding of our
regression so we'll actually go ahead
and then talk about how we can estimate
the relationship between features and
outcome variables in easy way so let's
go ahead and talk about that
so now we'll talk about something which
is now now once we and now we have
studied about you know he this is how we
asked this is what we have to do this is
what ml is about estimating
relationships so let's start talking
about how we estimate relationships
between variables
right so let's let's get started and
actually talk about that right
um so over here what uh so now uh before
going on that let's talk about what what
it What does it means to say that data
is linear right data is linear what is
it what does it mean so data that can be
represented on a live line graph right
it's a data which can be represented on
a line graph and there's a clear
relationship between two variables
between two variables is a clear
relationship between two variables that
the that that the graph can be shown on
a straight line so there's a clear
relationship with you which which you're
saying and one unit one unit increase in
X is showing a constant increase in y
right that's what the data is said to be
linear you might have studied in lower
classes Just For Those Who would know
who who just want to recap I just told
about that
this is an example of a linear data this
is an example for linear data this is an
example of a linear ignore the lines as
of now okay ignore the lines as of now
just go just go about the just go about
the data which you have out here just
just go about the data so you see that
the data is linear if the data would
have something like this you know very
uh very random you know there's not
showing any clear relationship there's
not doing any clear relationships
between between variables then it might
have not been this is called a nonlinear
so data is linear over here
and over here over here assume that this
is your data assume that this is your
data so now assume that this is your
data we're on x axis we're on x-axis you
have something like the number of years
of experience so you're going to build a
system so uh let's let's formulate a
problem right now you want to build a
system you want to build a system that
predicts the salary of a person given
the given the
um
years of experience of a person so given
the the years of experience of a person
you know predict what to what will be
the possible salary so if the person has
a two years experience you have such
such number of salary so you are given a
data in a CSE and a CSV file load you
give give given a data in an Excel sheet
and in that data and in that data you
have something like this uh record and
your you have one information available
which is the years of experience and
assume three and there is the label a
Target variable we're going to predict
the salary which is in let's say five
right which is in 5K dollars five k five
thousand dollars to ten thousand dollars
whatever per year
according to Indian market
um so over here you have years
experience and the salary of that person
right and this isn't a 5k okay so if
there's five over here that means five
thousand okay so uh and then you have
the data and then you plot this data
over here now you plot this particular
data over here because you have only X
variable you have only X variable and
then you have y so you know you're given
X you're gonna predict y out here right
you're given X you're given X you're
gonna predict why right so I just want
to talk about one of the thing which is
super important right now is is this
something known as functions
conscription to functions so in
functions what we do in functions what
what we do in functions what what we do
say for example that this is a function
which X squares the number which square
is the number so this function takes the
input value of x take the input value of
x and outputs y
and outputs Y which is a square of X
right so when you plot this function
you're going to plot this function this
looks like a parabola this this this
looks like a pattern this this is a
parabola okay so X and then f of x then
it takes the it takes the input value
does some processing and Returns the
square of it Returns the square of it
which is a square right so in this case
we want to tell we're gonna We want to
build a function f so we're going to
build a function f we're going to build
a function f we're going to build a
function f that takes up your Builder
function f that takes up years to
experience of a person that takes up
years to experience of person and map
this which we call this X in this case
the input value the the thing which
you're going to input to the model like
give this input for example in cancer
prediction we will give the input like
BMI weight agent to give input and then
as output we're gonna We want to predict
what will the salary of the person
that's the output out there that's the
output out there which is the salary of
a person so you this this does something
so this does something with this input
value and then returns you the salary so
now so now we're gonna build a function
now I'm going to build this black box
thing this this this this thing out here
this particular whatever processing that
does with the user experience so we're
gonna build that you know for for
building that we wanted to learn it's
the algorithm called linear regression
where it helps us to building that
particular processing that takes up your
input feature X and does some processing
and returns some values file
okay so so how do we learn that function
f that takes the value y um es expense
and Returns the Y so let's start off
with the geometrical understanding so
assume that you have the data plotted
over here on x-axis you have years
experience and one y-axis you have uh
salary of the person so this is the data
which you plotted this is the data which
you plotted I hope so that you know data
plotting at least given the tables
you're given the tables out there you
should you should be able to uh plot
data out here very easily right so when
you plot this data out here when you
when you plot this data out here we've
brought this data out here now you look
the ignore the black line as of now you
plot this data now now your what what
you do you find a straight line you find
a straight line that best fits the data
that best fits the data you try to try
to find the line that best fits the data
so why do we find the line that best
fits the data right that's a good
question right so assume that assume
that you wanna you have
um
four years of experience your four years
experience so what what will be the
possible uh salary of yours so if you
have the fourths four years of
experience forced to experience the
actual value states that the actual
value states that you will be having
somewhat like you know
um I think eight eight thousand dollars
for a new right but your model so so
basically the intersection from X and
the in the intersection point so
basically the intersection point is this
is this point so this is the
intersection point and this intersection
point is your is your is your model
approximation model approximation so
let's talk about what exactly this model
approximation means model like
proximation is something like your model
approximated so this is there is a there
as as we say for example assume that you
have you have you have your examination
and is the examination similar questions
comes or exactly same question comes
right so it might happen that your
approach might be different from the
books approach
it may be similar question it may be
similar question so you answer
differently right so you over here don't
exactly answer the same thing you
written differently for example in
science exam in science exam you don't
write exact exact the same question
exact the same answer there is some of
course the your you have a proximate
answer right not exactly similar to the
original answer notice actually or
similar to the bookish answer but
similar to that so if someone asks what
is photosynthesis you might ask you you
might write your answer in different
language but the original may be
different so there's there should be
some difference between both of the
answers okay so in the same way if
someone says that someone asked a
question what is the sale what is the
salary of person with the US experience
for where they ask they give the years a
four
we have some processing done and then it
results in some values
okay and as of now we are trying to
understand the geometrically how it
should work if someone asks what is the
what is this idea if if the person has
the four years of experience that says
that if if if I ask what is this year's
experience when when when when the years
experience is four
it says that the the actual answer is
this the when actual answer is this
actual answer is this with original but
there is the force the difference but
there's of course the but the actual
model approximated this this straight
line as of now this is straight line so
as this is a straight line so we found
the straight line that best fits the
data okay so we found a straight line
and then we go gone and see okay this is
the point of intersection and this is
your model prediction this is your
function approximated value not exactly
same but similar to that the small
difference between bulbots and then
right
okay so now you may may have served
several questions please don't worry
we'll tackle each and every question in
detail
okay
so let's start tackling each and every
question in detail now over here what
you've seen is that assume that this
particular information and this
particular information so there is of
course the difference there's a model
approximation and your actual actual
value so what is the difference between
model approximation to Natural value as
I again told in Science examination for
a particular question there might be
different answer but concept is same but
different answer right in their own
words in bookish language but you might
have different answers in any other
language so there's of course a
difference so if the difference is high
that means the concept is not same so it
will so your your examiner will match
your answer with the original answer and
if the difference is similar then that's
good but if the difference is high this
this the the dissimilarity is high then
the answer is wrong because you might
have written in when you when when you
were told to write the photosynthesis
you you came and write written something
like
um respiration right so that's that that
will be wrong right so I think that's
that's a very very good example State
over here so now your the actual answer
though someone asked about
photosynthesis so actual answer is the
bookish answer which is so correct which
is 100 correct we call that thing as a
ground truth and then you you return
that is a student approximated answer
that that student might have written
some answer so we we match both of them
but take out the difference how how how
similar they are if the similarity is if
the Sim if if the similarity is if this
if the similarity is less that means
that uh that the answer is correct but
if the simulator is high that means oh
that something is away right that
something is wrong that they have
written as respiration instead of
photosynthesis uh chemistry is the
something never mind so this is what the
difference between model approximation
so in this case only your model says
that for this much for this much of
experience this is the particular uh
value of this particular salary but your
actual value states that this but
there's a difference so higher the
difference
but why did I say that best fit line but
why did I say this specific line so why
did I say this best fit line because for
example assume that your line is like
this which does not best fits the data
which does not fits the data well so now
if you have four years to experience if
your four years of experience you have
four years of experience
the model approximate is that
intersection point which is nothing but
which is nothing but four four thousand
dollar but actually but actually it was
six rights so the difference is high so
the difference is super high right but
but actually if you see that this is
your actual value so this is your actual
value right this is your this is your
correct answer but this is your model
approximated value this is a moral
approximate value right so what there's
a difference between so over here
there's a small difference but over here
it is a bit large difference so that's
why we want to find the line which best
fits the data so now for example
so now for this so now for example
assume that you go to this line or or
the and this is the best fit line which
is out there which is in over here but
assume this this line we have four years
experience we have four years of
experience this is but actually the the
correct the correct uh the correct is
this one so of course there's difference
but this particular but this particular
line which best fits the data right
which best fits the data uh where we are
using that uh to make prediction right
so now I think you gotta you got a way
to
um approximate your values you got a way
to approximate your values now now let's
worry about let's talk about
um
in detail okay let's talk about in
detail what exactly I'm trying to tell
is why exactly how exactly we got to our
answer so what our problem was our
problem was that we wanted to extract
patterns from the data basically going
to learn from the data and make
intelligent predictions so we're gonna
find the best fit line that means
learning that find that best fits the
data for example you want to learn your
you know to train your mind that best
fits the uh
the concept the best fits the concept
and around that concept you utilize that
concept and that's called hypothesis you
utilize that step to further make
prediction to further make predictions
or to further solve the question so in
that end just in this way only it first
of all it first of all makes the best
fits the data best fits the data by a
straight line it should be linear right
it should be linear in a straight line
and then it best fits the data and then
we can use this best fit to see okay if
we have currently we have only one input
value if there is more then there's a
several things but yeah
so given that you can just go go and
then this is the point of intersection
so this is your y value which is in this
case the Y values on Y axis so we simply
predict that I hope that it makes sense
if it does not please review the lecture
again and again and if you still don't
please go and review the concepts of
Class 8 and 9.
okay uh why to find the best fit line
that's a good question about why exactly
we want to find the best bit line
um so I have given a very very nice
example out here which I've just
described to you
so now uh you might you might have
question on how do we find this best
straight line how do we find this best
fit line so let's try let's go ahead and
let's try to find this
um how exactly we go ahead and find the
best fit line so so now you might have
question okay now we have the data like
how can we find the best fit like the
first the first solution in your mind
might come that we can plot our data on
X and Y excess and then use our drawing
skills to draw best fit lines so you can
simply say and draw like this and then
draw best fit line but the major defect
is we cannot really make predictions
from that so how can you make exact
predictions from it tell me this won't
defect how can you tell give me the
exact protection you cannot give me the
possible exact prediction you can just
still approach I've just told over here
proximated right not exactly the same
what model approximate just approach are
you sure approximated that's the first
effect and the second effect is what if
if you have more than one features in
information for example currently it's X
and Y only where you have years
experience to predict the salary but
what if your ears experience the
designation the skills the ratings Etc
so for Access four input values you want
to predict one salary so this is a
multi-dimensional thing you cannot
really plot a straight line that's the
first that's the first solution cut
where you cannot use the joining skills
to draw a straight line which the best
fits the data so how can we get this a
straight line so the second solution is
that as of now let's go ahead and talk
about only one only one thing which is
which is you know you you you're only
given only one information which is X
which is the year's experience when you
predict the Salvage that is only one
so how can how can we uh do this so
second solution might arise that you
might have seen this in your early
classes Y is equals to MX plus b
why is it this is the equation for any
straight line so y equals to MX plus b
is the mathematical equation for a
straight line where M indicates the
slope of the line and B B indicates the
intercept of that line slope means how
much y changes when X changes and
intercept B which is the y-intercept
which is the y-intercept where your line
cuts at y right if you don't don't know
about the concept don't worry I'll just
speak I'll just recapsulate uh a little
a little bit on this so what exactly
slope in this example so slope in this
example states that how much my salary
will change
how much my salary will change if my
years of experience will change that's
the slope that's the slope which says
how much your y changes the salary
changes when X changes that's a slope so
M over here is your slope and M is also
the coefficient of your x and x in this
case is a years experience plus the Y
intercept where at exactly your y
intersects and y y intercept is one of
the major thing because we will talk
about bias term later on but over here
if you have this Y intercept over here
if you've then white recept also plays a
very nicer so over here this is the wine
this is a varied white cuts on the
y-axis
so now there's one interpretation which
we can get from this that if we are able
so this particular line is fully
dependent on this in these two
parameters only these two parameters can
change this line right only slope
because X will be anything right but but
m and b determines how this line should
be
the slope and the volume step so if Y
intercept is different it should be like
this it should be like this and slope is
different it should be like different
different shapes so that your your
straight line your best bet line depends
on the slope and the B which is the bias
though so a straight line is dependent
upon slope and the Y intercept so if you
are able to find if you are able to find
the slope and the best interferent in
intercept that best fits the data we got
a new line so very interesting very
interesting uh um an analogy
is why I am saying that they are
dependent why I am saying that we are
depend that our straight line is
dependent for example so you have you
have you have this data where I plotted
the very small small amount of data and
in this example uh and in this example
assume that we have this this particular
assume that we have three three
different best bits lines let's go with
the first one let's go to the first one
this over here our slope is different
and y intercept is different that's why
R it is not perfectly fitting our data
so now we tweaked in a way that we
changed we changed the slope and The
Intercept we got to this it okay okay
fits the data
but over here which again changed and
seen that it it is also it fits the data
very well right so so you're all use a
straight line is dependent upon m and b
so if you're able to find the best slope
and the best y-intercept for the
particular data which you have you will
be able to to
um
to have the very to to have the very
good line to have the very good line
right that's a that's a nice analogy I
hope so that you're getting whatever
time you tell is I'm just trying to tell
you that you want to get the best M
which is the slope
and the best bee because it determines
your values
it determines your X values
right so I hope that this this gives a
sense that our so if you're able to find
m and b we will be easily able to get
the best fed line I hope that this makes
sense
okay
I don't need to again repeat it again
and again so this is a very dummy
example which which which you're seeing
in front of me uh is about is is about
horsepower and sales so so you're you're
given the horsepower of a car you're
given only one information as of now as
I said will only go with one information
so you're given the horsepower of the
car the RSI based on horsepower what is
the sales for the car right you know you
are identify that so to find the best
fit line that best fits this data so if
you plot this data it should look
something like this so if you plot the
data we have to best fit data so
sometimes you don't need to really draw
make your grass you to you know draw you
know find the tuition you'll find a
straight line or linear equation
um not linear equation yeah so the the
straightly straight line equation that
best fits the data okay
so your build is function f your build
this function app that takes in
horsepower
and then and then thus and then multiply
and then you have multi and then you
have the straight line equation which is
used for use which is used for making uh
predictions so we need to build a
function f that Maps your X which is the
horsepower to the sales establish a
relationship between both of them so
here we are multiplying with M with X so
that we can say that m is will will come
will come to that but over here we want
to we want to give the function
horsepower and multiply a horsepower
with a slope which is how much how much
how much how much uh why how much house
horsepower how much sales changes when
horsepower changes plus Y which is your
y-intercept which is y-intercept where
it intersects on Y axis so now you might
have questioned that how the why we
multiply and how does this affect the
output so when we multiply what effects
does it goes on output variable what
effect is Y intercept gives to the
output variable that's something we
should talk about in interpretation of
our coefficients later on but as of now
you can get that that this is the
equation where you put in the values of
X you'll get the particular value
okay you can see over here that let's
let's assume your slope is three and
intercept is 4 which is dummy as of now
if you take our function so now this is
a function like this now you have built
your function I've built your function
you built your function built your
function so you simply give the value of
x and then get your answer
and the regular prediction which is
number of sales which you'll get
okay
so um now you might have service now now
you might have uh several question right
now like how can we find our best mnb
like currently we have just taken a
dummy example so how can we find best
mnb what exactly this mnb contributes to
the uh sales what why exactly we use
that first of all at first place why
exactly we use it Etc that that can be
will that will be answered in later
phases as you go but as of now what I
just want to tell you you have got to
know the very nice geometrical
understanding of linear regression and I
hope that you will really uh utilize
this to recapsulate the concept so if
you want this nose you can get that from
my website you can also enroll in the
course which I'm teaching in fully ml
Pro which is from teaching from baby
Basics to earning opportunities
Etc so I hope that you will enroll in
that let's catch up in the next video
so folks we are going to continue our
journey on regression analysis so in the
previous lecture we had a talk on the
some example and we have shown that how
each like we have m and b and how this m
how horsepower has its own weight and
then we have an intercept we have talked
about this if you haven't seen my
previous video please go and see about
that so our main idea was how can we
find this main M and this intercept
which we usually call as B okay so my
question was how can we find how to find
these two terms because your best fit
line depends on this m and b only right
so basically that that was the basic
question that your best foot line
depends on this so for if you want to
get the good fit line then you need to
find this m and intercept which is a
slope of the particular variable how
horsepower and The Intercept of that
particular variable so I hope that that
makes sense now what what you exactly
going to do we're going to study about
how can we find best m and b for your
data which is the eventually in other
words best Straight best fit straight
line in your data right so what was the
POS what is the sum of the possible way
which we can think of so over here what
is one of the possible way is to hit and
trial different different values of m
and b and see what works well right so
for example for example in the in the in
this example you understand you're gonna
use the you know build a function f that
takes the horsepower as an input that
takes the horsepower as an input and
predicts the number of a sales so if you
want to promote your car with that
horsepower what is the possible number
of us is where you're gonna get right so
you're going to build a function f that
establishes the relationship between
your horsepower of a car and the sales
right so you know predict how how much
sales would be done if the if we
actually use the horsepower as an or how
much sales are based on horsepower what
is the relationship between them right
that is the one question out there but
what I want to convey is that over here
for for building let's assume that X is
a horsepower you have MX plus B and M
for for finding the relationship right
so here over here m and b we need we
need to find out so over here you you
cannot just plug anything like we have
seen that if you plug anything we are
going to we're not going to get a best
fit line so what can we do we can we can
try out several values of m and b so we
can try at 1.1 or the and then some 1.2
and then with these values given the x
value we took in test how well these
values are by plotting it on a straight
line like this so um we plot on a
straight line and see how it performs by
hit and trial right we first of all
perform like this and then the next what
we do is we conduct another we try
another value and see if you're getting
the best fit line so you've got to what
eventually will do you will try several
set of m and b right and then you will
try to plot the best fit line or the
plot that equation and once you plot it
you will be able to see okay this is the
best way I know this is not so you'll
plot and see how is it the best fit line
right so head and trial different values
and see what works well but it has
several problems the first problem is in
it will be very hectic it will be very
hectic and time consuming and time
consuming okay first thing second is
what if if you have a 3D or 4D um in
higher dimension of data right you might
have you might have higher dimension of
data and you may not be able to plot
every time and then see right so in that
in that real world data will not look
like this it will have a millions of
examples millions of input features
right so uh we exactly want to talk on
uh that so we cannot really plot and
then see against right so that second
one is it will be very hard for us to
eventually plot the data and see every
time So eventually hectic and time
consuming so we need to cut that
approach out what's the next approach we
have an optimization algorithm which is
based on this hit and trial only which
is based on this hit and trial only but
we do it very strategically you learn
how we do it very strategically using
mathematical process right so I hope
that will make make more sense when I
actually go into this now so let's let's
see let's see how to see what works well
right so how to see what works really
well so over here as of now we have seen
that we can use optimal optimization
algorithm to come up with that so uh but
before that we need to see how what
works will and what not then we can come
to this optimization problem so if we
want to see the graphical problem like
over here we have two sets of data so
the first set of data has this this this
data and then you plot the best fit line
and this is the best fit line available
for your data and over here you you you
don't have the best line so this this
particular this this particular equation
is wrong but this particular equation is
correct but why because in this
particular equation has a best fit line
or this particular line uh fits the data
best and this particular line does not
fits the data valve right so that is one
of them now over here you can see that
over here you can see that it is not
fitting the best fit line so what is is
that and what is the conclusion we're
trying to make is if you want to see the
best headline which I've already seen is
will will be this but by now we are only
seeing or we are only telling by seeing
the data we are only seeing uh we are
only telling how is this the best fit
line is the best fit line by only seeing
the data but data will be you know you
have only the horsepower as of now now
there will be lot of a lot of input
variables for example you may want to
establish relationships you know you may
want to establish a relationship between
maybe horsepower and then you know on a
on another one which is the brand of the
car you know the social media you know
engagement of the car and blah blah blah
I'm going to find the relationship where
all of these three to a particular
variable sales so we have to find you
will be getting three Deals we'll learn
about this uh multiple uh multiple
linear regression soon but you will see
that we will have three dimensional data
even four dimensional five dimension of
data right but it's not always possible
to plot it will always not get only some
100 200 300 or you'll get millions of
data points right you cannot plot
everything right you cannot plot and
then see that how it's performing that
is a graphical method for General
understanding it's not for something
which you have to do in real world but
sometimes it also comes in handy if you
have a small amount of data but
eventually you'll have to deal with
numerical way right so for example when
you plot the when you when you plot the
line you can for example assume that you
have a equation x f f of x is equals to
x squared so the the the graphical will
look like this the graphical is Parabola
the graphical is Parabola but you cannot
eventually use this Parabola nicely to
get your answers for larger values you
know for larger way for subset you can
do for two or three you can do but what
if one two five nine nine and nine so
you cannot even do that you cannot even
try to use this Parable to do that you
can eventually do that but it's very
hectic and very not possible sometimes
it's also not possible right so in that
case what you will do you'll utilize is
numerical way x squared f 2x is equal to
the function numerical this is the
function this is f of x graphical way
and this is the numerical way this is
the numerical way right so we'll go with
the numerical way your plugins go one
two five nine nine and then you just one
two five nine nine times one two five
and nine you just squared this and you
get it exact value and then you'll get
it exact value right so just in the case
of linear regression okay we have the
graphical best fit line to from at our
data but this graphical line is
represented by a numerical value which
is MX plus b we need to utilize the
numerical as well I hope that you
understood why the importance of
numerical is given over graphical
graphical for understanding as well so
now let's come to numerical
representation that works really really
well over here which is which you're
seeing in front of me is that you have
some data points out here so assume that
this is your one data point is another
this is another this another this is
another so you have some data points out
here if some data points out here right
you have this blue points are data
points in with labeled examples so this
data point has x value this and Y value
this this report so it has the labeled
example y as well y as well please note
that we're dealing with supervised
learning algorithm and we should know
that this is the part this has y right
cool so over here assume that assume
that your X is equals to 24. okay your X
is equals to 24. your predicted would be
assume that this is a straight line you
plotted the best fit line you plotted
the best fit line so this is the best
fit line which you have in your data
right and then X is equals to 24. this x
is equal to 24 if you just see if you go
above it will this is actually the this
is actually the ground truth this is
actually your label value but over here
this is what your model predicted
because model will predict at the point
of intersection the point of an
intersection is a model prediction right
for example if we say x equals to 20 x
equal to 20 would be gone gone gone gone
gone and here it intersects right
because we don't have any example we
don't have any x equals to 20 a label a
layer or data point in your data but
over here the reason why you best fitted
the line so that we can predict like
this and then if we if we see the Y
value there are 45 as the prediction
right this is how we make sense but over
here but something but let us assume
that this value 24 for 24 your true
value your ground truth means true value
for example what is ground truth you
have a score you have scored 45 out of
15 years test scores this is a 45 which
is the correct value which is the truth
but your model predicts that you have
scored 57 out of 50. so this is your
this is a predicted value or
approximated value and that was your uh
45 out of 50 is your ground truth 45 is
the ground truth so over here as well
for this particular Podium X1 for this
particular data point x equals to 24 x
is equals to 24 so X is equals to 20 4X
x is equal to 2024 your predicted value
your ground truth is 38 right for
therefore x equals to 24 but the model
prediction Lies over here at the point
of intersection so when you just go over
go above you see the point of an
intersection over here and the model
predicted value is nothing but 47.
right so actually the correct value for
x is equal to 24 is 38 but your model
approximated or predicted 47. so of
course there's there's some sort of
Errors you know for example you might
have noticed that when you're actually
worth in class 10 DNA you know when
actually DNA copying is done there are
variations right there's some there are
some errors so when model approximates
it comes with errors as well right so
those errors between approximator and
correct value 38 is the correct value is
and third 47 is the approximated or the
model predicted value the model what
what model thinks what model thinks x
equals to 24 and what model thinks
decided by the straight line right uh so
that's why we say that best with line
freely works for best fit line we need
to have for a line we need to have a
best fit in the data then it will
perform very well right so the
difference between the predictive is
approximated and the actual value the
correct value which you call as a ground
truth is called Nothing but residual or
difference of Errors right so it's
called residual or difference of Errors
let's take a look at another example by
taking a look over here so assume that
assume that you have this particular
data point you have this particular data
point assume that this one this one so
over here you have X is equals to maybe
12 and when X is equal to 12 your your
your correct value your correct value as
well as your correct value the blue
point is ground truth as well as your
moral prediction lie on the same point
which means y i which is a ground truth
which is ground Truth for x equals to 12
and Y hat I which is your which is your
model predictive value are on the same
point which means that they both are
equal and assume that the models is that
you will have 1200 samples 1200 sales
your model predicted to 100 sales and
actually 200 Sales was done which means
that a model was perfectly accurate your
model is perfectly accurate right so in
this case the error will be equals to
zero error will be equals to zero
right so I'll take one example to make
you understand assume that you're
working on you're working in a date as a
data scientist and ask him stop and over
there you want to predict you're going
to predict based on past data you're
going to predict what will be the number
of a sales Fund in the next day so your
model says that there will be 200 Sales
next day right but actually 200 Sales
was done which means they are on the
same point so over here with x equals to
12 then a y hat is equal to 37 and when
y i is with 37 and Y hat I also has got
37 which means both are equal and the
residual between them is equal to zero
let's take a look at another example
when your X is equals to 24 when your X
is equals to 24 over here your the
actual the blue point as well as the as
well as the predicted value is on the
same point which means that you predict
it as well approximated is r equal
let's take a look at another example
when your X is equals to let's say 29
you have
you have this as the predicted value
sorry this has a correct value which is
a ground throat and this as your
approximated value this this has an
approximate a value this has a correct
value I'm not so the this the difference
between both of them is a residual so
your correct value is little bit more
than the actual predicted value so what
predict value is nothing but the point
of intersection when we drop on the
x-axis I hope you are getting what I'm
trying to say I'm just trying to justify
that that the difference between the
ground truth as well as the approximated
value nothing else I'm doing I'm just
trying to justify that okay let's read
something for x equals to 24
approximated more operative is 47 but
the ground rule is 38 so the error term
on error between Y and Y hat which is
why hat means which is approximated in
ground truth is nothing but 9. so the
error term is nine higher your error is
better approximation is what does this
mean high order error is in bad Deb
approximate is for example assume that
you are in an ice cream shop and then
you pre and your model predicted 1200
sales which which will happen the next
day since the 200 Sales will happen but
actually only 400 sales happen so the
difference between you know for example
you're giving a match test right you
write a very different steps right to
different different times a very
different answer rather than the actual
answer so you're absolutely wrong right
you should be at least close to it when
you're giving a Science examination you
written something you written some texts
which is the actual which is the your
answer which you think is answer and
there is a correct answer in a marking
scheme right there's a correct answer so
your your what you what your teacher
will do your teacher will match with
this if the error is so much in this is
so much the the difference between so
much then the error is bad so that the
bit difference between the why why I and
Y hat or sorry y hat i and y i which is
the moral which is the actual value and
there's a more applicable value if the
error between in them is high then
battery approximation is why I have
given you a very simple example one
example is ice cream shop which is 1300
and 400 so error between them is very
very high
right and that's why we don't have
that's why the higher the error will be
that your approximation will be right so
I hope that makes sense about this
higher error and bad approximation is
but what we can do we can for evaluating
how well our lines are but why are we
learning all of these things the reason
why we are learning you know R and Phi
how well this line is for based on
numerical representation by seeing if
you can tell okay this is good but
numerically we should be also be
verified right so what we do we do for
every sample which we which you have in
your data right so what you do for all
these Blue Points you take out the
difference of Errors for all these data
points for example for example y1 which
is this y one my y hat one minus y1
which is equals to 9 right which is
equal to 9. so you taken out for the
first for the first one and then you do
for the size second one y two y two so
if you see over here Y2 where is Y2 yeah
this is Y2 so this is your predicted
value this is your predicted value and
this is your ground truth so the
difference between them is 44 which is a
predicted value minus 45 you get minus 1
right so this is the this is the
difference between predictor and the
actual value right and then you have per
Y3 for Y3 you have difference of Errors
where you have y 3 which is the actual
value and the predicted value which is
minus 4 and then you have y 4 and where
the predicted actual value are on the
same point you have 0 and you do for all
the data points okay this this blue
lines and blue points are nothing but
the data points these blue points are
nothing but the data points right so you
do for you calculate the for example
what you do eventually so let's take a
scenario to make it little bit more easy
to understand right
when you actually let us assume you have
10 problems in an exercise 10 problems
you have the problems one two three four
five six as well as you have the
solutions so what you do what you do you
make your own 10 Solutions you make your
own 10 Solutions based on the questions
what you have learned you you make your
own 10 Solutions right and these
Solutions let us assume that this is
your name is model and you approximated
this or predicted these Solutions now
what you do you match it with this you
match with the correct Solutions given
in your book right so higher the
difference is bad your answer is right
well that's what we are doing over here
to evaluate how well our paper gone is
we we match each and every Patriot value
with that respective correct value for
example question number four we match
the question number four with question
number four the correct answer as well
as the so we just match and check how
where it is and we give our mark space
on that so just like this for evaluating
how well the best vet line our are we
just have this straight line line and
given a straight line employee we
evaluate more operations minus the
correct value for all data points
available in your data right we do not
do for data points for data points which
we don't have any label for that for
example we cannot do for uh assume that
uh we cannot do for let's say two we
cannot do do for let's say two right we
cannot because we do not have data point
for that but we can do for the maybe
even seven right we can do this because
we have the prediction over here and
then we have the model practice the
correct value over here okay
I hope that makes sense and then you
then you take out for and then you have
a n number of errors or we can say e
number of Errors Eis so you have e
number of Errors e will be equal to the
number of data points which you have in
your data right so it will have the E
number of Errors how N1 minus N2 and the
one denotes y hat I and N2 denotes y i
and then you have negative values as
well somewhere so there are two issues
which we come we have m n we have
several number of Errors how can we
combine all of this into one single
number to better describe our model and
then second one is some of our error
terms are negative so you can see that
they some are negative right so what we
do to take care of this so we can solve
the problem we have the negative sign we
can get rid of by two processes by
squaring the number or by taking out the
absolute absolute of that in absolute of
that number absolute of that so for
example you can we could simply take out
the absolute obvious whatever the answer
which integer the absolute or the
squared absolute or this Square so
Square will just cancel out as well as
absolutely we will just cancel out so we
can we have two approaches either Square
to the differences or absolute
differences so what we usually we what
what we will usually do is we are going
to use the square of the number I'll
talk about why we are not using absolute
but there is an apps we also use
absolute as well but I'll tell you later
on we'll just wait for my confirmation
for some for some maybe next set of
sections and then the first problem is
all negative we can either use any any
of the approach to fix the negative sign
but but even after fix it we have
certain number of M number of Errors m m
is nothing but equals to the number of
data points and every as I said your
error should be equal to number of data
points because the difference is where
because you'll be only to your only ask
your model to take out the answer you
ask your model to take out the answer as
uh for the questions which we already
have the correct answers so that we can
match and test how a model performs so
what we can do we can take that average
of M terms we can have take out the
average of all the errors E1 E2 all over
e m but then what we can do we can put
that in a submission format so that we
come up with the formula so formula is
this 1 by m summation I equals to zero
all the one or the M4 every Eis we take
other every errors hence the expanded
Formula 1 by m i is equals to zero all
the way out of the m so you do so you go
from I equals to all the way out of the
M right y i y hat I minus y i squared so
over here you're taking out the
differences and differences you're
squaring that up and adding the another
I equals to 1 then I equals to 2 and
then I equals to three so please note
that you have already studied the
summation format right so how it will
perform for example assume that you have
a date you have a data point you have a
data point something like this where you
have
one two three four five right you have
one two three four five so I equals to
one is equals to I equals to I equals to
zero I equals to one other M right so
you have y one y one minus y a y one
that's quick right so you do for y
equals to one I is equals to two I is
equals to three I is equals to four is
equals to five so you do for every data
point for all the and for all the detail
points in your data you add a squared to
remove the negative sign and then you
app and then you have the approximation
value by uh sorry the difference of
errors this is called the residuals
which you will get and we divide the
value by by all the summation all the uh
sum by m right I hope that this makes
sense this this formula makes sense so
this formula should make sense to you
you know people usually learn these type
of formulas but it's eventually what
you're doing you're just thinking of the
differences of the multiplicative value
and the actual value is squaring it up
to remove the negative sign and then
you're taking and then you're taking the
average of all of them you're taking the
average of all of them
and this comes up with the name of cost
function or we can say mean squared
error for evaluating how well our best
fit line is
how well our best fit line is we will
work on a worked example
so why is it useful first it is way to
evaluate the best fit line it measures
the performance of our model so higher
the MSC is badder model is why because
higher the MSC will indicate that
differences are also higher so as I said
that if the differences if the
differences are higher then it's not a
good model right we had to talk on that
right so this is one of them this is one
of the key criteria which you should
know so it is way to evaluate the best
fit line and this is way to measure the
performance how well so higher the error
is battery so you have to make sure that
your cost function is approximately or
is or around zero
so now we come up with the more
conventional formula which is J of m and
b so basically we're evaluating our m
and b is equals to 1 by 2 m i is equals
to zero all the way out of the m y I
have minus y i which is the difference
of headers off you take the average but
what is 2 over here what is 2 over here
what is 2 over here it's because of the
convention but usually people say
because of convention but eventually
when you learn about this optimization
algorithm which I was talking about
which I was talking about this too
really helps in getting written when you
actually do the calculation stuff you
know sometimes researchers find an easy
method to easy to calculations and these
two really helps in that optimization
algorithm we'll see how this helps when
you actually derive the formula but as
of now you can just remember it okay now
to recapsulate what what we have studied
recapsulate what you have studied is
what we can eventually do is that we can
take out the differences between more
addicted and actual value moral
predicted and actual value and then
Square it up to get rid of negative sign
and we have several values now now we
have to Simply divide the term or by the
number of values in your data set which
is take out the average of them higher
the error is that your model is because
the higher the different it will
showcase the higher the differences is
right but there are two questions now
why we don't use absolute
and what is 2 what is the 2 over here
what is the use of two over here and we
will talk about the real reason of why
we don't take out absolute and why we
don't use two over here right why why we
are not using ingredient descent or
optimization section tool so let's
quickly work on a verb example of mean
square error that will make more sense
so you have your height over here you
have your height over here and then you
have your weight over here so basically
given height of a person you're gonna
predict you want to establish a function
f that takes the height of person and
then predicts what's the weight of that
person what's the weight of that person
right so given this height and predict
the weight
right so now over here you came up with
this you came up with 0.8 X which is M
plus 9.0 which is B so you came up with
these with these formula so as I told as
I told that you have your uh now what
you do you will put in the values of X
for the known for the only axis for
which you have the known label right or
the data points only and you may figure
how we came up this zero point is 9.2
it's because I just randomly written it
because I want to show you not how we
get this but how we evaluate its
performance okay
so what we do we have 0.8 we have we
have zero zero zero point eight which is
over here multiplied by this 43 plus 9.2
which is you just exchange the value of
x every time 43.6 44.5 for every values
for every excess values now now what we
do we compare the correct value and the
model approximated by the correct value
in a model approximated value correct
value and model like rocks correct model
correct model we take out the
differences errors okay we have these
errors out here now what we do first of
all we Square all the terms and then we
sum it all up and then divide by m which
is one two three four five five and then
6.08 is your square error so when you
apply this formula you will get that
okay so basically what we are doing over
here is nothing but taking out the
answer for every axis and then comparing
with actual answer
okay cool I hope that this worked
example of Ms really helped and
everything is pretty much Crystal Clear
let me know if you have any questions in
the descript Community or in the comment
box and try to answer each and every
question now what you're eventually
going to do is talk about the
relationships talk about relationships
in terms of mathematics not in terms of
life because I pretty much stash up in
relationships and life so please ignore
I'm not good advisor on relationship in
life but I'm good advisor on how can we
establish relationships okay we'll talk
about the definition of relationships
we'll talk about some rotational changes
and then we talk about how to find that
beta0 and beta 1 which I've been waiting
for a long time we have several ideas
they build from a plain English language
and then we go to a level but prior to
this I would suggest that you're pretty
much comfortable with derivatives the
geometrical understanding of derivatives
as well as a bit of you know formula and
rules and derivatives it will really
really cool so now what we need to do is
get started with a bit of next sections
about relationships till then I'll talk
later
so now what we're going to do is talk a
bit about relationships relationship is
one of the most uh important thing to
talk about because usually people tell
you know establish a relationship or
establish a relationship and blah blah
blah and eventually you you get confused
what exactly this term the relationships
means
so we have even just clear about that
what exactly this relationship means so
that it makes much more sense out of it
right so over here whatever what I'll
try to do is tell you what exactly the
relationships are tell you what is that
relationships are and then I'll I'll
tell about two types of relationships
which is deterministic relationship and
second is a statistical relationship and
why we want to focus only on statistical
relationship over the course right so
let's talk about what exactly the
current thing which is studying right
now the current thing which is starting
right now is a linear regression which
is a statistical method that allows us
to summarize data and study
relationships between two quantitative
uh which is the quantitative variables
which is that type of continuous
variables so we have seen it that
supervised learning supervised learning
has two types of problems one is
regression problems and another one is
classification problem so we have two
types of problem classification and
regression problem in terms of
regression problem how can we identify a
problem is regression problem if the
target variable or the thing which you
want to predict the thing which you want
to predict the thing we're going to
predict is continuous is continuous data
or is continuous data or some sort of a
non-countable or non-finite or something
which is continuous like the age of a
person the height of person the salary
of a person they are the con their
example for continuous value so if the
target variable is is is of con is of
continuous data then
um then the then it then we known then
it's it's known as the regression
problems then it's known as the
regression problem right
cool so linear regression is a
statistical method we'll talk about what
exactly the statistical method means
that helps to summarize data and study
relationship between two variables now
you you may ask hey ayush what do you
mean by study relationships and
summarize data so you'll study you'll
you'll understand more practically later
on but assume that you have a function
here function f of x your function f of
x that tells you that tells you about
the the price of a house in a certain
area given its size right so you are
given a size of the house so you're
given the size of the house it will make
you it will make you it it will predict
it will predict the price of the house
this is the output variable which which
you wanna get right so given the size
you know predict the price of the house
right so what does this F tells F will
tell you f will establish the
relationship as F will tell you about
what is the relationship between these
two right it will tell you what is the
relationship between these two right
that's that's the first thing which the
tries to answer this and second it will
summarize by how if we increase size by
this much by some unit then what will be
increase in price so if we make price if
if we increase size by 10 units what
will be the increase in price right
that's what it tells it's it tells you
about the relationship it tells you
about if one increases what will happen
to another right they will study about
interpreting the coefficients soon
interpreting the coefficient so but
that's what the that's that's that's
what it uh conveys that you have
um
uh relations between two quantity
variables where you have a particular
over here which is it tells you about
the two uh quantitative continuous
variables or the features okay so assume
that assume that you wanna predict the
sales of a particular car given these
particular features so you know build a
function f
that takes the manufacturer that takes
the model that takes the engine size and
that takes the horsepower that takes all
these four field input features and
predicts the sales of a particular car
it predicts the sales of a particular
car so basically we we we tell okay this
is a manufacturer this is more of the
guy this is the engine size is a
horsepower and predicts the sales so how
this function f which it will eventually
help us the function f will tell that is
if if we how this manufacturer is
affecting the sales how this model car
is affecting the sales how does engine
size is affecting the sales and
horsepower is affecting the sales so we
can figure out which of the following is
affecting more of the sales like if we
focus more on manufacture then for
example assume that model of the car
affects the sales the most so we can
focus on model of the car a model of the
car to Brand it up to get more sales
right because this is this is generating
more so the sales for us or if this is
generating then we can focus on
showcasing engine size or begin to go so
focus on showcasing device power or we
can focus on showcasing manufacture
according to our analysis that's why I
say it helps us to summarize and study
relations between these variable and
output variable y
okay
so these variable which we give as an
input are called explanatory variable or
independent or predictor variable okay
or value so why we call this as an
independent independent or predictor or
explanatory first of all every each
individual feature each into each
individual feature or variable are
independent of each other for example
this particular variable is not
dependent on this manufacturers is not
dependent on this for its own existence
model the car is not dependent on the
engine size for its existence horsepower
is not dependent on the engine size for
this that's why you call the independent
but this particular sales variable is
called the dependent because this this
is something which you're trying to
predict we cannot predict sales if any
of these variables are not here
right so sales is dependent on
manufacturers sales is dependent on
model the car for its own existence
right
um you know I I hope so that that is
clear there's something to be removed
over here that this is not the predictor
let me just remove this maybe it makes
more more sense yeah so now this is this
is a response or dependent variable this
is a response or dependent variable
explanatory variable means it itself
explains it like it it is explanatory by
itself manufacturers we know that what
are the card that's why it goes
explanatory variable right or
independent I hope so that tip mixture
you can see our data fundamentals
lecture for more info
cool so the algorithm let's first talk
about what is an algorithm algorithm is
in step-by-step procedure is in
step-by-step procedure to solve a
particular problem and we and we have an
algorithm in machine learning to study
relationships and summarize data so I
hope that this gives you good sense of
what this various examples we have a
talk okay so there are several types of
relationships which you can come across
first type is deterministic relationship
deterministic relationship so you might
have coded in Python that you have
forecoded a function in Python that
converts Fahrenheit in so your DF code
in fudge that converts Fahrenheit to
Celsius right so you have code in Python
that converts Fahrenheit to Celsius
right so that is the deterministic
region why I am saying that is a
determinist relationship the formula for
converting your Celsius to Fahrenheit so
we can build a function f that takes in
the value of
and that uh for the that that function f
is a fatter nine that dates in the value
of c and nine by five C plus 32. so this
is this is an example of a deterministic
why it is deterministic because you can
simply plug any value of C you'll get
exact for X you'll just you it will just
be converted into fahrenheit so there is
a defined relationship already there for
F and C so if Celsius is this much then
it will just calculate things up and get
you out of f if you know the value of C
if you get the value of C you can easily
get the value of f exactly okay
because this is already defined formula
which we have this is already defined
relationship which which we already have
and it is linear sort of thing for
example if if your cells is 0 then your
Fahrenheit will well well with this if
your Celsius is 10 then your uh then
your value will be also on Y axis which
is the Fahrenheit so you if you know the
value of C you plug in the value of c
and then you get exact F other examples
are if you want to calculate the if you
if you calculate the the
the area of a circle which is pi r
squared right or Pi d right so this is
one this is the area this is a defined
you plug in the value of pi and diameter
you get the area right 1 by 2 times BH
Define relationship you plug in the
value of B and H you get the value so
these are defined relationships right
this equation exactly describes this
exact these equations it exactly
describes the relationships right plug
in the value it will multiply with some
factor and then except and then are you
it to a a to 8 will multiply the C with
some factor nine by five and then add 32
to it right and is the exact or defined
relationship between the two variables
and this also defined relation between
the two variables right but in machine
learning we are interested in
statistical relationship right in
statistical relationship with the
relationship between two variables are
not perfect please know that
deterministic candidate and statistical
indeterministic your relationships
perfectly defines the particular uh
variable between two variables but the
statistical it does not perfectly
defines it okay
I hope that it that that is much more
clear so you know find so one one such
example is you're gonna find a
relationship between skin cancer
mortality and latitude right so you want
to find you know find what is the what
is the what is the relationships if the
if what is the ratio between latitude of
a particular country and skin cancer
mortality so if latitude increases
whether it is skin cancer decreases or
increases this is a question right this
is a question so this is the data which
we have this is the data which we have
on x-axis we have the latitude at the
center of a state on our y-axis one on
y-axis we have mortality deaths per
that's per 10 million this is the
mortality rate this is a mortality rate
and this is your latitude
and all the blue points are the data
points now what you did you you you
model the your straight line on this
which best fits the data and that
straight line is of this where your
intercept is 389.2 minus
um I think yeah yeah that this this this
this particular thing is bit wrong over
here this this should be yeah so which
is three three point three eighty nine
point two minus 5.98 X where this is uh
assume that this is your
um straight line this is your straight
line okay this is your is straight line
out there this is your equation for this
straight line this equation for this
straight line I hope that it makes sense
and this is the negative relationship
this is a negative relationship first of
all we'll talk about the positive
negative relationship and further on
later on but uh but as of now you can
see that this this equation is defined
by this
um this to stay straight line defined by
this particular equation now how can we
interpret what is going on over here how
can we interpret what is what is going
on here so assume that you can see the
higher lat altitudes of Northern us the
less exposed you did due to the harmful
rays of the sun therefore the Lesser
risk
nevertheless risk so let's uh let's
figure out it is saying the higher
latitudes of the northern us higher
latitude means oh over here High higher
latitude which which are going to the
the right or the side then you then this
uh 45 to 50 so higher latitudes higher
latitudes means your legs exposed to the
harmful days of the Sun so when you go
over when you when you go this side in
the highlights so if you see there is no
data which suggests which suggest that
any any uh values of cancer mortality
right cancer mortality is it there's a
less or even for Town whatever there is
a less not too much not too much 150
there is nothing but on so if you go to
the right side road or the more the
higher the altitude is less the more
mortality therefore less the risk okay
but over if you go over here down 35
there is a lot you know there's a whole
chunk of uh information out there or the
mortality rate out here okay so I hope
that this gives a good sense about it so
but over here you can see the
relationships are not perfect sometimes
over here there is this much right but
the relationships are not perfect
because we don't get exact value we get
approximated value but will not get
exact value so if you if if if you have
seen over here if you have seen over
here that we have that that we were
getting some sort of residuals that that
we were getting some sort of residuals
right so your model has approximated but
didn't got the exact value this is
called the exact value but your model is
approximated and the model has
approximated it
ok so I hope that this gives a good
sense about what is why exactly it's not
perfect it shows some Trend it is
showing some Trend as we go to the SVS
increase the latitude your cancer
mortality date is it in decreasing okay
and it also shows the scattering
relationships you can see that all the
data is a scattered and it's the
scattered relationships so as you can
see that this is this is what the
statistical and over here over the
course we are going to talk about state
of modeling the
statistical relationships okay cool so
if you are interested in finding the
statistical relationships so now now uh
we'll some we will summarize what
exactly we studied after changing some
rotational changes so that it makes
sense in the next lecture what exactly
we are going to do if we are going to
talk about how can we estimate the
coefficient how can we estimate that m
and b in that equation so you have X is
y equals to MX plus b how can we
estimate m and b by giving you some
rotational changes and then we'll talk
about how what is the interpretation of
that m and b in different terms and then
we just and then we'll just recapsulate
whatever we have studied so that it
makes much more sense and then we
finally go on understanding how we can
get that in simplest terms
so everyone uh now what you're going to
do is we're going to talk about a bit
about how can we estimate m and b what
are its interpretation what is this
interpretation what is this
interpretation like what exactly it
means and Etc after some rotational
changes
so yeah so first of all what are we
given with so you so you're given the
data so you're given the data X1 then
you have y1 so basically it is a
supervised learning problem so you have
input value as well as its label y1 X2
Y2 X3 Y3 all the way down to the x m y n
so you have particular input value
according with with with these labels X2
with this label X3 with this label so
you so you're given the data and we try
to find the best fit line based on the
given data which we have that best fits
the data that's our end goal so why best
fit line a very nice question to tackle
why do we want the best bit line right
so line which best fits the data have n
errors and they're small as possible in
overall sense okay so be on a fine so we
wanna find a line which have n number of
Errors which are n number of errors and
there's small as much as possible
overall sense well so what does this
mean overall sense in overall sense
means that we have n number of Errors N1
N2 N3 N4 N5 n6 N7 n8n9 right so this is
the this is the so over you can see that
we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve so we
have a total number of error 12 errors
so 12 means when we take an average it
should be very small so overall means
average so it should be as small as
possible and then and then we can simply
and then we can simply approximate by
going off from the x-axis at the point
of intersection that is the Y that is
the that is the coordinate which
contains y as well and then we get a
production y okay so we have a way to
achieve it by least quiz criteria so
least release quiz criteria is something
which which will study as well later on
but we have a way to achieve it which
will study later on but what you can
ignore this as of now so this forms the
best fit lines so our equation for best
fit line X1 is m x i plus b so let me
just make sure that this is something
this is something which we should ignore
yeah uh so which is H of X is equals to
MX plus b m x plus b this is the this is
an equation you plug in the value of x
and then you get a prediction and then
you could get a prediction for the
straight line so our goal is to find
that m and b right
right so we can evaluate our best fit
line using our MSC only Square criteria
so we can simply evaluate evaluate our
best value line one by two m
I equals to zero all run out of the m h
of x minus y minus y squared Why are we
squaring because to to avoid the
negative as we are taking the average
and adding 2 as a convention but will
but we'll see why this two really helps
while uh in latest pages of gradient
descent we'll talk about that but you
can assume that as a convention but
we'll talk about really we will talk
about that why is that two because I
think this is important to talk
um so you can use simply use this
equation to take out some errors and
higher the error is where your model is
so you use MSE to calculate how your how
you are performed so how you're good at
errors if error is small so errors
depends on the straight line
so if the straight line is bad like this
is like this is a this is something
straight line this is your assume that
this is your data and this is a straight
line so this is this straight line is
bad right so your errors depends on
straight line and your straight line
depends on two values m and b right
because this particular this particular
value has its own Y intercept and has
its own M so B and M right it has all so
it is dependent on M which is the slope
and a y intercept B the slope and The
Intercept so what we want to do we're
gonna We want to reduce our errors right
so if you want to reduce our errors what
we should work on we should work on
straight line we should work on getting
good straight line and if you want to
get a good straight line we should work
on what we should work on in getting the
good values of m and b we should we
should find good slope and Intercept in
order to minimize m and b that with you
in order to minimize your cost function
to find mnu so in a fine m and b that
minimizes your cost version which is yo
you have a cross version J of M B which
is equals to 1 by 2 m i equals so J of M
comma B uh 1 by 2 m i equals zero all
the one out of the m h of x minus y
squared so Square for negative sign
average Tower and 2 4 as a convention
so to find mnb that minimizes the cost
quench so what are its notational
changes so what are its notational
changes so again to to to repeat your
summary we we have a hypothesis
hypothesis give some error like to now
here but now we say it how how the
hypothesis is this we get some error and
then we and then the error depends on
straight line the straight line depends
on m and b so the final good slope m and
b together and if you get the good
straight line it will automatically
reduce the error a whole story is
represented on a screen
I hope that this gives a good sense
about whatever I'm talking about so
let's do our goal is to minimize this
particular thing which is J it's it
should be J I'm so sorry I'm very sorry
some of the um I'm I'm very sorry about
this about sometimes you get you you
have a bit of you know on errors and all
you can definitely put in a Errata page
we can fix this up right it will be much
more helpful if you help us to complete
it okay so what are some of the
notational changes so over here right
now we are using MX plus b as of now h
of x h of x equals to MX plus b as if
now for as for our prediction function
what we can do we can assume we can
assume B to be beta0 and M to beta1 okay
these are the parameters so why are we
doing this the reason why we are doing
this in industry in Industry you will
see mostly this beta 1 and beta0 and
also it will help us to be bit more
clear about you know
industry or the online articles so when
you go to online article you make sure
you're comfortable with the beta 1 and
beta0 sometimes instead of beta 1 and
Theta 1 and Theta 0 or sometimes you
have some other notation but we'll use
this beta 1 and beta0 so over here you
might assume why are not we taking M as
a m s beta1 Ms beta0 beta0 but as as a
convention we always take we always
start off with our bias term B B beta
which is B plus m x so B is assume beta0
plus beta 1 times x right
okay I'll just make sure about this so
your M becomes beta 1 and B becomes
beta0 okay so we can write beta 0 plus
beta 1 x that resolves that is equal
equivalent to B plus MX
these are the parameters but the meaning
stays the same beta 1 is nothing but the
slope and beta0 is nothing but your
intercept so now there are other names
as well so over here over here when you
multiply 2x 2 is 2 over here it scales
somewhere it scales your X right so 2
over here is a phase of weight given to
this x just like that X has a weight we
have a feature which is X for example
the horsepower horsepower has got in
weight what's first gotten beta 1 or we
can see even in this case horsepower X
has gotten weight M so in this case the
horsepower Garden uh weight beta 1 and
beta0 is intercept or biased we'll talk
about what is this bias term means later
on but this is a y-intercept okay from
where it should intersect at y axis
I hope it it uh gives you a good sense
about it cool so I just want to talk a
bit more about uh these things a bit
more on your uh hypothesis uh so your
hfx is equals to beta0 plus beta 1 x
right and beta beta 1 is a feature
weight and X is a nothing but your uh
but your uh but but beta1 is nothing but
a coefficient of your feature or the
feature weight or a parameter beta0 is
also intercept we core by convention we
have beta0 x 0 plus beta 1 x 1 or we can
say beta B times x 0 plus M times X1
okay so what does this mean they both
are equivalent but but we are going to
use a new notation which is beta0 X 0
plus beta 1 x 1 okay or you can say b x
0 plus m a m x 1 both means the same so
I'm going with the beta 0 x 0 plus beta
1 x 1 by conversion x z is not but
equals to 1. so whenever you multiply
anything with one it just remains that
number so beta0 so that's why we write
beta0 alone plus beta 1 x 1 okay so we
have so we have x 0 to be equals to 1
right so that's why we don't usually
write x 0 okay so I hope that you
understood will uh it will be more handy
when we'll talk about multiple linear
regression we will finally understand it
but as of now just keep in mind that we
have did the bit of rotational change
everything Remains the Same just our
notational changes introduce beta 1
instead of M and beta0 instead of B
all sorry makes sense I hope so that you
that that you understood about
relationships in detail uh and now you
can you can easily ignore uh there's a
direct formula but I just want you to
ignore it because I don't want you to
focus on that uh I hope so that you will
not focus on that now what we will do
we'll talk about we'll talk word so we
have a hypothesis h of x h of x equals
to beta 1 times X1 Plus beta0 so this is
your hypothesis so what does this beta1
represents what this is beta0 represents
in terms of you know predict the price
of a house given a size you're given the
size of the house so size has beta 1
times the size of the house plus beta0
so what this beta 1 represents or how
does this beta 1 affects your output
variable if you introduce B beta 1 how
does it affect on your output variable
and what is beta0 effect on your output
variable we'll talk about that later on
so everyone we come back to our next
section of our video which is talking
about uh which is talking about
um interpretation
enter
production of coefficients of
coefficients parameters or slope and
intercept both all mean the same so
usually just just to make a remark just
to make a remark over here your f i i
sometimes use f of x is equals to V
beta0 plus beta1 so function of baby on
a builder function f f that that Maps
your X to your output variable uh h f x
means the same and Y so they both they
all mean the same eventually at then
you're taking out just an output
variable y right this you're taking the
dependent variable right so all mean the
same value interchangeably just to make
sure that you are on the same page so we
are going to use this uh this this the
particular formula uh eventual equation
uh where it's going to take out the Y
which is the dependent which is a
dependent variable and beta0 is an
intercept term and you have a beta one
is a coefficient of x or feature weight
of X or we can say slow okay
and so now so now so now let's start
talking about so now let's start talking
about about what is the significance of
your beta0 and beta 1 in terms of
problem statements that that will make
much more sense that that will make much
more sense so let's get started now so
assume that so assume that let's start
talking about beta0 so beta0 is nothing
but call The Intercept the Y intercept
the Y intercept term the Y intercept
term or buy a storm
by the septum and the biostore so this
is what the beta0 is so what this is
beta 0 represents what does this beta0
affect the output variable how does it
affect the output variable right so
beta0 represents the value of y when X
is equals to zero when X1 is equals to
zero so your beta0 comes into play when
represents the value of y beta0
represents the value of y when X is
equals to zero so when 0 multiplied with
beta 1 that will be nothing but beta0
plus 0 so Y is nothing but equals to
beta0 that's the first scenario when
beta beta0 really helps is when x is by
chance if when X is not there whenever
when you don't have an information we
just go with the Baseline this is what
called This is known as a baseline this
is known as Baseline so when X is equal
to 0 when X is equals to 0 then when X
is equal to 0 then your Y is equals to
beta0 so that in other words The
Intercept of the regression line with
the y-axis okay so which means which
means this comes into play when X as X
is equals to zero okay
and it's also The Intercept it's also
The Intercept it's also The Intercept of
the regression line on y-axis so it's a
y intercept right so if beta0 is
positive if beta if beta0 is positive so
let me just make it clear so if beta0 is
positive is beta0 is positive if beta if
beta0 is positive it means that it's it
means that the equation line starts
above the y-axis above the y-axis which
means it's it's above the y axis of over
here something like that but but if it
is negative then it says below the
y-axis so you know uh it's it's like um
if if your y if if your uh intercept is
positive if your inters a bit positive
it will stay some somewhere over here
but if it's negative then it will stay
somewhere over here right so that's one
of the that's one of the property so
let's take an example to make sure that
we better understand this like uh to
what exactly when x equals zero so
suppose suppose was going to build a
simple linear regression model where y
represents the price of a house and X
represents the size of the house so you
know build a function f that takes in
the size of the house and and predicts
the price of the house so the Builder
version F right uh you know window
function f that takes a sign and
predicts the price so beta0 beta0 would
be the price of the house so so this
equation will be modelized beta 0 plus
beta1 X1 so beta 0 would be the price of
the house would be the price of the
house when X is X is equal to zero so
beta0 plus beta 1 x 0 which is which is
beta zero zero multiplier beta 1 is also
of course zero so beta0 would be the
price of a particular house
when price of particular house when when
the size of when the size of the house
is zero when the size of the house is
zero or nothing okay that's when the
beta0 comes in play that's when the
beta0 comes at play so let's take a very
simple example let's take a very simple
example to make you understand one more
thing so assume that that that that you
want to predict uh the the application
is predicting
exams course exam scores predicting exam
scores so in a build a function f that
takes in the number of hours you study
number of hours you study now what was
the r study and predicts the exam
predicts this exam scores of that
particular child so that's that's the
basic uh that's the basic function and
you and you build and you build a
fortune we'll talk about how we come up
with this mnb later on but to build the
function f of x which is nothing but
equals to beta0 plus beta 1 x so f of x
number of our study which is equals to
assume that your beta0 is 60 plus
um plus beta 1 is 5 and X so we have
just taken random one we are just taking
random number for a second for example
talk about how can we take out this
beta0 beta one later on but just assume
that you're taking the random one right
so over here over here your your
intercept term your intercept term is a
number 60 and your and your coefficient
is nothing but uh uh uh the five as is
as this five so so your beta0 is 60 this
means that if if this should if the if
this shouldn't have been studied
anything if the student haven't started
ending which means it goes to 0 60 plus
5 times 0 is another 60 so if storing
has not studied anything at all which is
a in with that is equals to zero the
predicted X exam score would be nothing
but 60 would be nothing but 60 which
represents the average which which is
nothing but the average score which is
nothing but average scores of students
who do not study who don't don't study
so 60 is nothing but the average score
of the students who don't sell that it's
a bit higher but that's what the beta0
represent beta0 represents the situation
when your x0 is nothing but equals to x
x 1 is in nothing what equals to zero
which means that that in this example
the person has not studied at all or in
on a previous example the size of the
house is zero which means the average of
the size average house of the price when
size of the house is zero okay I hope
that you understood what exactly this
beta0 means if this beta0 means and it
uh yeah it it makes sense but in case of
sometimes video that does not make sense
but it acts as a biased term but it acts
as a buyer's term the average term uh
that's very well this is a bias as well
Okay cool so we have studied about beta0
now let's talk about beta1 now now let's
talk about beta 1. let's talk about beta
1 in in predicted so beta1 so beta0
represents so when X is X x is zero but
beta 1 is the coefficient of x right
beta 1 is a coefficient of x so we are
multiplying x with something beta 1 that
means it represents that how the how
this beta 1 will affect this output
variable y so it says that it is
repeater one represents the change in y
for one unit increase in X so if X
increases by one unit what will be the
change in y that's what the beta 1
represents that's what the beta 1
represents beta 1 represents what the
change in X the change in X the change
in X for a word sorry the change in y
the change in y what how how much y will
change if we increase X by one unit
let's take a very simple example let's
take a very simple example to make you
understand about this for example if we
have a simple linear regression model
where y represents where your particular
y represents the number of hours of
sleep a person gets okay the number of
hours you're going to build a function f
you know you want to build you want to
build a function f that you're gonna
build a function f
now in a bit of the Builder function f
so let me just clear this so over here
we build a linear version vary on a
predict the number of hours a person
will sleep the number of hours person
will sleep uh the number of hours the
person given given that then given beta0
plus beta 1 the number of a cop then the
number of coffee cups the number of
coffee cups like the the problem
statement is going to predict the number
of hours the person will sleep given how
how many number of a coffee cups he has
drank okay that's that's the function
which you know uh me so if you have a
simple linear Vision model where y
represents the number of R so y
represents the number of R's a
particular man's lead we divided this is
the number of ask and gets it with the
sleep a person gets and X represents
your X is nothing but the number of a
copy cops a person had right then the
beta one represents the beta one how
this is how what does beta 1 Test B data
1 represents the change in hours of
sleep for 1 cup increase in a coffee
consumption so if we increase the coffee
consumption by one hour what will be the
change in number of hours of sleep of a
particular person okay I hope that your
understanding over here the number of
coffee cups assume that number of how if
we increase if we drank one more coffee
what will be the effect on this output
variable that's what beta 1 says about
it that's what beta1 says about it let's
take a look at the previous example
which which we had so the example was
the predicting service exams course
we're going to build a function f that
takes in the number of study hours the
particular person predicts so beta0 plus
beta 1X 60 plus 5x so now we have now
now we don't have x equals to Z now we
don't have that that is worth a beta0
but now assume that assume that um
what this is beta1 Tells over here beta
was tells that for every additional hour
of a study if we increase X by 1 or
which is one unit which is every
additional hour of study
X increases by 1 the predicted score
exam score also increases by 5 increases
by 5. so this P this 5 represents the
rate of change in Y which is the exam
score the rate of change in exam score
what will the change in exam score given
the given there is one unit increase in
x one unit one unit increase one
additional hour of study so in this case
for every additional hour with study
which is X increases by 1 the predicted
exam score increases by five increase by
five this is the rate of change in y
change in y with respect to change in x
by one unit increase in X with respect
to X okay so assume that if a student
studied if a student studied three hours
so now F of 3 which is nothing about 60
plus 5 times 3 which is 60 plus 5 times
3 which is 15 which is 75 which is 75 so
student has studied three units and
three three hours extra three hours
additional hours so three times five so
it will increase by 15 times the
Baseline will be increased by 15 times
so we can study if a student has studied
for three hours the predict exam score
will be 75 which is 15 points higher
than the Baseline if this one has not
studied at all
which means that that does the if your X
is equals 3 then there's a then there is
increase in X okay then then if for
every additional hour whatever is
additional hour the his or her score
increases by 5. you can see clearly that
how this uh how this 5 is affecting your
output variable how this 5 is affecting
your output variable how this 5 is
affecting your output variable how this
five is affecting your output available
oops
5 5 is affecting the output variable out
there I hope that it makes sense to you
as well okay
currently it was positive but sometimes
you you have negative as well sometimes
you have negative as well okay sometimes
you get negative uh scores as well so
let's talk about negativity as well uh
which will make much more sense and
we'll uh I'll give you a sheet where we
have much more examples of
interpretation that will make much more
sense as well right so assume that uh
assume that if you have a linear
regression model where y represents the
number of R study and X represents the
age of a student okay so you you want to
predict you want to predict the the
number for us a particular student will
study given the age of a age of students
so you know given the age of person to
predict the number password student will
study you know given like higher dates
higher than high higher different study
and the coefficient for X is minus two
so you have got beta0 plus beta 1 x and
x over here is
the the age of a person right so if your
beta 1 is nothing at minus 2 which means
it's different so what does this
indicates this means that every one year
increase in X so X is nothing but age
right so every one year increase in X
the predicted number of hours of study
decreases by two you can see our
misconception was that it is that that
higher the age higher the study hours
but over here it decreases so minus 2
represents so if your beta is positive
this means your If X increases then beta
absorbs increases in this case a
predicting stress exams course if the
study hours increases then the exam also
because the beta was positive but in
this case if beta is negative my beta 1
is negative which is minus 2 so which
means for every additional hour which if
X increases sorry if beta 1 sorry if if
if if if X increases your output value
decreases
but in this case if X increases outer
values also increases when beta 1 is
positive but in this case in beta 1 is
negative when X increases output output
decreases
one such example was that that the the
the the in this case beta 1 is -2 which
means for every one year increase in age
the predicted number of study will
decrease by this factor which is minus
2. okay
I hope that this makes sense so we have
studies we have written over there here
as well here as well that if there is a
positive relationship there's a positive
relationship X increases leads to Y
increase as well as well okay
so you can see increase in size also
also in reason uh price so I hope that
this gives a good sense about whatever
we are talking about I'll take one more
example maybe to make you understand uh
in much more detail so that we are on a
good page
okay so what exactly what I what I want
to do is uh take an example of
predicting sales you know to take an
example of predicting take an example of
predicting sales and this is this is a
nice example to start talking on so
suppose you have a data set that
contains information on Advertising
expenses and the sales of a company so
so you know you know make a function f
you know make a function f that that
you're going to predict the the
advertising expenses of the you know
predict the revenue you know predicted a
venue the the sales of a person based on
the like you know give the advertising
expenses like how much you expect how
much you spend on advertising and and
and predict what and you know predict
why which is the sales you know you know
establish a relationship between
advertising expenses and the sales
advertising expenses means the the money
you spent on Advertising of of a company
okay so you have only one feature X and
you're gonna predict to buy and predict
why so your so your uh f of x will be
nothing but X is because advertising
expenses which is equals to beta0 plus
beta1 X so assume that your beta0 is
nothing but one thousand plus beta 1
which is 0.8 x 0.8 X so what does this
mean what does this signify so this
signify that your beta0 is thousand beta
0 is thousand what does this mean it is
thousand if the company does not spend
any money on sales if the company does
not spend any money on sales which means
X is equals to zero your sales with the
the revenue the revenue there's the
sales revenue would be one thousand
which is the average which is the
Baseline when your Baseline of Y which
represents the average revenue of
company when they do not spend without
any advertising okay
let's beta0 but what about beta 1 but
what about beta 1 beta 1 over here is
0.8 so this says that for every
additional dollar we spend for every
additional dollar dollar wage we spend
which is one unit increase in X will
lead to increase uh the total will lead
to the sales revenue increase by 0.8
dollars so if increase one dollar on
Revenue then 0.8 then we'll or will get
a raise of 0.8 dollars in Revenue
so this is the rate of change so this is
a positive relationship so it means the
the the the the advertising uh revenue
is in coupled increases uh then the
sales also increases
okay so assume that your company spends
five thousand dollars on Advertising so
your if five thousand okay this is
equals to beta0 1000 plus 0.8 5000.
so this is nothing but your your total
answer would be tot your total so your
total answer would be five thousand
which is five thousand so your total uh
your your your answer would be let me
just calculate so it will much worse
plus 0.8 times 5
000.
5000 which is nothing but five thousand
uh dollar is the five five thousand
which would would be the sales so
basically if your company has a spend
five thousand dollar on Advertising the
predicted the predicted sales or the
revenue would be five thousand which is
four thousand higher with the five
thousand or with the final sales if you
if if you uh spend five five thousand
dollars the the five five thousand
advertising which means that there's a
four thousand higher four thousand
higher than the Baseline Revenue so this
is four thousand higher than the
Baseline Revenue right so this is a
positive positive guy so it says that
for every increase in for every in for
everyone you increase in the
advertisement every one dollar increase
in the advertising your Revenue will
increase by 0.8 dollars
I hope that this makes sense now I'm now
I'm not going to talk more in that uh
will you be I've given you in enough
examples for you to explore by your own
uh I hope that this really helped I'll
be catching up in the next lecture when
we'll talk about how can we estimate our
ex how can we estimate our beta0 and
beta 1 in 3D let's get started in the
next lecture hey everyone welcome back
to this lecture in this particular
lecture what exactly we are going to
cover is uh we'll just recapitulate
whatever we have learned and then we'll
talk about how can we find beta0 and
beta1 in the in like our whole you know
discussion is uh if we don't have better
beta bet Azure and beta1 we'll be not
getting our best line eventually we'll
be failing to get the good predictions
so that was one of our one of our uh
goal so let's recapsulate whatever uh we
have done so we haven't our hypothesis
function or a prediction function our
hypothesis function or prediction
function and over here the hypothesis or
prediction function states that you have
a hfx and a builder function or maybe um
FX that that you're in a better version
F that takes in the value of x and then
and then uh taking value of x and map it
to Y and Y can be any any problem for
example you want to predict the sales
given uh given the advertising expenses
or you want to predict the exam scores
given the number of hours study so you
have input value of only one in one
input feature as of now you have only
one input feature X you have only one
input feature X and given uh and and
using this one input feature X sort of
predicting what is the uh y right but it
may happen that you have several input
features X2 X3 all that are out of the X
and you have several input features and
based on the several input features you
will predict the Y but we'll take a look
at that several one later on but first
of all let's build our Baseline so
whenever you work on any type of problem
the first you should think about how can
we how can we build the Baseline build
the Baseline and a working solution then
after building a baseline we can extend
it okay usually I have seen a lot of
people you know initially they started
focusing on Advanced things and
eventually they they end up losing time
money and Etc so what I recommend is
start with the very basic or same
Baseline and then build upon that so
just like this we are doing over here we
are currently taking only one feature as
of now only one feature and then we are
trying to predict and then and then you
will see that how will extend it
streamlining it very nicely to other
features as well two several features
several input features as well okay
cool so
um let's get started so over here which
you which which you're seeing over here
which is the hypothesis function which
is the prediction function you put in
the value of x and we get a prediction
and you have to learn your beta0 and
beta 1.
you have to find USB resident beta 1 and
then you have your MSC which is which is
used to calculate which is used to
calculate your uh how well your best fit
line is how well your best fit line is
which is 1 over 2m or I equals to
alternate the m h of x i minus y i where
we are taking the difference of
residuals and the squaring to to remove
the negative sign and then we are
averaging it up so that we we get an
overall sense and we're adding 2 as a
convention or you will see that how this
two will help us later on but as of now
assume that this is a convention so
what's what's our goal is our goal is to
minimize a mean squared error which is
mean squared or Y divided mean square
error because it's we are taking mean of
the squares of the error because we are
taking squares of the error because
these are called errors because these
are residual the differences are errors
and they're squaring this up and then
you're taking them in that's that's
where it's called the mean squared error
and our end goal is to minimize this
mean square error minimize this mean
square error in order to find your bl0
and beta 1 because our best fit line
depends on this blog beta0 and beta1 so
we'll see approach that is commonly
finding these so we have to find this
beta 0 and beta 1. so what are what are
your initial ideas right so let's talk
about what are initial ideas I would
like to give you some seconds five
seconds from now on to think about what
what ideas what idea you can come up
with what idea you can come up with to
actually to actually get this beta0 and
beta1 so you can take five seconds from
now on to think about what exactly you
want to achieve and you can actually
take a break as well if you are just
feeling overwhelmed but I'm trying to
make an explanation so easier
so I hope that you have understood now
over here in I what is the idea number
one the idea number one is to try out
several values of beta0 and beta 1 and
see if with that particular parameter
whether your cost function is decreasing
or not so what I'm trying to say that
you can try out several first first what
you what the idea is that you can try
out random say for example you guess
beta0
oops what happened to me
OMG
or give it uh yeah so you can try
several values let's let us assume beta0
to E1 and beta1 to be zero you've taken
these values and then you plug in the
value of over your beta0 beta 1 and then
you evalu and then you take in the
predictions for every X's X is out here
for every predictions and then you've
taken out the MSC and then we have taken
we have done this please don't uh
interfere if you don't please see my
past lectures okay so we have we will
take out the MSC now we'll take out the
MSC so if with the 0 and 1 if our MSC is
decreasing first of all if if our MSC is
decreasing if our cost is decreasing if
our error is decreasing then what we did
then then we'll update our values of
beta0 from for example assume that the
first in the when when you get started
you say every to be 0 and 0 you
initialize beta 1 and beta 0 to be
random values let us assume bit 0 and
beta0 will be initialize the zero and
beta 1 is 1. so first of all initialize
and then you try a different value okay
and then you take out the cost function
with this m a mean square error the
error from this particular uh betas and
then what you do you oh you you randomly
take another value you just take another
value the X 0.25 or beta 1 0 1.75 you
take the value and then you check MSC
and then you check your MSC if the MSC
is less than the previous one then you
update the beta value okay then you
update the beta value
right so you update the beta value if
with this with this new value if your Ms
dick is is less than the previous one if
your error is less than the previous one
right and then you update your beta
value to be the new one whose error was
less than the previous one okay and then
after this you have beta0 to be 0.25
beta 1 episode so it's 1.75 now this
updated one right where MSC something
MSC C okay now you update we now again
update 0. maybe 95 and beta1 to be zero
Now Beta 0 is 0.95 and beta1 to be 1.95
so you take to you you take these two
values and then you check okay now if I
check our MSE is less than previous one
if yes then we have the then we again
update the value then we use the not
previously but the current which is 1.95
and beta beta 1 equals one point uh 995
beta 0 is equal to 0.95 okay so we use
the updated one so what exactly we are
doing we are trying out several values
of beta0 and beta 1 and see if with that
particular value of the parameter our
cost one should decreasing as compute
previous one or not if it is then you
update and if it is not we just stick to
the previous one okay
so our first step in this idea what we
would initialize your beta0 and beta 1
and we evaluate with these uh how do we
evaluate using this cost function where
you predict on every samples of x i and
then you compare it with the y i and y
hat I and then you simply predict it so
the cost function will be super duper
high right so the cost function will be
super duper High because when you have
beta0 to be 0 and beta 1 because so it's
the cost function will be super super
high now you try different values of
beta0 and beta 1 like 1.4 and 2.5
irrespectively which is beta04 1.5 beta
1 through 2.4 and see if the cost wasn't
decreasing so if the cost function is
decreasing as compared to previous one
you update the beta value from 0 to
these values and keep on doing this
until and unless you get low error
you get low error right so you have to
try out several values of beta and beta
B beta 1 beta zero and then until next
to get a lower error so now what's the
big deal in this the big deal in this is
that we can keep on trying
so what to do like this is something
which you have to think of right so we
need a strategy right so we can keep on
trying but we should know a strategy to
keep on trying we cannot just think
about any any value and then just go
with it right it will definitely not
make sense right so what exactly we want
we want to think about in terms of we
want a strategy for us or we want an
algorithm to try for us this is a good a
good good uh this is a good strategy but
with an algorithm to try this strategy
for us to try this strategy for us in an
efficient and timely manner within
strategy so what's that strategy the
strategies we want we want a system
which automatically tries out several
values without any human intervention
tries out every values every in every
iteration so what is iteration in this
case you might be confused in this so
when your beta 1 is equal to zero and
beta0 is equal to zero so you have these
betas right this is now when you update
now you now you update the value so the
first iteration would be now you update
the value and then check the Mac then a
second iteration you update this the
value asked about the previous one and
then check MSC is less than if it is
then you this is second iteration the
third iteration means the third time
you're changing the value and seeing if
the msc's so that's iteration okay so we
want a system which automatically tries
out the values every iteration in such a
way that your iteration at nth value you
iteration at the last parameter value
which is the last iteration or something
like that would assume that you want to
make a 20 iteration so at 20 the
iteration is better or maybe this your
second iteration at the the the error at
the second iteration where you have
updated beta 1 and beta0 should be less
than the previous one okay it is what is
telling the iteration at the nth value
where for example third iteration in the
in the third iteration the parameters
value of the third iteration should be
better than the second iteration
and how to check betterness by MSC
it's better than that before iteration
oh so that you got it this is a strategy
you want now how can we come up with
this strategy this is something you know
this this is something which you should
be able to uh confront by yourself so
how what is the exact strategy for this
to occur so the strategy is the strategy
is uh the strategy is we can make use of
something known as uh let's not go to
what exactly I have a very different
mind to teach you all so assume that
assume that uh we we want to know so
what exactly we we want to know so how
can we check how can we check we want to
check that that that whether by cost
function or whether my mean square error
is decreasing if I change beta0 us um if
if I change the beta 0. so what exactly
you wanna know whether whether my cost
function cost function is decreasing if
I change my what if I change my
beta0 or and beta1 so I want to check
this right I want to check this so you
might have heard about uh let's let's
let's start going again a mathematical
term so we wanna we wanna check this
right so what is the week and we can
check this so you might have heard about
um slope okay so let's talk about change
in y over change in X how much y changes
how much y changes when X changes that's
that's what is change in whatever change
in X so how much y changes when X
changes so what if I can write how much
J changes how much your cost function
changes when you change when you change
your beta0 and how much your cost
function changes when you change your
beta1 so can we get our change the rate
of change
right so if my cost function decreasing
as compared to be as cash come to the
previous one this is good we can check
the rate of change by nothing but the
slope by nothing but the slope uh we
which which you have heard now now here
comes an interesting part now over here
how can we take out the slope of this
because we eventually want to take out
the slope of this particular uh function
how can we take out this a very
interesting question so the though let's
let's let's worry about first of all
tell me what is the if you if you can
applaud this function f of x how what is
the what what will the plot looks like
so I would recommend you to plot this
function on a graph right now where you
plug in the values of x and x squared
plug in the values one one two four
three nine plug in the several values
and then plot it the plot which you're
going to get the plot which you're going
to get is a nothing it's nothing but
something like this
but something like this okay uh parabola
okay or something like the uh some the
so if not not exactly Parabola but uh
you if you plot this on if I I just
plotted it on terms of you know a
positive one but if you plot this uh but
the but the parabola if you if you
eventually plot this up if you
eventually plot this up so let me let me
let me just plot this up
since the plotting would look like this
which is the function x squared this is
a this is uh this is a function this is
a graph of your x squared this is a
graph of your x squared now this is the
graph of this x its weight so can you
tell me how can you take out slope in
this because at every point every Point
uh your slope changes so there is not a
constant slope right so assume that you
wanna take a slope at this particular
point so at this particular Point what
does it tell what what does a slope will
tell how much uh that how much it will
how what what is at this particular
point will will tell how much your x
square will change when you change this
a little bit let's forget it you can
though let's say you wanted to take a
slope at this particular point you want
to take a slope at this particular point
because slope pattern is not is not
constant right it's not same all over
the graph it keeps on changing right it
keeps on changing so now now it is not
possible so what we do there's a concept
of derivatives which takes out slope of
a curved line okay of a curved line I
hope that this gives a good sense now
this Parabola why does I introduce this
Parabola to you interesting question
right observe carefully observe
carefully can you see this
this is something assume that this is
something a x and then you're squaring
this up isn't your cost function will
look something like parabola
right because we're squaring directly
squaring this up right it will look like
something like Parabola so when you plot
this equation up and you plot this
equation up you will get you will get
something like this something like this
something like this okay
you will get something like that now on
x-axis you will have your betas on
y-axis you have your errors so now again
it might can confuse you for every point
of the betas for example let let us
assume this is a beta0 okay so in beta0
beta0 over here if beta0 is uh if beta0
point is over here so your error at this
point where error with this beta0 is
very high
error with that particular beta0 is very
very high if beta0 is over here if beta0
is over here
beta0 over over here error is bit low
the previous one if beta0 is over here
error is bit lower than so this
represents this uh the x axis represents
the beta the values of beta 1 beta sorry
beta0 and Y represents the error y
represents the error
okay so over here what our goal should
be our goal should be to to get the beta
to get that beta value to get that beta
value over we want to get that beta from
here to here so that our error is very
very less approximately equals to zero
So eventually we're gonna get so assume
that this is a beta 1 this is a beta1
and then over when when the beta1 is
over let us assume beta1 is something
like
um four
is something like 4 okay beta1 is
something like four so what will be the
error error will be super duper High
beta 1 so now you have beta 1 at a
little bit less than or maybe uh
something like that so b b beta 1 is in
this case if beta 1 is less than the
previous one and the error is also less
so 80 I'm just taking an example it can
be more as well it can be more as well
don't worry don't worry about anything
currently it's a very simplest example
which I can plot for you okay which is
now beta1 you try you wanna reach to a
global Minima you wanna reach to a
global Minima not local Global Minima
where your error is very very less where
is negligible so you're going to start
with the beta value whose error is very
very high and then you have to learn the
beta value on a chain keep on changing
the beta value so you're seeing that we
are changing this is definitely beta
values aren't in unless our error is
nothing but equals to zero
okay I hope that you're getting what I'm
trying to send me I'm just trying to
convey that you're gonna keep on
changing beta value you keep on changing
the middle value that will help us that
will help us to get your beta that that
will help you that that that will help
you to get beta 1 equals two so beta 1
the error of beta 1 is equals to zero
okay
I hope that you that that you're getting
so how can we take out the rate of
change how can we take out the rate of
change so how much your error changes so
when when your beta beta0 changes how
much you're at how much your error
changes when betas are at this
particular Point changes beta0 will be
saying will will be not same it will be
changing right so what will the what
will the change in error when that at
this particular point so what is what is
the derivative of your error with
respect to this beta0 at this particular
point
okay
so let's uh uh so it will be more clear
once we uh understand more in
mathematical perspective but eventually
what our derivative is telling it is
telling that how mature Dairy how mature
uh cost functional error will change if
you change your beta a little bit
okay
let me change your beta a little bit so
we use the concept of differentiation
which is how much y changes when X
changes Matlab key how much your error
will change when your beta changes so in
a nutshell we are looking for this
strategy one we are just looking for the
strategy where we can take a look if
this something increases or decreases
we're just looking for that strategy and
here we go here we go so here we go
where it tests the d y by DX where
you're taking out that where where we
are when when you take out the start
when you you have to do for individually
for different different parameters
because you have two parameters beta0
and beta 1 right beta beta 01 is slope
and one is Pierson but it's not
something like it's the best of now but
over here it's the stock the
optimization problem so you eventually
take out the derivative of your cost
function with respect to beta0 and
derivative of the COS function with
respect to beta 1 because we have to do
so it tells you it this tells you how
much your cost function will change if
you change beta0 a little bit how much
this cross function will change when you
change beta 1 a little bit so if that
changes if this it it it will happen in
every iteration so the second iteration
assume that it changes and it decreases
then it then it if and then compares to
from the previous one and see if there's
something low yes then you update the
value of beta0
so there's a change in a when beta0
changes same here as well same here as
well okay
I hope that you're getting what exactly
I'm trying to convey now here's your
algorithm here's your algorithm here's
your algorithm
um for updation like you get a change
now you get a change now you have to
update no you have to update your values
as well and then you look for the
another beta value right
so you update the this is this is called
the update rule this is called the
update update rule where you first of
all update beta0 with old beta so
basically you have a new new beta0 new
beta0 and then we'll assign this we this
is assignment operator where you have
new beta Nu beta is equals to Old beta
minus the learning return I'll talk
about that times the change in X with
respect to the the the change in your
cost function how much your day of the
how much error changes when beta0
changes
we'll expand this will will take out the
derivative in just a second but assume
that so we multiply the learning rate
for this so what is learning rate
what is learning rate so but but before
that uh we'll we'll talk about that
learning rate later on but let's let's
stick at some point
over here beta0 is is the old beta0 like
over here if you have beta 0 to be 0 and
beta 1 is equal to 0 then this is the O
this now we have the second iteration
second side second iteration here beta 1
uh beta uh so you have been new beta and
you have to take out the new beta so you
have the when you actually convert beta
1 is you assume that you have a zero
minus the linear Alpha with respect so
basically this is the old old beta has
covered the previous one the pre the
previous beta okay the old beta minus
the learning with Alpha and this change
change of rate of change of rate of cost
function with respect to this beta0 and
then you do for beta 1 as well I'm so
sorry this this
should be beta1
this should be the one okay this should
be beta1 uh now over here over here so
now you may have several questions the
first question is would be why are we
subtracting our old beta the reason why
we are subtracting because we're going
to minimize our function right one way
to think about it it's it's it's it's
not something uh uh legal but we can
think about that we want to minimize our
function right when we want to go down
and minimize our function so that our
error is less so we're gonna minimize
that's why we subtract I mean if
anything you need to minimize sort of
subtract and then it will tell you it
will get this this change this this
calculates the change it calculates the
exact points using derivatives at the
current points okay
and of course there's the change and
then you were learning rate Alpha which
is nothing which is nothing which is
nothing which is nothing but the
learning rate Alpha so over here over
here you are going down at a certain
speed right at a certain rate
at a certain rate you're going down at a
certain rate so the rate of going down
the rate of going down the rate of
reaching to a global Minima is nothing
but called The
Learning rate okay it's nothing but
called The Learning rate the rate or by
which we go in we we learn with the the
read by which we learn is also known as
learning rate we'll take a look at we'll
take a we'll have a separate video on
learning rate we'll talk about some of
the best cases and cases of learning in
great detail but you can assume as of
now it's case the back it scales the
change by the factor of Alpha and that
is the rate of learning in a geometrical
perspective
I hope your understanding
cool
let's get started
top so the what are the steps to to
summarize you initialize your beta0 to
band beta 1 equals to zero I assume that
U is ratio of beta 1 to any number any
random values and we there is a
initialization techniques we'll study in
deep learning not as of now but you can
ignore it you calculate and gradient at
the current point with the current
current value of course the error will
be high you scale it a factor of X when
minimize it by subtracting you subtract
the old betas here the update rule app
happens and they repeat two and three
points two and three points right you
repeat you calculate you you and in the
first iteration you calculate the
gradient with the previous now in the
second iteration now your betas are
updated now it's not the initial but
it's the updated one which you which you
which which you get after applying this
update rule right and then you apply the
derivative and then you uh get the and
and then you get the new beta and then
you go to third iteration and then you
now you it now you beta R of the second
iteration so it's okay so you repeat the
two and three points how much by how
much we're going to repeat first of all
we can do it for like Beyond a repeat
for 20 iteration third iteration for the
iteration or space we can we can learn
this when you're when you're uh when
you're uh when you actually converge
when you actually when your beta when
your beta is actually when you're uh
when you're when your algorithm is
converged so what what we say can burst
is that your step size is smaller like a
step size smaller than the tolerance and
then the learning rate stops when it
reaches the global Minima okay
and you will learn about this you can
ignore this as of now we'll have a
separate video on learning rate to make
you better understand about that
okay so and then we do for beta0 and
then we do for and then we do for beta 1
as well and then we do for beta 1 as
well okay doing the same thing we are
updating the beta1 the new beta1 the old
beta minus learning refer the change
okay and then you repeat until some
conditions what is the number of hitters
should be 24 or 20 iterations where you
I for beta I equals to 0 and 1 we apply
the folder for beta0 and there is update
with simply simply do for all the betas
out there whatever beta 1 and beta0 you
do for both one okay
now now your question would be how can
we calculate the derivative of this So
eventually you don't use usually use the
derivative you use the partial
derivative of jio bi with respect to bi
b b i so this this exactly means that
the in both means exactly the same but
this is a partial derivative which is
applied in a vector Calculus if you want
to learn more about you know uh calculus
and everything if you haven't yet I
recommend you to watch this playlist
which I created over a year ago which is
quite famous playlist uh not by so much
of people but eventually it is very nice
if you if you wanted to learn about
calculus and great detail I've tried
after I've considered everything which I
know about calculus over here
so how can we take out this partial
derivative of J of uh how can we take
the partial derivative of your cost
function with respect to a particular
parameter this exactly means the same
then how much it cost function changes
when you'll be the beta changes
okay I hope that this makes sense so you
see that they do the same sort of work
overall you seem simply same sort of
work but this is all the vector calculus
so how individual parameter like
eventually how individual parameter
affects your MSE and over here I have
taken out the derivation I have taken
out the derivation I have taken out the
derivation for your model now you might
be confused how this derivation came
we'll talk about that for a single
training example uh in a free form so
I'll just talk about when when will I
should do a real world example no then
then I'll show you the derivation ignore
this as of now this is just for notes
purposes I'll show you a worked example
Hands-On so that it will it is more
clear so now when you when you actually
calculate when this will yield to this
formula to this formula we'll learn how
to utilize this formula in for uh we'll
now you plug in the values now over here
this this will give you the rate of
change
okay listen to the rate of change so
we'll talk about what is the
interpretation of this what why do we
use derivative what is the
interpretation of this number and
various things this is just a starting
point my aim was to make you understand
that we have an update Rule and then we
have this uh give a storyline for what
exactly how do we learn and this is the
story behind the the learning point
okay so you can see that we are having
the this is the derivation when you
calculate the derivative of the cost
function the cost function is which I've
seen with respect to particular
parameter you get this particular
equation
okay so we'll put we'll talk we'll talk
about this in just just in next section
we'll talk when we'll work on work the
example please ignore others now but
just remember that this is the derived
if you don't want to do the calculator
stuff you can actually ignore the next
section as well but I really really
recommend if you want to uh fully
understand greatness and you should be
able to learn about it
okay now I have listed some examples of
learning rate so over here which which
I've seen learning rate Alpha is a
learning rate which decides by how much
you should Converse the rate of learning
okay so we have learning is 0.1 starts
with this and then it slows down and
then it converges slowly so if you see
that at this point at this point it is
very very slow why because it is at as
it is learning the end and and it no you
can understand this today it knows that
the con it knows that it is a my my
conversion rate is coming so I have to
be very cautious because I am so I have
to be a bit slow because when you have a
when you drive a car you don't drive at
a same speed right you don't have it
stays same speed you strive same speed
you drive that fast bits whenever
required the breaker comes you slow it
down right or whenever the stop is going
to slow it down that's why the stoppage
is slows but if but if your error if you
if your learning rate is too high you
this is the learning rate which you have
to choose according to your problems
statement according to the data which
will talk about that later on will
actually the practical but there's
something which you have to tune like
try out several and see what works well
so if you're learning that it's too high
it will mostly diverge so for example if
if your car is going on okay with a high
speed so if you push a break if you push
like 100 kilometer per hour so push a
break car is most likely to fall down
right well like it it will most likely
to fall down it will most like to crash
like hell so if the learning result will
diverge like this it will never converge
to the Minima it will simply keep on
diverging you'll it will never reach to
a stoppage
and if your learning rate is too small
then it will never converge okay because
it will be two percent super duper so if
you drive at one two one meter per se
per per kilometer you know it's it's uh
I mean I I just mess it up so if you try
slowly you'll not able to reach okay
cool this these are some of the learning
rate variations uh we'll talk about that
later on but I hope that you understood
what grade is it in upper level now
let's go and do the work example and the
derivations and all to make you more uh
understandable about all of this thing
so hey everyone I'm back uh with work
example of trading descent learning and
we will eventually take a sample data
and perform a real time learning on that
and then I'll show you how it is super
simple to understand query in descent
even with mathematical reasoning uh if
you're if you're not comfortable even
with math I would recommend you to watch
it right it will be much more better for
you
so let's get started
um over here I wanna I wanna take a
sample data so sample data which I'm
which I'm going to take is you have a
one input feature well whoops my mind is
so diverted I'm using yellow color and
white so X and Y and in this X and Y you
have 1 2 2 4 3 6 4 8 please note I'm not
going to take a huge data otherwise it
will take me years but I'm going to take
a sample data but I'm going to take a
sample data this is a sample data where
you have only one independent feature
independent
feature and then you have your output
variable output
uh variable or Target variable okay you
have one independent feature and then
you have output variable and Target
feature Target variable which predicts
in a builder function f in a bill of
function f or takes the value of this x
is the values of this and Maps it to Y
so to build a function f that RFI is any
sort of relationship between these two
right
so basically this for for you it may be
super simple right to understand the
relationships but eventually I'm going
to take an example to show you how our
machine learning algorithm will
interpret this how our machine algorithm
will go on understanding the
relationship okay because I am always a
Believer or of understanding from the
Baseline so that you want to send a core
of it you will understand even the big
things of it
so your f of x is uh when you when
you're taking a value of when you put
put in the value of x you'll predict y
so build a function f so your Builder
function f so the equation it's equation
so sorry so your equation for this line
so equation for this line or the Y
equals to MX plus b or Y is equals to
Beta is 1 times X Plus beta0 so your
point is to take out beta 1 and beta 0
out of this using great in this set so
what's that first step the first step of
ours is nothing step number one step
number one initialize initialize
your beta 0 and beta 1. so I'm going to
initialize beta 1 to B1 and beta 0 to be
zero so this is two two things which I'm
going to initialize initially okay
because an N thing you have to
initialize first then the second step
which which you have to do the Second
Step which you have to do the Second
Step which you have to do is calculate
the error is calculate the MSC calculate
the Mac with the initialized with the
initialized beta
or values
with initialized beta values and so how
how can we take out first of all let's
say it's very simple you have your uh Y
is equals to Beta what what was the beta
1 beta 1 with 1 times X plus zero this
Tesla's equation you plug in the values
of every X over here you plug in the
value one two three four right so uh the
Y bread one so y red one which is equals
to nothing but uh one times one plus
zero which is nothing but equals to one
so you keep keep on doing for every
sample so I press two wiper three the
prediction which is one times two plus
zero equals to 2 1 times 3 plus 0 equals
to three and one times four plus zero
equals to four okay
so now you have to calculate the step
now you have to after taking the
predictions now what you have to do is
calculate MSE is calculate is calculate
MSC calculate MSE by nothing but 1 by m
I is equals to 1 all the way out of the
M as well all the all the way around to
the m so what exactly we can do we can
simply uh say that one thing is we can
also use our formula which which we had
of that 1 by 2m which is nothing but 7.5
divided by 2 which is something 3 plus
35 yeah so what exactly we can do what
exactly we can do is we can either use 2
over here but as of now let's ignore 2
as of now what do you say let's let's
ignore two as of now uh because of uh
and just just just for sick of
Simplicity more but eventually we'll use
this too so maybe let's add 2 over here
as well 1 by 2 m but uh but eventually
we are we're just going to take the
squares nothing else more so let's stick
to this only what do you say let's stick
to this one it's much more uh better so
1 by
M of course we will change it later but
my point is not to make it perfect
accurate but as of now uh if if you see
in your machine machine learning
libraries they're consistent enough but
let us use Simple it's very simple
without using 2R and anything which is
one by uh and you have your edge of x i
h of x i minus y i it's great for the
spirit for removing and the difference
is it's great for removing the negative
sign so now it will yield to 1 minus 2
squared plus 2 minus 4 squared plus 3
minus 6 squared plus 4 minus 8 squared
divided by
divided by 4 and that will yield that
will yield to nothing at one plus four
one plus one plus four plus nine plus
sixteen divided by 4 and that will the
third P plus 4 which is nothing but 7.5
okay this is your error this is your
error if you utilize these two values
now
uh let's add one more page let's add one
one one one more page now once you have
the once once you have the MSC now you
have to use gradient descent now a step
is you have to use use Grid in descent
use gradient descent to minimize to
minimize your uh your cost function
which is G of beta which is G of beta so
to use Grid in descent to minimize that
cool so let's eventually talk about how
can we eventually do it so your cost
function is so I'm going to write the
conventional cost function to show you
what exactly this 2 means in uh how how
exactly this two eventually help us
so uh this it it will make you more
clear so 1 by 2 m your I is equals to 1
all the amount of the m
h of x i minus y i
squared so this is your cost function so
basically what our goal was to take out
the partial derivative of this of this
because our what was our grain initial
formula formula was this formula right
so we have to take out this we will take
will take out the derivation we'll we'll
take out the we'll do the calc will do
the calculation of this how how we even
do you will see it right now so we are
going to take a derivative of J of beta
with respect to with respect to beta0
first of all let's let's do for beta 0
okay so what this is split will tell it
will tell how much will cost until
changes when your beta0 changes so it is
nothing it is nothing so what what will
be undertake of the derivative of this
whole set of functions this whole
function so how how does it sell so
which is nothing but derivative of of
the whole functions we will write that
with respect to beta0 so the whole
function is one by two m
I is equals to one all the one out of
the m h of x i minus y i squared okay
this is your uh this this is what which
shown us all so what I'm going to do I'm
going to take out the sum rule uh some
sum sum outside so I'm just some some
rule outside which is 1 by 2 m
then we take out the derivative then we
take out the derivative of your of your
uh this function which is over here
you're going to apply the change audio
over here you're going to apply the
chain rule on this particular function
so X of I minus y i squared okay
now you're going to take out the
derivative of this how you're going to
do it we have a two Function One inner
one out Outlet so you will take out the
1 by 2 m 1 by 2m I is equals to 1 all
the way out of the M derivative of of
this particular pass function that
derivative of this this particular over
here you was the outer function
multiplied this is over here we're going
to apply the chain rule over here I'm
going to apply the chain rule of
calculus so we are going to take out the
derivative of outer function leaving as
it is inside times the derivative of the
in inner function the derivative of
outer function is nothing but equals to
2 comes over here by a by the power rule
and then we subtract minus 1 from here
so 2 uh and we leave the inside as it is
as it is for outside derivative and over
here 2 minus 1 is nothing but equals to
one well times your derivative of your
inside function which is beta0 and say
and say inside function is nothing but
minus y i okay so this is your uh this
is your uh equation that that you're
trying to solve Now 1 by 2 m 1 by 2 m i
is equals to 1 all the way out of the M
all all different out of the m and then
you simply solve for it which is nothing
but your 2 and 2 cuts out so you see
that 2 and 2 cuts out so now we will not
write two and then your final answer
would be 1 by m h of x i h of x i minus
y i this is your derivation this is your
derivation you might think yayush what
happened to this this becomes equals to
1 this this becomes equals to 1. why do
we say that this is equals to 1. so
let's talk about why exactly this is
equals to one so when you take out the
partial derivative of this function h of
x i h of X I A minus y I with respect to
beta0 with respect to beta0 what is that
if we expand this h of x i is nothing
but
is nothing but let us assume the beta0
plus beta 1 x i minus y I with respect
to beta0 right so over here we're going
to take the with respect to beta0 so
except beta0 every except this except
this everything is constant everything
is constant so that is that that that
that that will be nothing but equals to
zero so it will everything is constant
and that derivative is nothing but equal
to so everything is zero okay now now
over here now over here now over here
now if if you go uh and if you see that
everything will be 0 because it is
except zero which is nothing but oh we
and the derivative of a constant is you
know it's it's zero so now now you see
now you add then derivative and now this
this one because this is respect this
this the whole equation will come P
equals to 1 y because because
when taking the partial derivative with
respect to all the letters except the
except beta0 are treated as constants
and their derivative constant is nothing
but zero and then you have beta0 when
you take out the derivative of that is
something which equals to one and we
have one over here and when you actually
do that because it's it it does it does
not have a constant and even if it as as
we know that a we it it has a constant x
0 and x 0 is nothing but equals to 1.
right so I hope that did make sense to
you as well uh if it not please see my
calculus lectures please see my calculus
lectures out here it will make much more
sense if you see I'm not going to go in
depth explanation but you can understand
this way that we come up with when we
actually take out the partial derivative
of jio beta with respect to beta0 is
nothing but 1 by m one by m
I is equals to 1 all there are the m y
hat I minus y i and y hat is the regular
model predictions plus okay so this is
your a beta0 now we'll do for beta1
and now we'll do for beta1 okay beta1
exactly the same the only thing changes
instead of one noun so when you actually
uh every Everything Remains the Same so
whenever when you actually take out the
derivative of beta with respect to beta
1 is nothing but equals to everything
Remains the Same everything Remains the
Same over here everything Remains the
Same 1 over m one over M uh I was to one
other the m y hat I minus y I multiply
multiplied by x i multiplied by x i y
multiplied by x i because now in this
case now in this case when you actually
take out the derivative of this take out
that derivative of this you will notice
that now h of x i is supposed to Beta 0
plus beta 1 x i minus y i right so now
take the derivative of this everything
except this one is constant this one
this one everything is constant now over
here we actually have beta 1 times x so
the constant is the this is the
coefficient of the curve x i so this is
X x i would be over Dash
okay so X I will be written over there
please see my lectures uh if you are
confused like how this x again this is a
rule of calculus and all if you don't
know please ignore uh
now over here you have you you got this
for beta1 as well right
now what you need to do we had an update
Rule now we have to update beta0
it all beta minus learning that Alpha
the derivative of beta with respect to
beta0
and then we have beta 1
beta 1 minus learning Alpha with respect
to
beta y right you you have this you have
this so let's calculate this one let's
calculate the first one the partial
derivative of beta with respect to beta0
is nothing but we have already taken out
I've already taken out the equation this
was our equation right this this was our
equation so first of all our prediction
our prediction one minus 2 multiplied by
multiplied by uh one minus sorry yeah 1
1 minus 2 V and we are multiplied by one
so it's it's we we should not write
anything 1 minus two and and then you
have 2 minus 4 which is your prediction
minus the actual Value Plus 3 minus 6
plus 4 minus 8 and then you divide by
the total number of values which is 4
which is nothing but which is nothing
but minus 2.5 which is the rate of
change okay you do the same for J of
beta with respect to beta 1 which is
nothing you will get nothing but 1 minus
2 but this time you're multiplying with
x i and the first of the X5 which is X1
and this is for X1 right the X X1 is
that nothing but equals to one so if you
go and Z your X Y is nothing but it's
now you now you do for SEC six second
one you do for second one which is a 2
minus four usually simply add plus 2
minus 4 multiplied by two plus three
minus 6 multiplied by 3 plus 4 minus
eight four minus eight multiplied by 4
and then you divide the total by four
you get nothing but minus seven point
five you get that thing but minus seven
point five minus seven point five when
you calculate so your uh with the
current value of beta0 to be zero and
beta 1 to B1 is only about minus two
point five and minus 7 which is the rate
of change now once we get it now once we
get it we can simply apply our update
rule our update rule was first of all
let's let's do for beta0 our old beta0
which we initialize was 0 minus 30 let
us assume that your learning rate is
Alpha we'll talk about learning the
alpha in great detail uh multi
multiplied by learning will also
multiply it with the rate of change and
the rate of change for beta0 was minus
two point five right and the beta 0 the
updated bit as beta0 is 0.25
and then your beta1 you do the same you
have one in this case because the old
beta was one or minus 0.1 multiplied by
minus 7.5 you get nothing but 1.75
that's an output okay this will be down
this is updated B doesn't updated beta 1
after in the first iteration okay as
because it now you what now what you do
now this this is now you're done with
the baby beta0 and beta 1 in the first
iteration in the next it's done in the
first iteration you calculate the MSE
and the updated beta0 and beta 1.
calculate the message
you'll be noticing that your Mac
is low is low so when when you
calculated when you calculated the MSC
with
uh with this uh with beta0 to B with
beta0 to be one and zero it was minus it
it was seven seven point five but when
you'll calculate your MSE with 0.25 and
1.75 it will be less as compared to
previous one please note that you can
try it out as well
and then you do the next iteration
number two maybe an iteration number two
you do the same step now what you do you
calc you calculate them you see you plug
in the values of you plug you up again
you again make the predictions you again
make the predictions with new beta value
so again with make the predictions with
the numerator value and then you uh take
out the error and after taking out the
error you simply apply the update rule
after calculating this derivatives once
again how this derivative is calculated
you have your new predictions right if
your new predictions and new predictions
you will get once again and then you
have to calculate that but once again
you're getting new derivatives and then
you can and then you have the iteration
number two iteration number two as well
iteration number three you do the same
and all until unless you reach to 20 or
whatever number of iterations which you
have fixed up
okay I hope that you're getting what I
mean whatever I'm trying to tell you can
try out this priori you may be confused
about iteration number two so let me
just be clear about it what exactly I
want to do what you can do you can first
of all you be you you have got new betas
right you make your wipe red once again
once again now you get your four
predictions after getting four
prediction you take out MSC with these
four predictions you've taken out good
now what you do you have you all do
already have your uh partial derivative
of cos function with respect to beta 1
and beta 2 you have some equation you
plug in the values now the now that
derivative you'll get is very different
why because your predictions will change
because you have because you're using
new beta value new parameter value your
predictions will change of course so
beta that derivative also change and
then you plug in the derivative over
here with now beta0 and beta1 with a
different bear beta0 is 0.25 and 0 beta
1 is
1.75 minus 2.5 and beta 1 to be 1.75
right
now again you will be getting new betas
where your MSC will be low as compared
to previous one I hope that this gives
you good sense and I really hope that
you understood this as well
and now I'm just going to uh now we'll
ask you to take ring because this was
something you know uh very tiring as
well for me and it may be tiring as well
for you in the next lecture we'll talk
about uh why does gradient recent use
derivative what is the significance of
it and I'll give you a Google sheet
where we have we have one more solved
problem of it and then we are finally
done with learning and then I'll
recapsulate you everything make your
summary so that you understand it and
then you go to other forms of
integration to study more about a lot of
things so let's catch up in the next
lecture hey everyone welcome to this
lecture uh so basically what I'm going
to do today is talk about some of the
key terms which may be uh useful for you
and then we'll talk a bit have a bit of
discussion around
um some of the types of regression
algorithm which is a uni varied or
simple integration or multivariate and
multiple linear equations we'll talk
about the other differences and all in
great detail okay
and then we'll get started with
extension form which is quite easy to
understand if if you have understood the
previous one so first of all let let us
understand why does gradient descent use
derivative of the cost function so first
of all let's figure out that and so any
so basically in linear regression so in
linear regression what was what is your
eventual board what is your eventual
goal that's a nice question to start
forward so your eventual goal is nothing
but to minimize but to minimize your
cost function or your MSE so that that
is a goal and and and your error between
all to minimize the error between your
predicted and actual Target value
so that we take that partial derivative
partial derivative of that cost function
with respect to a particular parameter
or a coefficient assume that in this
case beta0 Okay so particular parameter
coefficient and which so what does that
derivative gives us is of course that
gives us the rate of change but what in
terms of how does this help us to go
down or how how does it help us to reach
to Global Minima that's a very nice
question to ask the first it gives the
first is the direction to move your data
be right whether to increase the beta or
whether to increase decrease the beta
right so it also gives whether we should
increase the beta increase the value
from 1 to 12 increase or decrease the
beta that's what it gives so direction
to move your coefficients or parameters
in in order to minimize your error so
for example if you have a current zero
should we minimize or macro so should we
move should we decrease or should we
increase this so This exactly the
derivative tells and it tells in such a
way that it minimizes the error
minimizes our MSC okay so the derivative
of your mean squared error with respect
to a point square with respect to a
coefficient or a parameter value or any
kind of beta 0 and beta2 sorry beta 1
and beta0 provides the rate of change of
the MSE with respect to particular so
how much that changes when this changes
and M so for example if your derivative
if if
uh derivative if your derivative is
positive if the derivative is positive
which is the rate of change is positive
then increasing the value of coefficient
will decrease the error okay first
please note that whatever I'm telling if
the derivative is positive with respect
to this so it tells that if we increase
the value of beta if we increase the
value of beta if beta is increased then
the error will decrease so if it is
positive then we increase the value of
beta please note that this is the most
famous question when when we talk about
the interpretation because this this
derivative also gives the direction to
movie whether to increase or decrease uh
degree of theta in order to minimize the
error right so if your derivative is
positive then if you increase the beta
your error will decrease with means if
the if it is positive if the derivative
positives it increases your beta okay
and if your derivative is negative then
increasing the values so for example
um yeah so just just just for a note uh
over here I think guys I I had a very
long interpretation I'm going to retake
it I'm going to retake it okay so now
the derivative of MSE with respect to a
particular coefficient provides the rate
of change how much your cost function
will change when you change the
coefficient so if your derivative is
positive if your derivative is positive
so whatever the derivative which are
taken whatever the derivative derivative
which you which which I have taken if
this is positive which means that if
increase the value of beta so basically
derivative what is it gives it gives the
direction to move to increase or
decrease the data that's that's what it
gets right so if you increase if if the
derivative is positive the derivative is
positive so if we that that means that
if we increase the value if we increase
the value of beta our error will also
increase so we'll have if the so so in
this test if increase the value of beta
a revelation 3 so so in so over here we
decrease it
okay but if your derivative is negative
if your derivative is a negative which
means that if you increase the value of
a coefficient if you increase beta by
some Factor by 3 is beta and you can
increase beta from the previous one it
will decrease the error it will decrease
the error right so over here we just go
with this change okay so basically this
derivative gives us the direction to
move your beta in if if the derivative
is positive that means if we increase
the beta our error will also increase
but if the derivative is negative it
means to increase the beta then the
derivative will decrease okay
I hope so if the derivative is positive
then we decrease the beta so that our
error also decreases
okay I hope that that this gives you a
good sense so by Computing the
derivative of these uh of this MSC with
respect to every individual parameter we
can determine the direction in which
each coefficient should be changed like
to increase the degrees in order to
minimize our error okay I hope so that
you got it and now our gradient descent
uses this derivative advertis uses this
derivative of the of the mean squared
error to update the parameters in the
direction in the direction to update the
parameters in the direction it minimizes
with this we will use the graduation
tool in the direction that it minimizes
the particular error so at every
iteration to at every iteration the the
gradient of a m the the gradient of mean
square error is computed and the
coefficients are updated in the opposite
direction of the gradient as we have
already seen how exactly gradient
descent works and and and it keeps on it
keeps on you know changing the direction
increasing or decreasing keeps happening
a positive of the gradient opposite of
the gradient and keeps on the come come
coming up until the unless we converge
to the global minimum so basically the
whole idea behind first it is the rate
of change derivative is the rate of
change second it tells you the direction
and second like how big the step is in
this case if you see that it is starting
in the big big step but eventually it is
started small right so if your slope is
large if your slope is large we want to
take a large step because we are far
from the minimum we are farm so if this
over here slope is large right so over
here it is far from the minimum so so we
take the big step but as we go towards
the minimum our slope becomes small and
that's why we have to take a little
little step so the your derivative tells
that how big this step we should take
I hope that this gives you a very clear
sense about what exactly our derivative
means and I hope that this gives a good
sense about why do we use study where if
for the cost function
cool
now we'll talk about a couple of types
of regression problems in great detail I
think this is important to talk and then
we'll end the end about this section so
there are two types of so now in the
next in in the next video we'll talk
about two types of regression which is
univarial submultivated multiple there
are a lot of regression we'll talk about
that it's one and then you put the uh in
you you make a you you make a vector X
you make a vector X which is which
contains the information vector and then
and then and and then you have a X1
X1 x0 X1 and X2 and then you make a and
and then you make a parameter vector and
then you make a parameter vector and
then you make a parameter Vector beta0
beta 1 and beta 2 and then you take the
dot product between both of them
dot product between both of them dot
product between both of them so when you
take the dot product between both of
them what does it does X zero beta 0
plus x 1 beta 1 x 2 Beta beta2 so we
started the linear algebra this heavily
reduces the computational time because
it follows something when it's
broadcasting where it's simply multi
multiplies and uh adds at the same time
and the calculation the dot product
which will perform the way of taking the
vector x x 0 x 1 and X2 and then beta 0
beta 1 beta 2 they take the dot product
it will be super duper efficient so we
have several Frameworks to do this which
is numpy framework you know tensorflow
which which provides the optimized
versions for the vectorized option this
is called the vectorized operations
that's why linear algebra comes into
place okay
now how can we write the dot product so
if you have the beta if you have the
beta which is the parameter Vector which
contains the beta0 beta1 all the way
around to the beta n number of a bit the
number of beta is nothing because the
number of features which you have and x
x my X Vector contains your X1 out of
the uh x 0 all done or the X N then you
take the dot product by Beta transpose X
this is this is how you can write or you
can say beta dot X okay you can write in
this way so you basically take the dot
product but what will come to dot
product we'll come to dot product later
on when we solve a real world example
but as of now this is how it works now
let's get started with more detailing
thing okay first is let's prepare our
design Matrix let's prepare our design
Matrix so this is left repair design
design Matrix is nothing but your data
how can you convert your data into a
matrix a CSV data into Matrix so in this
case in this case you have your design
Matrix X okay X contains your data okay
so assume that you have X1 X2 X3 all the
number of features so extra size of the
house price the number of bedrooms above
the house the number of Earth so it it
can have any number of p number of
information so here we have written p in
the K instead of hence we have p number
of information okay and the for and the
first data point can be represented as
if you have seen The Matrix lecture you
could have understood this very easily
so the first data point in your the
first data point in in your data is X11
which represents that it is the first
row and First Column which means is it's
the first it is the first it is the uh
for it it is available in the first row
which of of the first information for
example if there's the size of the house
this is the first okay now this is the
second row first information this is the
second data point of the first
information which is assume that this is
the size of the house the first
information of the size of the the house
second information of the size of the
house so you have same information but
different different samples then you
have price then you have number of
bedrooms so first information of the
second second feature which is the
number of bedrooms second information
about the bedroom so there's several
samples for the same right so you have
so on over here you have different
different features or as a number of
columns and then on the number of rows
has an N number of a number of rows okay
first data point First Column first row
First Column second first row second
column so First Row Third column all you
know the first row P column okay
and then at last you have an nth row
First Column and a throw second column
and a throw Peak column okay so it says
that it can have p number of columns or
n number for an N number of rows okay so
this is no nothing known as design
Matrix this is nothing known as
design Matrix okay and then you have
this Y and Y then the the why why n will
be equals to X N okay so the number of
rows then the number of elements which
you have in your parameter y Vector is
equals to the number of rows which you
have in a design major because it is a
super supervised learning problem and
every individual row has its y1 Y2 all
the way around to the Y N
every has its own label so it it it it
may be it not be smaller than it x n is
equals to Y and the number of elements
in y n should be equals to the number of
their data points in x n okay
cool now what we can actually take out
we can actually take out our y hat i y
hat I which is the predict prediction so
now you might be thinking that okay
every individual parameter has beta0
beta1 all there are the beta P okay p
number four now should we are we going
to multiply beta 1 with all the
variables over here beta beta beta is
the two with all the variables and how
exactly the hypothesis function how
exactly is will this work
a very very interesting question so your
prediction your prediction why had I why
had I was a prediction first of all you
have beta0 beta0 by default comes in
beta0 times x zero so basically
sometimes you know what we do we
actually have a n times P plus 1 10 and
N times P plus one in this case we add
another column of 1 1 1 1 1 1. we'll
talk about that why do we add one okay
so your you get a predict you you
actually have this prediction y hat I
which is beta0 plus beta1 x i One beta 2
x i 2 plus beta all that are beta p x i
p what does this mean this will you
you'll only have to understand if you
understand this thing okay so you have
your Y and Y how you can get your
prediction you can get your prediction
which is y hat I which is why hat I you
can get your prediction you can get your
prediction you you can get your
prediction from your model by for
example eventually you have to make you
you have to make a prediction for
calculating how well your equation is
right so you actually have a parameter
Vector which is beta0 beta one all done
or beta P which is the which is of size
of p plus one p plus 1 because there's a
p number of features plus one which is
beta0 okay
so you multiply it so basically in this
case we also add there of one over here
so I'm just going to add to make sure
one one one all the way around to be one
so only one so this this indicates X
zero okay so that beta0 multiple gets
multiplied with this we'll talk we'll
talk about that uh in a bit so we have
this particular and now when you
multiply this Matrix with a vector it
should lead you to a vector of your
predictions so every individual sample
have will have it because uh because a
row is a data point second row is
another data point so basically it's a
column columnar difference you know
what I'm speaking about is assume that
assume that you know make you you have a
data like this you have a data like this
you have data like this okay data like
this and data is mostly you know like
this so you have uh so this particular
Point has this label Y and now you have
to make the prediction for this y hat I
so that you can compare the both and
then the take out the differences so
take out the Y hat for this particular
data point and then for this particular
data points so for this part because
every row is a data point every row is a
data point okay what is it that that
will eventually help us in taking our
this or learning from our data okay hope
so that it makes clear
we'll talk about this uh this in a bit
but before that whatever exactly want to
convey to you all is you can actually
convert this you can take this X1 you
can take this X1 you can take this X1
which is all the uh
this this column into into a a row
Vector you can actually convert this so
X1 transpose which means eventually x x
one or S like like click this we can
convert like this and then you have X2
transpose X and transpose you take this
and convert this into a row Vector take
this converts into a row Vector this
this this has its own benefits we'll
talk about that and your cost must
become like this we'll talk about this
all of this in retail just will will
come come to this please ignore as of
now
cool so you have X1 x2ox X3 all the way
it's it it has some feature we have the
x0 which is beta0 and then you get a
prediction y using nothing okay
categorize as I've already talked about
this your p number of samples are
generalized to P samples and the
parameter Vector p and we have y Vector
Y which is the ground truth okay you
have a matrix distribution which is
nothing but which is also the data
Matrix and the design Matrix now based
on this now based on the every
individual data point will have its own
prediction uh will have its own
prediction and then we compare with the
ground through the actual prediction and
then take out the error and then take
out the error okay so every data date
data point has its own prediction and
then and every column has its own B2
which is the beta values
okay
understood in this case you are seeing
that exorcism being ultimately
aggregating of the information now let's
get started let's get started in how can
we actually how can we actually take out
the Y hat one y hat two y hat three y
hat I all the way around the number of
features which we have let's exactly
work on that so y hat one which is
equals to beta0 which is equals to beta0
which is uh equals to beta0 so where I
am going to write it up I don't know
yeah in this case see this example uh
now over here I think I read I written
sorry now you want to make now you know
now you want to get a uh predicted
prediction you know a prediction vector
and then you have your y uh and and then
you have a ground truth over here put
your prediction vector and first of all
you have this one you you made a a
column where you have one one filter
okay why you'll notice and then a
parameter Vector B okay when you
multiply this Matrix this is this should
be equals to this should be equals to so
when you multiply this Matrix with a
multiply with this Matrix of the product
The Matrix is n times P plus 1 y p
number of columns plus one column which
we added right now times you have P plus
1 times 1 is B number to columns which
is one and will there is only one column
so when you when you actually we under
take out the take out the multiplication
between both of them the dot product
between both of them multiplication with
the product okay
in this case what we'll do you have
beta0 as I said that every individual
Point has its own prediction okay it
should not be like this it should be
like this every data point is is is a
row okay so beta0 times 1 beta 1 times X
One One beta 2 times X12 all the way out
of the beta P times x 1 P so basically
you take the first row you take the
first row of the vector multi take the
take the dot product between the first
row of the design Matrix or data Matrix
with the first element of the vector
and multiply with every element of the
first uh row of that every element sorry
sorry I I think I just mess it up I
think I just made up you take the first
row of the I just I'm so sorry let's you
take the first row of the design Matrix
and then you take the vector so
basically you have your you you have
your row Vector you multiply with the
you you you multiply with the column
Vector so you take the dot product
between the row vector and the column
Vector row vector and the column Vector
which is nothing you'll come up with One
X One One X one two all that are the uh
this X
1p so X11 x 1 2 all X1 P all another X
and there is one so take this and then
you have a column Vector which is beta0
beta 1 beta take the dot product between
both of them so dot product will yield
to something like this so beta0 This
beta0 multiplied with this one beta 1
multiplies this then plus of course beta
3 beta 3 multiplied with the third
information beta 4 multiply the fourth
information fourth fourth information
the I did uh fourth information a
particular data point in that fourth
information okay I enter I in ith index
and then you have got your prediction
you just take out this and then go to
your prediction now you go to Y2 which
is the which is the prediction for the
second row okay for this second row so
basically you do the set you take the
second row you take the second row and
then you take the uh and then you take
this Vector do the dot product with both
of them it is beta 0 times 1 beta 1
times this is the same information this
is the same information it is the x21 is
it is saying that is the second data
point of the first ever of the same this
if the size of the how does the second
data point okay second data point of the
first information so beta1 times x21
beta 2 times X2 beta 3 times 6 2 x 2 3
so you have this b y two all different
out of the y n all that are the y n you
you do for all the round of y n which is
a y uh n number of uh predictions which
is beta0 times beta 1 x and one which is
the nth data point for the first and for
any data point for the first information
the beta 2 times x 2 x and 2 which is
nth information for the second sorry NF
data point for the second information
any data point for the third information
and nth and for n and a data point for
the piece information okay and between
you have y i which says that you have
beta0 times x times of course one times
of course one because everything is one
in the end and that first case beta 1
times x i one I three data point for the
first information either a point for the
second information either a point for
the third information and either point
for the beat information right and this
is nothing but your prediction function
for nothing but your simply
uh multiple linear regression hypothesis
function okay you can write this in a
coefficient in a vectorized format which
is y hat is equals to X B and this will
yield to n times 1 vector
I hope that this makes sense okay
now over here now once once we have this
now you can I actually uh now once we
have the multiple you have the
hypothesis function uh we'll do a verb
example just like we did for linear
regression simple line regression we do
a simple work example for you to be
better comfortable in
um okay
cool
yes so now you have this now you have
this now you now what you have to do now
you've got your buy now if you compare
this y hat I with Y how well your how
well your this particular uh equation is
so this can be which you have you you
have this J of PETA which is your cos
function which is nothing but equals to
this which is for defined for simple
animation but eventually you will notice
one thing you will notice one thing you
have your vector in this case you have
your vector in this case you have Vector
in this case you have Vector in this
case right of course you can write your
vector not a big build you can actually
what you can do you can actually you
know take out uh something you can take
out something like this you can have the
Y hat and Y and then subtract it and
then you're getting another vector and
then you simply add all the elements in
that vector and divide by the number num
number of terms you can actually do this
but this is computationally
computationally expensive and
computational expensive we avoid in
machine learning because it's already
two not too much you know
um what do you say but you know very
every time taking so what we do we have
a vectorized as we have the vectorized
hypothesis function if someone is
vectorized which is computationally good
we have convex vectorized cost function
as well which is defined by this which
is Geo beta which is 1 by 2 em X beta
which is your prediction function which
is the prediction which is why you had
eventually y hat minus y transpose X
beta minus y hat well sorry y not this
is your prediction and this is a ground
truth prediction ground through so you
have this Vector this this also use the
same Vector this this yields the vector
this yields the vector this is the
vector this is the vector okay so how do
we how do we derived this cost function
so let's let's talk about how do we
derived that
okay so let's let's break it down let's
break let's let's not take this let's
take a very simple example where you
have very where you have a vector X
where you have one one and then you have
first first information first first data
point of the first information so first
second item one for the first and if you
have only one predictor which is an
independent variable and then you multi
and as you have only one uh information
you have beta 1 and beta0 as as as a
simple integration but let's frame this
on a multiple things okay so when you
when you want to take the prediction
it's nothing but X beta so you take the
beta0 and beta 1 this this the first row
multi take the dot product between these
two the the vector which is the
parameter vector and the first row uh
and then when you take the dot product
and then the and then you write the
equation over there and then take this
this particular vector and then multiply
with this Vector sorry row Vector then
you dot the dot print between both of
them the dot rate between the row vector
and this Vector so you'll get the three
data points out here now what do you do
now you have this now the what will so
you have the prediction for you have the
pre action from your model now what you
have to do as I said that you want to
you want to identify what is the
differences between both of them right
as please note that if you want to know
the geometrical perspective of course
Solution please see my previous lectures
because I've already told this I'm not
going to tell again and again so you
have now you take out the errors the
residuals how how apart from they are so
you simply have the prediction function
the printed the prediction which which
you got X like XB which is equals to
nothing but the back Vector minus y hat
which which is nothing but what which is
nothing but a ground truth okay
so when you see this when you see this
you will simply have this and now we
have to as as as to as to remove the you
know the squared sign here sorry the
negative sign we Square we Square so
this is going to be square so if this is
going to be square so every individual
parameter is going to be squared so when
every individual parameter is going to
be scaled now you can see that this is
going to stay so you can actually you
have X beta minus y beta sorry X beta
which is the which is nothing but which
will yield the prediction function which
Vector minus the ground root transfer so
basically let's remove transfers as of
now so you have a couple of times x beta
minus y so you say simply take the
transpose for better multiplication of
both of them and eventually you will be
getting a very nice so you have noticed
a pattern you know using a vectorization
it will eventually helping you it is
helping you out
it is helping you out very very easily
it is helping you out so basically you
you you're simply multiplying You're
simply multiplying this two times the
this square of this so basically you
have this so you have this transpose for
better computation you can see for that
if you a field we'll do one sample
example just to see how does it work uh
so now rather than doing this extensive
computation you can simply you know
multiply the subtract the vector and
then take take out the dot productivity
in both of them to actually get the
answer
okay
hope so it makes sense
okay yeah the dot for a bit in both of
them to actually take out the answer and
then you divide by 2m or 2 over here is
added because of the green decent
convention but you can actually remove
these two as well to take out the what
average
I hope that this gives a good sense
about how to how do we came with this uh
cross function uh efficient cost
function
um apart from that I think we covered
pretty much very very well about this
multiple line regression uh and then now
once we have this cost function now
you're able to evaluate it now what
we'll do now we want to minimize
minimize the cost function you'll see
that how I do that how I do it using
again gradient descent I'll choose I'll
showcase you the difference between the
partial data as we are using the partial
derivative why we are using a partial
derivative a very interesting question
but I'm just I just wanted to be with
the convention I just don't want to use
that d d is used for scalar programs but
this partial that depth derivative is
used for what
is used for
um
Vector formula but but basically uh I
think uh I'll just note it down for you
for for you all that okay here we are
using uh in terms of future notation the
the reason why I use that uh partial
derivative in that uh when actually
we're solving green descent is for so
that it so so that it works perfectly
for a fusion notation which we'll study
right now so it makes you be a bit handy
otherwise I could have introduced video
so you might be confused so that's why I
didn't introduced over there
okay so cool I think it's now in the
next video we'll talk about how can we
optimize our cost function and apart
from that I'll show you an analytical
analytical solution how can we without
any procedure we can just take out our
beta's value in matter of no second in
in a matter of no time with Pro with
calculating and then we'll talk about
how can we evaluate uh and then we'll
talk about uh some of the hypothesis
testing uh which is t-test f-test and a
lot of things going to come up and you
will be eventually enjoying all of this
thing and after that what we'll do we'll
talk about something known as uh
assumptions of linear regression some of
the assumptions and then we'll do
another project as well uh you'll be
super duper enjoying that as well I if
I'm enjoying to teach you all of this so
let's catch up in the next lecture
London bye-bye hey everyone welcome back
to this lecture uh so basically uh we
are at linear regression where we'll be
talking about multiple linear regression
I already have the notes for you but
that's bit less so I just want to
elaborate with you uh to you with some
exam which may help you to understand
much more better so we'll do a we will
have a set of worked set of examples for
you to better understand all of these
things okay so let's get started now so
basically uh let's have a let's have an
example so that I can show you the
vectorized operation and everything so
assume that example over here is X1
uh X2 X in X1 you have one two three and
four and X2 you have two three one and
three and then you have the you have a
two independent variables and then you
have one dependent variables which is
three the four point five four and six
so you have the data available you have
a data available like this so let me
just draw a straight line you have a
date you have a data available where
these two uh these two variables which
is out here these two variables are
independent
Independence this is no dependent output
variable and this is nothing but your
white or your dependent variable or your
dependent variable okay so this is the
data now so now so now you have the so
now you can make a design Matrix so you
know so now you can make a design Matrix
first of all uh first of all we'll we
will calculate the we'll have the
hypothesis function out there okay so we
are now we're gonna train our linear
regression model on top of it so how
will train first we will uh put put that
in form of a matrix which is nothing but
um
one two two three three one and four
eight and then we have one one one I'll
show you what is the use case of this
one just in some just in some you know
uh moments which you will see that why
we are adding one more over here so let
me just have this in a nice way if x
equals to one one one
so with the we have the design Matrix
we'll talk about this later on we'll
talk about this later on and then you
have beta and then you have beta so
basically every individual feature has
its own beta right so beta1 and beta2
beta 1 and beta2 right beta 1 but but we
also have something else beta0 right so
how beta0 basically when we do the
multiplication so basically we take the
first row multiply with the uh take the
dot predicate in the first row and and
the vector B so basically the here is
here we have only two for example assume
that we haven't taken this particular
one one one then we would have only one
two and this this would have been left
so we have to multiply beta 0 to 1 as
well right because beta 0 times x 0 x 0
is equals to one that that's why so you
assume that you that you have
initialized your beta
with uh maybe a zero so but before that
you have the beta over there and then
you have your ground through ground
throat Vector which is three four point
five four and six three four point five
four and six okay so you so you have
this uh ground Truth uh over here now
what you do now let's now with the
available settings now let's let's do
one thing let's form a hypothesis
function so you can get your prediction
vector by multiplying Your Design Matrix
with the with the parameter vector and
this will yield to to
um this will lead to a vector this will
yield to a vector which is equals what
what was our design Matrix design Matrix
was one one two one two three one three
one one four eight and then let's
initialize our beta value beta0 beta 1
beta two all the all the way to zero
because we have to you have to find the
best setup so in the first iteration
what you do you just initialize
okay I hope that this really makes sense
uh to you
now once we have that now once we have
that what we will do after initializing
our beta values after initializing our
beta values to zero what we will do
we'll simply have this zero zero zero
and now we'll take the field we will
take the dot review the first row and
the column of that the first row The
Dropper when both of them will yield
nothing but Zero The Dropper between the
second row in this Vector will lead to
zero this and this is zero and zero so
predictions your predictions are zero
which is a y hat so once you have the
predictions from your model when your
betas are all set to zero you'll be
having that okay
and then and then now we have to compute
the cost once you have the model
prediction I have to estimate how well
how well so when you when you have the H
of X in this case is nothing but beta0
plus beta 1 x 1 plus beta 2 x 2. so with
B resor is nothing but zero times X1
plus 0 times X2 so how well this this
equation or best fit line is of course
this is super bad because we have
initialized as this is the first
iteration so let's compute the cost so
when we compute the cost when we compute
the cost of it
cost
function so cos function is computed by
this so we have already had a talk on
the derivation of our cost function
which is nothing but 1 by 2 m
X beta
minus y Vector transpose X beta minus y
okay so this this was our equation so
let's let's first of all compute let's
first of all compute X beta minus y okay
so when you how can a cow can you come
come compute this we have model
prediction minus the ground truth moral
position was 0 minus 3 0 minus 4.5 0
minus 6 and 0 minus uh sorry 4 and 6.
okay this was 4 and 6 so you have your
model friction minus the ground truth
which will yield to a vector which is
minus 3 minus 4.5 minus 4 and minus 6
this will be your uh this this this will
be your when you calculate this now what
we will do we'll take this we have
calculated now we'll take the transpose
of this so when you take the transpose
of
the transpose of this which is nothing
with equals to minus 3 minus 4.5 minus 4
and minus 6. we have this this
particular transpose Vector now we have
the transpose Vector now what you have
to transverse Vector multiplied that
multiplied with this particular Vector
then you will have Simply Now
you have uh one by e 2 m so here you
have here you have four examples m is
just one two three four four date four
data points one two two by four is
equals to eight one by eight times one
by eight times minus 3 minus 4.5 minus 4
minus 6 and then you have the non
transverse Vector which is minus 3 minus
4.5 minus 4 and minus 6 when you
actually calculate this up and you can
actually calculate this up which is
nothing but which is sorry
so this is nothing but
um nine plus uh 25 so 9 plus 20.5 plus
16 plus 36 as you multiply the element
wise operation
and then what do you do and then you
simply add it up and that will jio beta
will heal to
10.156 so you'll have this
um
okay so you have seen that how we have
taken an account of this hypothesis
function after that we have had this
taken out the and and we have taken out
the cost pension out there I hope that
this gives you pretty much a good sense
about how exactly we cover up things now
this was our vectorized operation out
there right so how this vectorization
really helps so this is a very important
topic to talk on maybe it's very useful
as well to talk on like how
vectorization question how vectorization
how vectorization helps how
vectorization helps so if you were to do
this normally you know if you if you
were to do this without any vectorized
operations first of all let us assume
you know you don't want to do it with
any vectorized operations first of all
even with calculation of hypothesis will
take too much of time no nested Loops
will come in will take too much of time
so when you have this particularly your
Zen general form which is the word h of
a h of X is equals beta 0 plus beta 1 uh
X1 plus beta 2 x 2 right so you put in
the value of x you would have put in the
value of x and then calculate you put in
the value of X2 calculator okay
and put it now that's for that's our
first data point and then you do first
second date I'm going to third port so
you do for all the four data points okay
now after this now after this what you
what what you will do you'd have take
out the diff that that you have to take
out the errors for every for every
individual right so that would take a
ton of time right so that's why we we
over here you have seen that how
Simplicity by at the only one time it
just calculates our error okay
cool so um so what are the what are the
operations involved what are the
operations
involved which you have studied right
now so operations the first operation
which is involved is compute the
compute your hypothesis or compute XB
which is nothing your X is nothing but M
times n plus 1 Matrix where you have one
included for 1 1 column and then you
have a beta which is nothing but n plus
1 Matrix and and then you have nothing
but n plus 1 Matrix okay and then you
have a beta which is nothing but n plus
1 Matrix uh sorry uh n plus 1 times 1
Matrix or the vector where you have
betas are also included that's why we we
have this plus one okay so compute this
so computation takes the the complexity
will take uh some order so that's the
first and operation is involved second
operation which is involved which is the
which is taking out the error like this
and then what you do and then we take
the transpose of this and then we take
the transpose of this and then we
multiply it okay so this is the second
method information and after you
multiply it you will be getting your
answer so the total time takes it's very
less as compared to the you can also
take out the runtime complexity you want
so now I hope that this gives a good
sense about what exactly we trying we're
trying to offer now what we'll do now
we'll go forward and talk about uh how
can we perform a gradient descent how
can we perform gradient descent outer
okay so that's the first question to
tackle so let's go ahead
and have this cutting template
and let's get started how can we perform
gradient descent okay so basically so
basically
um how can we perform limits right
gradient
descent
amazing question right so how can we
perform so you have J of beta your cost
function is nothing but 1 by 2 m
X beta minus y transpose X beta minus y
so this was a cost function right so now
this is a COS function as I've studied
that you have to take the partial
derivative of a COS with the gradient of
a COS version so there's a difference
between partial derivative and
derivative so there's a difference
between partial derivative of cos
function with respect to a parameter and
uh derivative of so previously so
basically this we use if we have the
scalar program if you have a scalar
program just just like we saw in our uh
previous simple simple a linear
regression but in this case but in this
case but in this case
um this particular thing we have a
vector program which we saw in a multi
multiple linear regression but I just
introduce you this into the first only
so that you'll be comfortable with what
exactly both mean the exact same thing
but this is for Vector programs this is
what Vector programs and this is for
scalar programs so basically whenever
you have whenever you have betas in
Vector you actually use this and then
when you have the same scalar you
actually use this okay
so what you do so what you do you take
out the you you take the debt you take
the dairy partial derivative of G of
beta with respect to a particular beta
why we take out and everything we have
talked that it gives the rate of change
it gives about everything the whole
story of geometrical we have already
talked about so you take the partial
derivative of it so that you can
identify the rate of change how much the
cost which is changing with a beta is
changing so that when you take out the
derivatives which actually gives 1 by m
x transpose X beta minus y so when you
actually take out the derivative I'm not
going to talk about the
um how can we derive it it's not
required maybe for you if you're not a
calculator student but we of course have
the reading materials for you to get
started with it okay so so what is what
is the Grid in descent algorithm so once
we have the gradient once once we have
the gradient calculated out here what
you can do we have the algorithm
following so go for I for I
in for I in range
number of iterations you want to perform
you wanna perform you want to change the
variable so that you so so so that you
can converge you take out first of all
the hypo if using hypothesis function
you take the doctor between NP dot dot X
and beta and then once you have the
ground truth now what you do you take
out the error now you take out the error
which is why you had minus y this y hat
is nothing but your modification and Y
is right and then you have a gradient
now you now you take out the derivative
of the gradient at that particular point
and over here it will sort of vector
will do one solved examples to better
for you so we take out this so we take
out the derivative of the gradient and
that particular point which tells us how
much how much uh change we are getting
in a cost function if we change the beta
a little bit which which was nothing but
which we have derived this is nothing
but 1 by m
times the doctor between the dot product
between your
your views so basically this is the
docker between the error this is the
error and it's the transpose let's take
out the top between the transpose of
your X which is this and the error which
is this so just simply multiply okay at
now once you have the editor once you
have once once we have that once you
have the gradient we can actually use
the update rule so your beta new will
contain beta old minus the learning rate
Alpha which is nothing we're learning it
Alpha multiplied by the gradient
multiply with the gradient which is okay
right this is the derivative which here
another partial derivative constantial
with respect to particular uh variable
okay
so I hope that this the this is the
algorithm which is for multiple line
regression let's try to do one thing
let's try to solve solve a very simple
example of using a grid in descent okay
so assume that I'm going to take a very
simple data set which is X1
X2 and Y which is 1 2 2 3 3 and 4.5 So
based on this on a predict the output
variable y so your design Matrix will
conclude f 1 1 okay because this is
important x 0 and then one two and two
and three this is a design Matrix this
is a design Matrix
okay and then you have a output the
ground root Vector which is 3 and 4.5
and then you have parameter Vector which
is 0 and then you have bit 0 0 so beta0
beta 1 and beta dou beta0 as a proper
bias term beta1 is the parameter of X1
and we advise the parameter of term of
X2 okay assume that your learning rate
Alpha is 0.01
and then now what you do now you compute
the gradient so now what to know because
but before that what you do but before
that what you do you compute the you you
run this algorithm the first step in
this uh when one running this algorithm
you're going to calculate your y hat and
the calculator y hat which is nothing
but X beta which is nothing but 0 0 okay
you calculated now you calculate the
error which is nothing over there which
is nothing but your 0 minus 3 and 0
minus 4.5 which is nothing but Z minus
Three N minus 4.5 which is nothing but
this is nothing but the error the the
difference now once you have the
difference you calculate the gradient at
that particular point where you
calculate the gradient in that
particular point which is nothing but
one by two one by two which is over here
m is equals to 2 that's why one by two
multiplied by your your dot product
between your X transpose the design
Matrix and the error the doctor between
the design Matrix which is the design
Matrix over here is one one okay which
is one once you attempts the transpose
of it will be one one
um
one two sorry sorry I guess I did a bit
wrong over here it should be one two
okay so one two and two three okay so
one one one two
and two three so when you take out the
transpose of this particular Matrix
you'll get this multiplied by multiplied
by oops
and multiplied by your uh error error or
difference Vector which is this okay so
when you calculate the gradient you
calculate the gradient you will end up
being well you'll end up being with uh
this particular variable which is
nothing but
it'll have c c let us assume that you
have variant now what you do you have a
gradient so when you actually work on it
when you actually work on it so this in
the new set of beta so I'm going to come
to the gradient here this is a good this
one even when you solve for it you'll
you'll automatically get it okay you'll
automatically get it just when you solve
for it okay so you get all the values
and you solve for it and then you have
the new beta is equals to Old beta minus
learnings and grad okay this this
particular grad and this is also a
vector okay so your new beta will be a
Vic Vector which is a three elements
which is the old beta is also three zero
zero zero okay minus 0.01 multiplied by
your vector multiplier by your vector
which is the C1 which is C2 and C3 in
this case if we exactly want to focus on
exact numbers this will be nothing but
minus 3.75 minus 6 and minus 9.
okay
so this is the basically uh the the the
C will when calculate will come out
which is nothing but your new set of
betas new set of betas will be zero zero
zero minus 0.01 times minus 3.75 minus
0.01 times minus 6 minus 0.01 multiplied
by minus 9 so you have this one and then
you actually calculate this 0.0375
0.06 and then 0.09 so this is your new
set of vector after first iteration okay
and this is the first iteration now now
you now after calculating the new betas
now betas are updated now you what you
do you you you run this once again with
the new B test calc with symmetrical
gradient and then get the new beta and
then do the same thing unless you the
number of iterations reached I hope that
this gives a good sense about how
exactly we work through and
um
for geometrical perspective you have
already talked a lot
cool um so I'm just trying to make sure
that you have every worked example into
your hand so that it's much more better
for you to understand it next what we
have next we are done with mostly um
this we'll talk about a bit about
analytical solution of linear regression
and then we'll talk about how can we
evaluate our model uh specifically and
then after that we have a lot of things
layer so let me just go there
so after the calculation we'll talk
about hypothesis testing which is one of
the most important thing over here which
is the how can we test our model the
significance and everything and then we
go to the next step which is nothing but
um actually talk about assumptions of
the model and then we'll do one project
and they'll wrap up this course in this
video what I what exactly I'm going to
do is talk about something else
analytical solution of linear regression
so basically what exactly we'll talk
about the anal what exactly we will talk
about in the analytical solution of
linear regression is you have direct
formula you have direct formula for
taking out your beta values by putting
your X and y's into it so how this is
derived and everything I'll be linking a
very nice resources in this particular
reading section of this or you or you
can see in the resources section for
this particular lecture I'll I'll give
you how do we derive this formula but
it's pretty easy if you get to it you'll
have the assignments as well for on it
so basically we have the direct formula
when we plug in the values of X and Y
and then we get our output variable y so
sorry uh betas right so we have an
optimized beta which is converged
because it's the best beta right so
there's a direct formula which is which
we call analytical solution that so
basically
uh so basically the formula is X
transpose X then we take the inverse
multiply with X transpose y so so let's
talk about let's let's talk about
um
and let's try let's talk about by taking
one particular example so assume that
this is a particular example you have
one one one one as X zero and then you
have one independent feature and one x0
which is nothing but for beta0 and then
you have output and then you have Target
variable uh which is Y which is the
ground truth now we utilize both of them
to actually take out the analytics to
take out the beta's values right so
basically so the first step is to
calculate the X transpose x x transpose
X so when you take out the sodium take
out the transpose of this so This column
this column becomes a row and row
becomes the column so basically one one
and five seven two zero and then you
have the particular Matrix Matrix out
here which is two uh two by five Matrix
multiplied by five by two that will
yield to two by two Matrix so when you
multiply this up you will get a two by
two Matrix which is nothing but this one
okay now the next step what you do is
take out the inverse of it so what is
the inverse of it or inverse of any
particular thing is one by this okay one
with determinant of the inner value
which is one by determinant and when you
take out the determinant of this
particular which is nothing but which is
nothing but multiplied by this minus
multiple minus 54 times 54. so this is
determinant this is which is not not
nothing but the area under a
parallelogram we have already talked
about the terminal everything in great
detail please see the linear algebra
lectures so when you take out a
determinant you will have 674 and then
what you do you take out the adju gate
of that and then and then you take out
the aggregate of that so educate of that
would be nothing but
um this one this particular Matrix and
then you multiply with 1 by this with
the the as you get Matrix where you will
get the your inverse of a particular
Matrix now once you have the inverse of
a particular Matrix now what you do you
compute you compute X transpose Y which
is this one you now we compute X
transpose I you'll get this particular
thing and then finally multiply this
particular Matrix this particular Matrix
and this particular vector by far
getting beta0 and beta 1 and that's the
required beta0 and beta 1 which is your
regression equation okay
I hope that this makes much more sense
uh now uh so uh as the as this was very
simple example uh for a calculation of
this but I actually want you to just
don't uh remember how to how exactly
those this is something which is uh
softwares are made to do it for you so
you don't need to worry about this what
you need to worry about is uh uh is this
particular thing like what exactly this
trust tells is here we have the formula
which directly gives our beta values
okay uh if this if this is not if you if
your this meter is not invertible
invertible it cannot be inverted then
you need to remove the extra features to
ensure that your D is smaller than or
equals to n so here the number of
features is less okay so uh this is a
very general General thing which you
need to know but uh but let's talk about
what is the difference between this this
is important this is usually asked in
interviews what is the difference
between gradient descent and closed form
Solutions gradient descent requires
multiple iterations okay so you have one
iteration second and it requires time
and you need to choose the alpha value
as well and it extremely works well when
you have when you have a large number of
features it is not it does not works
well when you have a large number of
features okay it supports the
incremental learning it suppose the
incremental learning okay it is a non we
can close from which is non iterative
it's just plug in the values and then we
get up values and then it's no need for
Alpha values we don't need that it is
slow if n is large if a number of
features large it is slow because it
will compute all the operations which is
linear algeb operation which is quite
expensive and then you have this
particular thing which is nothing but a
you can you compute X transpose x uh
which is roughly order of NQ which is
extremely extremely time taking so if
your if your data is small and is small
then I suggest to go close form but if
data is you know large then I support
incremental learning which is great
indecent okay
I hope that this this gives a very great
sense what exactly is an analytical
solution means now what we do now what
we'll do we'll talk about how can we
evaluate our machine learning model by
going on to the next slide so let me
just make a template let me just make a
template
uh over here so toilet paper and over
here what I'll do I'll talk about some
of the methods how we can eventually uh
talk about how can I evaluate our
machine learning model in a right way
okay so uh so the first uh the first
measure which we have already have seen
earlier is nothing but known as mean
square error so the first measure for
evaluating how well your model fits the
data which is nothing but mean squared
error so what exactly mean a square
error is is the average of this great
difference between the predicted value
and the actual values and emphasizes the
impact of larger errors on overall error
so basically what exactly this test
tells you have the MSC which is nothing
but 1 by m some sometimes you write 2
over here as well but let's ignore two
ways of now so 1 by m multiplied by I
equals to 1 all the way around to the
end all day round to the end all the way
around to the m you do you you you do
for every example for every example for
every examples you take out their
prediction take out their prediction uh
sorry you you you take out more
prediction minus y i which is minus your
ground truth and square to remove the
negative to remove the negative sign
once if so to remove the negative error
if if there's any right so basically
what does it tell what does it do it
gives you it gives you
it gives you the the the difference is
the overall differences the overall
difference is the overall
differences
in your model but that's a one note to
be taken out here one note to be taken
out here you see that we are taking mean
you see that you are taking mean so mean
is highly affected by outliers so assume
that you have a 2 3
2.56 and then 99 you understand this
this can easily affect your energy
however models performing best value one
example is a perform very worse right so
over here your MSC will yield to very
bad example to to a very misleading you
know misleading uh error because it is
it is waiting eventually taken a mean
and this is something giving us a
misleading outcome right this is
something which is to give giving out
the misleading outcome so basically we
say that it emphasizes the impact of
larger errors on the overall sense so if
you've got the if you if you if if
you're getting that a large MSC that
means that it is not something like
every error is performing it emphasizes
it emphasizes what is emphasizes the
impact of large errors the impact of
large errors like this like this in
overall sense in overall in overall
sense but I just told about the MSC so
that's one of them another one is
another one is is about mean absolute
error mean absolute error so it's the
average of the absolute difference
between the predicted and the actual
values it measures the average magnitude
of errors in a set of predictions
without considering the direction so
basically so basically what it does
tells that you have mean absolute error
and what does it tells that the first of
all the formula for this is a nothing
but 1 by m
I is equals to 1 all the way down to the
m and take an absolute value of y i
minus y i okay and not squared over here
please note that we have that you don't
need to square so basically what what
we're doing and rather than you doing
Square to remove the negative sign
you're taking the absolute value and so
that we get rid of negative terms so
basically that means that if we get rid
of negative terms if we if we get rid of
negative terms if you did get rid of
negative terms what does it mean it
means that if you don't have if you
don't have any direction it it does not
if while you take out this then it does
not a negative a positive reduction it
just says we don't have Direction so if
we get the rate of negative Direction
which also means that we get rid of the
direction without the considering the
factor of whether it is positive or
negative and let's not focuses on that
okay
um so uh it does not consider detections
but it takes the average of the apps
when you take the average you'd be
positive positive B positive C take the
average okay it is not taking out the
differences that consider that is going
in other direction it all in the like
consistent like it's it's like we're not
considering Direct in this case so
that's mean absolute error that's one of
the way to think about it okay
and that and another one which we have
is nothing but called root mean squared
error which is nothing but called root
mean square error so let me let me just
write root
mean mean squared error or somewhere we
call rmse so what does rmse means this
is a very important uh thing to talk on
rmsc is nothing but a square of your
mean square error square root of your
mean Square so when you take out the
square root of Mac that will give you
rmse which is root mean squarer okay
that is the square root of that it has
the same units as the dependent variable
so why does we
um
why do we take out MSE because the units
are same as the depend the target
variable that's why it is easier to
interpret you know some sometimes we
take out the MSE because we want to come
back at this format where it was okay
you can understand in that way here we
squared it no we're going to come back
at where it was without considering the
negative sign so here it tells you the
it it converts back to the units which
was previously in okay cool though so
these are very small errors which I
really want to talk on uh one of the
important and most important is nothing
but called are
r squared error r squared error and in
that we have SST which is uh which is
total sum of squares and uh residual sum
of squares which we'll talk about that
today okay
Okay cool so let's talk about these both
in great details so that
um you have a very nice understanding of
what exactly you need to do okay cool so
um let me just start off with one
example so let's say let's consider a
very simple example to illustrate the
the the the the R square error so assume
that you have a data set with one
independent feature okay and one
dependent feature okay so let's consider
your the index number the observation
number which is observation number is
one so we have X which is the in index
which is 1 and Y which is also which is
the target which is three okay so two
two 5 and then you have three three
seven and four four nine so you have the
index number the the OBS the observation
number the observation number and then
you have and then you have the
independent feature and the dependent
feature so basically on a map of
function x to the output variable y okay
so now so now you've built a linear
regression model on top of it when you
built a linear equation or model on top
of it uh basically we need to do the
hypothesis test we sorry we know we need
to predict we need to predict the Y hat
right so that we can calculate so that
we can so that so let's take an example
beta0 is something there 0.1 and beta 1
is also 0.2 then you want to test it
right so you have to take you have to
say you have to perform the predictions
on the X and then compare the prediction
y hat with Y right so your y would be
nothing but so your your actual y was 3
5 7 and 9 and your model predicted 3.5
5.5 7.5 and 9.5 which is the model which
richer model has predicted okay now we
have to compute the r squared we have to
compute the r squared so the formula for
compute we'll talk about the geometrical
meaning in just in some minutes but the
formula for computing the r is squared
the formula for computing the aspect is
nothing but 1 minus SSR divided by s s t
okay this is the formula for calculating
the
um
what formula for calculating your r
squared but let's talk about let's break
down what is SSR and what is SST so SST
is nothing but it's the total sum of
squares so SST is nothing but total sum
of squares which is total sum of squares
what does it tells SST represents the
total variation in the dependent which
is the variation in this so let me just
highlight this the variation
the total variation between the
dependent variable is represents the
total total variation in the dependent
variable uh difference is what what
difference is what variation it shows
between whom so it shows between the it
shows that the total variation how much
variation you get into this okay how it
shows that by showcasing the difference
between the actual value and the mean so
your SST your SSD formula is nothing
you'd go for ISO soon all around the m y
i minus y which is the mean device and
and and squared okay to get rid of
negative sign so what does it tell it is
explaining about your why it is
explaining about a Target variable it is
where the where we take out the
differences between the differences
between your uh prediction your your
action not a prediction ground explains
the variation between the ground and the
mean of this so what is the average so
assume that average is six so the what
is the so three three minus 6 which is
minus three right so the variation
between your variation between the
actual values and the means what is the
most common value value in this and what
is the What is the who who are in beside
of them what is the variation is over
there so that's what it tells so
basically it is saying the very we have
already talked about variance a lot I
don't know if this this customer once
again so it measures the variability of
the target variable without the
considering the influence of the
independent variables over here are you
seeing I'm taking y hat I'm not taking
my hat I'm just taking out I'm just
taking out the variability of my target
there how much my why is spread out how
much my why is Target variable which is
dependent variable is varying out right
it's wearing out without considering our
betas wouldn't beta1 because over here
this is this is our data right we are
not considering anything we're just
taking the Y uh which is we are just
taking the Y uh which is the mean and
then we are just trying to take out the
variance we are just trying to take out
the variance between uh with with that
mean so basically and then we are not
doing any sort of if there is no any
influence there is no influence no
influence of your independent variables
we are not used there is no influence of
the these independent variables or in
literally anything over there
when we calculate so so your formula for
that was SSD was this where to summarize
that you're taking out the differences
between your predict your your not
predictive the ground truths values the
target where the the actual Target
values and the mean of that to take out
the difference uh so to take out the
variation in that particular or the
variability in that particular variable
okay which is why then you have nothing
but something known as SSR is nothing
but SSR so which is which is the full
form is nothing but residual sum of
squares so the formula for this is
nothing but SSR is equals to uh I is
equals to 1 all the one out of the n y i
minus y hat I squared so this is
something which if I'm which you're
familiar with here we are taking out the
taking of the the variability of the
dependent variable so basically we're
taking out the variability of the
dependent variable considering our y hat
considering our ads but you can take out
the variability of this here we are
adjusting out a variability without
considering the Y head here we are over
here taking over Liberty whether
considering the y-hat because we are
going to definitely taking the residuals
through it explains it represents the
unexp uh the it so basically higher the
variability May higher the variability
method more the difference and more the
difference back the model because your
model could not be able to predict so
higher the variability explained in this
which means that the more the model is
not able to capture which means that
more is not to explain again I'll
summarize in very simple terms the SSR
Is Nothing But whichever studied so I'm
just going to reframe in different terms
that you're taking out the variability
of your dependent variable taking the
variability of your dependent variable
considering the effect of Y at how
you're doing that previously in SST what
you're doing you're taking on that
variability of Y hat without considering
of Y hat just sticking out the mean of
that and then just taking out the the
way the very with the variation but of
yeah you're thinking the variability
with the considering so higher the
variability means that your three is far
away from 3.5 that's what it means you
know so if the variability is high that
means the errors
this how spread they are from the mean
so basically the the variability is also
which means the way the variability is
high the model could not capture it the
model could not learn it in a nice way
okay so SSR over there is indicates that
this is the formula so now once you
about know about SSR and SST now you can
easily come back to formula and what
does it tell let's let's talk about that
so your formula tells me your formula
tells me so assume that we want to take
out of R square so first of all let's
let's take out wire y uh which is let's
let's put let's take out the r squared
for this position number three point
three plus five plus seven plus nine
divided by four which is number six and
then you have s s t you take out the SST
which is which you'll get a 20 and SSR
which is residual which is nothing but
two okay now we can easily compute it
now you can easily compute it which is r
squared which is nothing but 1 minus 2
by 20 2 by 20 which which will get 1
minus 0.1 which is 0.9 which is when you
convert in percentage term which is 90
so the r squared value is 0.9 which
means that 90 of the variation in the
dependent variable y can you explained
by the independent feature X using
linear regression so if we are able to
explain if if our if if there is a 90
variation in the dependent variable that
means that 90 of the answers are able to
correctly are your email generation
means model is able to give 90 of the
correct answers you this is ninety
percent this this is your model is able
to correctly identify ninety percent of
the examples you'll understand in this
way ninety percent of examples are
correctly identified okay but it's not
exactly what I'm saying is something
like 90 variation ninety percent
variation is explained by your model
which means the ninety percent of your
variation which is which is perfectly
explained so the if if the variation is
low if for example it's 20 20 so this is
pretty pretty much low so your model is
not able to uh exp your model is not a
best fit because it is not able to
explain your model if your 99 90 by 90
you model your line vision is able to
explain the X explain the in the is
explained okay I hope that this gives
you goods and what exactly this is
higher the R square value good the moral
is because it's able to explain more
variations in the dependent variable y
given or explained by the independent
variable X so X is able to uh which is
your linearity model is able to uh
explain your why okay but one thing to
be noted over here there is
one thing which I really want to write
over here
over here maybe let's write it out so
the r squared which means that the X
percentage of X percentage of the
variation of the variation
in the dependent variable in the
dependent variable
y can be explained
can be explained
by
X using LR so this is what is said so if
the variation is large then then your
model is good but if the variation is
less than your model is not but it
depends on problem to problem as well
okay but but over here see over here
that you have X so what is it tells then
there's if there's 90 percent of the
video for in this example the 90 the 90
of the variation in this particular Y in
ninety percent of the variation ninety
percent of the variation in this
particular Y is explained by X is
explained by x x seems to be useful
feature is explained by X using our
linear regression okay so if 90 of
variation is explained you can
understand your your you are able to
your you've given the information you're
able to correctly under 90 of them okay
so this is this is one way to understand
it but yeah this is a very messy thing
to help you understand r squared we'll
have one practical example to have a one
one more lecture on square and there is
something whereas adjusted R square
we'll talk about that buckets and the
end of this lecture I really hope that
you really enjoyed this and now we are
coming to the ends of our lectures
specifically cool so uh we'll talk about
uh hypothesis testing which is one of
our last phases and then we'll talk
about assumptions uh which is one of the
my favorite Topic in the world do
project and then we'll end up this
lecture hey everyone welcome to this
video is uh in this lecture what exactly
I'm going to do I'm going to talk about
one of the second last topic of whole
regression analysis course is about
hypothesis testing and hypothesis
testing is one of the most you know
ignored as well as one of the most asked
questions
um that the topics from which the
interviewers asks integration analysis
and we'll talk about this in pretty much
very detail with several examples as
well like how do we use hypothesis
testing a linear regression we'll have
the Practical implementation of it as
well in various terms and uh and then
after and then after uh working on the
hypothesis testing we'll go forward and
talk about uh I will go and forward and
talk about something called as some
something known as assumptions of linear
regression where we'll talk about
something but that's for later purposes
currently our aim should be finished
this hypothesis testing in very detail
now one thing which I recommend over
here is sometimes you will see formulas
I would suggest you to completely
ignore those formulas okay um sometimes
you know there is a some some formulas
will come up the main idea from which
which you have to take up is how you can
understand the concept the core of it
formulas can be seen later on as well so
how can you understand the core of it by
understanding the Crux by several
examples which I'll try to take Okay
cool so now what so now what we will do
we'll try to start off with this but
before that I just want to clarify some
of the things that uh as as I say
formulas will come please ignore if you
if you're not able to understand it and
at any point if you're not able to
understand I suggest go to a Discord
server go to a Discord server and ask
directly by giving the time stamp you
should tag the help or create a ticket
directly out there and then ask the
question uh in a machine learning
section about uh any such questions if
you have so let's get started eventually
uh with this with this
um
basically uh you you have you must have
studied about hypothesis testing in
statistical and probability lectures uh
if you haven't please I consider to
watch a little bit of lectures around
hypothesis testing because I assume that
you know a little bit about hypothesis
is testing however I'll I'll I'll also
describe over here if you don't know but
uh I if if you're not comfortable with
Statistics and probability I would
suggest the highly suggest to go and
watch our stats and prop lecture stats
and prop lecture which is one of the
most important you know uh lectures but
it is available on our course which is
cs01 or you can say machine learning
course machine learning course by Anton
you will be able to see everything out
there but let's get started with
actually this this lecture so basically
what is hypothesis testing hypothesis
means some sort of statements or to be
made some thought some sort of
statements which is not yet means this
is the hypothesis which we want to test
we see now this is a hypothesis which
you want to test so the formal
definition if we go to hippo this is the
formal definition if you go to a
hypothesis so hypothesis states that the
the hypothes states that is what that
the statement or the explanation like
for a statement is made based on limited
evidence or maybe small amount of
evidence for example for a for example
one or one of the example that that one
of the example can be if you stay up
late then you feel tired the next day
that's that's one of her hypothesis
that's one of our hypothesis right
um so these are some of the hypothesis
so how can we test that hypo how can we
validate that hypothesis is valid or not
how can we validate how can we valid the
current example which you have taken the
current exam what example which you have
taken the example which you have taken
to see we say we we are saying that if
you stay up late then you feel tired the
next day that's one of the example so
how can he add if I stay up late if you
stay up late how you'll find like how
can we validate it so hypothesis testing
deals with validating your hypothesis
yes
um using several tests you know you
conduct tests for identifying that but
but never mind let's actually talk about
uh let's keep talking about hypothesis
testing so it is a statistical method in
terms of statistical maths it's just a
statistical method which helps to make
decisions about the data eventually for
example that statement what was that if
you stay up late if you stay up late you
feel tired if you you you feel tired
okay
um that's one of them another one is
let's say let's say for the sake of the
example another hypothesis can be daily
exposure to Sun leads to increased level
of Happiness that's one of the
hypothesis so previous hypothesis was
that the previous hypothesis was if you
stay up late if you
stay late if you stay late you feel
tired you feel tired you feel tired
second example of a hypothesis exposure
to sun exposure to Sun what does it
leads it leads to increased level of
Happiness increased level of Happiness
increased level of Happiness so this is
one of them so these these are some
examples so basically hypothesis testing
what does it do what does it do it
validates it validates whether this
statement is true or not based on the
data which takes the decision whether
this statement is true or not based on
the available data based on the variable
evidences okay so there are eventually
two types of hypothesis which we
generally know something else a null
hypothesis and alternative hypothesis or
or you can say H1 so s0 and H1
so what does it mean like null uh or an
alternative and blah blah blah so let's
talk about uh both of them in great
detail so that you you you could
understand in pretty simple language
um so let's take an example that he that
uh that that your hypothesis is that
that your hypothesis what is your
hypothesis which you're not validate
you're gonna validate whether whether
you're let's take in a pharmaceutical
pharmaceutical company uh invented a new
drug of weight loss drug okay so they
they invented a weight loss drug they
invented a weight loss drug and they
want to test they want to test this
hypothesis that the weight weight loss
is effective okay and if the hypothesis
is true then we say that if this this is
the hypothesis what is hypothesis weight
loss drug is effective okay so we're
gonna test this happens whether this
weight loss drug the company invented
with the new weight loss which they have
invented is it effective or not so this
is a hypothesis which we want to test
which we're gonna test okay so there are
two types of hypothesis the first one is
no line second one is alternative so
what is the null hypothesis in this
particular example the null hypothesis
in the in this particular example the
new drug the new weight drug which is
which is which is published or which is
evented has no effect on decreasing your
weight okay so we say that so we say
that your null hypothesis the in the in
the population this is the population
mean which is that that indicates in the
pop in the pop with the drug effect on
the population is zero means the drug
effect on a lot of people is zero okay
and that's null hypothesis what exactly
no hypothesis States it says that a drug
has no effect but an alternative
hypothesis what is it states it states
that your drug has an effect your drug
has an effect on decreasing the weight
loss which means that a population the
the in in the population this is working
which is not equals to zero what does it
mean ecosystem and what does it mean to
mean the population mean equals to zero
which means that it has no effect
population which is not 0 which means
that it has some effect okay because if
the mean is zero the on the number of
people for example this this is going to
assume the number of people which for
which this drug if affected is zero
which means that the drug does not
affect but over here it is so the drug
eventually affected the population okay
so how can we value how can we test it
so basically so basically we want to
test we want to test whether whether
whether we will consider null hypothesis
or alternate and uh a particular example
this particular
can be either classified in null or
hypothesis or alternate hypothesis so in
a context we want to conduct a test
we're going to conduct a test we're
going to conduct a test to identify
whether it is null hypothesis which
means the drug has no effect and an
alternate hypothesis which means the
drug has an effect okay so this is two
of them which one to go forward so we
have several tests in our statistical
tools to conduct whether whether the
drug has effect or not some of them are
t-test f-test and there are several
other as well so we'll study about
t-test in real detail F test will be
given to you as in homework uh to
actually work on your by yourself
because we want you to be not even spin
food like this we just want you to be
export and everything by yourself as
well so you now now you're at a journey
where you have to explore things by your
own right if you have came over game
over here this means that you have
achieved a lot in your career as of now
in terms of learning okay so now so now
as you so of course when you conduct a
test it will give some sort of number
assume that c right so in in what and
then what we do we call for example
you've got C so so a week so we know
you're going to classify you know you're
going to classify whether whether this
is a null or hypothesis so if if that I
assume that you conducted a test as in
though don't worry we'll talk about
Easter in the great detail you conducted
a test and then you got some number c
okay you got some number c so we check
we check with the significance we three
with a threshold and we say that if your
if your if your test value is is smaller
than is smaller than is it smaller than
this particular 0.00 which is five
percent which is five percent smaller
than five percent then what we do we
reset the null hypothesis and then we
accept the alternate hypothesis which
means the drug then we re then the drug
has an effect so if if your if your TV
if your value from the test which you
conducted is smaller than the
significance value which is 0.05 this is
a standard threshold which we keep
foreign
test will give you some number and then
you and then you compare with it if if
the test value is smaller than this then
we say that the drug has an effect why
we'll talk about that later on great
detail as well about this don't worry
okay and then if if it is if if it is
greater if it is great out your T value
is greater than this then we say that it
is a alternate hypothesis sorry if we
resect the alternate hypothesis and then
accept so basically anything a widget
anything above the five percent and your
your validity value or the test value is
greater than five percent then we say
that the drug has no effect and then we
say the drug has no effect it is smaller
than five five percent the drug has an
effect okay
and that that was one of one of the
example let's talk about in great detail
this this was just an example to
Showcase you the hypothesis testing but
how we use the hypothesis testing in
linear regression that's what that's one
of the most famous questions to talk on
um I just I just was uh getting a Red
Bull I'm so sorry for that okay so uh
how can we think about in terms of
linear regression and this is something
which everyone needs to know about this
this is something which every everyone
needs to eventually know about so let's
get started with that as well yes
cool so how can we use that in uh linear
regression in linear regression so
basically
so basically
um I'll just go through a past example
so that you could be understandable in
the easy way I rather prefer all of this
thing okay so this is this is one of
them this is one of them where we talk
about F tests Yeah so basically how does
we formulate our hypothesis in terms of
linear regression so in a case of linear
regression the claim is made that there
is an a relationship so what is an
hypothesis hypothesis is that there is
there's exist a relationship between a
response and a predictive variables now
you might be thinking why do we need
hypothesis testing why do we need
hypothesis testing so basically how and
how does it helps and how does it helps
now this all of this might be in your
question but first of all I I understand
that your question is so let's go ahead
and talk about why exactly we need
hypothesis testing so assume that assume
that
um you you want to build you want to
build you want to build a function f
that takes in the number of hours of
study number of hours and the attendance
per percentage of a particular child and
then predict what what will the exams go
so so it takes the X1 and X2 and
predicts Y which is the exam score okay
so it takes X1 and X2 and predicts Y and
this is a nice uh this is the function
which you have to build this is the
function which you have to build up okay
so you have um now now now
it may happen now it may happen now what
what do you want to do you want to
interpret right is this significant to
outward variable is this information is
this particular independent X1 is
significant what does that mean
significant significant means important
okay
like you can understand is is it
significant is it even reliable for this
so basically what we do
and the first hypothesis formulation is
is there exist any relationship between
both of them yes or no how can we
identify a relationship between both of
them how can we identify is there any
relationship between both of them uh the
input variables and router variables by
calculating the significance okay how
much this value X1 is significant to
this output variable y okay because this
is important in terms of the the reason
why it is important the reason why it it
is important see example X1 and X2 and
you're getting the Y so so basically you
identify the relation between both of
them so if there is no relationship then
your machine learning model will be not
able to perform well so you can tell to
stakeholders that there is no
relationship it with the in into the
number of hours a particular student
study that that whatever number of hours
to do in a particular study it will not
affect exams course exams course will be
the According to some of the factors
okay so this can be one of the possible
factors so if we should first of all uh
assure ourselves that there is a
relationship okay this is this is one of
them so there is a relation how can we
identify there's a relationship between
input variables and output variables we
can identify the relationship between
the input variables and output variable
by identifying the significant say the
significance of our input variables to
outward variables okay so we can say
that okay okay so this is uh is this
significant to our output variable yes
or no yes or no is this significant to
our output variable yes or no X1 is
significant so if a is is so question is
is your is your number for our study is
significant to your exams course
so this is the this is the hypothesis
formulation hypothesis formulation what
does it says that there is a
relationship there is a relationship
there is a relationship between input
and outer variable between between input
and output variables or independent
features and dependent features okay and
then we go to the X2 and then say okay
is this something related to is this
something is the X2 which is the
attendance is also is is also
significant talk about yes or no okay so
this is how we this is this this is why
important because we want to distribute
into identify is this very even
relationship and assume that X2 does not
have a significant so we can drop this
column we can drop this feature if you
drop this feature it will definitely
help us in getting the robust model
because this is just unnecessarily over
here because it's not contributing to
your output variable does not have any
relationship with output variable
understanding what I'm trying to say I'm
just trying to convince you just I'm
trying to convince you that there is a
relationship there is a relationship
there is a relationship if there is a
relationship that's that's the build of
a hypothesis formulation
we'll talk about all of this in great
detail but you can understand this
exists a relationship between the
Institute between the response which is
the Y and the predictor so if that's the
hypothesis formulation okay so what the
the formulation of hypothesis times says
that if the claim is represented using
the non-zero then then the alternative
have this is the uh this is Alter
alternate hypothesis and if your beta
value are zero then this is a null
hypothesis I know you didn't understood
anything let's talk about uh what is
what exactly that space statement says
so what will be our null hypothesis in
this claim and what will be our
alternate hypothesis null hypothesis
null hypothesis means that there are no
relationship between whom between your
independent X1 X2 and
um y there's a row no relationship
between X1 and X to Y and what is the
alternate hypothesis alternate means
completely opposite okay that there is a
relationship there is a relationship
between X1 and X2 and Y okay so in so we
now now how can we how can we say that
how can we even make it more
mathematical so null hypothesis we can
can we say that null hypothesis where
your beta1 and beta 2 are equal to 0. or
we can say all your betas are equal to
zero or your all your beta 1 and beta 2
are are equal to zero null hypothesis
means so if so for example let you I
know it's it's very simple to understand
the concept please apply your mind now
over here that you have your hypothesis
which is beta0 or um beta 1 beta X1 plus
beta 2 x 2 okay you're understanding so
if we say that if we say that that if if
if there is if there is no effect if
there is no effect of this an output
variable which means that this is equal
to zero this is equal to zero all right
bro I'm just trying to say that if if
this is equal to 0 that means that will
do yield to 0 and that will it does not
that will not affect your output
variable but whatever eventual null
hypothesis is saying that your X1 X does
not have any significance right so where
beta 0 is equal to zero that means that
X1 does not have any significance if
your beta 2 is not is equal to 0 that
means X2 is also does not have any
significance in output variable okay so
here all betas will be equal to zero a
null hypothesis all betas are equal to
zero in a null hypothesis an alternate
hypothesis says that alternate
hypothesis which means that all the
betas are not equal to zero are not
equal to zero that's your hypo this is
your hypothesis now you might be
thinking a bit of off key how this is
how this is coming again I'll summarize
it for you
that your h of X is nothing but equal to
beta0 plus beta 1 x 1 and beta 2 x 2. so
so null hypothesis what does it say is
that there's no relationship if there's
no relationship that beta will be down
if we make beta 1 to beat a beta 2 to b
equals zero that means it will hold
yield to zero and this will hold you to
zero which means it's not affecting any
output variable right but what if if
there's if if the if there's something
out of zero that is alternative which
means that that it is affecting some
sort of outer it is affecting some sort
of output a variable so a null
hypothesis we say that all R beta value
are nothing but zero but alternate all
our value is nothing but not equal to
zero this is our hypothesis for
emulation in linear regression I hope
that this gives you a very good
understanding about what exactly we aim
to start solving about uh this okay
so so now you can see that if everything
is equals to zero if everything is equal
to 0 that means this is a null
hypothesis which means that does not
have any output that does not have any
consequence or output variable but if
there's not even result that means they
have a consequences on output variables
so there are three types of tests we
should uh talk on uh which is test for
significance of regression is it a
regression problem or not maybe it can
be easily classified when we'll talk
about linearity assumption it can be
easier talked about a linearity
assumption which will see that later on
one is test t-test which checks the
significance of individual to
coefficient regression coefficient so
what is it tells so what does it tells I
think I did a little bit wrong yeah yeah
so it what is the T Test us T Test as I
said that we have a hypothesis where our
s0 where what does null null hypothesis
indicates there are beta values nothing
but equals zero and an alternate
hypothesis what does it indicates either
beta value is not equal to zero is not
equals to zero this is our formal
formulation apart is testing which on a
test original test so in a test we want
to test whether there's exist
relationship or not so we have a test
right we conduct a test and then it gets
at some certain value let's assume C so
if that c is a smaller than 0.05 it's
more than five percent we'll talk about
that this this again significance just
in a second but if this model then then
we say that we say that we reject the
null hypothesis that means the there's a
no release except that there is a
relationship but if it is greater than
0.05 that means that we reject the
alternative with that there is no
relationship between the variables okay
reject this in order and then we accept
this uh we'll talk about the
significance just in a second so this
test check the significance of
individual regression coefficients
individually okay not something like
over it's it checks that whether it be
whether this X1 is is six is significant
to Output variable or not or whether
it's X2 is significant to Output
variable not how does it checks that if
your beta 2 is equal to zero so your
your hypothesis will be a zero where
beta 2 is equals to zero NH hypothesis
with beta 2 is is not equal to zero so
this is a hypothesis it checks
individually it checks individually and
once it checks individually we can
easily take out the overall overall
significance okay so so so if we take if
we take out individual uh significance
then we can easily is okay this X1 is
not in the not significant then we can
remove this X1 how how can if the beta 1
of X1 is a zero that that means that it
is not significance and then we have
something known as t-test and then we
okay uh sorry F test and F test is used
for taking out the overall significance
the overall significance overall
significance of your regression barriers
overall which means whether this overall
equation is significant or not okay
significant means overall so the
hypothesis formulation would be the null
hypothesis would be beta of all the way
devices and an alternative which is all
the video value is not not equals to so
this is the hypothesis form formulation
three test let's talk about the first
test t-test def test will be left left
upon you to explore I hope that I'm
giving you a very great knowledge is out
of it and I really hope that you'll
utilize this information because for me
it takes a ton of time you know to
develop this and I hope that you will uh
that you will that that you're enjoying
this course out till here and if your
till here that means that's something
you're a special guy you know uh that's
you're a special guy and you're always
up for very big challenges out there
okay cool so now now I've been talking
about something known as significance
value so we'll conduct the t-test so how
can we how can we conduct the t-test so
there are some steps for conduct for
conduction of a t-test
I'm directly going to the you know
t-test uh formulas so that it is my it
it will make much more sense to you only
when we'll do one example
okay so let's go to uh
one T Test example yes so you're a so
your first so you're basically again
I'll just write the t-test example so
that it makes much more sense yeah so
your so your hypothesis formulation is
hypothesis for emulation is so assume
that let's take an example because I
really like to take examples in every
bit whatever I'm explaining because that
something is makes me motivated to like
your and you're able to understand by
the simple examples so example what this
example says example says that you want
to build a simple linear regression
model we build a simple linear
regression model build a simple linear
regression model and what is that same
simple integration more model it will
build the function f build a function f
that takes in the the text and the
square footage the the the the the
square footage or or or you can see the
size of the house size of the house and
predicts your price and predicts your
price so given the x value is going to
predict y I'm just taking a simple
linear equation to make you understand
so in this case what zero
okay and Alternatives means that your
beta1 which means the beta1 which is the
beta 1 is the say is the coefficient of
this X1 right beta1 is not equal 0 which
means that there is a this this means
there is there is no relationship no
relationship relationship between X1 and
Y which means that no religion resizes
the house and price the size of that
does not affect a price and this there
is this alternate means there is a
relationship between X and Y that means
that that means that there's the release
the size of the house definitely affects
this price okay so when you fit when you
fetch the linearization model and you
fit the linear version model you have
the following equation now what you do
you calc you do the test now you do the
T Test how will do will talk about just
in some sentence but the formula for a
calculate for the formula for doing the
for the formula for doing for for for
doing this test is we as we do
individually for every parameters right
if we do the individually for every
parameters so the T we calculate the T
statistic the t-st statistic for whom
these statistical for the size of the
house because it does individually
assume that it assumed so we'll take the
take out the T for every individual
parameter So currently I'm going for
only one so it takes a t statistic for
the size of the house which is estimated
coefficient estimated coefficient the
coefficient value so in this case it
will be
beta 1 minus zero beta 1 minus 0 divided
by the standard error of that beta 1. a
very nice equation of very confusing to
a lot of people now let's talk about why
does it confusing and let's talk about
each and every Integrity of it okay each
and every Integrity of it so uh we'll
talk about why are we subtracting it why
are we dividing with sound error what is
a standard error and yeah so and and and
and after conduct after conduction of
this test what we do so that it makes
much more uh sense to you in your
initial stages as well okay so let me
just uh let me just open my uh from a
calculator because this is something
which I'll be required which will be
required so let's first of all talk
about let's first of all talk about the
general formula so the general formula
for calculating the t t value to
statistic for a particular beta for a
particular beta is nothing but estimated
coefficient that is coefficient which is
estimated because we have to take every
this happens stress testing only can be
tested if you if you have a fully
trained model so that you can test your
hypothesis okay estimate coefficient
minus 0 divided by standard error of
that coefficient standard error of that
coefficient so what does it measures
what does it measures so what we do what
we are doing over here so basically
we're calculating the T statistic and
then we are subtracting the hypothesized
hypothesized value from the official
from the estimated coefficient so so you
might be thinking what is hypothesized
value you this is something which is uh
confusing to most of the people so
hypothesize the value is the value of a
coefficient under the null hypothesis so
we we first of all assume okay in uh
basically what basically what we do we
hypothesize something we make a we make
something like true like there's a no
ratio we prior to assume that there is
no relationship okay and then we
disprove that and then we disprove that
so hypothesized value is zero in this
case because your hypothesized value is
zero okay so estimated minus the
hypothesized value which means the value
of the coefficient under the null
hypothesis okay this is the hypothesized
value which is
if the beta 1 is equal to five that that
means I'll write a five over here
already assume that there's no
relationship now we disprove that uh
with with with t statistics so if you're
not even disprove that that means there
is no relationship but if you're able to
disprove then we accept the alternative
hypothesis okay so over here this
actually usually that there's no
relationship so basically we subtract
with the hypothesized value and then we
divide by the standard error so what
does a standard error means what does
standard error means so let's just go
and talk about uh let's just go and talk
about a very nice explanation of
standard error because this is something
also also people you know uh worry a lot
about so standard error is nothing is
nothing but
um uh it's it's nothing but accuracy the
accuracy of an estimated value the
accuracy or how much uncertain or how
much uncertain your regression
coefficients are so I'll take a very
simple example to make you understand
about this
um so basically assume that uh so assume
that you built a linear regression model
and the standard error is the measure of
uncertainty of the estimated
coefficients and then describe the ratio
basically uncertain uncertain
uncertainty means the student standard
error so I'll just write it over here so
standard error it measures the
uncertainty uncertainty uncertainty or
the accuracy
accuracy or preciseness or the
preciseness of the estimated
coefficients of the estimated
coefficients this is a very important uh
to talk on that that the standard is
nothing but the accuracy uncertainty
preciseness so that lower the
uncertainty means better your
coefficiency so basically it evaluates
basically it evaluates how your
coefficients are uncertain how how your
estimated coefficients are accurate how
your uh how your uh how your estimated
coefficients are precised and all so
these are certain uh certain words to
talk about so basically so basically you
calculate so basically you calculate and
say that okay this is something is used
this is something it is used to indicate
how precise or or precise or accurate
your estimated value are okay so again
you might be your might be thinking so
you might have beta 1 equals to two beta
is equal to 2 by estimated by your
gradient descent okay by estimated by
your gradient recent that's one of them
so when you estimate a beta1 so how
precise how much how much precise this
is how much precise is how much accurate
this is is how much earns how much
uncertainty it contains how much
unsureness how much it we are sure about
this
we quantify that so we quantify how much
we are sure about that we quantify how
much we are accurate about a particular
beta value that's what the standard
error means standard error means how
much we are sure about that particular
beta value okay how much you're sure
about that I hope that it that I hope
that it gives you so if your standard
error is high if your standard error if
it's time if you if your standard error
is high that indicates that there is
more runs under uncertainty more
uncertainty a less accuracy less
preciseness
okay so if your uncertainty is high
which means not sure about that that
means that is bad no if you're not sure
about if you're not too much sure about
the particular coefficient that means
that that that means that there's
something wrong with it if it's super
accurate with that and you're also not
accurate so if your standard is small
that means that your alternate is low
which means you are too sure but you are
able to quantify things you are able to
quantify how much sure and unsure you
are so in this case if you are sure if
your unsureness is too low which means
that you're sure of that beta values to
that that means that is uh that is good
so your assignable error should be less
so basically what we are doing so
basically what what we are doing we are
simply subtracting we are simply
subtracting sorry we are simply first of
all the now now you understand this full
equation you have you calculate the T
value calculate the T value which is
beta 1 minus 0 divided by the standard
error so now what does the division
gives you what does the division gives
you this is something which is usually
taught in the statistics class classes
and I usually recommend you to not even
uh which is the which is the which is
not even recommended for you even if you
if you if you're just curious you can
just go ahead and talk about things uh
but what exactly what I'm gonna do is
talk about my interpretation from what I
under understood because that's
something you know I I also have to take
care whether whether I understood it
nicely or not right
um so uh let's talk about that uh
otherwise it will be bit off to me as
well so the T value which you're going
to get over here the p-value which is
going to get over here which will give
you which will give you a number so that
we can compare with the threshold we'll
talk about to the threshold just in some
second just just after this topic so the
T this is called the T statistic this is
called the T statistic is that is what
is the what is this test it helps us to
assess the significance of the
coefficient relative to the variability
or the the estimate or the uncertainty
of our estimates so what does it tell
again I'm going to repeat it tells you
please remember the significance it
tells you I'm just taking in same very
I'm not taking very mathy you know if
you if you go online no everybody is
taking so mathematic things I'm not able
to even understand why they are taking
mathematic things but it tells you the
significance it tells you the
significance of a coefficient of a
coefficient relative relative to the
uncertainty uncertainty uncertainty of
the estimate of estimate that's exactly
what it what what what is it t-test
gives you in geometrically if you
understand it geometrically it can be
thought of as how many standard errors
the how many standard errors the
estimated coefficient is away from the
hypothesized value so again
geometrically meaning
and geometrically meaning I know this is
something uh this is something
unconfusing as well I can I can ask you
to ignore it as well but uh but if you
just want to understand it much more
depth it will be easy for you so it can
be thought of as a it can be thought it
can be thought as uh it can be thought
of as how many standard errors how many
standard errors as standard errors are
away are the the the the coefficients
the coefficients the standard errors of
the coefficients is away from the
hypothesized value is are we from what
is hypothesized value which means that
we already assume it which is
beta is nothing which is which
hypothesized value which is equal to
zero so what does it get now this is
something which which how many standard
errors are away from that away from that
okay so now what does it give the taste
test the the what does it give is it
gives uh so if one once you calculate
your T once you calculate the T
statistic so we're gonna understand two
ways either by this particular example
of this particular what does it give is
significance of a coefficient relative
to the uncertainty unsureness what is
the significance of particular
coefficient with respect to the relative
to the there is uncertain uncertainty of
the estimate higher than certainty like
it's not good right so the last T
statistic so now let's talk about what
does it mean if you have a large t
statistic if you have a large D
statistic what does it mean if you have
a large D statistic so if you have a
large D statistic you it indicates that
your estimated coefficient is different
from the hypothesized value
is different so last is statistic means
that your that your estimated
coefficient that your estimated
coefficient is different is different
from the hypothesized value is different
from hypothesized value which is s0
which means that there is a relationship
that there is a relationship between
your h j which this is between your beta
1 and y okay
so this would last the statistic mean
you will will be talking about it
usually it depends whether if you have
the P values we have to compare with our
P P value but as of now why do we do why
do we divide we divide it because
because it tells you the significance of
our equation now once we have the
significance now how can we say that
okay this is the perfect like how can we
identify whether to accept the null
hypothesis or whether you expect the
hypothesized value which means that the
pre-assumed thing which is there's no
relationship or should we accept it or
should we reject that there is that we
have an Evidence to say that that there
is a relationship between that okay uh
let's talk about that this is something
important to talk on as well I'm just
talking uh too much and so sorry for
that but it's actually 30 minutes but
that but this is something which is
important as well uh in terms of
understanding level as well okay so
let's talk about uh P value let's talk
about p-value so p-value over here what
is it p-value means so so once we have
the t t statistic we once we have the T
to if we compare with the threshold
value usually
this threshold value 0.05 or 5 and we
say that if you T statistic is less than
five percent is less than five percent
then there is a then we can resect our
null hypothesis and then we can reject a
null hypothesis and say that there is if
it is greater than five percent then we
say that okay this is something
um
we can reject the alternative that there
is no relationship then we can say that
there's no relationship if your T
statistic is greater than like the three
critical value the T critical value okay
uh currently T statistic is different
from T critical value D critical
valuables will talk about it just in a
second but assume that you got a some
critical value and then you compare with
a 0.05
okay
okay so uh you can take a break as of
now even I'm speaking for the last 40
minutes but that's all right this is
something which we have to do if you
want to understand uh hypothesis testing
in detail
um so so basically what is the so so how
can we say that how can we say that that
if your T critical value the critical
value the the value which you will get
the probability the the the critical
value which you'll get is if it's more
than five percent then only if it is how
can you support that statement we can
say that how can we say that how can we
say that as I said as I say that the
null hypothesis is a statement that
assumes that there is no effect there is
no effect on the relationship so there's
there we introduce the concept of
something known as P value and threshold
value odd is also called nothing but
p-value so what does p-value means it
says that it says that the observed
result is unlikely to have occurred by
chance alone and so basically what does
it mean I know it's something uh chance
and all it's something which is also
very great to understand it
uh but I'll take a very simple example
uh so that you have uh a nice
interpretation so assume that you want a
300 test if new weight loss supplement
is effective on weight loss or not again
the same example which I've taken up so
you conduct experiment on two groups of
people so group number one and group
number two conduct on two groups of
people and then once you are one groups
that takes the supplement and other
takes the uh place which is the other
takes the supply once one group takes a
supplement other does not fix that
supplement okay so hypothesis what does
null hypothesis States null hypothesis
is that there is no effect of that
supplement
okay that there's no no effect and and
no difference there's no effect so
basically there is a two groups again
there's a two group group number one
group number two so each taken their own
treatment affect the supplement those
the supplement number one and supplement
number two okay so the null hypothesis
states that there is no difference
between these two so in identify if
there's any difference that's a
hypothesis and uh the the hypothesis uh
the alter alternate hypothesis says that
there is a difference which means that
if there's a difference that means there
is something cooking in that so we can
of course use that for treatable effect
but I bought the null hypoall state that
there is no difference so after you
conduct the experiment you calculate
your critical value and then what you
have a significance you value and then
and then your critical value comes
critique critical value 0.02 0.02 okay
and 0.02 so your value is 0.02 which is
the T critical value by by doing the
bike taking all the T statistic you
calculate 0.02 now now your threshold
was 0.05 0.05 right so so what this
means that that means that there is
enough evidence to support that the
weight loss supplement has an effect on
the weight loss so there is a Soviet X
we reject the null hypothesis we reject
the null hypothesis
represent so if if your critical value
is is a smaller than your significance
value then we say then we reject then we
reject our null hypothesis and accept
our uh alternate hypothesis
now you might be thinking why the why
does it happen like that why does it
happen like that
uh this is something uh this this is
something which also you need to
understand so this is a general thing if
a critical value is smaller than this
then we say that okay reject the null
hypothesis and then we accept that
there's a so but if but if you got 0.07
that means that you have to resect but
you have to reject your alternate
headphones except the null hypothesis
okay I know this is something hard to
understand as well in the initial level
but you have to understand it anyway
assuming that you have the name for this
cool so how can we connect this how can
how should we connect this P value the
concept of p-value to linear regression
so the so in linear regression your
known hypothesis states that the
independent variables and dependent
variables has no effect your independent
variable has no effect on the depending
which means so all your betas are equal
to zero and the P value associated with
every coefficients help us to determine
uh that has a significance with us so
basically you have a critical value in
this case you will you'll be having
critical value for every uh betas okay
so correct currently we'll be having
critical value or the P P value for this
size which states that which states the
significance of our size of the house on
pre on the price
and so in this example in this example
as we have seen so you obtain so you
obtain the p-value or we can see so
there are P value or we can say critical
value we can say critical value by
taking the T test and then and then
comparing with the t-test distribution
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
this you calculate the T test after
calculating the test over here after
calculating this after calculating this
you compare after you take out you know
after you take out some number you
compare with the table you compare with
the table and the table you it is a
table which is already uh published on
the internet okay you you don't even
remember everything you don't need to
worry about how this came you compare
okay this this is something over here
now this is uh we have to we'll we'll
select the how do we select the p p
values as well later on but you you
calculate how much significant how what
is the probability that this is that is
that size of the house is significant
okay you calculate that P you calculate
the P value for the coefficient of what
over the coefficient of your size of the
house and now we say that if if your P
value is less than 0.05 is a threshold
which is the threshold you reject the
null hypothesis where you say that there
is not enough evidence to accept the
null hypothesis so you might be thinking
what does it mean bro why do we why do
we don't don't cities if it is if your
baby value like if your probability is
higher that means that it is something
significance that is not okay p-value is
always related to the null hypothesis so
higher the p-value is the more you're
providing evidence that there's no
relationship Lord is that there is an
Evidence to reject them there is
evidence for alternative that there is a
lower chance that there is a lower
chance of
um of there's a lower chance that it
occur that it is a a null hypothesis
okay
I hope that you are understanding what
I'm trying to say if you are not then
please watch the lectures once again so
that uh you are able to understand
in much more easy way
um so if if you want I can actually take
an example I can actually take an
example to help you understand there's a
what is chance and all but let me know
if you want to understand about that
like how can we there's a support to
statement how can we say
how how can we say how can we say
that why not greater why not greater uh
currently you can understand this way
that if the P value is smaller if the P
value is smaller than 0.05 you reject
the null hypology except the ordinary
hypothesis okay
if you if you wanna know please let me
know about that as well because I have a
very nice explanation but that is bit of
out of the context of the course but
it's all right I can actually understand
like uh I can actually understand this
this something which people face as well
cool
I hope that this gives a good sense now
let's do a very nice example a numerical
work example
so that you understand it nicely and
then uh I will be done with the t-test
you'll be left with f-test by your own
and we're left with the F test which you
have to explore by your own I'm not
going to talk about that so let's talk
about uh so let's continue our previous
work example our previously worked
example was that your you have a square
footage you have a square footage which
is one thousand two hundred to one
thousand two hundred one thousand two
hundred and then you have 1500 1700
2100 2300 2600 and 3000 okay and then
you have nothing but the Y where we have
the price of the house you can
understand some sort of price okay I'm
not writing the data but I'm just making
it like this okay so your equation will
be beta 1 plus beta0 sorry beta0 sorry I
think I did it wrong beta Y is equal to
beta0 plus beta 1 x okay x x y so assume
that your beta0 as you assume that your
beta0 is nothing but 5 50 000 okay fifty
thousand and your beta 1 is nothing but
equals two hundred okay so we can so
first so let's State our Nolan uh
alternate so no less as H 0 is
H should do is where all your beta
values H1s the Alternatives they are not
equals to zero that there is a
relationship existence you calculate the
T statistic you calculate the T
statistic T statistic how how it is
calculated estimated we under calculate
for beta 1 okay okay because we're gonna
take out the significance of this x one
you calculate the beta 100 minus this is
the estimated minus zero why because
because the knowledge because minus the
hypothesized value in this case it is
equal to zero divided by divided by the
standard error the standard error of
that coefficient the standard error is
also is a it's it's a nice formula for a
calculating of a standard error but in
real world you don't need to worry about
the formula you can actually look on the
internet to calculate the standard error
formula so the standard error which
which you're gonna get the standard
error which which you're gonna get is
nothing but the the whole calculation
will yield the whole the whole
calculation will yield to 100 divided by
10 which will not nothing but equal to
10 so your t t statistic is ten now you
might be thinking here use this is the
greater than this but in most of the
case this will be greater right no once
you calculate the T statistic now you
take now you convert this into you're
going to understand you convert this
into a probabilistic value
understanding this way I used to
understand this whether you convert this
into some sort of proper some sort of
probability value so that we can compare
with a threshold
okay so the four calorie for calculating
the threshold for practic for uh for
calc for calculating the threshold of
critical value for calendar in the
threshold critical value so that we can
compare with our significance so which
is 0.0 so that it can compare because we
cannot compare this we should compare
properties values we calculate something
else degrees of freedom degrees of
freedom degrees of freedom is calculated
by n minus 2 N minus 2 the number of a
fluid number of rows which you have in a
column the number of rows which you have
in your data minus
um which is number of parameters of your
model in this case it is seven minus 2
which is nothing but 5. now you may be
thinking what is degrees of freedom
again new question asked so degrees of
freedom is is nothing so if you if you
also review the notes I have written a
very nice and detailed uh notes on what
is degrees of freedom so that you also
understand it so if you go down so
degrees of freedom degrees of freedom is
nothing so assume that your data set
contains 10 observations and regression
model has two parameters the intercept
and the slope okay in this case as well
it was intercept and the slope the
degrees of freedom is equal to eight so
what is degrees of freedom his use
derives the number of independent ways a
system can change number of independent
ways the system can change this is used
for calculating if you're not able to
understand I I would say ignore it but
eventually even a but eventually this
has a statistical meaning where it says
that number of a number of uh
independent values or the independent
values in a data set so basically beta 1
and beta of course is dependent right
number of independent values of your
model the number of independent why we
say that this number of independent we
can search online about more about
degrees of freedom but this number of
independent value which uh so basically
the two are dependent because it's slope
and intercept which is dependent so we
can subtract it from our whole data
number of observations will eventually
degrees of freedom
degrees of freedom so once you calculate
the degrees of freedom in this case is 5
okay now now so now now your
significance value is 0.05 degrees of
freedom is uh 5 degrees of freedom is 5
degrees of freedom is 5 okay so your
significance is this degrees of freedom
is this now let's go ahead now let's go
ahead and talk about something known as
uh
now let's talk about something known as
uh T table distribution so ACD
open up the T table distribution
to do that you'll need to be online oops
I'm not online that's pretty bad
so yeah so I'll put up the I'll I'll put
up you you just you should open it
online by your by your own I'm not
online as of now so I suggest you should
open by your own so that you understand
it by yourself as well open that online
and then just go to a table and then if
you see and then if you see on x axis on
the top of it yeah you have nothing but
uh you have nothing but T values the the
the
probability which is you have you have
to go to two tails in in regression you
always use two tests not one test the
difference is listed in the reading
materials please see that so in two
tails you see that 0.05 you see that
there is a 0.05 and then if you see the
fifth the degrees of freedom is five
that is the 2.57 2.571 2.571 is your is
your critical T value is
2.571 is a critical T value is a
critical T value now you compare the Cal
the T statistic T test statistic
statistic with the critical value with
the critical value you so it shows that
it shows that if you your of course T is
greater than 2.571 these gradient of
course 2.571 so we resect the null
hypothesis and because this means that
there's a significant relationship
between that so you you you might be
saying that here you should just some
some seconds ago you told that that it
should be smaller than the critical T
value so as not not about that but in
this a t test of course we do in several
examples but in t-test we simply do this
is we simply reject the null hypothesis
in the favor if it is if a test
statistic if a significance a level is
greater than the approximated uh
critical value because of course it
changes no it changes so as I said your
T statistics should be greater than
should be sorry uh should be greater if
the if the significance is greater than
your approximated value then we say that
okay this is something to be predicted
nicely so I hope that this gives a good
sense uh if you want to know more about
all of these things I would really
suggest uh go forward and talk about
have also given several examples above
so if you go and see several examples of
mine of t-test of t-test you can go over
here and talk about like for every
individual predictor variable for every
individual predictor variable you should
be able to view it nicely but my point
was that you can easily use the
materials to actually uh t-test to
calculate t-test statistics and then
approximate the critical value and then
compare the and if the T Test with an
approximately critical value then you go
forward and accept that okay
cool but uh but you know but you but you
have to also make sure that uh your
Trail but but it depends on several
other problems from the test to test uh
so that's that that was pretty much
about uh these statistics statistic
um now what we'll do now we'll now we
are done with almost hypothesis testing
now we'll go ahead and talk about
assumptions of linear regression and
then we'll wrap up our whole course with
the one project hey everyone welcome to
this one of the our last reflectures I'm
super excited that we came along over
here and I hope that you really
understood each and every Integrity of
everything which should which you should
know uh we have talked a lot of things
as of now and it's still not ended here
let's say we still have a lot of things
to explore we still have a lot of things
to cover up and one of the things to
cover up which is one of the most famous
interviews kind of thing is assumptions
of linear regression so basically what
I'll do is I have tried to make it in a
unique way or structural way okay so
basically uh we have several sub topics
to cover in this that's our sub topics
are linearity then you have you know
Independence then you have normality
assumption and there are several other
assumptions listed out here so what I'll
try to do what I'll try to do I'll make
sure that you understand each of the
substation great detail and I'll make
sure that you also do your substantial
research by yourself okay
cool so basically uh let's start off
with the first assumption let's start
with the first example these are the
notes for you to you know review quickly
but I prefer using my own hand right now
so let me just open my new hand which is
uh this one let's open a dotted paper uh
once you open the dotted paper let's get
started now so the first uh so the first
assumption but but what exactly
assumption is now you might be thinking
hey are you showcase this is assumption
but what exactly assumption is and why
do we need to study about this so
assumptions assumptions so what is the
definition of assumption so tell me the
definition of assumptions so first of
all let's get it clear about what
exactly the formal definition on
dictionary says because anything which I
learn about anything I just make sure
that I know that definition of the topic
so uh thing is the the what is
assumptions the the thing that is
accepted as true or as certain to happen
without any proof a very nice uh
definition so what this says when you
apply a linear regression model this
linear regression model assumes a
several thing without any proof it
assumes that your that your data should
be linear it should follow linearity
assumption almost sky or no constant
variance assumption are there a lot of
assumptions so you're so your assumes
all of these things and assumes and
assumes all of these things and then and
then you can expect your model to work
fine so if you're so if any of those
assumptions fail like if any of the
assumptions fails then you then you
cannot explain the LR model will only
perform best you'll only perform best if
and only if these assumptions are met
assumptions means certain things are met
like for example for example uh when
when we have something like let's let's
take an example when you prove something
or uh or whenever when you say now
assume that this is something and then
you put an argument so when assumption
is that not true then how can you say
that particular thing uh will work right
and so uh assume that uh assume that we
have some certain uh assumptions to be
there and then we expect these
assumptions to be true for our LR model
to work perfectly fine okay so this is
this is one of the definition of
assumptions in a great detail now what
I'll do now what I'll do I'll I'll talk
about there are several so so as as I
talk there are several assumptions so
I'll talk about some of the most
important assumptions for you to explore
it out right away and then we can
further get started on uh onwards okay
so the first assumption which is which
which I'm going to talk about is
something known as linearity assumption
linearity linearity assumption please
ignore my handwriting I have to write it
super quickly that's who that's why I'm
writing it super super duper quickly so
linearity assumption says that it what
what does it say is that it says that
the relationship between the dependent
variable independent variable is linear
okay so what does it says the the
relationship between as this linear
regression and so it expects the
linearity Assumption where it says the
dependent the the depend the
relationship between the independent and
the dependent variable are linear so
what exactly linear is as I've already
talked about it means that we can have
the we can have this straight line which
can represent or approximate our data so
we can have a straight line that can a
reasonably approximate our data okay so
uh over here this is a very nice example
of the linearity Assumption this data
where we have only one paint put feature
in the output variable you plot this y
onto this and X onto this now over here
it you it can be your data is linear why
because it can be approximately on the
straight line data but in this case this
is not a linear over here you cannot
make a straight line to say to data you
it it forms something like this which is
not linear okay it cannot be reasonably
approximated as a straight line so
that's what the linearity Assumption
says okay so this is an important why
this is important or by why this is
important because accuracy of the linear
equation model relies on the underlying
relationship which is nothing but linear
okay so if your model is not linear
assume that in this example assume that
in this example the so the errors will
be super super high as and if the errors
are super high which means that your
model is not performing well and it can
fit in any way you're not able to
perform well you have to use extensions
of linear education to work on this data
but we'll talk about that later on but
over here it will not definitely not
work well pretty well okay so this is
something which you should know about
like this is an important assumption
because it will lead to unaccurate
predictions because of high error Okay
cool so once we have those assumptions
like once we have those assumptions so
which which you can see if you plot the
data on a graph the point the point
should show that it should be reasonably
represented in straight line and if does
not form the straight line this means
that they are not significantly
appropriate or we should use as other
significant model which is a probably
normal regression or other regression to
actually make it more appropriate Okay
cool so this was on another example now
as I told once we have these assumptions
once you to okay this is the Assumption
now how can you test how can you test if
the if if that particular data set
follows linearity assumption so no not
linearity assumptions or not we have to
test no so we have another sub so how
can we test it over here what we did we
just did a visual inspection we just did
a visual inspection okay this is
something which you can draw a straight
line but what if you have a higher
dimensional dimensional for data so
there are several ways to test your
model okay the first test which you uh
which is uh which is very popular is
nothing but visual inspection visual
inspection so in that visual inspection
in that visual inspection what you do
what you do the first thing which you do
is Scatter Plots the Scatter Plots the
first way to test if that if your model
for if your data follows linearity
assumption or not is apply scatter plot
so what exactly Scatter Plots does so
what exactly Scatter Plots does what is
it does please we simply take and add
independent and or dependent variable we
have to of course do it in a 2d plane of
course so when you have the on y-axis
you have the dependent variable x axis
we have independent variables and you
plotted so if the relationship shows the
straight line or the or the linear data
that that means it is volume but if it
does but it does not then then it is not
near assumption is not satisfied so
visual inspection is one of the most
common ways as well but over here the
only downside though is if you have more
number of variables large number of
variables input features independent
features here to plotted against every
individual and then see if it works but
but you know it's sometimes not good as
well but eventually it helps you to get
a better understanding but this is a
Scatter Plots to uh eventually help okay
so uh so this is this is one of them
another one is which is more common like
over here we have to plot for every
individual independent feature X 2 and
then Y and X3 and then Y and all we have
to do for Scatter Plots but in but
another example is let's say how can you
test with residuals plots residual plots
so residual plants plots is one of the
most common ways to
um to test those assumptions what you do
you simply put you simply
um
you simply take the you simply take the
residuals and then put it on a y-axis
against the predicted or the uh
predicted values or the independent
variable so basically you take you on
y-axis you have the residuals on by
sorry on accesses we have the prediction
you have the prediction okay on why
because you have the residual so why uh
on Accessory Y axis will prediction
sorry other situles and put on the over
here prediction so you might be thinking
here how does it even make sense right
so let's uh let me show you a very nice
example of how what exactly residual
plots looks like so that it makes
perfect sense to you so I just going to
uh take a very nice example maybe that
will uh make much more sense uh so I'm
just uh drawing out a very nice example
so that I can actually send it from Mac
to my iPad that really works you know uh
sometimes it works and sometimes it is
not so let me just open up a very nice
so open up a safari where is my Safari
yeah so yeah so how can I download load
this cool so I send this on my laptop
from laptop to over here now I should be
able to show it to you all so this is
the example of a residual plot this is
an example of a residual plot and what
does this plot says on on X on on x-axis
you have the temperature and then y-axis
you have the residuals now if you see
that now if you see the when you when
you plot the related values against the
residuals against the residuals the odd
or even attempt or even the independent
variables against the residuals it
should show what it should show it
should show a very Cur a very random
scattered point so over here you know
you see they are very randomly scattered
there's that that's not the residual
plots there is the on y-axis you have
residual and x axis you have that
independent variable so this does not
forms any sort of you know a pattern
like this uh what what patterns I'm
talking about like this or like this or
like this it is not forming it is it is
a very random one you cannot even fit
any sort of models is very very random
and they're around zero only they're
around zero okay so so if if if if the
linearity Assumption holds if the
linearity Assumption satisfies the
residuals are the residuals are
scattered randomly are scattered
randomly okay are scattered randomly and
they're around zero they're around zero
okay I hope that you you are unable to
understand this pretty well uh this is
this is the visual inspection this this
is what you do for visual inspection
another way is something known as uh is
is something known as partial regression
plot partial regression plot partial
regression plot and this is something
which you have to explore by your own
this is something explored by your own
I'm not going to teach teach about that
but you have to explore by your own uh
because this um because now you are at a
stage where you have to explode by your
own as well I cannot spoon video
everything but this this is one of the
way which which you should explode right
now by yourself another way to test
another way to test it is is nothing is
nothing but something always statistical
tests statistical tests so we have seen
our our hypothesis testing in that
hypothesis testing we have several tests
which is t-test f-test you know now so
there are several test for States
testing the significance of our
um coefficients or independent features
so just like that you have a tests for
testing the linearity assumptions for
example one of the test is nothing but a
rainbow test is nothing but rainbow test
the rainbow test I'm not going to go
into mathematical details of it because
this is something uh you're not studying
statistics in detail if you want to
study statistics just go and search more
if you're interested you know but I
don't suggest you to go in so mathy
details of it because nobody usually
asks you just need to know okay there's
something just available which we have
to use for testing is linearity or maybe
something known as har we call it test
which is one of our one of the most like
uh statistical tests which is often used
for testing this other like how can we
eventually uh talk about things how can
we eventually test if if the model is
linear or not okay uh so just you can
you can explore the mathematical
diseases how do we test exactly but it
just follows the same thing which I've
studied the test assesses we have a null
hypothesis the null hypothesis states
that the null hypothesis states that
what is a test it states that the
there's a the relationship between the
relationship between your X and Y is
linear so it it assumes that it already
assumes now we have an alternative it
says that it is not the relationship is
not so so so what we do we conduct the
test and once we have the critical uh
the p-value if the P P value which we
get from after conducting the rainbow or
the these test if it's smaller than 0
0.05 which means which means that uh
which means that you can reject the null
hypothesis uh if if it is more than you
can reject the null hypothe which means
the resumptions is is not satisfied
because you are saying that it is not
linear okay so this is one of the this
is the the same same concept holds for
every hypothesis testing another another
example is another example so these are
some of the some of the ways to
summarize up linear regression
assumptions holds for you know there
should be linear significant
relationship between flow two variables
uh we have scatter Scatter Plots then we
have residual plots and then we have
partial regression plot and statistical
plot and that we have uh hypothesis and
tests uh sorry there are several
hypothesis tests available to test with
the darts whether it follows statistical
or not okay I hope that this gives a
good sense about our linearity
assumption now what we'll do we'll talk
about something known as another
assumption which is nothing but called
as uh the remedies of it yeah yeah this
is this is one of the way to think about
it I just forgot like we have some
Revenue remedies about how can we fix so
once our assumption so assume that your
assumption is violated so assume that
your assumptions is assumptions are
violated assumptions are violated now if
the if your if your model does not
satisfy linearization which means that
your model is not going to work well
right so so we keep so
you told about that this will not work
well so what we should do if this does
not work so I will say that fix that
assumption make it the make make it from
non-violated to non-violated assumption
okay
and this is what you have to do so there
are several remedies for it you know
remedies means something to fix if the
if it is if it is being violated we have
to fix that as well hashtag fix extract
hashtag fix is also very famous thing so
you have to fix that assumption so there
are several remedies the first remedies
is nothing but called transforming
variables the first remedy is we call
transforming of our variables
transforming of our variables over here
you can see that we transform our
variables so um this is one of the
Transformer variables so what does that
mean transformation of our variables
which means that if the relationship
between the predictor and the response
is appears to be you can try
transforming the predictor or to see for
example you can take the square root or
log or or Square of a variable for
example assume that you have a house
price square and then you want to
predict based on the so you know based
on the size and predict the house price
you have uh you have something to one
thousand then you have 200 000 uh then
250 sorry 1 to 200 square feet and you
have to 250 000 so use what you can do
you can apply the
log you can apply the log or the square
root you can apply the log or a square
root on you know on maybe on uh on on
variables okay on on variables so that
it comes on a it it becomes linear okay
so you apply the transformation on the
variables you apply the transformational
variables used to study more about
feature in genetics if you want to study
more in degree level or all of these
things I suggest you take the course
which is cs01 bo4 which is one of our
famous sports available online
um so you can actually uh talk about
this so we get we we take this log
square root or Square of the predictor
variable so independent variables out
there so that it works perfectly so that
you bring that bring them back into the
linear way so when I take the log it of
course comes in linear uh so this is a
very nice uh note to make sure to so
that's one of the transformation of
Remedy uh variables another one is ADD
higher order terms had higher order
terms or interaction terms which means
that if you have your X variable then
you make another variable X but you
square that but you squared that okay so
you add the so you add the cubic per
Cube cubic terms or quadratic to help
capture the even the non-linear
relationship So eventually this
introduces a concept of polynomial
regression in this Century entries
concept of polynomial regression but
that's something for later on where you
introduce the higher order of you know
uh the variables where you just take the
X and then take the x squared and then
you have x 2 x 1 take the X1 squared so
you just introduce the higher order uh
terms for example quadratic or cubic
which helps to capture the non-linear
relationship another one is like if
nothing is working then you should start
going on to take out the different model
okay
different model means you can consider
using Gams or decision trees models like
random Forest which can better capture
if you're if if you data is non-linear
too much in order to satisfy the
Assumption then I think you should go to
random forest or somewhere like that to
actually uh cover up our assumptions of
uh random Forest you know okay cool so I
hope that gives you a very nice
understanding about a linearity
assumption what the next switch we'll
talk about is something known as uh
Independence assumption which is also a
very nice assumption and then after that
we'll talk about Homo scarcity and
normality assumption and then we'll wrap
up the lecture on this
what's up
hey everyone welcome to this video in
this video what exactly I'm going to do
is going to talk about independence
assumption this is one of the again the
second most famous assumption available
right now which is Independence which is
independence
assumption which is again I said the
second most Independence assumption
which is like important so the what does
independence assumption States
independence assumption states that what
is it states it states that that the
errors or the residuals which you have
the residuals which you have the
residuals which you have there is the
the residuals which you have are
independent of each other okay so for
example you have X1 and then you have y
and then you have a b c d and you have y
one y two y three y four and then you
have y hat which you've taken from which
is y hat one y hat two y so your error
will be will be Error 1 is equals to Y
hat one minus y one error 2 is equals to
Y it had two minus so so the error
number one should be independent of area
number two or error number two two
should be independent of error number
one okay so errors or residuals
associated with the in this the data or
the observation should be should be
uninfluenced by any other observation
out there so error number two should be
uninfluenced by any other so error
number two should not get affected by
the error number one okay or error
number two should not get affected by an
animal else so I guess the the the
individual assumption states that the
Assumption switches holds that that your
observations associated with one
observations should not influence the
error associated with the another
observation
okay if you don't fix this you will end
up with biased results uh unaccurate
estimates unreliable predictions and a
lot of things can happen uh so this is
the this is what the assumptions say
that you're uh that your error should be
independent so let's take a very nice
example so example states that that you
have you have something known as
electricity so you want to predict the
electricity uh based on the uh based on
the temperature in a city based on the
hour okay so we collect the hourly data
for entire month so you have hourly data
which is and then you have temperature
okay and then you have your electricity
demand temperature electricity and
demand so one two three dot dot dot 15
16 17 dot dot dot and 80 85 and 90 dot
dot so this is this is one of our you
know uh this is one of our
um this is one of our data which we have
in our annual test whether this
assumption has a wholesale Independence
assumption or not so if you see that the
demand for electricity at one hour at
one hour at one hour might be related to
the demand of the previous one right so
so basically so basically what what is
it trying to say you it's it's something
which is trying to tell you that assume
that the electricity demand at on up at
our two might be related to the previous
hour right might be related to previous
hour electricity at three might be
related to the previous hour hour number
three multiple to the previous hour so
you see that there is some sort of
relation and as we said that there
should be not any relation of course if
this is written then of course errors
will be also related okay so electricity
uses strengths to show a pattern so when
you when as we are using electricity it
is being so that we have it is greater
than the previous one that's what it is
showing okay it is as the hours
increases your electricity demands also
in which it is showing such some sort of
pack pattern over the course of a date
so it is of course showing the pattern
over the course of the day because it is
related to each other so what is it
showing for example over here higher the
demand is higher in the day and lower
demand at night or lower demand at night
so this is something which is which
which can be showcasing the patterns so
over here this is showcasing the trends
which is not good right this means that
our that our points are independent
violating the independence assumption
and that's one of our important major
issue so that's this this is what
assumption indicates how can we test our
assumptions for testing our assumptions
for test testing and assumptions we have
couple of things again we can talk about
residual plots
and residual
plots so again you you can take your
residuals and plot it and plot it or
like like this you take the residuals
and plot in on a y-axis and you take the
fitted value the prediction value
product on x-axis right and when you
plot it and when you plot it you will
see you will see that you will see that
uh you you'll see that uh
you will see that there is no patterns
or trends of the residual so there is no
patterns there is this there's no such
certain patterns uh of over here this
over the line they are distributed
randomly or scatteredly if there's some
sort of patterns like this you know like
this so we can say that that's that
something does not hold true but over
here this does not have pattern but but
in the case of this it will hold a
particular pattern when you when in this
particular example to hold a pattern
okay uh so you this is a visual
inspection uh from which you can see the
another one is nothing but call
statistical tests statistical tests and
statistical tests what does it say is
that you have couple of tests which is
Durbin Watson test the urban Watson test
which will give you some sort of number
and then we say that okay that that
number is greater than the significance
to 0.05 which is a P value then we say
okay we can reject the null hypothesis
and say okay this something is correlate
so we'll talk these are tests which have
already seen the way we conduct tests
and all in previous lectures but Darwin
Watson test and uh versus got Freight
rest God Freight test so let's talk
about a bit about uh Durbin but your
your stance should be that you are
making it researching a bit more about
it okay
and so how can we so that so there is
one of them is
um is what we can do so what exactly the
Durbin Watson test means the Durbin
Watson uh is specifically was introduced
what Hawaii why it was introduced it was
introduced to detect the auto
correlation Auto correlation Auto
correlation it it was it was came on to
reduce the auto correlations in the
residuals in the residuals in the
residuals of Allah so what is means
autocorrelation the residual so which
which directly means what is auto
correlation first of all autocorrelation
nothing but the correlation between the
residences correlation means is there
any relationship between both of them so
if they're highly highly correlated
which means what they are indeed they're
dependent on each other so so basically
it tells you the correlation between two
and the two residuals at different time
points so basically it's it it means
that it checks with the errors are
correlated across observations or not so
if they are that means they don't they
don't they don't satisfy this that the
independence assumption and if they are
not correlated then then they satisfy
the Assumption okay so dermin Watson the
Durbin Watson test which you have it
lies between zero to four zero to four
and if you turbine Watson gives test of
a 2 value 2 which means that there is no
autocorrelation and if there is no
autocorrelation between residuals that
means the Assumption satisfies because
there is there is no barriers correlated
with each other okay so but if the
values are less than if the values are
less than two that means there is a
positive correlations which means
there's a positive quarter we have
already talked about positive and
negative correlation please see the
lectures of probability if you haven't
bought the course please now go and just
enroll in a course if you haven't
studied about problem statistics so
value less than two suggests that the
positive correlations are nothing but
are nothing but um the positive
correlations which you have is nothing
but uh a value less than two if your
turbine was to test statistics give less
than two that means they have a they
hold a positive correlation but uh which
means the residuals are positively
correlated across observations but your
value is greater than two suggest
negative correlation which means that
residuals are negatively correlated so
your value should be two if they want to
satisfy this assumption if they're less
than two that means they are positively
correlated if they're greater than two
then they are negatively correlated
across the observations okay
um yeah so uh how can we perform some of
the steps so what you do you first of
all fit your data and then you calculate
the residuals you calculate the
residuals
you calculate the residuals after
calculating the residuals what you do
you take out D in in T Test you're
taking out the T value over here you can
take out the test statistic which is D
um you you can search online for the
formula but formula is not even required
you know if there are Auto automatically
tools which does for this now once we
have this D now you what you do you
compare the test statistic to the script
critical values for the Durbin WhatsApp
the the the table which we have okay the
tables are statistical software come you
compare it and if your D is less than
that lower critical value or greater
than that then we resent the null
hypothesis of no autocorrelation which
means assumptions is likely violated for
example what does it says what does it
say that you conduct the test and then
if and then we again our null hypothesis
and Alternate hypothesis comes into play
and if it's greater than that and then
we reject it and then so this resection
automation will eventually happen Okay
so but uh but mostly what you do if you
could be statistic gives two that means
there is no autocorrelation but however
you can perform test as well for
detecting autocorrelation but one of the
few more drawbacks of it the Durbin
Watson test is is more for you know what
it's more for time series data it's more
for time series data okay so that's why
uh we have to use a you have to use
proper you know tests for all of this
thing I hope that you understood about
how can we test our independence
resentment so there are several remedies
for it so there are several remedies if
the assumptions are violated how can we
fix it so one of the way to fix it is
add additional variables so you can
actually add additional variables you
can actually add the first one is add
additional vars add variables so for
example if there's any underlying factor
which is causing for for example in this
case which you have taken example that
your this this this has a this boil it's
independent y because it might be
related to previous one
so we can find a factor which is causing
we can try to find a factor which is
causing that dependence and then we can
you know add this Factor as an
independent variable okay to uh we can
add this Factor so you're adding more
variables definitely helps definitely
helps for for example in this example
what we can do we can introduce another
variable we can enter introduce another
variable we can introduce another
variable what variable time of the day
time of the day in this case the time of
time time of the race we will introduce
another variable so time of the week
which is night night morning so how does
it help how does it help this helps how
does it help if if we convert we can
actually take it that we can actually
understand the pattern your model could
understand the pattern okay this is
something is
um uh daily practice you want to be able
to capture the daily patterns that's
that that was the factor so you can
consider adding more variables according
to what what is causing this this Factor
so basically at night time so we can
actually explicitly add this to actually
help you so that your model does not be
depend so this is one of them you can
add more variables uh we'll do one
proper example as well don't don't worry
you can use time series model
for time series model drill relatively
works well in these type of examples and
then at last you have nothing but called
mixed effect models but that's something
it's like that's something you can use
hierarchical
hierarchical linear models but I
suggested to export by that alone it's
not too much use but it's exactly that's
what people actually use sometimes if if
you have hierarchical data but I suggest
you to learn about hierarchical linear
models HLN a very nice uh concept around
it okay so adding more variables you
know uh time series using another
algorithm all of this really helps
good so I hope that you understood about
independence assumption now we'll talk
about uh homo schedule assumption uh
which is also known as non-uh constant
constant variance constant variance
across it
so I'll talk about that uh where where
your variance of all the residuals are
constant across all the levels so we'll
talk about that homo this no constant
very uh constant various assumption uh
and then we'll take one example and
after that we'll have our simple last
one which is normality and then we have
no multiple linearity which is left upon
you for you to explore so let's get
started with
um what homo scarcity assumption or even
say no constant variance assumption no
okay cool
so what does this homo scarcity
assumption states that I I really have a
hard time understanding you know
pronouncing this so please ignore if I
sometimes pronounce it wrong so most
characteristic assumption is a
statistical assumption that states that
the variance of the eritream also with
this spread or very what does it means
the spread of the values variance means
spread of the values okay uh how how
does it spread across the mean so the
mean of that how does the variance is uh
in a regression model is constant the
residuals or the variants are constant
okay they're constant across all the all
the predictor y variables you may be
thinking yeah use what the
okay so what what what just you told
okay so uh you have uh you you you might
be confused how what exactly does it
mean so let's talk about what exactly
does it mean so you can assume that it
is a it states that there are variance I
assume that you know variance the spread
of values of the researchables is
constant across all levels they do not
change or you can say this spread of
irresiduals should be approximately same
for all values of the independent so you
have
so they should be constant across all
independent values okay this should be
constant if they are not if the variance
of the residuals increases or decreases
transmitter Dr domestically for example
at at Road row number one error is
something C and over row number two
error is C plus hundred that that means
that is that increases and at around row
number three C minus 100 that means it
decreases you know so it increases this
decrease dramatically which means that
it is not following that assumption that
is not constant the variance is not of
constant across the individuals of your
samples then we say that it is not
following our assumption that voltage
the Assumption okay so uh I hope that
really helps about that again over here
for testing it we have nothing but
called residual plots we have nothing
but called residual plots which really
helps to test the homoscadicity
Assumption so what is uh so let me let
me just uh again if there's too many
patterns then you can conclude that
there's no such assumption so just going
to uh make you aware about like a very
nice example maybe for you which will be
super helpful if you understand it a
nice way so just going to have it over
here the PNG file uh uploaded right here
share done
and then I'm going to share again
airdrop
and iPad
oops Yeah so this is this is one of the
nice image which I usually use to
explain it so this is this is called a
residual plots we have a residual plots
we plot and the y-axis residuals on
x-axis we have some sort of uh fitted
values you have to put if we have fitted
values or the predicted values or the
model pretty values on on y-axis you
have the uh on y-axis you have what on
y-axis you have nothing but uh residuals
or Nexus we have fitted values and when
you plot it if you it shows some sort of
patterns over here you see that it is
showing some sort of patterns over here
it is showing some sort of patterns but
over here it is not showing any sort of
patterns right so in this example if if
your model shows something like this
that means the assumption is satisfied
you can go ahead with it but if this
like if there's some sort of showing
patterns that means that assumptions
does not hold this is this is example of
a heterostasis heterostaticity and this
is also example heteroscadicity but this
is an example of homoscadicity which
means that it was a homoseconditional
assumption is true which is consider
your variance your errors are constant
across the uh
across the independent variables okay
and there's no Trends or there's no
Trends over here it is increasing over
here it is decreasing now where there is
it is constant across all variables okay
uh this is what this is a visual
inspection another one is nothing but
called uh we have several you know uh
statistical tests just like as pre
previous one which is called the Pagan
test Pagan test
or a white test white test and all of
this you don't really need to you know
understand what exactly uh it does but
again the hypothesis testing formula
looks in you have the and null
hypothesis alternate and then you
perform the test and then checking the
significance value and then you say okay
there's something greater than then we
reject or accept statistical test for
all the statistical tests which you have
to understand by your own by searching
online I'm not going to do with it
because it is out of the scope of the
course as well it is not required as
well for for initial steps at least
so and once you once you assume that
your your model does not satisfy so what
are the remedies how can we fix it so
fixing can be happen in two or three
ways two or three ways okay so uh two or
three ways so let's talk about what are
those two or three ways the first way is
we can transform our variables transform
transformation can happen transformation
can happen so you can add you know you
can apply transformation or dependent on
an independent like a log transformation
or square root transformation or inverse
transformation and then see if your
assumption is being fixed or not another
one what you can do which is weighted
linear regression weighted linear
regression what is weighted linear
regression says that instead of using
ordinary which you use right now you can
use weighted which what it does it
assigns weights towards you have a nine
observation so it assigns the weights to
every observation okay based on their
variance based on the variance but
weighted linear regression is something
which is which which you should learn in
the extensions of linear regression
um which is upon you to understand it
much more graduated I'm just doing it
because I want you to and make explore
by yourself so not empty and giving you
that nobody gives all of these names but
I'm giving you to explore by your own
and the another one which is we should
explore which is uh more sort of you
know uh used to remedy is something
known as hover regression or quantile
regression quantile
regression content regression or hover
regression and these two are used you
know for uh techniques for you know what
it is used for uh checking whether
whether uh and and this this really
really helps in fixing those quantile
regression and hover so I suggest you to
explore these three types of extensions
of linear regression which helps to
satisfy this assumption so I really want
you to go ahead and then stop this
lecture and then go over and search
about this learn about this make a note
and tag me on LinkedIn
Okay cool so I hope that you're done
with this homo scarcity assumption uh
now at last we'll talk about nothing but
call normality assumption which is our
most you know as well as it's not you
know what most it's something which is
required for everyone you know cool so
let's get started with normality
assumption so what is it normality
assumption states that normal resumption
states that normality assumption states
that that the residuals now previously
in Independence and the constant and
homoscope is the constant you know
Independence independent of each other
uh constant and now we talk about they
should be normally distributed you know
that word is normally distributed you
know what is said to be write me in the
comment box what is it said to be a
normally distributed a very nice uh so
I've just wait for five seconds what
does it means
so tell me what is it means your
residuals to be normally to be normally
distributed
so let me let me just write the question
so that at least I can check for it and
you and in the comment box uh yeah so
please go ahead and invite it
um so that I could understand
foreign
so what does it say to be a normally
distributed which means which means that
your mean is that that that your
distribution is following a normal
gaussian distribution okay your mean is
following a normal gaussian distribution
that your residuals are following the
normal when you plot the residuals they
should follow something like this where
most of the values should lie between
this range okay should right should uh
this should be symmetrical this should
be symmetrical most of the value should
be around the mean your mean is
something that nothing mean is equals to
zero and then you have the bell shaped
curve which is symmetric which is which
should be which where the mean should be
close to zero in the case of the
residuals in the case of residuals your
mean should be close to zero in the case
because residuals are of course zero
right because we don't want to be
residuals to be high so it should
satisfy our normality assumption it
should satisfy our normality assumption
I hope that so basically uh normative
assumption states that and what is
normality assumption say it's that that
your normality assumptions refers to
assumptions that the errors are normally
distributed in other words that your uh
it should be well shaped or belt shaped
curved with a symmetrical positions with
most of the errors clustered around the
mean and fewer errors so most of the
errors so even even plotted so most of
the errors should be over here so it
should be constant so you see that it is
related to the previous one this
constant show here most of the error
should be constant it should be
independent and there should be around
they should be similar it should not be
this it should be very one one or two
error should be at extreme like very
different but it should be most most of
them should should be uh between like it
should be around the mean okay
uh over over here you can see that if
you violate this it can affect the
validity and the conclusions your model
is going to make and it can also often
result in bias and inflated standard
deviation errors so again which can
generally affects the accuracy
so there are several ways to test the
and the easiest way is to plot a
distilled plot is a normal plot which is
nothing but a histogram or something
like you know histogram with a belt
shape curve uh which which you usually
do so let me just introduce you with uh
a very nice image for this as well maybe
for you which will help you we have two
two types of plot which we can use the
first one is quantile plots the second
one is uh histogram plot so assume that
I just want to take a very nice example
in which example I should take I don't
even get it
um so I just gonna use this
so assume that assume that you have
this particular example
where you plot the residuals on a y-axis
where you plot the residuals on a y axis
and then see okay your eventually your
your your bell shape will shut form like
this it should it should form like a
gaussian distribution that's one of them
when you plot the where you plot the
histogram where you plot the histogram
and then what you do when the plot the
histogram with the Bell shape curve and
then and then you apply the distal plot
on top of it so that it looks like a a
density plot you know the density plot
and it should look like a gaussian
distribution or you can what you can do
you can create a quantile quantile plots
what does quantile content plot means it
means that what is content quantile
means that it means that if the
residuals are normally distributed
should fall approximately along a
straight line now this may be a bit of
you know a bit off to you so let's just
go ahead and talk about it so what I'm
going to do is have it like over here
quantile plots I'm just going to send it
out to you over here
you usually you know what I do I usually
teach along with it I I just don't like
you know to teach it like uh like like
like just having a preparation because I
feel like having a preparation really
affects you know uh the way we teach
so of course I have a preparation but
not too much
because I like to be very natural so
over here you can see that you have a QQ
plot and UV plot if so what is QQ plot
indicates the QP plot sees that that if
your distribution are now if your errors
if your residuals are normally
distributed then the points on the the
point it should lie approximately which
is approximately over here this normal
distribution their lies approximately on
the straight line but over here this is
not a normal distribution log normal
distribution so your points are so
points are in a diverse the points are
not on the straight line over here this
is also not on a straight line but over
here this is on a straight line so if if
you get the content plot like this then
you say okay this satisfies our
assumption and then you have several
other statistical tests just like
um previous one like which is over here
we have sapiro will test or you can say
Smith Smirnoff test where it is used but
will what will perform the test one of
the test in practical but you there's
that something is according to you if
you want to do it but I like to do it by
normality assumption which is just my
visual inspection
what are the what are the remedies for
it transformation is one of the most
popular remedies removing the variables
which is which is causing to be it in
non-normal so you can remove the
variables which is causing to be
non-normal or you can talk about or you
can use different other algorithms such
as quantile regression as I told that
you should be comfortable with that
um and actually in the course you know
the course which which we have CSO one
we teach about all of these extension as
well but as of now I feel like as we
made it for fee we just wanted to
explore by your own as well okay so this
this is about normality assumption where
we where we are ask our residuals to
follow a normal distributed plot
Okay cool so I hope that really makes
sense uh now what I'll do I'll just wrap
up so now we are we are done with almost
all the assumptions now what is left is
something known as no multi-collinearity
assumption which is for you as a
homework to uh understand it's very easy
and very very tricky as well if you
don't understand the right way so but
that's that's something which you have
to deal by yourself or talked about 10
hours of lecture that's something which
you have to do by your own as well right
and we have a talk in very things in
great detail and I really hope that you
understand all of these things you have
what we have came to an end actually so
we are done with the assumptions and
everything now what's next the next is
nothing but we'll go and do a sample
project one simple linear regression and
one multiple linear question to Showcase
you several other things as well so you
don't need to worry about a lot of
things let's get started with the final
section of the course and then we'll say
goodbye
foreign
welcome to the mostly the last section
I've been telling in the Practical
session so we'll so uh so we'll now
start off with the practicality stuff
get you comfortable with what we have
learned and how to implement that as
well okay so we'll we'll definitely do
that but but prior to this you have a
programming assignment for you so that
you could you could Implement linear
regression from very Scratch by your own
I'm not going to do that what I'm going
to do I'm going to utilize libraries
teach you the core and Concepts and
cruts which nobody else teaches that's
my aim so uh we'll be we'll be doing a
short a couple of lending regression
project one of the one of them is using
simple linear regression to give you a
basic idea about how we go about
building a very nice report how do how
we go about interpreting the results of
linear regression and Etc and as my as
as my strategy suggests we'll start off
with the Baseline and then we will
slowly extend to the to the multiple
variables as well right so so what so
what we can do we can actually uh do
that in terms of uh having more sort of
you know adding more sort of uh projects
in future if you want to go with the
free one but as of now let's let's get
started with the very simple example on
how we can use linear regression for
identifying predict advertising
prediction but before that I'm pretty
much sure that you might be confused
about what exactly the project is and
how we're going to go forward with it so
basically let me show you what exactly
the project I'm going to start over the
problem statement and then after the
problem statement I'm going to make you
familiar with something known as uh
with with some with something known as
um like what a simple and linear
regression and then we'll do a couple of
stuffs like 40 for example data
ingestion and then we'll talk about how
we will do the model how do you test the
assumptions and Etc so I hope that that
really makes sense uh apart from it and
uh and on the other other hand uh let's
get started I eventually talking about
first of all what exactly the data is so
first of all we have the advertising
data set as they have already seen a lot
uh and you'll also seen the programming
assignment which you'll be doing uh
please see the course website where we
have listed for the same so over here of
over here you have three variables you
have three variables which is TV a radio
and newspaper and these are listed num
listed listed it's listed
um expenses which which a particular
company has put on for example they have
they have spent around 200 that 230.1 uh
on uh on on expense on TV at advertising
on TV 37.8 000 on Radio and 669.2 on
newspaper advertising and based on
Advertising they got 20 20 22.1 this
much sales okay so so basically we had
this is over here we have the expenses
in which every company has did on TV
radio and newspaper and we are going to
predict uh what is now what is the
significant number of a sales so now
your task as a data scientist is to
identify which which in which mode of
advertising is much more liable for is
which which a company should increase
the expense to get the sales and which
one
um which which one source which should
completely vanish it like we should
completely ignore it for example in some
cases okay you uh you you might say okay
for this particular example you might
want to go with TV because it is more
significant in getting more sales as
compared to newspaper or radio right so
so your comp so so that's that's what
your work should be as a data scientist
it's helped to take help the
stakeholders to take better decisions
out there right so what decisions they
they have to take they have to they have
to take the decisions up about like
whether to use TV whether to expand and
spend more on TV radio or newspaper or
couple of them so we have to identify we
have to identify which variable
independent variable is giving most of
our most amount of contribution to sales
which particular medium of source is
giving most amount of informations to
the sales and that's our problem
statement so what I'll do
for for being super simplistic as as I
told it's not a full-fledged project
it's just for the learning purposes not
for the putting on a portfolio so
basically uh over here what exactly
gonna do I want to take this TV and I
want to take one of the I'll take one of
the advertising source and understand
his impact understand its impact on the
awkward variable sales for example I
could take TV and then understand its
impact on sales so I can build a linear
regression on top of it we're given the
TV the expense curve given on TV it will
protect me the sales so that I can and
if I open this much and then I can do
for separate variables and then I can do
for separate variables and then see
which is which is having the most amount
of contribution however this is not veto
it we actually use the multiple linear
regression where we'll use a three of
them to actually predict the sales but
that's for you to try out not for me as
a programming assignment we have listed
detailed programming assignment for you
where we will do a small thing and then
you have to extend it to further okay so
over here or over here what we'll be
doing we will be making the data into a
simple linear equation which is a simple
PDF where you take the only one column
as of now so that you have X1 you have
one a one into an independent feature
and then one dependent feature and over
here I'm going to RFI the significance
of TV onto the sales the significance of
TV or to the sales however you can also
include other variables if you want to
understand the significance but as of
now let's let's get started with it uh
you'll be also doing a very nice
programming assignment where you'll be
actually understanding answering that
question of which one to go forward with
which one of the medium source to go
forward with so let's get started with
actually talking about uh the how how
can you code in a computer
so uh everyone back to this lecture uh
to this project so I'm going to start
off with the data injection so the first
step of any Machinery project is to
ingest the data and I really like it to
be in certain sort of class and
everything so basically over here over
here we have
um we have some we have a class and we
have a little data ingestion class which
ingests the data advertising and then
lows it down to only one to uh to a
simple for to a data set where we can
use Simple linear regression on where we
have only one independent feature and
one dependent feature so the first step
is to initialize the class for the file
path so we required a file path when
someone instantiates this cloth class
and then what and then what we do and
then we have a method called load data
which reads the CSV which reads the CSV
from the specified file path and then we
get the and then we get our specified as
I said that it that we want the specific
TB and sales only so that it is for
learning purposes and then you
concatenate both of the X and Y
variables and then we return that data
frame okay so this is a basic data
ingestion class not a big deal to
understand it okay now we can actually
use this now we can actually use this
over here
over here which is uh where where we are
importing so ignore everything just just
go over here you can you can say from
source which is the source folder dot
data ingests with the file name import
the data ingestion class and then you
say okay this is inside instantiator
class and then um and then Source it to
the or the make it to the
advertising.csv and that gives your
simple DF that that that will give you
the data frame which is a simple DF
which we want to perform on okay now in
data ingestion is done so let's run our
file to actually see okay that will make
much more sense and I'm going to use
something like uh very nice over here so
I'm just oops
a little clear LS and then I'm just
going to have this
uh if I have actually an environment
fiction so I'll just uh environment
variable so what was the name LR Raj
maybe I'm not sure yeah uh so Honda
deactivate
so that's clear okay so uh I have
activated my environment if you don't
know how to activate you will also
seeing the reading materials for that or
the other otherwise in the next set of
projects I have showed you how to do
this okay so I'm just going to remove
this because it's not required yes over
here now what we'll do over here now
what we what we will do is we will
simply uh run this python dot python
main dot pi and I'll just I just want to
run that uh just gonna make it comment
and I I just want to take a look at what
exactly the data frame looks like so
it's going to print that data frame
print that data frame it's better it may
seems good to you so that you can see
what exactly it's working on so so when
you when you run it you'll be eventually
getting a date a data frame where where
you have only one column which is an X
and Y over there okay so it eventually
takes time initially and then it works
fine so you have the TV which is that
expenses on TV and then the sales which
happen if you have advertised on TV so
that's a data ingestion is done now the
next step is I'm going to do a basic
data processing please note that in the
next project which will do we'll have
the very extensive data processing thing
but as of now I would suggest you can
ignore this as if now okay uh maybe uh
you which it it just for information
purposes if you want to know how we are
performing basically what we're doing we
are we are importing a class known as
data processing class and in that we are
instant sharing uh instantiating with
the data frame object sorry uh ends with
which which takes an input which is data
frame and then performs couple of
methods the first method it applies it
identifies if there's any outlier the
box plot we box plot and see if there's
any outlier in that particular TV's
variable because linear regression is
it's sensitive to outliers so we have
the TV and then we just see if there's
any outliers if there's any we identify
uh who who are those outliers
numerically okay and there are several
ways to deal with it capping trimming
and several ways to identify as well we
should be seeing in the next lecture
please ignore that as of now
so when you're going to go to main.pi
now uh now you can just import the same
thing you can simply import the same
thing which is the data processing from
that data source folder in the data data
preprocess file and then you simply run
it so let's when when we run it it is
okay let's have a fi if there's any
outlier so it says that there's no one
here apply so let's print it out let's
let's print out books I haven't printed
that so outliers so if I just print it
out you will be able to see that there's
zero outliers in that trigger column
okay of uh using z-score but you will
identify your method to actually uh NF
which are outliers and I would recommend
to if you don't know about outliers you
should wait for the next lecture as of
now you can ignore this this is not the
scope of this uh process the scope of
this process is focus on model building
only so now once we have the bit of
Crossing I just want to show you the
process nothing else like okay after
data ingestion we process the data in a
good way and then what we do we go on
how can we build a linear regression
model so how can we build that so we'll
be using stats model API because I
really like that as computer as a
scikit-learn because
um I don't know why but yeah it it is
more interpretable it gives more results
it gives more explanations when we off
after after building up the model okay
so basically we'll build a class which
takes in which takes an X and Y which is
the independent and dependent variable
and then we and and then and then what
we do we add a constant which is one one
terms you know in X is a design Matrix
and then one one one one one uh a column
of one so that we multiply with beta0
and 1 which is SM dot add constant we
have SM as an allies for this a for for
this library and then what we do and
then we make a method called fit and
that fit what it does we are calling or
we are calling orderly squares which is
equivalent to linear regression and then
we're calling dot fit and when we're
calling dot fit by giving your
independent variable and dependent sorry
dependent variable independent variable
where we were saying okay this is
something as a dependent independent and
this something is dependent so more of
the relationship using linear regression
first first what this fit fit will do it
will perform all the steps First Step
hypothesis second calculate the cost
third is perform the gradient descent on
top of it until unless your model is
come first we have already talked about
what exactly fit method does it fits the
method for example we have already seen
what the algorithm is take out the
hypothesis take out the error take out
the dead take out the derivative and
then perform the gradient descent n
number of times just after you updating
and updating beta's value so that's what
fit does okay fit means it trains your
linear regression model by the number of
iterations so when you actually go and
see what it whatever exactly isn't that
our OLS is you will be seeing all this
stuff but but basically it trains your
using gradient descent algorithm
cool and then return the model and then
we can print the summary of our model
what exactly after training our model
what exactly the summary of our model
looks like what exactly the summary of
our model looks like and if you if
you're getting confused what this dot
fit method does please take a look at
online from for a scratch implementation
of limitation if you're still not sure
about how do we programming it up but uh
if but you have to attempt a programming
assignment for this for better
understanding you print the summary of
the line regression model which is model
is equal to self.fit first of all you
train the model and after you sell those
that you train the model and then print
the summary of the model and return the
trained model so that anyone can use it
for prediction so over here when you
actually uh when you actually uh use
that so let's let's have a basic simple
integration model over here and let's
print it out let's print print that
stuff out this model summary so
um basically we have we're just calling
dot summary we are just calling dot
summary and when you're calling dot
summary it first of all trains the model
prints out somebody and then return the
model so how does that summary looks
like which is the most important part of
this lecture is we have this OLS
regression results which is telling okay
this is the dependent variable what
model we are using and a lot of things
we shall talk about that in just a
second about how we can interpret the
OLS results regression and then once we
have our uh oh what is results now we
are we have a model trained with a full
report of how it is performing how our
model is performing how they're
performing in different different tests
and Etc
and Etc so this is something which will
which which we'll talk about okay uh
each and every Integrity what exactly
this what exactly this what exactly this
report says and everything in Greater
detail so let's talk about how can we
interpret each of them in a nice way so
I would suggest if you go to
interpret.md so when you when you go to
interpret.md you have pretty much
everything listed out there so I'm just
going to focus on important you know
explanation of which is required for you
as of now and which is in the scope of
the course uh like confidence the
interval switcher which we haven't had a
talk so I'm not going to talk about that
but we are going to talk about most of
the things which is the starter which is
also very very important
cool so let's talk about that so first
of all let's let's assess the results so
now we have trained the model that can
take in the TV expenses and then can
predict and that can predict what that
what what will be the possibly the
number of the sales which are which
you're gonna get so what you can do you
can simply go over here you can simply
go over here and then say okay here and
then say you will model dot predict
model dot predict you given though you
you you're given the value of TV sales
and then that will give you you're given
the value of TV sales and the previous
year through the particular variable
which is the uh which are TV expenses
and that that will give you the sales
okay so this is what what you're going
to model or predict but that's something
for you know I just like you can easily
do that I assume that because that's
something which I will also explore by
your own okay
cool so over here you have the first
first and the first one is dependent
variable and dependent variable is a
dependent variable in the model where in
this case it's the sales going to
predict the sales given the TBE expenses
second one is r squared as you know we
had a talk on r squared right in Greater
detail how do we evaluate our how do we
evaluate our linear regression model so
over here so over here our r squared our
r squared which is nothing but 0.812
which means that 81.2 variations of the
sales is explained in our TV that means
that is pretty nice which is 81 of
variations in the sales whatever the
variations comes in in the sales is
being described by your TV expenses and
that's pretty much put it's good so
higher r squared indicates the model is
better fit to the data where lower is
not good okay
uh but but it also depends on problem to
problem so you'll so you might have to
worry about that as well but but
basically over here it explains pretty
well uh what is adjusted r squared
adjusted our r squared in this case is
almost the same is almost the same which
is 0.811 and what has what exactly
adjusted R square is it's just it's
nothing but a modified version of your R
square modified version of R square so
what is modified version of r squared
for example it is a measure of a
goodness of fit for the linear equation
model that adjusts for the number of
predicts now you now you might be
confused in this so let's consider very
very simple example
consider that linearized model that
predicts the sales of a product for the
amount of money spent on Advertising
okay so r squared will give us an idea
about how more how well the model fits
on the data how well your sales is being
described by your independent variable
okay now let's see now let's say that
you add under additional independent
variable such as how much your how much
your company spent on radio spending
okay so the r squared value will
increase if the radio for for example r
squared which which we have will
increase if the radio is pending
improves the model OKAY like if if the
radio spending improves the model R
square will also increase right so
basically so basically it will increase
even if one of the predictor is not
improving the model okay so you put
another variable X and then if it is if
if it is not improving but a radio is
improving then increases so r squared
might not be significant if you have a
more lots lots of predict independent
variables okay
lots of independent variables so I just
R square is pretty much same because we
have only one variable and they are
almost same because over here we have
only one to check the the two to check
how much they're explaining to the
output variable y but for example if you
introduce to one of the variables like
radio newspaper then you will see a
massive difference because because if
you have a large large number of even if
one of them is increa is improving the
model you're asked whether it will
increase but r squared just increase the
RS but I just ask it what does it do it
only increase R square if and only if if
and only if if your overall it just if
your overall model is improving okay so
that is our adjusted R square you can
take a look if you want to know more
about it
method what method which you're using B
squares method where we are using
greatness uh grain is almost same but
little bit of difference and all but we
are using gradient descent algorithm to
optimize it and then we have something
else F statistic and so F statistic
which you have already talked about in
hypothesis testing and F statistic which
tests the overall significance of the
regression model in this case the F
statistic is this much which tests how
much your regression model is good so
basically uh so basically of over here
which you see the app statistic which
does overall significance of a
particular model and if you convert that
to a probability probability of say F
statistic which is around
7.93-74 which means the model is highly
significant how can we say that the
model is highly significant so you might
be thinking here you 7.93.4 is values
very very small like very very large
right but it's not actually if if if you
know math then you'll be able to
understand this that actually a very
very small number okay so so what we'll
do we'll compare that value the
probability will compare that value
against our uh against our uh PP value
and then we can see use and and and then
we can see over here and then what in
the in the p-value we can we can we can
test okay in this case we we can have a
null hypothesis that the co if that the
model coefficients are equal to zero
okay
a low P value indicates that the
evidence again so we can so P value
which is the P value P value lower than
0.05 which so that will if if it is then
will be resected so over here it's
actually lower than
0.0.05 then we'll say okay this let's
reject our null hypothesis the null
hypothesis was that all our betas are
equals to zero so that is not so so we
can see that it's pretty very zero that
model is highly significant to our uh so
your your DV is highly significant in
predicting that but but uh but the this
this F statistic can be for several
other values as well it tests the
overall sense so if you also see the
highly significant then if you use three
of the variables of radio newspaper and
uh what this TV then if it is
significant you say Okay three other
variables are very highly significant as
well in predicting the sales
okay uh number of observations there are
200 observations as of now as I said
there's degrees of freedoms so degrees
of freedoms in this case it's 198
because you have 200 200 number of rows
and then you simply have number of rows
or number of data points minus the
number of parameters in this case only
beta 1 and beta 0 beta 1 is related to
TV and bitter is the constant term uh
it's there's the biased term so what
exactly degrees of freedom is so what
exactly this does is it represents the
number of independent values in your
data set number of independent values
okay this actually helps in calculation
this actually helps in calculation of T
statistic or F statistic and lot of
other way but this is what the DF
residuals is it's saying they are DF
residuals it's nothing but here 198.
okay so covariance type so what is
covariance type covariance type over
here is nothing but uh non-robist we'll
talk about that what does that what does
that mean what does it mean but the
covariance type is the type of the
covariance used to compute the standard
errors of the coefficients again the
blah blah blah it's very difficult to
understand but I'll I'll explain in a
nice way so that you understand it so
over here what is a telling that is your
standard matters us first of all what is
standard errors we have all drugged the
other how efficient how efficient or
accurate or how reliable our
coefficients are for example a very nice
example which will destroy or say you
want to predict the mean height of all
adult males in the United States of
America we can take a sample of adult
males and calculate the mean height of
the samples will be from the sample we
to calculate the mean height so how much
so we say that because the sample is
only small portion of the whole POS
population so the mean height of the
sample will not directly match the
population sample that's true right
that's true this is mean height will of
course not matter so the standard and
what is it tells it tells the measure of
the variability of the height of the
sample which provides what is the what
is the it provides an estimate of the
uncertainty so how much we are sure
about how much our sample mean is
accurate how much a sample mean is
accurate accordance through the
population mean so small on me is
smaller than standard error is more
precise the estimate for your population
estimate so you're based on Sample mean
you're predicting the population mean
which means that you're using uh there
is some sort of standard error switch
tells that okay how much precise we are
in getting the population mean given we
have the uh sample mean
and in this case covariance type is non
robust which means we calculate the
covariance of our Matrix without any
elimination of the data without any
elimination of the data so what exactly
does this tells what exactly does this
sense I'm just just going to go over
here and then tell you about that so
over here if you read read this out
as typically non robust where there is
no elimination of the data to calculate
covariance between two features but what
exactly covariance is covariance is a
nothing but it tells you the
relationships between two random
variables so for example you have two
stocks which is S P 500 and ABC
Corporation you're going to assess the
directional relation what is directional
directional relationship so if SP is
increasing what is happening to ABC
Corporation so what is the covariance
between SP and ABC so it tells either
one is squeezing or one is decreasing so
basically this is the data is an example
and it's extra and the variable is y
random variables over here both are
increasing that means they have a
positive covariance this one it tells
you the direction of the relationship
not like if one is the wood then what is
happening to another so if both of the
stroke decreases then we have certain
things so that's for the covalences it
tells you the relational uh it tells you
the relationships between two random
variables okay
uh cool so I hope let me just ensure
that yeah it's running cool so go
variant shows two videos between uh how
to move with respect to each other and
blah blah blah it just tells you about
everything over here okay
uh no that's known robots which means
that we don't eliminate any data okay
which is most common way coefficient so
coefficient is coefficient is nothing
but coefficient is nothing but for
constant which is the bias term which is
beta0 is 6.978 which is the average when
X is your X is equals to zero and TV is
0.000.055 and constant for the Santa
error for the constant is 0.323 which is
how reliable how reliable our uh our
constant or or the our how accurate or
precise our estimate is for bias term
and how to estimate how good I estimate
for TV which is pretty much very low for
both of them
and then you calculate the T statistic
which we had a talk which which we had a
talk which is T statistic which is a
look at each statistic for constant like
how because this is what is it it tells
you it tells you the a signal the
significance of the individual
parameters it it tells you this it it
tells you for individual parameters okay
so we just calc which is calculated by
dividing the coefficient by the standard
error of that coefficient so how so
basically that's the T statistic now
what you do you compare the T statistic
so this is the basically you have the
p-value uh you have the p-value for each
coefficient which measures now if uh and
you can see that both of the P values uh
both of the P values are close to zero
which means that they are that they are
pretty nice you know they are less than
0.05 and they're both significant to the
model okay we have Omnibus test which
test though now now over here we are
done with a couple of things which is
the testing significance of a model now
what we do we have the Omnibus test what
exactly Omnibus test does it tells us
that we have absorption which is
normality assumption in a linear
regression which tells whether our data
follow our residuals are normally
distributed or not so Omnibus test
statistic gives you exactly the uh to
that helps to validate the Assumption
that's why I really like stats model API
because it tells you everything which
you need you don't need to calculate
further on so Omnibus statistic which
gives you 0.013 and the probability
which get the prob the P P value which
is 0.993 which suggests that residuals
are normally distributed how can we say
that they are normally distributed so
over here which which which you can see
the the the the the probability value
the probability of Omnibus value is the
p-value associated with the test
statistic which was calculated okay so t
t statistic you know T statistic
statistic which we can calculate and
other things so here the probability
common Omnibus is the if your if your
value of the prop the probability of
Omnibus value types of the test is close
to one that means our likely normally
distributed and there if they're less
than that they are if they're less than
0.05 which means they're not normal
distributed right so over here which is
0.993 which means that are close to one
that means it's a normal distributed
another one is Durban words and test
which was used for testing the
independence of residuals whether one
into one one error doesn't not affect
another which we had a talk so it
usually ranges between 0 to 4 and the
value indicating two which means they'd
have they they follow the assumption but
less than they are you know uh positive
and greater than they are greater than
to their negative
correlation right so um so uh but so in
this case your double Watson test is
around two which means that they also
follow the independence assumption now
we don't need to check for too much and
then value close to as you can see that
you can uh read over here and then we
have another test which is another again
for normality assumption which is Jack
beta test you know there is a lot of
pronunciation uh for the same like harik
beta you know so it depends on what you
use so you you have another test you
don't need to understand how exactly the
mathematical working was setting it's
just for statistics purposes so which
tests assumptions of a normality of the
residuals in this case your beta
statistic as you know first first you
have a t value and then the critical
value right so first of all calculate
the beta statistic which is this much
and then you calculate the probability
of that which is from the table
distribution which is 0.979 which says
that residuals are normally this what is
the probability which is the so so that
we have the problem so that we can
compare with the significance right
Alpha value otherwise how can you
compare this this is this is not a
probability convert that probability so
we suggest that the residuals are
normally distributed how can we say that
you can read that how can we see that we
have actually written you everything
which is over here
uh that that also tests suggests now now
we have skewness is skewness means that
skewness means so how can I explain your
skewness is skewness is a statistical
you know uh I think that you have to
enroll in my course for learning about
all of these things but but basically
um but but basically skewness means that
excuse suggests some normality
assumption okay uh so basically it has
also also helps to calculate our
normality so over here in this case is
minus 0.08 which means the residuals are
close to being normal distributed I
suggest you to you know have a look at
in detail about skewness and kotoris
because this is something which you have
to and it won't indicates the validates
our normality assumption over there but
I suggest you to explore by your own
because something is takes a long time
to explain that is that that I explained
in my probability course
cool and this is the condition number uh
this is not important you can actually
ignore but actually condition number if
you if you want to know about like uh
and so you have a condition number over
here condition number what is it states
it represents the sensitivity of the
predictions of the model predictions to
small changes in the value of
independent variables so how much your
model prediction will change if you
change the training data and then
retrain the model okay so if you reach
if you change the training a little bit
and then how much that will change so
higher the higher the condition number
is better uh sorry uh small kind of it's
a small condition number indicates that
the model is a relatively insensitive to
changes which suggests are relatively
stable okay so they are not sensitive so
basically smaller condition number which
means that even if you change the data
your predictions will be remained stable
it will not drastically change I will
not trust it it will not drastically
change so I hope that that really helps
um that really helps now uh I hope that
this this provides a very nice
explanation about our condition number
and the summary of everything now what
you can do now you can have now now we
have now we are done with the
interpretation now I can actually go to
something known as buy your own which is
explanation and explanation consists of
everything which we had talked on a
lecture like I had uh of over here again
what exactly the report is what is the
small summary of the model over here I
have interpreted I've interpreted every
the important you know tests and
everything I've also validated the
assumptions I've also validated the
assumptions if you you can also go on uh
images and then see figure one figure
two figure three and all which which
will give you a very nice as uh for for
every assumption by your own okay if you
want you can actually tell me in a
comment box if you want to if you want
me to develop for it but you can see
that I've written a very nice blog for
this so that you don't need to worry
about too much and also just what are
the further improvements or limitations
which can be listed out there for you to
work on and that's pretty much it about
this project I'll be catching up the
next project till then bye
hey everyone welcome back to another
lecture and section which where we are
going to eventually talk about one of
the last projects for the midterm so on
regressions on on regression part and
then we'll move on to classification
projects so basically what this project
indicates this this project says that
that in this uh in this we'll try to
predict cancer mortality rates for the
U.S countries right so what exactly this
uh what exactly the problem statement is
ETC so here's the walkthrough of the
project which will go through it first
we'll start off with the introduction
which is this lecture so we'll start off
with the introduction lecture and then
give you some motivation to start with
it and then we'll uh go through through
the Rick what are some of the required
installations and what is the virtual
environment setting up the virtual
environment setting up your workspace
Etc
and then we'll go forward in
understanding exploratory data analysis
so inex in exploratory date and Analysis
we'll try to do some you know a Basics
Ed of the data set and we'll try to
understand uh more about the data and
then after that we'll go through uh
preparation of the data what is
preparation of the Dead data means which
means cleaning up and then feature
engineering Etc
and then we'll model our work uh where
we'll Implement our linear regression
model to predict what is the death rate
for that particular country in that
particular country for the different
different states
I hope that makes sense now now uh what
I'll do is
make you make you make you go through
all the the first part of this project
work through is Introduction section
where we let's talk about uh what
exactly we are going to solve in today's
lectures
so basically you can go to the uh given
link so Wireless regression challenge so
you'll be having the link in the readme
of your project and so if you go over
there so basically this is a challenge
listed by data.word which is one of the
good challenges which I've ever seen and
basically this challenge says that that
you want to predict that your task is to
build a model to predict what is the
rate of cancer mortality what is the
rate of the the person dying with the
cancer for U.S countries okay so if you
go and see the data so the data the data
dictionary where you have several
independent features and then you have
one dependent features so what is let's
let's talk a bit about on this is you
have the data dictionary let's let me
show you first of all the data the data
which you'll have is over here this is
the data which is which is in CSV file
okay so you have a total of
3047 rows and 34 columns in which in
which there is one column which is a
Target variable so let's talk about what
is which is the color which is Target
variable which is Target death rate with
the target is the death rate which is a
dependent variable it says that mean per
capita which is what is the death rate
uh in per capita which is 100 000 cancer
mortalities and then you have again the
same thing average mean number of
reported cases of cancer diagonal
diagnosed annually so you have these
features which is average counts if you
go down you see average count and then
you have average dates per year which is
mean number of reported mortalities due
due to the cancer average death per year
then you talk about incident rate mean
per capita and the median income per
country then you have population of that
country percent of population country so
you have the features out here you have
the features out here and every feature
has its own description listed out here
so I suggest without doing anything go
through the understand every feature and
try to first of all understand what
exactly each feature is trying to tell
you okay
um so basically the the years of data it
contains is from 2010 to 2016 and
between that you have several number of
information out there right for example
you can just go and see
um some birth rate which is the number
of live births relative to number of
country women in the country which is
the person of married households person
of country listening who I don't find a
category which is not white so basically
these are the information for a
particular observations
okay so let's go with that example so
first example is where your average
Union count is this much and then you
have a death rate where given all of
these information you have to predict
this particular information which is the
death rate so where is the death rate
um death rate
yes so you saw you have to predict this
target variable so this is this
particular is the target variable where
you have to predict this given all the
information out there given all the
independent features so these are
independent features and you have a one
which is a dependent feature I hope that
makes sense now
um so what exactly we will do let's uh
let's go to this now given the data so
basically we need to predict the rates
so cancer mortality rates for the USPS
come countries out there right
um which is nothing but how many people
died uh we have to predict the death
rate using of uh death rate which will
happen uh using cancer okay with the
cancer diseases so build the task is to
build a multivariate which is multiple
um Lane regression model to predict the
death rate for the US countries right so
what what should be the deliverables
when when you when you will complete
this task what should be your following
deliverable it's like what you're going
to deliver to the task master whoever is
checking your assignment is first is
yours should be model equation where
you're where you should have a model you
should have a statistical software where
you're telling about R square mean
squared your code file and the model
Diagnostics whether your model follows
the linearity Assumption Independence
assumption Etc and then your
interpretation of the model and there
are other factors to also consider in
this okay so I hope that this this will
tell you a lot and now I hope that this
gives you good sense about what exactly
we have to do now we you you may be
thinking we'll be covering each and
every part as you might have already
noticed that we have covered this part
which is assessing them which is a model
assumption test as well as the
evaluation part so these two things are
in your assignment however we'll do the
big chunk of portion of this project to
help you better understand mainly the
data processing steps and all so I hope
that this gives you good sense about
what exactly because we are going to do
um so I as I told our our aim we have
come we have given you the short
introduction about the problem statement
problem statement is nothing we have to
predict the death rate per me uh which
is which which is the uh death rate and
what is the forecast using which
happened with cancer mortalities okay
now uh you might have some issues like
Understanding Variables so here's you
have to do if you're having a very uh
height a hard time and in understanding
cancer mode uh whatever the independent
features then suggest you research that
particular term online on Google and
then you'll be automatically
understanding what exactly you need to
do right but as of now we want to
predict what what will the death rate in
that particular country given that in
that sort of information so basically if
you go out here
if you go out here you will see a
geography in that geography in in that
geography you have the geography as well
as for for that particular place and for
that particular year you have all the
information available I hope that this
gives you a good sense what exactly the
problem statement is now in the next set
of lectures what I'll try to achieve is
I'll make I'll start off with a very
basic introduction of what is the
require required installations which you
need to do what is environment variables
so we'll start off with the basic
introduction to environment variables
and then we'll move forward accordingly
hello everybody
um now we'll talk about one of the
theory theoretical concept today is a
bit about on programming basis but this
should already be covered in your python
if but if you don't know I widely use
this uh virtual environment uh in this
project so if you if you don't about
virtual environment at all uh this
lecture is for you maybe uh but if you
don't know completely python this this
lecture is not for you please complete
your python stuff click in Python you
you're taught you taught in these all
these things so please make sure that
you have some idea what exactly these
things are but if even if you don't if
you have basics of stuff not done then
you will be able to solve things up cool
so let's get started uh actually is
first is I will to what our agenda today
to talk about a virtual
environment
variables in Python
our agenda is to talk about this
especially in this particular lecture
and uh first of all let's so let's talk
about uh what exactly they are right so
virtual environment in is an isolated
working copy of your of your python
version that allows you to install any
sort of packages or dependencies which
you have for a particular project so I
know it's something which is a very big
definition let's let's say one thing
you're working on Project number a
you're you're working on Project number
a and also you're working on Project
number B project number B you have a
python you have python installed you
have a python installed right and then
in that python you have several
libraries installed such as numpy
installed panda is installed
matplotlib installed blah blah blah so
in that python version you have several
dependencies and packages are also
installed right and now now now you now
now you have this package packages and
all so your project a also downloads in
your base version your pro in Project a
you download your whatever first of all
down download your package is required
for project from these um which these
and every library has its own version
right they have the V1 V2 V3 Etc and
Project B might also have the uh might
also have some some sort of similar
libraries or different different
packages installed okay but but but you
may be thinking but over here but over
here project a is utilizing my it might
happen that project a might have
different versions requirement different
versions requirement and Project B might
have different versions requirement
right that's one of the way to think
about that if your project a requires if
you project a runs on numpy 1.0 then
project if Project B works on numpy 2.0
then that's an issue right you you
cannot uh run Project B on that first
library right on the other hand you
might be having questions like
um so so so so we need uh so you you may
you might be thinking how can we solve
this there's one way to solve this is
that we can have every project
separately so we can have a project
project number a we can have a project
number a with with its own python
version with its own python version with
its own libraries version so its own
libraries versions with its own
dependencies
right so for example numpy can be
dependent on several other uh packages
to work right pandas can be dependent
upon numpy matplotlab right so a single
Library can be dependent upon several
other uh packages so one way to think
about why do we need first of all what
is virtual first of all the the problem
which arised that a particular project
project number a might have different
requirements of your python version they
require 3.8 but Project B requires 3.9
and they might require several other
other set of versions of your libraries
and maybe there there might be different
different dependencies so for example
numpy can be dependent on pandas and
password but pandas can may not be
dependent on matplotlab right so this is
dependency conflicts which means which
may can happen and Etc so what is the
ideal solution
we can have a a container we can have a
container sort of thing we can have a
container sort of thing or the variable
sort of thing a variable sort of thing
or an environment sort of thing for
every project so we have two projects so
project number a so we create an
environment for that particular project
number a and in that project number a
you might install your own python
version your own python version you
might also install your own uh libraries
your own libraries so now you can run
that project a using this and whatever
versions you have and then you make this
another environment for project number B
for a project B and in that project B
you can have different different
versions so you've given a numpy 1.2
number one 1.3 and then you can activate
this environment if you're running this
particular project you can have project
C with different versions with different
versions of your libraries or Python and
all right and then if you want to if
you're into runs from number three you
can activate this environment
if you have project number D then you
can have several other versions and then
you can actually if you want to run this
project then you can activate this
particular environment
okay so this is one of the way to to
think about it right uh so basically you
can you can you can have a different
different versions of a packages and
different different for the different
different projects for the different
different uh environments
and and and and it will and we have and
we can create this and this will not
affect anything on a global global means
where you have a globe global winds
which is which is out of which is the
which is setting over here in that
Global you have certain packages
installed python installed on a path
environment but in that a global one you
have several of the virtual environments
available
right there are different different
tools that use to create these sort of
environments one of them is when another
one is conda another one is uh one is
when another one is conda another one is
uh let's let's say for us for a second
example uh pinev
so we have these three where you can
simply create your version bar and
environments out of these tools right
so let's talk about a bit about you know
a bit of reasons why exactly we need a
virtual environment in our daily life as
is something which is super important so
uh there are several reasons which we
might use for virtual environment the
first one is package package
management
so this is the first one which is in
package management you can you what you
can do you can install your packages you
can install your
packages you can install and manage your
packages or libraries libraries for
particular projects you don't need to
install in such a way that it should be
applicable on every project it can be
for a particular project and this like
you install it like you install you
manage your project you you have a
project and then you have several other
dependencies so you have to only in
practice this you can package this
without affecting the project number two
on which you're working so you might
have noticed in my previous projects I
always create a budget environment so
that it does not affect my other
projects and dependencies right another
way is we isolate our projects which is
another one is
um is isolation another one is ISO
isolation
isolation means that if you have lots of
environments you have lots of virtual
environments for all for project number
a project number B project number c so
you can have these virtual environments
so changes in the project number a does
not affect the changes in Project number
two even they if they have a same line
because they have all installed
separately they haven't all are
installed separately by creating a
folder so everyone has their own folders
and in that they have their own packages
so if every environment has their own
different different versions or it may
be same as well but uh one is that one
does not affect others so in covid-19
used to isolate
people so in just way over here as well
we isolate you guys
okay now uh you might have another one
is which is the another one is
reproducibility
okay so this is another reason of
reposibility which means that let's take
an example you run a particular project
number a you run a project number a and
that there has own requirements you know
that has short should have numpy should
have pandas in that project should have
C born should have uh this this
particular requirements all the all the
technical requirements right
so when you have when you package this
up you can exactly set up in such a way
that it will work on other systems as
well you can also deploy to production
so whatever you change change it over
here changes the production as well so
you can actually have a very good
reproducible pipelines out here and I
hope that this gives you good sense
about what exactly uh you need to you
know you should be able to but the
reproducibility is not nothing but
sharing of your uh project to others or
deploying your project to a production
that's why because it may happen that
you have a global slate safe say for
example of global environment and in
that you have hosted project number a so
even if a single dependency error occurs
in the system which is running for users
and production will fail right so you
have the separately so that your model
is also reproduction
is contained in a single container or a
one environment I hope that this gives
you good sense about what exactly we
wanted to talk on packages and all now
what we'll do we'll try to get into bit
of coding part so now we are compared to
complete a bit of theory which which was
needed before it now what we'll do we'll
try to install our packages now and then
we'll get started with a basics of you
know exploratory data analysis and try
to understand from there hey everyone
welcome to this uh another video on what
what you're going to do we are going to
set up our project and make sure that
you're also following you have to
downloaded materials and all so you're
also evolving to that throughout the
course
um so what I'll do today is make you a
bit comfortable with
um a bit of you know setting up the
environments and installing required
libraries getting it through the
notebooks which we have getting it
through the important steps out there
right so let's start with that first of
all I want to show you one thing which
is a documentation of python weight
where it says that we'll be using van
we'll be using when to actually create
the environment variable out here so um
so now if if you want to create the
virtual environment if so if you if you
if you really want to create the virtual
environment then what we can do we can
simply have this maybe this one which is
python mvnb which which is that so
basically I have opened my UK when when
you unzip your file when you unzip your
file you will be having this stuff okay
so now you open your terminal you open
your terminal and go to that folder so
when you clone that when you when you
when you'll be downloading the zip file
when you'll be downloading this ZIP file
open that zip file and open go in that
folder so it should be easy right so CD
and write the go go into this file and
open your vs code in it right and once
you open your vs code
um write python
um Dash M and when it's in the case that
we're going to create a virtual
environment and let's name that as a OLS
regression challenge so just write OLS
which will be the name of our
environment and then let's click on
enter and that creates and that creates
uh we noticed do you want to select it
for the workspace folder yes I want to
select it for workspace folder now we
have created a virtual environment we
have created a virtual environment named
OLS where it says that you can see that
a new folder has been created where all
our files will be installed or our
packages will be installed now it's
containerized in a particular
environment so now project will only run
if that environment is activated if this
environment is activated okay so how can
we act how can we activate this this is
this is pretty much uh like like I'm I'm
totally you know uh trying to make sure
that how eventually if I'm if I'm uh you
know in initial versions how I'm going
to make sure that you're able to
um get it so so basically uh if you go
to the you know so if you go to the bin
for bin file and then you have something
which is activate which is something
which is activate so you can either go
there and then uh confirm it right
either you can go there go there like CD
and blah blah blah you just go there or
you can just have a sets like let's say
let's say uh you want to go at
uh in the folder of CD OLS Ed OLS CD OLS
eventually I I actually use pi and V to
be honest because
of my organization because in previous
organizations they were using pi EnV but
I recommend you to use when because it's
just initial version of yourself that's
why they come in to use that then I go
to select go to bin and then click on
source
Source activate
or maybe you can run simple simply the
activate as well it should run very fine
so now when you see over here OLS which
means that now you're particular now you
can run your project with that
particular environment okay
now you can go out of that however you
can also write source and then you write
you know OLS
OLS and then you simply write our bin
and then you simply write activate Okay
it should work perfectly fine right so I
actually gone and showed you this step
by step uh solution of that right
let me just zoom in a bit maybe it may
be beneficial for you uh to notice which
is out here so let me just zoom in a bit
Yeah so now we have now we have
activated environment now what we need
to do now as I said now once we have
activated our environment now what we
have to do we have to
um let's let's go through the uh project
let us go through all the files right
that's much more better rather than
showing it like this so now you have the
now you now will see something like this
after every in after we have activated
your environment so though so I'll
recommend you to go to readme.md and
it's in readme.md you'll find everything
which you need which is what exactly the
problem statement Etc now now what we
need to do we need to record and we need
to install the required libraries which
will be going to use in this project so
we'll be going to use this this project
as well as we have some other libraries
to install so we'll install that for
sure so uh as of now we'll install these
libraries frequent which which have
created the requirements which says that
these are the requirements for this
particular project which means these are
the libraries which are packages which
needs to be installed for this project
so when you will go to there and then
what you can do you can simply add first
of all which python so let's type think
about which is the python which which
you're using over here we are using the
python which is created for this
environment and then let's talk about
which pip you're using using pip for
this particular you can see that OLS bin
and pep so pip is also for this
particular environment now what we can
do we can simply install pip install R
Dash R requirements so what what this
does what this does so it you you can
simply name all the file name all the
libraries with with the specified
versions which you need specified
versions which you need for that
particular Library will come to that how
we got how we created this at the end
but as as of now you can simply have
this pip install and this this indicates
that we want to uh you can also install
it individually but I was I have added
in a file so so I can install it all at
the ones by a single command which is in
the requirements file and then it goes
in the first install the first second
third fourth all around the end and then
simply click enter once we click enter
it takes it takes a bit of you know
um time to do that and then you will see
that it is being all the packages are
being installed so all the packages are
I think uh being installed over here
where they're installing matplotlib
they're installing numpy they're
installing scikit loan they're
installing stats model and then we are
done so we got a bit of warning over
here what that warning says that that
the version which we are using the paper
version which we are using it's not
upgraded so let's upgrade our pip
version so let's let's upgrade our pip
version so we can simply add Python and
then use this particular command so it
is saying that you used to use this
python which is a python the the
absolute the the path of the Python
python is over here but you can actually
absolutely use that python because you
have just checked that python the which
python the python is like the
environment python only and then you're
installing uh install and then you
upgrade the PIP you simply upgrade your
pip and then click enter now it upgrades
your pep to the latest version which is
23.0 now that warning can be removed so
I hope that this gives you good sense uh
about what exactly we wanted to wanted
to do now we have the working we have
the working uh available things out here
where we set it up our project now we
are we now we are ready to start off
with our explanation of the project so
uh if you if you open our notes if you
open our notes we had this notes out
here we had this notes out here let me
just move it a bit you have the
introduction we have done with the
introduction all the setting up
everything however we haven't covered
this setting up get repository which
we'll do at the end node right now so
now we have the required instincts now
what do will now we have the data so
when you when you when you open this
data folder you have you have a lot of
things available out here you you know
you ignore this these two as of now
because
this is something which will be built in
the project only you will see that is
the data and this is the original data
right so I suggest to go in this data
and this data you will find out the data
which is available out there so let me
just open that so I think uh
when you open this in CSV file it will
look much more better I have already
shown you in the introduction session
very very if you go over here you will
be having cancer regression dot CSV you
will be able to see the data out here
okay now over here the first step is
will the first step we should see a very
simple way where we had a class where we
are taking out adjusting the data and
second what we'll do we'll start off
with understanding our data okay so I've
created a very nice notebook where we
did a very extensive Ada dealt with you
know outliers we deal with a lot of
things out here so we'll cover that in
re-read it so I hope that and then we'll
after the after the after the Eda will
cover some pre-processing techniques
we'll cover some feature engineering
techniques then we'll cover some
pre-processing steps Etc
I hope that this this guy too super well
let's catch up in the next set of
lectures to understand the Ed and
everything out there so everyone welcome
back to another lecture especially on uh
some theory part which we'll try to
discuss you know some I will start off
with this basic Eda and then with the
basic idea we'll try to figure out what
is the possible you know uh data uh
cleaning techniques and data preparation
techniques which we have to go forward
with right so let's let's start talking
about actually about all of these things
but before that we're going to review a
quick concept which we have to go
through is about quartiles right you can
read about deciles percentiles in the
previous in the lecture start in the
probability and statistics part I would
like to go through only one concept of
over here which is quartiles so what is
quartile quartile is something which
basically quartal is a part of quantiles
where we divide our data into some sort
of distribution which are equal sized
right or subgroups okay so we divide our
data into subgroups right so we have
already studied that it divides our
distribution into four equal parts so
quartiles divides are in distribution to
four equal parts
uh and there are three quartiles so here
assume that you have this data this data
so to assume that this is a column two
four five six seven eight so divide this
data into equal equal parts where you
have first first second third and fourth
so you'll see that the all are equal
equal parts and this is the quartile
number one this is quartile number two
and quarter number three so quartiles
are at the cuts where we divide our uh
equal parts right so the first step of
is for taking all the quartiles so what
is quartile quartile is where we divide
a distribution four four equal parts and
quartiles are like Q one Q two Q three
are the quartiles where which are
present at the cuts and they first of
all we have to put our data in a ordered
format it should not be unordered
otherwise it will not work right over
here over here you have for your quarter
number two is the median quartile number
two is the is the medium so let's talk
about quarter number one and quarter
number three in great detail
uh so basically you're seeing and you
you're seeing in front of you that you
have a date that your distribution of
your particular data right and this is
hotel number one where and this quarter
number two and this quarter number three
so given this particular information q1
is the central point between your
smallest value and the median of your
column okay Q3 is the median the Q3 is
the median and Q2 is the highest score
so basically what given this example so
assume that this is this this is an
example of your marks you got right this
is this is an example so we put in order
format now you take out q1 by this
formula you take out q1 by this formula
you take out um Q3 or sorry uh wait you
take out Q3 you take out Q3 which is the
middle value by this formula and you
take out q1 Q2 Q3 which we have already
taken out right and now what q1 tells
you q q 1 tells you that 25 of this
course are less than 68. so if we have
the quarter number one if we have the
quarter number one which which is at the
position number five which is 68 so we
say that there is 25 percent of the
values there's 25 percent of values
which are less than 68. quarter number
two tells there are 50 percent of values
which are smaller than which which are
smaller which is which are smaller than
um you know
so whatever median is there so there is
50 value which is smaller than this
particular median like 50 values like
this 50 and the fifty percent who are
greater than this so that's why uh Q2 is
called a median which is the middle
value we're 50 greater than this and 50
smaller smaller than this you have Q3
where we say that Q3 which says that
which is a 75th percentile or you visit
where it contains the top 25 percent of
this course which are greater than 84
right so basically it is saying that uh
whatever is called which are greater
than 84 that's what the uh greater than
84 are the uh 25 of the values which are
20 last 25 top 25 percent of the values
right so this is also called the 75th
percentile where it says that 25 percent
of the scores are greater than 84 and 75
percent less than 24. so basically out
here out this we say that there is 25
percent of the score which are greater
than 20 which are which are greater than
84 because that's the quarter number
three for this particular example
greater greater than 20 84 and there's
75 percent of the examples which are
less than this okay
again I'll repeat quartile number one
says that the 25 of values are smaller
than this q1 whatever the value over
here 50 of the values are small and and
why once is the 25 of values are smaller
than this particular value and 75 sorry
and 75 percent of values which are
greater than this particular quartile
and you how you can take out you can
take out by this formula okay
I hope that you're that you're getting
one way to interpret it q1 is the middle
point q1 is the middle point between the
lowest value in your data and the median
of your data right median of a data that
that that is the because 50 what is the
half of 50 because the medium is called
the 50th percentile so what is the half
is two which is a 25th so you have you
have to take the median this is the
central point between both of them
and Q3 is a central point between median
and the largest value maximum value in
your data okay this is the one way to
interpret it another one which which you
are going to talk today is IQR what is
IQR IQR it tells us how far apart your
first and third quartiles are okay
indicating how spread out your 50 of
your data is so what it is telling so
what it is telling that
um
um what it is telling that you IQR is
the difference between your quarter
number three and quartile number one
okay where it says that because most of
the most of the data lies between these
two right because most of most of the
data Lies over here right so we're gonna
take out the range how how do you take
out the range first of all is the simple
range is taken out by maximum minus
minimum right but that is that is that
is that is
um not resistance to outliers out yeah
we have we have a talk we we had a talk
please see the problem lectures please
again I'll repeat it is if we use our
formal range
where we take out the maximum value and
maximum and minimum value then it can be
told Liars y you can see over here which
you have listed it out for example you
have this data out here right now you
have portal number one 3.5 quarter
number two six and quarter number three
eight okay which are the cuts so what so
we can say that there's 25 percent of
the values which are less than 3.5 fifty
percent of values which are less than
six and eight um with 25 of values which
are greater than negative okay so so
assume that assume that you can take out
IQR IQR which is which is the quarter
number three which is the which is the
range of the range of the range of the
values where your most of the data are
present okay
where your most of the data present you
should think logically as well in this
over here
it is we are taking out the range of
this particular where are most of the
data line right where are most of the
data lines so they are not likely all
outliers outlier are the one where they
are out of the distribution where
they're out of the distribution right so
IQR is the it tells it tells it tells
the range it tells the it it it
describes the range between these two uh
quarter number one and quarter number
three where it says that how much your
data is
um uh you know spread out just like the
range where you talk about number three
minus quarter number one because we just
take out the range of this particular
part of the data that's why score number
three minus quarter number one V2
so you get 4 and range S7 but why we
don't use range why we don't use a range
because let's take an example we
introduce 100 over here 100 over here so
100 minus 2 which is 98 right but but we
if we take a but quarter but quarters
will not change over here the portals
will not change so our IQR will be
resistant to even these outliers but
range will be affected right so that's
why so that's why where are most of the
data are present we take the range of
that that's what the interquartile range
I hope that that gives a good good sense
of what exactly we wanted to have a talk
on now what I'll do in the next uh after
the review of this we'll talk about a
very nice stuff which is box plots so uh
let's go into the next lecture and talk
about something known as box plots
so hey Vox welcome to the another
lecture on box plots so uh eventually we
have I think we haven't had a good talk
on box plus and all but it's very easy
relatively easy if you know about
quartiles and all right so assume that
assume that you have a data assume that
you have a uh data out here so let let
me just first of all give the title as
box plots right box plots I know my
handwriting is not good but that's
something which you have to bear with
and we'll extensively use this box plot
to do video night to to do a nice thing
okay
um so basically assume that you have
this data 18
and then you have 76 and then you have
29 then you have 15 then you have 41 46
25 54.
38 20 32 43 and 22. so you have this
data available out here now the first
step as I told the first step
the first step is to sort it all right
in an order so when you sort it in an
order you'll have 15 okay let me let me
use another pen
um assume that you'll sort it on another
order which is 15 18 then you have uh 15
18 is 20 then you have 22 then you have
25 then you have 29 then you have 32 and
then 34 38 41 43 and 46.
right so this is our assorted data now
so now once we have the sorted data now
um and then we have 54 sorry uh then you
have 50 equivalent 76 so now we have
this sorted data now what we need to do
right so now once you have that sorted
data we're going to take out the
quartile number one quarter number two
and quarter number three right that's
our goal to take out so how can we take
out this as I said divide your data into
equal equal parts first is divide your
data into equal equal parts so first of
all let's find the middle value so
middle value so first of all let's let's
count the number of values one two three
okay so let me just one two three four
five one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen so you have an even number of
values right so that's something so
basically I've already conducted it so
when you take out the median of even
then it then then I think you should
tell me the formula in your Discord so
go over there and tell me the formula
for median you should you should be able
to have already covered this
um so the the median will come out will
come which which is over here which is
the quarter number two which is around
33. so the values over here are the the
values at this side on the left left
side are the 50 of values which are
smaller than 33 and the value switches
over here are greater than 33 which is
the 50 of the values I hope that that
makes sense now so now once we have this
quartile quarter number two now we have
to go forward to quartile number finding
one so quarter quartile number one we
have to find we can use that formula to
find the index I have already used it so
this particular is the quartile number
one this particular is quarter number
one this particular squatting number one
right and now and now we we want to find
the Portal number three which is over
here which is over here which is
volatile number three so now you see the
that we have divided our data set into
four equal parts one two three and four
right one two three and four so we have
already divided our data into four equal
parts so now your portal number one is
quarter number one is twenty two quarter
number two is which is the median which
is 33 and quarter number three which is
43. so you have fifty percent of the
values which are smaller than twenty two
sorry twenty five percent of values
which are smaller than twenty two fifty
percent values are smaller than 33 uh
and then and then there's 43 or sorry 25
percent of the values which are greater
than 43 okay so currently you have this
particular example uh with its statistic
we which you have now what what you want
to do as I told let's take out the IQR
as well IQR right uh what is IQR IQR is
the range where all the data lies in
right which is Q3 and minus q1 where all
your data lies in which is 50 of the
data which is 43 minus 22 which will
give 21 okay so that's your IQR so
that's your IQR now what we need to do
now what what you need to do okay first
is we can go forward we can go forward
with taking out the maximum you know we
can pick the minimum and then take out
the maximum and then make a box plot out
of it but for outlier identification for
outlier identification we need to make
whisker whisker okay we're going to make
whiskers so what is Whiskers Whiskers
gives you that a maximum a maximum and
the minimum value in your data
and a maximum and the minimum minimum
value data according to the IQR range
right according to the IQR range so it
gives the maximum and the minimum value
in the data according to your list value
21 according to this Mass so basically
we have the maximum and then if you say
if any Delta points go above this
maximum then that's an outlier or any
data points which go below this minimum
then that's also an outlier so for
outlier and the identification with
respect to our IQR because IQR is
resistant to outliers so we're going to
take out so we have a viscous which
gives us the
um
uh the the maximum minimum values which
are also resistant to our data which
which helps under the detection you will
get to know just wait for a second
second now we want to take out the
maximum and a minimum value so minimum
value can be taken out by the minimum
value can be taken out by Q um I think
we can take out q1 minus 1.5 times IQR
right that's the minimum value that's
the minimum value and then maximum value
can be taken out Q3 Q3 plus 1.5 IQR okay
so this is the formula for minimum value
for taking the minimum value in the date
of with respect to this out IQR range
and this is for maximum now you may ask
how did how does this came this is
something which you can go forward even
if you want to research how does this
derived but that's a very general uh
explanation behind this but that's not a
scope on this my scope on this to tell
you that we want to find out the maximum
minimum values with respect to the
outlier range if there was simply a
range or something you would have just
taken the minimum and maximum values
right but that cannot be used as the
outlier I'll tell you the at last why
why we cannot use the minimum maximum
why we need to take out the minimum
Maxima with respect to IQR so if we do
the calculation to 21 minus 1.5 times
your IQR which is 21 and then comma
because that's for minimum and this for
Q3 which is 43 plus 1.5 multiplied by 21
you get you get nine points minus nine
point minus 9.5 and then you get 74.5 so
this is your minimum value and this is
your maximum value so if anything goes
above this sorry if anything goes below
this minimum if any data points go low
go below this data point we say that 9.5
minus 9.5 if any goes above this this is
called the upper limit and this is
called the lower limit so if any any
goes above this we say that that's
thoughts on outlier so let's try to do
with the help of a diagram so let's try
to do with the help of a diagram so I'll
make a very nice diagram right now
uh so assume that you have a diagram
over here you have the diagram over here
a number line so let me just make a
diagram like this and let me just use
another pen yeah so we have zero then
you have 20
uh 30 40.
50 60. let's make a let's extend this
uh 70
80 right so you have time so you have
this num num number line out here now
now basically what what was our outlier
what was the outlaw our outlier our
sorry what was our quartile the quartile
number one was 23. number two was what
33 and quarter number three was 43 so it
is slightly over here so you simply make
something like this
okay I know this something is not great
but this is this is what it looks like
and this is your portal number so now
this particular is quarter number one
this particular is quarter number two
and this particular is quartile number
three as it makes it it is 22 it is I
think uh 33 and this is 43 okay so you
have these three outer quad uh quartiles
as of now which I've already seen
now we wanna we wanna now one thing
which we can do we can simply say that
something like this we take out the
minimum and a maximum and then just add
it for example in this case the minimum
is in this case the minimum is a 15 so
we can have over here you know we can
have like this minimum case and then
what is the maximum maximum is 76
maximum is 76 so we can have uh
something like this okay
we can have something like this but it
but I'll tell you why it will not work
first of all you see that 76 is out a
bit bit out of the distribution is bit
outlier just by seeing it right so so
I'll tell you why why it will not work
first as we said as we say that IQR is
resistant to outliers and IQ represents
the 50 of our data so if we take out the
maximum minimum value using IQR that
makes makes more sense because we'll be
able to identify where are most of data
lies so if any of this if any of the
data goes out of that light spreading
out we'll consider that as an outlier
right so now so now I think it will
makes more sense if you just try to now
mix and make make it more sense sense
sensible yeah so now we wanna we have
this minus 9.5 we have this minus 9.5
where we say that where we say that we
have we make a whisker we make a whisker
we make a whisker which is minus 9.5
which is minus 9.5 so and then you have
the 770 I think what was that yeah
it will be something over here so
anything anything which is uh now now
anything which is which this is for this
is for the maximum it's for the maximum
value and this is what the minimum value
okay so maximum and this is for minimum
value okay so anything anything any art
data so how can we use this to remove
our data how can we use this to remove
outliers from our data so we say that
anything below minus 9.5 anything which
below minus 1.5 is outlier ending above
minus above 74.5 is outlier because this
is the distribution this is the range of
our of our maximum data where are most
of the data so anything above this so if
we see our data anything below minus
sign to 9.5 there's no anything below my
n minus but there is
um above 74.5 which is 76 so we simply
say that we consider this particular
thing as an outlier this particular
thing as an outlier okay this particular
thing is an outlier
this particular thing is outlier and we
remove this data from our plot right
from our data so we remove that outlier
right there you know the linear
regression that other that lots of
algorithms that are sensitive to
outliers okay so you have to remove
these outliers we'll we should study
later on as well so we'll remove this
outlier by a box plot where I'll some
summarize the concept you take out the
you take an order you take out the
quartiles you take out the IQR you take
the maximum minimum value by this
formula by this formula which is which
is out here q1 minus 115 Times Square
IQR Q3 plus 1. maximum is for minimum
anything above this is bad anything
above this is outlier anything below
this is outlier I hope that makes sense
let's catch up in the next lecture to
actually see the Practical effect and
how we actually do it to identify
outliers in your data set hey everyone
welcome back to another video
um so now what we'll do we'll start off
with you know Eda stuff and uh
processing stuff which we eventually
need for a project and I'll make sure
that you understand each and every
Concept in great detail
so you can actually read all of this
thing which which you have done done it
for you but let's start off with uh we
have we are done with the injection of
the data now let's start off with this
file don't know what is what's this file
don't worry we'll figure it out
the first line of the code states that
the first line of the code says that we
ingest the data from our data ingest
file so it goes in data and just file it
ingests this class so if you click over
here if you click over here you'll be
going to this ingest data class and over
here in this class you have the init
method which is a Constructor and then
you have a method which is get data
which will where we ask for the path of
the data where the data is present in
your folder and then we read the CSV if
it is a CSV file we read that okay and
then we return the data frame right so
let's see it goes and changes data it's
it just Imports that class
then it goes in processing data it goes
in processing file and then it imposes
the following columns which we'll take a
look in a bit you have to just wait for
a sec right which will take a look in a
bit
and then you have for from future
engineering we are import where there is
another feature engineering file where
importing some functions which is
important to us as of now right which is
important to us as of now right so now
you see over here we have ingest data we
have ingest data and it's we are uh we
are you know what what we are doing we
are simply
um
instantiating a class and then using
that class as we said we are using the
method of the class if you see that
method methods get data over there so
using the method in just database is the
object which is the blueprint of the
class we say that we will get the data
from the following uh from from the
following folder so we go to OLS we go
to data and then simply copy the
relative path of it right and then we
import that and then now once we have
the data now it's ready to start with
some of the processing which is required
as of now but before processing uh what
what I usually like to do I usually like
to you know go through all the basic
data you know see how how's the data
looks like you know see some of the
missing values if if I have any and talk
about distribution right so let's let's
before going on the distribution one
let's before going on a processing one I
would like to take a time to explore a
bit of you know explorated data analysis
and Analysis and all so what's what was
our project our project was to identify
the number of debts which was due to the
cancer in a specified population for
over a period of a Time typically one
year so mortality rates are nothing but
a number of deaths are good for a period
of time in this case we have we have
given already in this competition you
have to build a multivariate least
squares competition to predict the
cancer mortality rates for U.S countries
right the first step is of course we are
going to import the libraries of course
sometimes I have imported in a bit
between as well so I'll do it as we go
along so we import our libraries as of
now we need pandas and numpy we pfpd as
an ally so that we don't have right
pandas dot every time to use Panda so we
have PD where we can use this PD now one
thing that you which would do using a
way we are not importing that class just
for sake of you know Simplicity I just
added it you know we can give it to any
people which is for Simplicity however
we can use that we can simply import the
you know from data from data ingest from
data ingest and then we simply import
the simply import the ingest data file
and then we sing assembly maker you know
um interest data which is I'm just going
to comment it out you know ingest data
which is in Jets data and then same
simply say key uh data is equals to
ingestinal so you simply have this to
actually import the data but as of now
just important that because of
simplicity so that you you could be on
the same page rather than going over
this so if anyone is seeing ADH they
should be able to understand it very
well so now once we have the data so now
let me start running it so before that I
would like to just tell you that we have
to over here you have to activate your
environment in jupyter Notebook as well
in in uh in vs code we have this we have
this select selecting of our kernels but
in vs code you can simply write you can
simply write like this
a source and then you simply have the
following command which we have used
earlier so now you see that we are using
source and then it is activating it so
you can simply use this as well you can
simply use the this as well source and
then use simply give the activity it
will be able to activate for that
particular environment however you can
change the kernel as well or call in
your vs code if you have issues if
you're having issues over there please
let me know I'm just deactivating
because sometimes you know conda I have
also a conda installed so I have to um
it's my system thing which I have to
deactivate it doesn't really matter it
is a base thing but I deactivate for a
safer thing but as of now you just
simply Source then you have uh which
which you have your source and then you
simply activate it okay and then also
this uh base base also gets activated
but it will it mean it may be not Vision
but but it is not going from here it is
my system things I don't know what's
what what happens but I think I need to
uninstall this Honda but never mind on
that but uh you can you can first of all
will activate that environment whenever
you enter the project First Step
activate that environment because that's
what the project right once you have
activated the environment now you should
be able to run it so let me run the
first first cell I usually use vs code
because it's much more simpler so it
says that for vs code we are going to
download VR4 for this particular
environment we have to also download the
IPI ipinel IPI kernel however however if
you're using vs code you should you
don't really need this okay you don't
really need
um to download every time but I don't
know but yeah for free score we have to
now it runs now it runs now you see that
it takes some seconds to run it and then
we simply say achar now let's let me
import my data so this is what your data
looks like this is what your data looks
like where you have the 34 columns and
five rows where it where we are asking
to show the five columns you can also
specify on a series 10 or 5 it is just
for the top five columns
is a target variable the death rate in
that particular span incident rate
median income rate uh Power type study
case study recap bind dink which is and
media range so you see that this is
something unusual you have to work on
this so I'll come back like it's
something you have Nan values OMG you
have missing values available you have
you also have you know
um what you also have if you've explored
the data if you explore the data you
also have you know over here which is
the English which is the categorical
values which is this text value so how
we are going to deal with that right
missing values categorical values in in
type of interval in type of interval
type of thing how are we going to deal
with this because we cannot just view it
to them because model will make because
this this acts as a string right now so
that model will not make sense so
there's couple of things which have to
take care missing values right the first
is missing values second is over here
which we see that this is something
unusual which is something unusual where
you are the lists in every written
column and then you have you know um
text variable okay object variable we
can use simply data dot info to take out
things out here to take out who
geography is in a string and then you
have enough all all values are float
Target there is float and then you can
take out the null and then it gives you
good information
so now let's take out so now once we are
done with exploration you can also take
out describe you can also write describe
so
[Music]
um
data
dot describe
and then over here when you do the
describe then what it does for every
column it describes some of the useful
statistical analysis for average a n
there are 3047 count with the number of
values in that particular column what is
the mean mean is 606 is standard
deviation 14 and 16 minimum value in
that column 6 25 of the values which is
76 where we see that there is this 25
percent of the percent of the value
which is smaller than 76. 50 value which
is more than 100 171 and 75 percent of
the and less rest 20 and more than and
so and 25 percent of the values which
are greater than 518 or we can say 20 75
percent of values which is lesser than
518 all right and maximum value in that
column is 385150 so you have now for
every column list list it out here
and then now now once we have the basic
things and now what we do we simply go
ahead and simply take out some of the
ask because we have noted on three three
things that bin uh that binwala thing
and then you have Nan values right and
the categorical so let's take out let's
take a look what number of missing
values which we have in which we switch
columns so if you run this if you run
this we say that null values we we put
the null values and then we say data dot
is null dot sum so what does this gives
um
uh this gives
um you know when when you print out
normal values this should give you know
this every column with the number of a
null values present out there with the
number of present or not there are only
three columns where your null values are
present there are only three columns
which are where your
um null values are present so we say
that you print the null value you print
the null from from the null values from
that series take the null values take
the null values whose known as great
greater than zero right so we simply
print that
and then we see there are three columns
post ECT and over here so now now there
are several ways to deal with missing
values which we'll talk about in later
videos so I'll give you quick solution
in this but we'll also talk about there
are several ways jnn computation simple
imputed blah blah blah so there are
several techniques for dealing with
missing values with their pros and cons
which will deal with in very detail that
we have now once once we have this let's
worry about other things let's let's
start exploring each and every variables
so once you have the basic you know
missing values exploration of the data
now let's go ahead and talk about how we
can
um uh now you have to analyze hnl
variables in your data to further
analyze your data so now you may be
thinking hey ayush how are you coming up
with these these things the first step
is an in anything is to do a basic
exploration okay have a template basic
exploration where you talk about what
are the number of there is there any
missing values is there what is the data
types available for every column what is
the maximum minimum values what what
values are greater than this odd value
is smaller than smaller than and the
next step should be to analyze each and
every variable okay each and every
variable out here that will give you a
very good set of thing first is we are
going to analyze our Target death rate
we're going to analyze our Target
variable right target variable in which
we say that
plot.histogram you're plotting the
histogram bins should be 20 color should
be blue and H should h of the S2
histogram should be black and then we
say on x-axis label that as a death rate
on y-axis river that frequency and then
title should be histogram of the day
three and then we show that Plot show me
the plot right now that's what it is
saying and I'll talk about what is the
entity interpretation of this so when
you when you actually take out the
histogram of this target death rate you
take out the histogram of this
particular column A of this particular
column this will result in this
particular histogram so you may have
high time in uh interpretation of it so
let's talk about interpretation of your
histograms
the values which are grouped into bins
along the x-axis so the values the
values are grouped along with bins so
you see over here you see over here on
the values on x-axis they're grouped in
bins they're grouped in bends so uh we
will talk we'll draw we'll talk about
the bins first of all uh as of from
which you see over here in this
histogram it shows all the threads which
are date divided in the bins and y-axis
on the in the counties you know the
frequencies in that bill okay so we say
that zero two hundred zero two hundred
is the I think uh fifty two hundred not
zero two hundred uh zero two hundred is
the sorry 5200 is one bin it's 500 to
150 is another but over here you might
have noticed that we have 20 bins as of
now but if you notice it very nicely
that is this the the the range of this
the you see you see the mouse right now
you see the mouse they are where I'm
indicating so this is 20 you know 20
bits so we say that that in this
particular bin what are the the number
of frequencies in this for this
particular bin what is the frequency
right for this particular bin what is
the frequency so that's what it is
telling that it shows all the trades in
x-axis with the bins over here we have
20 20 20 bins uh 20 20 and then another
20 right and y-axis is the counties in
that bend so for the for this particular
bin this will be the counties on WE
simply have this 100 we have this this
bounties for this we have this much
versus 550 around for this particular
okay so for for 150 to maybe let's take
an example of this particle bill so we
have this uh
but if you have a type of thing so now
this is the simple interpretation of
histogram which you've already seen but
but it is but now once you have the
basic understanding of histogram what
will how this will help us right first
it help us to identify ourselves how
this help us to understand a particular
variable in terms of statistical format
first it will help us to identify what
is the center of the data what is the
spread of the data and what is the verb
is eventually what is the range and what
is the shape of the data right so let's
talk let's answer these three questions
what is the center of the data but but
before that lets to note something
number line spams from the minimum value
to maximum value the number line is
broken into equally sized intervals you
see that all are equally sized these are
nothing but called bins covering the
range of values over here it is 150 150
to this will be uh maybe we have 20
bands so in this particular we have all
the values all the values which lie in
this range page right which lies in this
range okay
um there will be where is the number
line is broken equal called bins and it
have the every win has the range of
values in that a histogram shows how
frequent a values occur in that
particular bin so his histogram it shows
how what is the how frequent the the
range of values occurs in that
particular how frequent on bikes is for
this particular bin there is uh 6780
that is the frequency right so that says
the frequency the height of each bar
represents the number of values in the
data set that fall within a particular
bin and when the the higher you know the
higher number of you know thing is and
then you have y-axis which is the
counter number though which is to be
discrete which which represents the
amount of data Falls in that frequency
of course and the histogram make it easy
to see which values are common and which
values are less common or which range of
values are less common in your data set
okay yes now now once now once we have
that let's go to some of the
observations so I've linked the resource
which is good for you uh first
observation is it is slightly positively
skewed data set so if it is not
completely normal it is very very
slightly positively skewed data set
right and then there are outliers as
well yeah so you see that over here you
see over here you see over here you see
over here say this these are out of
distributions and this outliers nice so
we got an idea this is an SQ data set or
slightly and you have the outliers and
this is also not this is not a
completely normal distributed this is it
is not completely normally distributed
and is mean is greater than median in
slightly positively skewed data set your
mean is greater than median and you have
three peaks in the data set so your buy
model data where you have three peaks in
your data set right for that particular
range this is the high this is one two
three these These are three picks that's
why we say buy model data but the most
important key takeaway which I'm going
to take from here which I'm going to
trans translate is the is we have this
The Columns which is slightly secured we
have the columns which is normally
distributed we have the outlier in that
column as well
like however
um we are not going to uh we have we we
will just take care later on about the
outlines but so that that is for this
particular variable so we do this for
every variables but that for example if
a thousand variables how are you going
to do it that something is a uh talk to
talk on specifically but I hope that
this histogram gives you a nice sense
about what exactly we're going to deal
with the next so next what we're going
to do as we've identified we about lies
we're going to use box plot to see
whether we really have outliers in a
great sense right so we're going to use
that and then have a have a very nice
understanding of that and for every
variable we'll do the nice exploration
and then we'll learn about outlier
detection removing and lot of things to
talk on you know there's a very lot of
things to talk about so let's go and go
to the next lecture and talk about that
so everyone let's get started with our
data processing techniques which we
wanted to so you will find a file uh
which is data processing test and data
processing data processing test is a
file where we are testing our all our
data processing you know
um our methods out there so we'll try to
uh go through go through a step by step
what exactly we are doing and why we are
doing that
right so first of all let's get started
with what exactly things which you're
going to use first we ingested the data
we get the data we imported data using
CSV file and then what you're doing
you're finding the constant column so
this is not appropriate for every case
so basically this fine consists constant
columns what this does this function
takes a data frame and it turns the
columns that contains a single value so
if your data frame if you if your column
has only one single value that's the
very very bad thing which can happen
right so it will remove it will find the
columns which is constant right which
has the single values which can indicate
either of categorical variables or the
variables which does not provide any
sort of values to your um to your data
right so we find the constant values
constant which is that a column column
set contains only a single value either
a11 either 222 or whatever
so constant columns you make a v we we
make a list to empty less constant
columns and we iterate through the the
column state of range rate data frame
dot column where we ask for the data
frame as an input to the function and
then we iterate to the columns and then
we say that find the number of unique
values in that column by using using
unique method and then if that unique
method is greater than one then append
that particular column in this constant
columns which are which which we are
doing over here and then we are
returning at the end the the constant
columns right so that's the first step
which which we are doing over here so it
says the columns that contains a single
value and then print out the constant
columns and then let's try to run it so
uh whatever what exactly what I'm going
to do is Maybe
go to run my you know uh interactive
window so I'll just run my interactive
window so we have OLS activated in this
as well so you see our act in Virtual
environment which is OLS is activated in
this now so we have that let's wait for
a few seconds then it should work really
fine so over here which you're seeing in
front of me is it is running uh the 30
lines of code which I've selected you
might use Jupiter notebooks or you might
run the whole notebook step by step the
the way I like is interactive you can
also go online and search about virtual
uh Visual Studio code interactive
notebook you will be able to find out so
if if you go and then search out uh
virtue sorry Visual Studio code
interactive
interactive notebook
then if you go and see then you'll be
able to see that python interactive
notebooks where you can actually
download each and everything and then
run the run that thing interactively by
select selecting the number of uh cells
so now it says the columns that contain
the single value is nothing so you have
a so so you have a column which has at
least more than one value so at least it
has a good spread so that's that's
something which you don't have to worry
about sometimes it may happen that your
columns can be a single value and then
you want to take a look if your data set
is too large enough
now you go to columns which contain the
thing a very few few number of values so
I've also written delete constant
columns so these uh this what what this
particular method does this drops the
columns which are constant but in this
case we don't have any constant columns
now we search for columns which is
um with few unique values where we see
that function takes in a data frame and
a threshold as an input like what number
of constant values and the return so for
example some columns may have few and
few fewer number of
values in that column so we say that we
what we do we simply say that we make an
empty list and then we Loop then we
iterate through all the columns you know
date data set and then Define the unique
values for every uh data frame and then
we say if the unique value is smaller
than threshold so for example you say
that you want to take a look at the
columns which has which has less than
three less than three unique values in
that particular column right so if if
that is smaller than threshold then it
says that append that column so you
basically have the columns which has few
fewer fewer unique column so it should
also give you a empty slide which you're
seeing if you print this out
so I can just print it print this out it
works like a Jupiter notebooks so it
says that there is there is no such
column so the even few unique values
with a threshold 10 okay with that
threshold then you can you can change
your threshold so similarly I have
several methods for as a template for
you to make this work in your further
projects like find duplicate the rows so
it may it may sometimes happen that you
have a duplicated rows as well so you
can actually delete the duplicate rows
by using these two methods where you
first of all find the duplicated rows by
finding dot duplicated and then you
simply drop the duplicates by keeping
the first duplicate so so you might have
first duplicate second duplicate third
where the second and third are the same
as first then it keeps the force and
drops the second and three right so you
delete the duplicate Etc so you have
couple of methods now here but but we
are not but we are not using them so now
you have the basic you know basic things
which is just for us exploring things
there is lot to left in data processing
now we have all of this left now what
what we'll do we'll do some or sort of a
basic feature engineering or feature
construction okay that's called feature
construction rights feature splitting
and construction this whatever I'm going
to teach right now is called feature
construction feature is splitting so
let's do that in the next video
so now what we're going to do we're
going to talk about something known as
feature construction and features
splitting in our data so one thing which
I would just want to highlight for you
is if you if if you see our data which
we have if you see our data which we
have is let me let me just go to desktop
and then let's let me go to my OLS
regression Challenge and then you have
the data now let's go to data and then
let's open this data and then worry
about two of the columns out here the
First Column out here is our Bend you
know you we have seen where the columns
were in a in terms of interval format so
you've seen build uh bending where it
says that your column is an interval
format 6194 so this is your lower bound
and this is your upper bound right this
is a lower bound and this is your upper
bound right so you have this column so
so it will it is of object type and the
model will not make any sense out of it
if it is left alone so what we need to
do we're going to take the first element
and you we store the first element in
another column and take the second
element and store that in another column
this is called the first lower bound and
it's called the upper bound right so
what we'll do we'll split out this we'll
split out the the values from this
column into different different columns
by making different different columns
right so let's see how we are going to
do it so we're going to use uh so first
of all let me show you first of all what
exactly that uh we are doing we are
using DF data frame and then assessing
that column and the assessing the first
value from that and the first value is
this if you see the type of it if you
see the type of it so type of it is
nothing but your string I guess so if
you see the type of it it is nothing but
a string so now you have that string now
to make the column so that it should
make sense otherwise it will not it the
model will not accept it
foreign
so this function is made in feature
engineering.pi file and in this what
we're doing we are making a empty file
bin dink where we are iterating in the
in that column so we are iterating for I
in that particular column so it will go
through first value second value third
value Etc and then first of all it will
remove all the parentheses my point is
that it will it will remove the
parentheses and the square bracket so it
is saying I to strip and then
um and then this particular
parenthesis and squared brackets so it
will it it will remove it so if you see
dot strip function in
if you see dot strip function in Python
if you see dot strip function
I mean um dot split which helps to
remove the characters from the beginning
or the end of the string right so it
strips out it removes the white space
and any sort of values which we wanted
to remove so it's play it removes the
parenthesis and brackets in this case
the parenthesis and brackets now we have
removed the parenthesis in Brackets now
we have this
um and then what it does it split the
string into a list so we can actually uh
split that string into a list when where
you see so it is it says whenever you
see this column split that split that
list split that string into a list
buy this so when when when the when the
push program sees this particular column
it says okay this is the first element
and then splits these two differently
right and then what it does it converts
the list to a tuple um considering that
we should have a unique stuff and then
it converts the converts individual
elements to float right so it from the
Tuple it Maps every individual to float
so each and each individual is mapped to
float and then finally convert that list
to a tuple to a list and then you append
that particular Uh I that particular
value into this so if I could show you
if I could show you what exactly each
steps looks like its steps looks like so
let me just show you each each and every
step this should make much more sense I
guess so
let me just print each and every eyes
uh whenever you actually uh go ahead and
then see that right
that should make much more sense for you
um let me just go to data in chest state
of test and then let's run it
first of all we have to you know save
that it will not work if we don't save
it so we have to save that
feature engineering and then just save
it first of all and go to data test and
then now run it from here to there in an
interactive window
it will take some time to run it
so now you see now you see the for the
first it was this it was this it was
this then it then it converted into this
particular thing that then it converted
into this particular thing by removing
all the parentheses by removing all the
parentheses right now by removing all
the parentheses over there so basically
you can see now
um where I was Data engineering
so you can see over here we are first
printing I the first printing I with the
removal of all the values out here with
all the values out here and then we are
getting the value of I we are getting
the value of I which is you know
um
specified value right which is the which
which we wanted now you can simply say
you can simply what what you can do once
you have the value once you have the
values which is remove all the
processing stuff which is converted into
a list which is converted into a list
which you can see over here which is
converted into a list now that list okay
now that list can be added instead of
those strings right and then what we do
we say that we we make a new column data
which is of lower bound make a new
column and then we say that for I in
that bend deck take the first element in
that list take the first element in that
list and then you in up in Upper bound
we say that take the second with the
zero the first element in the in the
lower bound zeroth and the first one
first so we say for every each and every
values right we also make a column
called median where we say may lower
bound plus upper bound divided by 2 that
will give us median and then we finally
drop that column which was useless in
this case so we simply drop this column
bending right
so this is how uh basically what you're
doing we're simply taking this value
putting this another in one column named
lower bound taking this value putting
this on another column main named old
upper bound and then we are taking the
median of both of this like this the
first element plus second element
divided by two uh and by storing that in
another column that might be useful
right so now this will start making
sense so what we did we splitted the
feature we splitted the intervals and
then we used accordingly according to a
statement and then we drop the columns
which are useless so now we have the
information which is good
so this is what what we did now if you
go and see our data which we have so let
me let me just show you the data which
we have
you should wait for a second
still opening that's very big to be
honest
yes and then and then we'll go to
categorical to column and then we'll
talk about uh categorical encoding in
the next set of lectures so if you see
out here that spreadsheet now if you see
over here now if you see over here you
have something known as upper bound and
lower bound so let me just show you to
you first lower bound so that lower
bound have this particular values upper
bound has this particular values and
median is this right so we have we we
removed that because that was we're not
picking sense because of interval that
was a string and model will not make
sense out of it we made something like
this which will make sense to our model
right
now we have something else categorical
so now another issue which we had
another issue which we had I just want
to show it to you what issue which we
had is this particular column
where is that column
uh data and then we're just going to
show it to you that's much more better
yeah so see this now we are done with
this now you see the geography column in
geography column we have the county and
the state right County and the state so
both are the same point right so can't
we have can't we split this feature
again and then have County in another
column and state in another column that
will make much more sense right so what
we do we simply say we simply say County
we split that with that comma because
comma is there so we split we're using
the comma and then we say that uh for
for for every column in geography and
then we say that take in in this case we
asked to take the zeroth element because
this will be converted into a list now
now we take the zeroth one because it
was splitted in the enter in with the
help of comma so it it will be converted
to list and then we take the first Score
first first element
and then we take the first element and
store that in a county column and then
we take the second element of which is
of course worse because it starts from
zero one so let's take the second
element store that in a state column and
then we drop the geography so now you
have another column for kids app for
counties and states
right so that that is feature splitting
and reconstruction this is this is the
processes called feature splitting and
reconstruction I hope that you got it
very nicely and that's it for this right
now um so what I'll do in the next set
of lectures is actually talk about we
have this something now we have the
columns which is splitted now we now how
can we convert how can we make use of
the state and the counties and how can
we convert that how can we make sense
out of it by different different methods
of categorical encoding that's also
super useful for you to understand let's
go back and let's go to the next lecture
so hey everyone so now uh in this what
I'll try to achieve is uh just what I'm
going to achieve is try to give you a
very nice and complete feature
engineering techniques which is uh till
the previous lecture we have completed
this categorical uh sorry to the in
geographical column we converted the
geographical column into two sets of
color which is county and state what I'm
going to do next it is talk about one
hot encoding which is
um so you have seen the the the the the
data where we had the values which is
categorical so now we have the two
categorical values which is this County
and state in County we have some other
end State we have some other set of
values now we have to come convert this
into some sort of integer or numeric
that should make sense to the model
right that's your your model should be
able to interpret it right so now what
we need to do we need to
um uh you encode those categorical
variables right so we learn about
several other encoding techniques later
on but we'll encode those category
variables or try to make sense out of
that English otherwise it will give at a
very a good error because your model
will not accept the English stuff it
will accept only the numeric and you
have to make in such a way that it
should make sense
Okay so
so what you what exactly I'm doing it
over here whatever you seeing in front
of your screen is you have a categorical
columns in that categorical categorical
columns you are selecting if in that
data table so selecting the data types
which are of object and then selecting
columns so basically what this category
column states that this is a list of
category columns whose object is data
type so most of the categorical
categorical columns whose data type is
object right so that's what we first of
all select the categorical columns and
then what we do we had the one hot
encoder you know uh instance we create
an instance with the following
parameters so let's try to go ahead and
then talk about what is what exactly one
hot encoder so I'm just going to go
ahead and then talk about uh show you a
very nice visual a quick uh
understanding of that so if whatever
you're seeing in front of me is my
screen so see this you have the
categorical vary variable you have a
categorical variable which is color and
then in that you have red blue green uh
blue so as of now instead
right so we in in this case we have a
categorical variable which is color so
what this one hot encoding will do one
what will coding will create the three
other the the the the number of unique
um values in that particular column will
be the equals to the number of new
columns which will be created and now
for this assume that color is uh for for
example in ID number one ID number one
we have color red where it says color
red is present but color blue is absent
green absent and zero a blue is absent
right same goes with color blue and then
when first article a blue is absent but
you see the color blue is friend so
that's why it's one so basically what
you what what we are doing eventually is
removing uh is is converting that into a
dummy variable type of thing we're
creating creating some sort of dummy
variable for every values and then we
are seeing if that particular variable
is available or not in that right so uh
I'll tell you a very nice example in
there so you can also go and see the
other set of examples so let us assume
that you go and see this one
assume that you have seen this example
and in the in this example you have I
land as a categorical variables and then
for every categorical variables you have
the you have the columns created for
every means the uni categorical uh
counts in that so Biscoe and then in
bisco the first ID is one because it is
present but tungsten is not present
that's why zero in the first ID in the
in the first ID right and see my mouse
so in the first ID bisco is only present
then a second ID at the last column
dream is present and the third we have
second tongue strain is present right so
this is how we create new set of this
this is how we convert this particular
one column to the number of occurred to
the number of a column which is equal to
the number of unique values in that
particular categorical variable and in
that what and and how we do it we have
the particular ID and then we see that
ID is present in that particular column
or not right so I hope that this makes
sense I'll be giving you a very very
nice example as well so this is what the
M1 hot encoding will do which over here
what is this parts is equal to true and
then handle unknown is equals to true so
what is this uh variables so handle
unknown is nothing but
um
I think that there is a very nice set of
yeah so handle and uh an unknown which
is this specifies the way I think there
should be some uh
yes so when giving an input so when
given an input uh if there is any
unknown values comes in so ignore that
for example for example in that
categorical variable apart from this
apart from red blue green you apart from
this some other you know a voided color
comes in but that's not present in your
data so we have to it is asking to
ignore that part okay
and the sparsity we are seeing that as a
false where we we don't have a sparse
data right so now we instantiate then we
say fit transform fit transformative
fits and transform so basically fit the
Transformer to X and Y uh which is a fit
the data and then transform it like
first of all fit the data like have the
uh all the all the cat all the things
out here fit the data and then transform
it like convert that into the
categorical variables over here right uh
for all the category variables in your
data set and you have one hot encoded
which is the data set which is one
hotter encoded now you convert that data
into a data frame but and then you name
that feature by ticket getting the get
features names out using the one hot
encoder um object and then using get
features names out by giving that
particular categorical column right
you'd name that as a columns and then
what you do you drop the categorical
columns which are now you have the
geography now you don't need the English
column you already have the numeric
converter new encoded column so you drop
that and then you concatenate the
numeric which which was there and then
the official data set
okay so I know it it might make sense to
for you to maybe understand it but let
me just make you clear with things so
let me just open that OLS
and then let's go to uh processed
let's go over there it will take some
time because it is a very huge data set
now which is which is being created and
I'll explain you every part which is
happening over here
so let's let let's just wait for opening
yes so you're seeing in front of you're
you're seeing in front you're seeing in
front of me which is uh your first
categorical column which is that
geography that geography is now
converted so now you see that we have
County uh abelia County and that first
ID it is not present so every unique ID
of that particular County uh that's that
every unique value of that County
variable is converted into the columns
now if they converted into a columns is
now if you see the if that I I believe
is present in the first row or dot it
says no it's not present but if you see
now this is there there are so many unit
values that's why there's so many
counties are created though so many
variables are created and there's a
downfall of it that's a downfall it but
we cannot do anything that's for the one
hot encoding says then you have state
then you have you know State I think it
it it is not shows full but you have a
state and for State as well for state
Washington States Los Angeles and Etc it
is showing off as well and then you see
that that it is it is mostly you see by
zero but at some point you will see that
there is one as well this this one as
well where it indicates that that
particular county is present in that
that particular variable
okay I hope that makes sense I don't
want to repeat it once again so this is
how it got converted this is a very huge
data set which is being formed right
there's a 1935 columns and only few rows
right but we'll deal with that so this
is how what a one out encoding is where
you convert our numeric to this one hot
encoding but but we'll take a look at
other encoders like you know
um there are other in encoders as well
where we'll take a look at that and then
now what you can do you can simply say
that one hot encoding and then you
simply encode the variables now you have
that now you have also seen now you have
converted the to the numeric now what
you want to do you want to
um
you want to fill out the missing values
so missing values in the data set
however we'll be having another section
of dealing with missing values but
currently what I'm explaining you see
first is first of all we take take the
columns which which we need to drop
right so here's my plan what I'm going
to do if the missing values exceeds 50
percentage of the whole data then we say
that remove that particular column right
but if that is below 50 we'll say that
let's deal with it with our uh
techniques which we have so the first of
all calls to drop first the variable
contains the call columns which we have
to draw so we select the columns from
the data frame where there are null
values and where the null value is the
mean of that null value the in that
particular column the mean is greater
than 0.5
if that percentage is greater than 0.5
then we simply drop if that's what the
particular columns with that particular
column in the data frame is if the known
values in that particular column is
greater than 50 percent we say that drop
it which is drop X is equal to 1 because
it is a column if if this was a row then
we would have written X is equal to zero
then if the values which are smaller
than 0.5 the missing values are less
than 50
then we say that fill the missing values
with that mean of that particular column
so for example you have one two three
four Nan and then six seven so now you
have only one value so you fill this by
the mean of all the values in that
particular column right you have other
methods to simple imputer K and an
imputer there are several other
techniques for imputing missing values
which is a whole set of interview
questions but we'll deal with that in
the next section uh like we'll study in
detail right so we don't have to worry
about that now this is something which
is dealing with missing values now now I
hope that now you now what you can do
you can simply use this uh in one hot
encoding drop and fill and then print
out the shape and then you can simply
convert that now we have the process
data where what we did we first adjusted
the data we found basic values which is
converted that intervals to bins
categories called categorical some some
call it splitted the feature
reconstruction feature splitting feature
engineering of converted categorical
variables into numeric and then we
recently dropped and filled the missing
values now we have the perfect data to
do the analysis on it to do the analysis
on it where now we'll deal with
something known as outliers so that's
something is the whole set of discussion
for the next set of videos so let's
catch up in the next video okay bye
oh
so now what we'll do now we have done
with the preparation of a data set now
once we are done with the preparation of
the data set now we'll go and explore
some of the most amazing things in your
data set which is working or dealing
with outliers so this project I would
really like to focus on dealing with
outliers so uh let's go let's go ahead
and let's try to figure out lot of
things out here
right so um in outliers we have seen a
very nice explanation of the outliers
but
um we'll talk about some of the methods
for dealing with outliers and I think
this will be a very long video uh so
bear bear with me up right so first is
what we're doing we're taking out the
box plot of our Target death rate where
we say that we I'm using plotly so I'm
using plotly where we say that we're
going to create a figure in that figure
you know on a y-axis we should have the
target death rate and then it should a
point pose Jitter box points to be
outliers Etc so this is a I'm using
plotly to plot my box plots so out here
out here you can see my first quartile
my first quartile which is
um zusic
161.2 and then my second quartile is 178
and my third quartile is 194. right
and then you have something upper fence
up upper fence is something which is
your maximum and there you have lower
fence which is this much so whatever
goes above this are are say to be an
outlier and whatever goes beyond this
whatever goes
um below the minimum I'll say it'll be
outliers but this is this is what we
have learned right but this is something
which we'll take a look at later on but
as of now let's go ahead and let's talk
about uh let's analyze rather than a
Target column right let's analyze other
The Columns as well rather than that
so first of all what I'll do what I'll
do is we have a column known as average
a n count right so this is a column in
our data set now with what we're doing
and think of the mean of that column and
then taking the standard deviation of
that column right and then we're
creating a this histogram to visualize
what is the distribution of that average
a n and then we plotting the box plot
using uh plotly so uh for line by lining
ice I'll be giving a resources for
learning plotly okay so I suggest you to
first of all learn broadly because
that's very pretty much easy so you can
first of all I suggest to learn plotly
where you're saying create a figure for
that data and then that data I'm into
we're going to have the box plot of this
particular column and the power it
should be outlined Zeta is equal to 0.3
and Point post is equals to 1.8 however
you don't need to remember all of this
what I usually do I just copy and paste
things so even I even sometimes I forget
lot of parameters so it's organization
eventually so what I'm doing right now
I'm taking out the now I am going each
now why I'm doing this first of all
let's understand why I'm doing this the
reason why I'm doing this I want to
identify outliers in my columns so just
for explanation sake of thing I am
giving the tools how I go about learning
more about how my individual variable
looks like how my how this average
airline columns are is what is the
distribution what is the mean what is
the standard deviation what is the what
is the correlation coefficient
correlation with my target variable what
is the number of outliers present etc
etc etc so in this this is a step which
I follow is a framework which I follow
is the reason why we are doing this we
need to summarize this is some summarize
this column average a n and count
statistically
so what are you seeing in front of me we
we have peer print printing the mean of
that particular column and then you're
plotting the histogram bills is equals
to 20 which you have seen the way in
interpretation of the histogram then
over here we calc and then you simply
box plot it and then over here you
calculate the correlation between the
averaging and count and Target which is
we are saying correlation is equals to
this particular column this is assume
that is a vector dot correlation with
whom Target death rate right so into
identify what is the what is this the
direction the strength between your
average and account and the number of
death threats in that particular country
so the correlation it will be given by
this and then you create a scatter plot
to visualize the relationship so uh yes
what I here's why I did first of all I
care first of all I did two basic
statistical analysis of this numeric
column mean standard deviation I I I
wanted to know the distribution that's
why I added a histogram I already know
the outliers that's why I added you know
box slot I want to know the correlation
between both of them that's why I added
this now you may think are we going to
do this for every column if you wish to
analyze any particular column you should
do it right if you wish to analyze if
you wish to know more about the data you
should do all of this stuff for each and
every numeric variables right that will
give you a better understanding about
holistic understanding about data
plotting the scatter plot to visualize
the relationship between AF averaging
and governance Target their threat so
let's first of all print this out from
starting then it will make more sense so
let me just run it eventually
so it will take some time to run it so
we'll just give it give it some time to
um run it
I think yes
plotly no module name plotly so
basically it is saying the plotly is not
installed so let me quickly install
plotly so plotly install pip and then
I'll just install plotly by using pip
install plotly
by making a nice pip install plotly
let's wait a few seconds to get it for
getting it installed I think it's get
start so once it gets stalled we'll just
run this
you should wait for some time
whoops it is saying a minimum type of
rendering requires an NB format 4.2 but
it is not installed
interesting question so let's go and
search for it so this is how you should
search if you I don't know so currently
I don't know the solution to this
problem okay now let's try to debug it
so it is saying that there's something
to do with this format right there's
something to do do this format I think
that you have to update your kernel you
have to upgrade your kernel I have to
upgrade your jupyter notebook that's why
it was saying you can simply go and then
simply run it and then you will see that
it will work completely fine then you
see that it will completely fine so let
me run this out and then you see that
and then you first of all restart the
kernel so you have to also restart the
kernel to be honest
restart because once you install the
libraries you also have to restart so
that it makes sense
yes now we are done with that now what
we do we simply have this
um so let me just first of all run run
it out so it says that what it says it
says that for a particular average a n
account you have mean of average count
standard deviation histogram you see it
is a positively skewed it's not normal
it's a positively skewed data set where
most of the data lies between your zero
to five thousand because there's some
outliers also present you see that there
are a lot of outliers present you see
that that this is your upper upper phase
lower fins and in this upper fence you
have 117 is the Upper Front so whatever
values Above This are outliers and
whatever values below the six are
outliers but you see the most of the
value slice between uh you see these are
the values which are OMG these are out
outliers
and then correlation between the target
is negative correlation where one
increases then other decreases so it is
saying that
um the the the the negative correlation
what it is one increases and other
decreases
right
right so as uh assume that
um so now you see over here now we see
now this is scatter plot where on on
x-axis we have average in encounter Y
axis we have a Target death rate you see
that there is some sort of a giving a
very nice stuff but you see over here
that uh but but let's let's in let's
interpret it so it is saying the mean of
average a n and count is 606 which tells
us on an average there were 606 cases of
cancer diagnosed annually Per County
right six and average the standard
deviation tells how spread out your data
is indicates it is quite spread what in
216 is quite spread with counties having
relatively low low numbers of with count
some counties having relatively low
number of cancer diagnosis annually and
some count is very relatively High
that's where the standard deviation is
high because the spread is high in this
case and this is further confirming
which you can see that is further
confirmed in your histogram or box plot
you see the correlation is minus 0.14
which tells us the strength and then
strength of a linear relationship
correlation of negative one indicates
that the perfect linear relationship
which means that one increases then
other variable decreases
a correlation of one means that there is
a perfect positive relationship between
both of them right so this is a very
correlation about how can we interpret
it so if in this case if one increase
then other other decreases but it does
not imply cause a cause I should please
see my lectures initially on correlation
does not imply causation but only thing
which I want to tell is to this is how
you can visualize or summarize your
particular variables by dealing with all
all of the shutsticks
you have several missing values as well
um I think you have several several
missing values however we are going to
import the process data to deal with
anything literally anything right so you
can actually ignore this as of now so
what you're going to do we're going to
import our process data but now over
here but now over here you will be a bit
shocked to uh see the outlier detection
so let's try to learn about outlier
detection in the next set of lectures uh
on how we can utilize how you can
utilize how we can utilize several tests
for outlier detection how we can
eventually utilize other things like
um uh like SQ how can we perform outlier
detection skewed data sets how can we
remove it right how can we remove our uh
out outliers from the data set by and
how can we use our trimming capping this
over several the techniques for dealing
with it we'll deal with that and then at
the end we will just save it and then
we'll go to model building which is
super duper easy part in this where we
send we have our model to eventually
train a model but the most important
part of this project would be the
outlier dealing with outliers and
working with data so let's meet in the
next lecture talking about things which
you have not imagined bye
so hey everyone uh what I'll do today is
talk about
um outlier detection which is the most
important you know uh lecture till now
which we which which you're going to
deal with today is that the most
important lecture and we'll try to
achieve uh talking about outlier
detection using z-score method we'll try
to achieve outlier detection using uh
IQR you know uh interquartile ranges
we'll also try several other techniques
like and how can we how what is
streaming what is capping
Etc in these sort of lectures so so
let's get started actually with all of
this
so whatever you're using in front of
your screen is for normally distributed
data so
um uh so first of all we'll try it off
try and try it try it try out outline
detection using outlier detection using
um
z-score and over here first of all we
import a process data the one which you
process very nicely and then we take a
look at the head of this and then we
take a look at the tail of this so let's
try to print out our head our head of
the data and then let's first of all
head of the data and we print out the
hair of the data this is how it look it
looks like but I think which we want
this to be in a form of rather than
printing let's print out something like
this
it should look like this where you have
five rows nine out of four columns right
because why why this is nine over four
columns because every value of that
categorical values B has become a new
categorical column
now now uh now for z-score where we are
going to use out we are going to use Z
scores we have studied z-scores in our
probability uh lectures so please go
there and review it back so we also
these scores are you and we are going to
use z-scode for outlier detection right
we are going to use Z score for outlier
detection
so basically so basically what what we
are seeing over here is that
um there's one condition for z-score
that your particular column or data
should be normally distributed so we on
a deal so we first of all want to select
the columns which are okay normally
distributed okay it is not like Hi-Fi
and all so you can go and see over here
as well how do I know if my distribution
is a gaussian if you want to go in math
depth but as of now we don't need to go
in it you can just use tests like you
know normal tests from sci-fi to
understand it so first of all we select
the numerical columns because why you
want to select the numerical columns you
want to select the numerical columns so
that only because you want to deal with
numerical columns and then you have
gaussian columns and non-gaussian
columns we make a two empty list and
then we say for column numerical columns
for polynomial columns we're taking out
the stat and P P value for normal test
which is which is conducted on that
particular column which is going to on
that particular column and then you're
printing out statistics and p-value and
if now this now our PSR significant
alpha alpha 0.05 so if a P value is
greater than that Alpha they're greater
than the alpha we we append our column
in that uh so it it so if so what we say
we resect our null hypothesis we reject
our null hypothesis and then we say okay
that if that P there's a significance of
that particular column is greater than
0.05 we say that that the particular
variable has the is the caution called
variable and otherwise it is
non-gaussian so uh we we we run it then
we run it it will take some time to run
it so you see that we ran it now if you
take a look at the length of the
gaussian columns there is only one
column which is normally distributed
there is one only one column which is
normally distributed which is PCT public
coverage
now with this what you now we have now
let's check with that's really you know
uh gaussian columns out here so when you
subplot it and then here's the
explanation of this code so what you're
doing you're creating a subplot with 10
by 10 size so this is what your figure
is create is of 10 height and 10 width
using a subplots function from the matte
library and there's Androids and
Androids and and callers parameter so
you see there is something known as you
see a few this is how so you have and
what is the number of rows and what is
the number of columns so if there is
more columns if there is more columns
which are gaussian gaussian or normally
distributed a normal distributor we most
likely go with this you know specify the
number of rows and columns and there is
only one column in one row because there
is only one value of gaussian columns
and then we go to your use for Loop to
iterate over the colors there is only
one column in the gaussian calls that's
why we just iterate once time and then
we plot the density function then
density plot of that function right
density plot of that function the X
parameter is set to access which is
which allows the plots to be displayed
on the same plot and the subplots
parameter set to True which specifies
that each iteration of the loop it
should create a new plot right that
should create a new plot that's why
subplot is equals to true and then a
share X parameter is set to false which
means that each plot should have its own
x axis so each plot should have own axis
that's why share X which is sharing the
x-axis should be false right and then we
tightly out tight layout means to
automatically adjust to fit nicely
within the figure so it it ought it
should automatically adjust so it fit
nicely on the computer
then we run it now we see that this is
the only color which is normally
distributed which is normally
distributed
now now what now what we're gonna do now
we're gonna take now we have the column
now we have the money the column right
now so we print now I'm going to take
the whatever data present in that column
right because we want to identify
outliers in that particular column right
so we are going to take out the data
from that column and then we're going to
describe that data so when you now you
have the now you have the gaussian data
if you print out the gaussian data so
you have only one column pcdi which is
gaussian because we want to process data
and then we just have taken the coil
caution columns out there right so it is
just giving the column columns which are
gaussian gaussian so now we have the
gaussian data now we can perform our
outlier detection on this and basic info
which is basic info which is mean
standard deviation count you know 25
percentile so 50 Etc which is the good
statistic which you'll use later on
then what you then what you're doing we
are taking the basic info so that we
should which we'll be using in our Bay
info which is means standard deviation
minimum and maximum
and then what you're doing and then and
then over here now here the part come as
I told you that in as I told you that we
need to identify the highest and the
lowest right highest allowed in the
lowest allowed and we'll be using the Z
score and that right so what what
eventually we are doing what eventually
we we are using z-score for eventually
taking out you know uh highest and
lowest so what what you're doing on this
case we are taking that particular
column and then what that mean because
this is a basic info basic information
taking the mean of that minus sorry plus
that's the maximum thing plus three
times the basic input then the standard
deviation okay this is the the currently
we're using z-score that's why we have
this formula why this three three can be
changed we give into uh no no the you
know values which go outside of that so
if you go and see you know uh z-score
outlier detection Z score
outlier detection
let's go to this so look you can see
that anything which goes and anything
which goes beyond this three then that's
outlier beyond beyond minus three below
minus three that outlier and Beyond
minus B Beyond three and that's also my
outlier right so the formula what's this
formula was this but you can see over
here anything Z score anything below
minus three anything above 3 above
standard division three they are
outliers right so if you see over here
that this that the nice any Z score
greater than plus three which is
standard deviation or minus 3 is
considered as a less than sand minus is
considered either as the outlier
okay so which is pretty much same as
this random deviation this is also
called the standard deviation method
some people call it but okay we're not
going to call that so we have the we are
going to take out you know uh for PVC
column not foreign
this column right uh this is the this is
the highest allowed so anything which
goes up above this anything which goes
beyond below this so this is for plus
three values and minus three standard
deviation so anything which goes this is
the my this is the top of the plus three
and this is the value of the Tom below
of the minus three so we say that
highest allowed in that column is 59
which is the plus three which is the
z-score and this is plus three and this
in this case a minus three lowest and
where we subtract it and then what
you're doing we are saying we are saying
he in process day now we are going to
print out so we say the process data
so you can see out here that what
exactly we're doing we are using the
function uses Boolean indexing to select
only rows in the data frame where the
values in the column are either greater
or the low or greater than the highest
allowed or less than the lowest allowed
and this results in the new data frame
operation and this is called the data
wrangling this is called the data
wrangling and in this case you have Pub
processed and then we go go to go to
that particular column and therefore
Loop iterate to every rows and then say
any rows which is greater than that
print out or any rows which is smaller
than this particular value print out
that and that prints out very nicely
your columns and there's only five rows
which are which are acting as outlier
there's only five rows which are acting
as a outlier
so what we do we make a function we make
a function we make a function where we
talked or where we make a function that
checks that deals with outliers that
checks whether that for that function is
outlier just implement the advanced
version of it where anyone can put your
own column name and then he'll be able
to able to get your the the data frame
right so over here you have deal with
outlier so it deals with outliers where
it Returns the out there it Returns the
data frame which which is the Outlook
outline data frame in that particular
column okay it is for that particular
column so it is highest allowed lowest
loud as we talked about and then the
data frame which we where that we select
the columns the rows where the highway
the where the values are greater than
high slot and select the rows which are
smaller than high lowest allowed and
then we return the data frame okay now
be honest we want to get the columns
from a data set so we have the gaussian
columns so now you have the gaussian
columns where all all our columns which
are normally distributed as of now we
have the gaussian columns which are
there's only one column in that which is
normally distributed but we're going to
go forward and talk about to the all the
there might be other columns as well
when you're working on a project right
so iterate through every column in that
gaussian columns
and then you say deal with outliers you
call that function and then you say
whatever what are the what is the data
data frame you have is gaussian data
which you have right now is the gaussian
data where we have only one column so
you have to also convert that to uh
gaussian data which should be the
gaussian data and in that gaussian data
you have these columns these uh this
this particular column because we're
iterating to gaussian columns and the
basic info which which we wanna guess
right the basic info which we have to
give as of now we have already taken out
all these three and when we take out the
shape and if that shape is greater than
zero then we see that that callers have
the I have the outliers so as of now the
as we expect PCD public coverage has
outliers
okay so what so now if you print out
this data frame now if you print out
this data frame so let's print out that
it uh let's print out the data to the
frame eventually
so you see that we have the data frame
we have the data frame which is a five
rows and five rows columns so you have
this particular data frame okay in that
particular column you have this this
value which is acting as outliers which
is acting as a outliers
but over here you see process data is
showing all the values but we are
interested in only this put this
particular you know uh
columns so we just remove we just remove
those trimmed trimmed those values from
our origin so we removed this outlier
this outlier this outlier which means
removing whole rows so there are couple
of methods while dealing with outliers
first one is streaming second word is
capping trimming is a technique which is
used to handle outliers in a data set
which means that outliers have values
that are significantly different from
majority of the values in a data set
when dealing with it is it is we're
dealing with outliers the goal is to
identify or remove them in order to more
accurate representation of the data
otherwise there are there are algorithms
which are prone to this thing so
trimming means removing the values that
are far the removing the removing the
outliers simply removing that's called
trimming trimming means removing the
outliers
so when it is useful where it is useful
when it is useful when it provides uh
when when when there's a when we know uh
it is easy to implement to be honest and
it and for interpretation of it it
provides a simple way to handle outliers
without having to make any sort of
assumptions just about removing like any
missing values
so here's what you do we go to the now
we have the curve now we have the calls
that have outliers right and then we
print the data frame where it has the
outliers right where we can clearly see
then it be iterate through all the
columns which has outliers then we go to
highest allowed and lowest loud and when
it trim the data trimmed data what does
it mean trim data which means we go to
the process data right and then we say
that and then and then and and then we
say that
yeah so over here over here we say that
that particular column is more than
highest allowed or I think this should
be or
this should be or or
um that particular is smaller than
lowest allowed is Greg is greater than
slowest allowed so if if that happens
removed remove the column right it is a
trim data where you're only selecting
rows only says only selecting rows which
satisfies these two conversations which
we already seen which is great greater
than values and uh smaller than values
right
so if you see the process data
dot shape
you're 47 so I think we we have to have
this both the conditions right we have
to add this both of the conditions to
further successfully do it very now it
removes all the values which are you
know uh satisfies these both conditions
it has to satisfy with this this both
condition right
now that's streaming trimming means
removing of the outliers by by your data
wrangling conditions where we see if
that particular value in that particular
column is greater than highest load for
that particular column we remove that
and then if that particular is less than
that lower allowed then remove that as
well
gapping capping is another technique
which is used to handle outliers which
means that uh which means that to handle
out Lies by replacing the values that
are farther away with the maximum or
minimum value so we just remove the you
know value values of that particular one
with the maximum or minimum so you can
see that highest and then we create a
copy and then we see that in that we
block loc we go to the values in that
particular column as we saw that column
in this case a public PC to average then
go to this column and then go to the if
there's anything which is greater than
high is allowed and then we simply go to
that column ABC is equals to the highest
that's a maximum and the same goes for
minimum so if you simply have this
capped data very simply remove
are we simply remove our uh you know
what our outliers with the maximum or
minimum accordingly
you can see uh anything which is greater
than highest loud which is go is going
going to be Mac going going to be
replaced with the maximum anything which
is smaller lower slot is going to be
replaced with the lowest allowed
now we have the capped now we have the
capped data now we have the capped data
now you can see that this Gap now this
cap the data will not have any such
um outliers in this any such outliers in
this
right and always you you can see we do
we are not removing any call and any
rows we just capping it so this is
useful when you don't want to lose or
lose lose of your information
okay
I hope that really makes sense now I
hope that you want you you understood
everything which I want to teach about
outliers and in the next video what what
you're going to do I think it's pretty
much understandable from now on but I'll
again make it for those who didn't
understood again so I'll make another
lecture on outlier detection if there is
a skewness in your column
so folks welcome to the next lecture on
um whenever many many of you have
requested me to work to actually
complete this stuff and that's why I'm
just going to complete this and you
might have questions around like uh why
the hell
um like uh on outlier detection like uh
first of all we have used you know for
we have separated our normally
distributed data so you so you might be
seeing over here we have separated our
normally distributed data for example in
this which is which which we had
outlier detection I think there should
be one
yeah uh which is outlier outlier
detection using on normal normal
distributed data so what you what we
were eventually doing in this
um approach
is we were trying to uh from our from
our uh whole data we were trying to
extract columns we were trying to
extract columns which are of uh which
are of which are not normally
distributed okay so uh for example there
are several columns that from that we
were trying to extract columns which are
normally distributed
um and you if you don't know what normal
distribution please see the lecture so
normal distribution which I prepared in
a very nice way so then we use some
tests to to determine uh we use some
statistical tests to determine whether
that is the whether that variable is
normal distributed or not and we have
used and then we use you know the thing
which is p values to to say to to
identify it that particular variable is
a normal distributor or not using the
certain test however you don't need to
go in depth about that how do we
identify that is for more like who wants
to go in in depth but usually in
interviews they don't ask like in depth
all of these things but it's good if you
if you know if you know about that but
that's something for statistics majors
and all but not for uh I guess for
machine machine learning
so now I'm so only we have we only we
have analyzed only one column so the the
reason why we are categorizing it first
is for um for the for for example for
normal normal distributed we use z-score
um for z-score for outlier detection for
normal distributed data right but but
there are several columns which are not
normally distributed as well as they are
um like they they follow other the
distribution so what should what what
should we do how should we handle should
we go to Every individual variables and
then identify uh and then identify what
is there in what is the
uh outliers in that particular column or
or we or
um what or what we do there is something
called as IQR interquartile range which
we use that for outlier detection IQR
for outlier detection IQR for outlier
reduction so let's let me just tell you
the IQR for the outlier detection yeah
so we use outlier for uh iqr4 outlier
detection and then uh that IQR works on
skewed data skewed means a positive
shifter or negative is negatively
shifted we have already talked we have
we have already had a talk on this
please make sure that you actually
um
go towards it now now coming back to uh
one of the questions which may arise wow
like
like a student asked me like hey ayush
how can we identify which columns to
test with them whether that column has
outlier or not just I'll let you know
one thing is that this is very very you
know a big problem this is a big problem
in um like you you can't just go to
Every variable and then do things
according to your own pace every each
one column here might follow normal
distribution and another column might
fall is Q distribution right so they
have two different distribution and
normal normally their z-score works and
on a skew there is other method works
right so that's a defined set of rules
which you already have
and and what we do is simply classify in
different different categories and then
we apply the required all outlier
detection techniques for the same and
mostly our data has this skewed data so
first of all what what we do uh you you
might have seen our data has 1900
columns
our data has
1900 columns so what we do so what we do
is we simply say that um like 19 why why
they have 1900 columns because we have
encoded our categorical data that's why
it went from you know from small amount
to large amount so first of all we
identify columns which are categorical
because they are of course cute right
they are of course at once or another
side so we don't want to touch them
because they are categorical so we
separate the categorical values how what
we do we simply say calls to remove we
simply make a list and then we iterate
through our data columns and then we say
what is the number of between in that
particular column we say if the unique
number of values in that in that column
is less than 10 which means they're
categorical however there is only two
two unique values if they're categorical
but still I for a safe journey I just
added 10 and then I added cost remove a
pen now I'm just using that list to drop
that so there is 1870 columns which we
are going to going to drop because their
categorical columns that's it's a nice
strategy that you might have other
strategies to remove the categorical
column because now they are not catech
now they are not string type or object
type they are numerical type and I'll
deal with nicely to numerical types data
but make sure that you don't apply the
basic processing like remove one single
values of few unique values don't apply
that because you have to know that this
is the categorical data
like that's for numeric not for category
now over here the code defines as you
can see that uh over here else now what
we do now what we do we identify as
skewed columns as I said now we have the
normal normal distributor now we
identify these cubed columns so whenever
you try to solve for outlier detection I
did recommend you do couple of things is
normal normal distributed data and
skewed data right so there are different
different distributions which I might
start it right binomial uniform Etc I
suggest to to take out to to research on
that okay this is the distribution this
is distribution of my data what outlayer
detection techniques which I can apply
to that so currently I have choose a
skewed data I have choose a skewed data
as Q distribution and skewd you might
have it shifted positively or negatively
anyway right so we identify that that
sort of data and then what we do we
simply say the uh over here what we over
here we have a function that takes in
the processed process data frame and
then the columns so what does that
columns form columns means the columns
in the data right so call our columns in
there that's it which is Wiki May we
make a list and then we iterate through
columns we take our dots Cube using dot
skew method we just take out the now the
skewness score and if that skewness
score is greater than 1 or if that
screen score is negative one then we
append that uh then we append that
particular column in that skewed calls
and if this and if there and if that
does not passes this condition then we
won't append right
um so you might have questions like how
how exactly is skewness and well all
works I did recommend to see how the
reading materials which are which we
have released for you please see that
that's the best thing which you can do
right now and then you visibly uh run
this one to add in five skewed columns
giving the data for skewness and the
data for skewness columns and you have
total number 16 columns 16 columns such
as Q data right and then what you do you
simply uh you simply make it just like
you created the gaussian data you create
the skewed data and then what you do you
simply create the to see the
distribution so over here you see over
here you've subplotted it where we said
we where we have I think for 16 and
weight columns so you have to sub plots
16 right so what we do 4 by 4 16 so we
can have four by four plots to put two
two to plot every 16 variables
which you can see and I've written this
explanation of the code for the same
please see that which you can see now if
you just uh if you just maintain it let
me just say plot image
output
open it please yeah
so first of all see this first of all
see this this is the distribution of
averaging and conditioner distribution
of average death so you have one two
three four four columns one two three
four four rows and you have all the 16
variables which you had now now you can
see that there they are at this their
their skewed data which you can see over
here possibly negatively and you can see
they are putting this is negatively this
is positively this is this is slightly
positively sorry negatively I'm sorry uh
I think I did wrong it is slightly
positively and this is positively so it
negatively positively and and you can
actually see that we have positive and
negative if it is going from this side
then this negative if this is going to
this side this is positive
right so uh and then you type layout so
that it adjusts Auto automatically and
then show it now you can see that you're
confirmed okay these these these are my
columns just skewed and then what you do
you simply box plot so that you see that
if they did they do have outliers by
using this particular code where you're
saying uh figure where you're giving the
column and the Box points outliers and
then your title is box plot what were
the number of columns to be added and
then you say okay go to and then you
apply this function to each and every
variable for that particular data for
skin skewed columns and then a column
and then skewed columns where you have
this cute data and here you can see that
OMG we do have this queued we do have
outliers we can see maximum and then
these are the information which are of
outside the way and this is you can see
outside the way
right and we have seen the
interpretation of the box plots as well
now you can actually see that this is
also the outside the these are the
variables Etc so we have this now how
can we deal with this the what what we
can do let's take a particular column
from this let's take a particular column
I am going to take
um this cute column which is uh for an
example as of now study recap and then
we take out the quantile range 25th cup
percentile the 25th percentile and uh
and then we take out 75th percentile
okay we take a 25th percentile and then
we can take out 75th percentile which is
a quarter q1 quartile 1 and quartile
three and then we take a IQR from that
okay and then we have upper limit like
but the maximum value which which which
we should have and anything goes above
this our outlier and lower limit which
is minimum and and things so you can see
plus minus over here we are multiplying
this and this is the Strand is strand
deviation oh upper limit and lower limit
and then you can simply say the process
data where you have it where you just
trim the data out here where you just
say take out the columns here which are
the outlier which you're seeing our
upper limit or they're of lower limit
they are below the lower limit upper
limit for this particular column is 209
and lower limit for this is minus one
through five and these are the columns
which you 504 rows in that particular
column has outliers
and then you simply uh and then you
simply apply this and then you simply
apply this column where we just had
listed this particular all the code in
through a sorts of the function a Define
and column for that particular element
is checking the quantiles q1 Q3 IQR and
then upper limit lower limit and then a
and then taking out that and then what
you what you're doing you're iterating
through all columns and then applying
this function on that giving the process
data and that particular column and then
you simply have the uh count then you
simply have the columns which has the
outliers right
now now you have the column switch which
has the outlier so you have uh one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen all 16 variables have their
outliers so what we've what we do first
of all we take out trimming there's two
approaches we have to talk trimming and
capping trimming removing capping means
um updating updating my uh values like
you know what what values updating my
outliers with the maximum one and the
minimum right so if that a maximum then
we if if if the values above the maximum
then you updated that with maximum if
the value is up lower then minimum then
we update that with the minimum you
might be clear if you have seen the
previous lecture otherwise I'm not going
to repeat once and once again right so
uh going to this code on trimming first
of all identify what rows to remove and
that can be done by this data wrangling
or the data extraction where you're
saying in that particular column in that
particular column
if that is uh that if that is greater
than lower upper limit and if that is
smaller than lower limit then these are
the rows to remove and then this is a
trimmed data where we actually this is
where we actually talker the trim our
whole data and over here we are tapping
it so here we are capping it out there
and uh and over here what this is just
an example as of now just to Showcase
we'll convert that to a function right
now and then we simply lock loc to
identify the rows and then we identify
the rows where your upper limit uh for
that particular column right for that
particular column for that the the upper
up any any value in that particular
column is greater than upper limit
update that with upper limit and any
value below that lower limit update that
with lower limit which is the minimum
value you see that your data is
maintained the same but over here your
data is trimmed
gapping gapping means
um you see over here again the same
thing you have converted the code to see
over here and over here we will cap will
not remove cap by removing we lose whole
chunk of lot of information that's why
we are tapping it over here and now you
can see we are simply say go to the
particular column sorry Row in that
particular column if that is greater
than upper limit for that particular
column update that with upper limit and
if there is more than lower limit update
that with lower limit okay
I I hope that that you're getting and
then we apply this capping this function
on everywhere every variables we have
outliers and then we see that we have
the data without trimming and we are
just going to cap it and then you can
now box plot on cap data now your capped
data has that now if your box plot on
that for every columns now you see there
there are no outliers and that's right
you want it you want the challenge
I hope that you get it and then we say
now we have we are going to use the cap
data only we are not going to use
something then we save our capped the
data into something else okay
I hope that you I hope that you got one
point there is one as high uh assignment
related to it there are lot lots of
things to try out you can actually try
out outlier detection using percentile
method that's your thing now I think we
are mostly done with the outline
detection on regression model on on
regression model uh let's talk about uh
in the in the next set of videos around
a regression model and then we will
actually talk about that in great detail
let's let's go in the further video and
let's talk about that
cool uh so we'll uh now we'll come to
now we have done with the data data part
and my whole point from this project is
to tell you about data stuff now we'll
just go and quickly review because we
have already talked a lot on you know
how to build regression model and all
and that's not my point on talking in
this project my point was different to
teach you several techniques feature
engineering collection and all
techniques to actually go forward with
that
now uh what now what we'll do we'll try
to model it very basic you know uh just
to let you know you know we have already
tried it out and then now it's now in
the assignment you'll be given to model
it accordingly so I'm just just going to
give you a very small Baseline and it's
a assignment will actually further
update this uh stuff now which which
you're seeing in front of me is we have
the first function but ignore all all of
that let's go to the let's go to over
here so what what I did instead of
classes or everything I just created
functions right I just created function
so that it is easy for you to understand
but in but usually I suggest you to work
with classes
first of all we are importing our Gap
data from the cap data which we saved so
you can actually use the df.2 to CSV and
give that particular path you'll be
saving that your file and then if you go
to the data data folder you have a cap
data over there and cap data is where
your where you have dealt dealt with you
know missing values and everything out
there outliers and everything
now uh what you will do is you simply uh
first is you have this particular thing
where you have the correlation first of
all you have the read read it and then
you and then the second thing which I
which I really like to do is identify
the correlation among numeric features
among numeric features and then right
right now it is eight it has you know
1900 columns and it will take so much of
time and the reason why I want to
identify the numeric correlation because
there is one assumption which you have
saw that um the code the code they
should not be correlated to too much if
they're correlated then they're not
providing any sort of information to the
output variable
and when I apply my correlation
techniques when I when I apply my
correlation techniques and and not have
in not in every process you have to do
you have to do this in exploratory data
analysis part where you are
understanding the correlation between
variables this should be done in an Eda
part right I'm doing it right now
because I think it's much for me I think
as of right I've just added added over
there just to make sure that we are on a
page like like why we are using this we
are using just to know that we can
ignore our highly coded correlation
coefficient and then you see our result
right so I just add it over here for for
a for a sake of learning but this is a
part of your EDM
um so you have a correlation among
numeric features where you are going to
the where you're given the data frame
and The Columns of the data frame and
then in a numeric column you select all
the columns here numeric and then
to be honest every column is to American
this right now and then you take out the
correlation it builds a correlation
Matrix with we have already talked about
correlation please we don't want to get
it but I'll tell you a small uh stuff so
let me let me just go to correlation
Matrix and then let's talk about that a
bit so so this is a correlation Matrix
so this is a correlation Matrix so I'll
just open that in another tab so this is
a correlation Matrix and in this
correlational Matrix you you find heat
map like this you find heat map like
this where where on on on on over here
on y-axis you have the variables on
x-axis you also have the variables let's
survive the correlation between the same
columns is one they are highly correct
highly coded with each other but the
correlation between survive and P class
is negative the correlation between
survive and this variable is this much
the correlation between servers so you
have the Matrix for every VR caviar
taking out the correlation between every
variables out there
right so it goes to it takes to the
correlation and then it's sick it it it
it takes it it has the empty set and
then what we are doing we're going to
for I in range for that correlation all
the coral and then we go to J and then
we are saying if the correlation of two
variables so the correlation between for
example survived and P class is greater
than 0.8 is 80 greater than 80 percent
we simply append that it's highly
correlated with each other right we
simply append that we simply append that
column so that uh we could know that
they're highly correlated features
so we were using that I when when I when
I ran that method when I ran that method
by
um
uh by applying this so basically what
you're seeing over here
is I had the columns and then uh over
here I had the columns and then over
here you can see correlation among
numeric features Gap data and cap data
dot columns so I've just given the cap
data and then Columns of that capped
data and then I I was I was able to take
out the correlation features and these
these were the most highly correlated
highly highly correlated feature uh
features among themselves and now what
now what what we can do we can we can
first of all uh remove the remove the
columns from the data first of all but I
don't really like removing it so what
I'm doing is I'm making a list where I'm
telling call for call in cap data dot
columns if the call is not in hike
highly coded so we are just saying key
for every column in your cap data which
is your data which you've imported for
every column make sure take give me that
column names but also make sure that
these are not in these high in highly
query if the if the call also not in
this so this is a list comprehension
which you might have learned in your
Python programming language
and I said please see the resampling
methods for this and we're going to
explain the single word diet right right
now please see the resampling method
what we are doing you're dividing our
data into training and testing I've
already uploaded lectures on resampling
please go and see that first before
coming to this
split the data and then we train our
model I'm not I'm not going to go with
this we are adding the constant why
we're either adding the constant because
we have to multiply with that bias term
that one you know x 0 SEC 0 is equal to
one so we are adding one to every rows
so that whenever b0 multiplies with one
only right which is the biister and then
we have
um and in the constant and then we have
LL model we are training OLS from the
the stats model API uh with the Y train
and X train within to intercept
and then you simply take your lard or
summary and then it is printing out the
summary and then you have the same goes
for significant variables so what we are
doing we are identifying the significant
variables so um let's talk let's talk
about that like I'll talk in a bit but
let's run this whatever we have as of
now so just to make sure that you're on
the right page
so so it will take some time to run
we'll just chill we'll just chill out
right now uh so it will take some time
to run
and so we should just stay calm stay
nice
do whatever is going to happen right now
because it because the columns are super
high and you and you and first of all it
might be not as much valuable to deal
with that categorical but to to have
those categorical columns so could the
correlation between categorical columns
I'll be giving you a very nice article
which talks about correlation between
categorical columns which tells you
whether that whether like and and and
will also uh worry about key what are
the variables which are significant
enough to make our model better like we
cannot go with these much variables to
be honest
because it will lead to several other
problems as well so first of all Let's
uh let's let's go with this now now if
you see over here it printed out the
columns which is of highly correlated so
if you see out here that we print out
the highly correlated features and then
now it goes and training of the model so
it is training of the linear regression
model and it will take extreme y train
this training on and then it is going to
print out the summary so let's try to
take out what exactly summary looks like
oops yeah this is the summary and the
summary is too big because you have 1900
columns bro you you understand your 1900
columns and to be honest we'll and and
the most of the night allow around 99
percent are of out of encoded columns
that's why uh that's why in this case we
but that's why we in this case you have
to remove some of them so for first of
all see that we have dependent variable
the the thing in which you want to
predict R square at just a r Square F
statistic you know number of
observations residuals you have moral
covariance type and then for constant
which is the bias term we have the B
beta0 is 94 with instant deviation the
TV and the P value for that average and
for every variable you have this this
much information a left a for every
variable you have this much information
left and there is so much of information
and it is not feasible to go through
every information so what I do I just go
through what are the features which are
numeric which are important which are
not categorical as of now so what I'm
doing I just could go on through you can
go through numeric and then talk out
talk some things but before that what I
can do is talk about things which is you
know signal we can take out the
significant variables we have learned
about that
so let's let's do one thing let's print
out the significance variable so let's
print out the variables which are only
significant enough so from 1900 we got
to 144 columns which are significant
enough we have done a lot of tests we're
using p values you can take out the
significancing significance of a
particular variable so we we using t t
statistics using T statistic we are
taking out the significance of each and
every variable over here so we have we
have using LR dot P values and that P
value is this is this is this particular
thing
is greater than this particular
information
these statistic we have t-test which you
which we are using right now this
particular thing which you're seeing
right now p is greater than test so we
are using for that if P value is smaller
than p-value threshold and threshold is
0.05.
okay I hope that you're getting that we
are taking on the money columns which
are which are which are which which are
greater than that so that uh sorry I
think uh so the values which are smaller
than zero zero zero point zero five so
that we can resect our null hypothesis
and say that okay these these variables
are important so we have only 144 or
1900 to 144 we've reduced the complexity
of the model
understanding what I'm trying to say now
what you're doing you're simply training
the model now with significant variables
though the reason why we are removing
this I'll tell you the reason why we are
removing this but first of all uh you
will get to know first of all let's run
this you'll get to know
you got an error you got an error what
you got an error in that significant
variables you also have the constant
column a constant means Constitution
which has one right so whatever what I
am going to do I'm just going to remove
it as of now there is actually a lot of
fixes right now but I don't want to
extend that you can fix it by your own
so what you can eventually do you can
create uh you can create actually X in
Extreme as well you can create a
constant column as well so that it
appears that so you can actually what do
what you can do
let me do one thing right now I think
that's something which which we can
eventually do
extreme and then just go ahead and then
add X strain and then constant I guess
what we can eventually do in this we can
you can add the significant you know
constant columns rather than removing
that so I think what you can go and then
add significant verbs and then
significant Vats we can add constant
yeah so you can actually do this but how
however that significant natural action
should be having your favorite you know
what you that should be having
um constant columns or you can what you
can do you can simply have this SM dot
you know SM dot add constant and then
you can simply add that constant as well
over there right so it is very easy to
do do things you can actually go to uh
xtrain.act constant and then the
constant will be also added right so you
can actually go over there and then
simply add SM dot add constant
right SM Dot
add cons because in extremely 8080 it is
not added right so we can actually go
ahead and then add the constant audios
as SM dot at constant and then we simply
have this x string so it adds the
constant you can actually use for loops
and all to also added but this is the
best way to actually do do that rather
than removing that so you actually
rather than moving that you can actually
add this and then once you add this so
let's run this so you might be having a
nice set of information so now it it is
complete now you run this now you run
this you should be able to see a very
nicer of info so now let's go and let's
print out the summary which you can see
so now if you run this now if you run
this you have less information as
compared to the previous one you have
just only few set of information to go
forward to
so yeah this is the one and then you can
also see the the R square is 0.68
however it is it is decreased but it is
a it it is a model which we looked for
right or however it reduced the
complexity of our model right our
complexity of our model the more
important is not to get the accuracy but
also the robust model the model which is
able to perform in most of the cases
very nicely
so this was it for the project and I
hope that you really like this
particular project and
um you now you'll be given assignments
for the for the same for rest of the
things which you have to do in the
project uh now you can get started with
making your own projects Havoc try to
explanation everything from very scratch
now I suggest to watch resampling
methods video regularization videos
which is going to come so please watch
that and thank you for the lectures